hey everyone this is shruti from simply
learn welcome to this video on the
digital marketing full course for 2021.
in this full course we'll be covering
topics like what is digital marketing
the tools used in digital marketing the
basic concepts on seo google tag manager
google ads social media marketing
facebook ads youtube instagram and
twitter marketing content marketing
email marketing affiliate marketing
marketing hacks digital marketing skills
careers and much more
for this video we have our experts rob
and rahul taking us through all the
topics so without further ado let's
start by talking about digital marketing
before we begin make sure to subscribe
to our youtube channel and hit the bell
icon to never miss an update from simply
learn
meet joey a digital marketer he works as
the head of digital marketing for amazon
but how did joey get here a few years
ago joey began to see a large number of
opportunities popping up in the field of
digital marketing to begin his entry
into the field he needed to understand
what exactly digital marketing was and
what was so great about it
first joey learned that digital
marketing was a form of marketing
through which you could advertise to
people digitally digital marketing
leveraged different channels like search
engines websites social media platforms
emails and mobile applications
it would give marketers the opportunity
to interact with and understand their
audience better and to increase the
trust in their brand digital marketing
would also show marketers advertisements
to people based on their actions and
preferences on the internet while being
less expensive than traditional forms of
advertising after understanding the main
concepts of digital marketing joey
realized there was more to digital
marketing than he initially thought
there are also many types of digital
marketing types like content marketing
search engine optimization pay-per-click
social media marketing email marketing
and affiliate marketing and once he
understood those types he set up a
digital marketing campaign for his
uncle's e-commerce website let's have a
look at what he came up with
first joey created content like blogs
videos infographics and case studies so
that he could generate audience interest
in the brand's products or services
this was content marketing
next he needed his audience to actually
see his content the first step was to
create content on specific search
keywords that were relevant to the
target audience
joey would make optimizations on the
website and have credible websites
linking back to the content
and lo and behold the website began
ranking on the first page of the search
results by continuous optimizations joey
would continue to improve the ranking
and ultimately make the website rank at
the first position this was seo or
search engine optimization and joey
could do all of this without spending a
single penny he could also drive traffic
to the website with advertisements
but for this he would have to pay a
certain fee each time the ads were
clicked
he could have text ads that show up in
search engine results image ads and
video ads that show up in websites and
much more
this was possible with the help of ppc
or pay-per-click
however joey wasn't done yet to reach a
larger audience he needed to tap into
social media platforms
he would use social media platforms like
linkedin youtube facebook and instagram
to advertise the brand's content he
would use these platforms to advertise
the brand's products or services with
posts images videos and more to bring
out the brand's story and engage with
the brand's audience who spend a lot of
time on social media
like pbc he could use the platform to
advertise the brand's products or
services with text image and video ads
which needed to be paid for
that's social media marketing
joey realized that a large amount of the
audience weren't visiting the brand's
website a second time he needed to keep
them engaged nurture them to make sure
they purchased the product
for this he would send them emails that
help them better understand the products
they visited on the website and assist
them in the buying process he would also
send emails to advertise his products or
services to potential customers that is
with email marketing and finally
although joey was able to grow the
brand's funnel he wanted more traffic
from third party websites this could be
achieved with affiliate marketing
affiliates would promote the brand or
product to their audiences for a fee
with the help of email signups
registrations conversions subscriptions
etc
after setting all of this up joey had
the hardest part of the process to get
through
the
although joey had worked really hard on
each of these forms of digital marketing
he only had moderate success
that's when joey realized he had to gain
more knowledge and experience so he
decided to get certified and get ahead
in his career with the help of
simplylearn he took up simplylearn's
digital marketing certification and got
the skills and training he needed to
become an expert digital marketer and
now you know where he is
you too can do the same and grow in your
career by clicking on the top right
corner and with that we've given you an
introduction to all the major concepts
of digital marketing greetings everyone
this is rob sanders and today we're
going to talk about what is digital
marketing so thanks for joining us here
at simply learn and let's get started
let's start talking about why digital
marketing is important so let's start
there on the why so
we're just a fly on the wall and we're
in an office environment we're looking
at two friends having a conversation
about digital marketing so
really if we're listening in
everybody every marketer is using
digital marketing for his or her
business now digital marketing has
become more popular than traditional
marketing that's not a surprise
so in response hey over the past few
decades digital marketing has evolved at
a rapid pace these days a lot of people
spend most their time on the internet so
what happens in the internet every 60
seconds well a lot happens every 60
seconds so according to social media
today i mean there's a lot of snaps
there's a lot of clicks there's a lot of
text there's a lot of videos watched
there's a lot of pictures being taken
there's a lot of
voice activated activity going on a lot
of tweets emails swipes there's a lot
going on here in 60 seconds so there's a
lot of activity on the internet a lot
and so
the one gentleman says hey can you also
imagine a few differences between
digital and traditional marketing
systems and then the expert responds of
course i can
certainly clarify a few differences
between digital and traditional and so
he goes on to say what the differences
are between traditional and digital and
let's look at that okay so on
traditional marketing we're talking
about print radio billboard newspaper tv
anything that's not on your mobile or
laptop so we know with traditional
marketing reach is limited with digital
marketing reaches maximum and what we
mean by that is hey when you print
something you're printing it for x
amount of people you're trying to
promote an event and you
basically create a thousand flyers okay
you figure that's going to a thousand
people maybe they'll share it so you're
looking about 2 000 people maybe just to
be generous well digital marketing we're
promoting an event we can promote it to
a whole lot of people depending on the
platform so 2000 is nothing when you're
targeting an audience on facebook or
google search traditional marketing
non-versatile and with digital marketing
very versatile so again going back to
our flyer printing an eight and a half
by eleven okay that's it you know with
with digital marketing you're running
display banners you have 468 by 60 200
by 200 250 by 250 300 by 300 i mean the
list goes on on the types of different
display sizes not to mention text ads
not to mention video or multimedia
so there's a lot you can do
to get your message out there okay with
traditional it's always delayed
communication okay so
meaning if you're trying to get that tv
spot there might not be a spot open
until one in the morning okay well what
digital marketing there is no hours okay
you can certainly get your point out
there and have people see it
instantaneously so with traditional
marketing there's a lack of real-time
results i mean this seems like uh it's
obvious but you know digital marketing
that's one of the biggest benefits
instant real-time results instant okay
nowadays
we're going to analytics you can look at
real-time reporting okay so we could see
real time results okay traditional
marketing can be very costly i mean if
you're not only doing postcards and
printing postcards but you have to mail
those postcards so there's postage fees
where with digital marketing it's very
very very cost efficient i mean meaning
you could pick and choose who you want
to target when you want to target where
you want to target what you want to
target and if you're doing search you
can put your bidding in place you can
put your hours in place you can really
control how much you actually spend that
to me is one of the biggest advantages
to digital marketing not only do you get
real-time results but you can control
costs and then obviously optimize based
on the amount of cost you're spending
based on those real-time results with
traditional marketing it's difficult to
reach a target audience you know with
digital marketing it's easy to reach a
target audience i mean you know i don't
want to bash traditional marketing too
much i mean if you're going to put a tv
ad in place you know you're gonna do it
on a tv show that tends to
gear more towards your target audience
but that doesn't guarantee anything here
we can simply go to facebook or twitter
or linkedin and just pick and choose
specifically who we want to target when
we want to target them so it just
becomes a lot easier to reach a targeted
audience on a digital marketing platform
and then with traditional marketing poor
campaign measurement with digital you
have easy to measure and optimize
campaigns and what we really mean by
that is because you get instant time
results because you can control cost
because you can reach your target
audience more easily all those a result
of okay you can measure and optimize
based on what our audience is seeing and
how much they're spending to see it we
can quickly make adjustments in order to
optimize the campaign for better
performance so that's generally what
that means that's a culmination of
pretty much everything
that we've listed as a benefit for
digital marketing okay so now
why digital marketing has been answered
with all the benefits that
it carries let's talk about the what is
digital marketing so
you know that
you know you want to do digital
marketing so
how do we go about that what what is it
exactly well let's just define it
digital marketing is just the act of
promoting a company's product or an
individual's product or service with the
help of a device or technology and so
obviously when we talk about device
we're talking about maybe a laptop we're
talking about a mobile device when we
talk about technology it could be an app
it could be
you know a cloud-based platform okay it
could be a piece of software okay so
a lot going on on the digital side in
terms of variations and what you can do
but that's in a nutshell what digital
marketing is you're really just using
technology to promote your product or
service so
we know because of the benefits in
digital marketing you can promote your
campaign on different platforms okay so
all those benefits we mentioned about
instant real-time results cost
efficiency
optimizing campaigns you could do that
on search you could do it on social via
email on mobile apps etc so that's what
we mean by with the help of digital
devices and technology well these
digital devices and technology come in
the form of search engines and emails
and mobile apps etc so
when we want to go
and promote our product or service using
a campaign we have different options so
there are different types of digital
marketing channels that we can choose
from and let's just go through that list
of digital marketing channels and the
first one is what i consider the king of
them all and that's seo so seo stands
for search engine optimization there's
search engine marketing there's email
marketing affiliate marketing social
content mobile and then we can get into
subsets of each of these digital
marketing channels but really we'll
start with seo because that's the king
and to me that's basically increasing
the quality and quantity of relevant
organic traffic
on the search engines including google
so depending on where you're located and
the us market google tends or has a
large market share so you want your
pages on your website to be found and
clicked on organically and so that means
that somebody types in a keyword you
want that relevant page to show up first
on google so somebody can click on that
link okay and we know that millions of
people specifically in the us but
worldwide you search on a daily basis so
if you're ranking for those relevant
keywords you can imagine how much
traffic you can get okay so that's seo
okay and here's an example so you type
in online shopping
well you can see the first listing here
is a paid search ad and we're gonna get
to that in a minute the second
organically is amazon okay so online
shopping you think maybe walmart you
think maybe
alibaba or you're thinking probably
amazon okay so no surprise amazon's
ranking for the keyword online shopping
and so if somebody clicked on their
listing that's traffic for amazon let's
move on to search engine marketing you
know known as sem or pay per click or
cost per click or ppc or cpc or
sponsored search or google ads i mean
there's a lot of different names
synonymous with sem so search engine
marketing is really just using paid ads
on search engines just as we saw the
previous example
if you want to be found for keyword you
don't have to worry about organic if
you're willing to pay for it you just
bid on that keyword and voila you have
the opportunity to appear number one in
the search results at the top of the
page for that keyword now when somebody
clicks on it you have to pay google if
it's google you're advertising on but
that's the beauty of search engine
marketing you can bid on keywords and
appear at the top of the search results
for that keyword example here if we go
back to online shopping well
myus.com
is bidding on that keyword online
shopping so they're actually appearing
above amazon's organic listing but
that's what they want to do they want to
be found for that keyword so if they're
not ranking for it organically well
they're bidding on it and if somebody
happened to click on that listing then
myus.com is going to pay google
something depending on what the cost per
click is and so that could be anywhere
from one penny to a hundred dollars it
depends depends on the keyword depends
on who else is bidding on the keyword
depends on the location depends on the
time of day
depends on quality score there's a lot
of factors involved and regarding what
you pay however
the benefit of sem is visibility and
getting traffic to your website for
keywords you're not found for so that's
why sem such a popular choice for a lot
of companies okay let's talk about
digital marketing that's a traditional
type of digital marketing channel it's
been around a long time you know we all
send emails on a daily basis and we
probably all receive emails on a daily
basis this is an effective way to
capture leads and convert them to
customers because with email you can
personalize your emails and you can send
your emails to a segmented audience okay
so if you have emails from
females who are 35 years of age to 44
that live and say this southern part of
the united states you can segment that
and send them an email and cater that
email directly to that audience and of
course you can put some nice call to
action in there you could design it
really snazzy and you could track it
just like you can any other digital
marketing channel so email is a very
effective way to really reach a target
audience because everybody for the most
part has a functioning email account so
basically here's an example of an email
that could go out you're selling a
product and the products promotion is
about to end well you know get that
email out to your target audience let
them know hey you have until tonight to
purchase a product and if you purchase
it you're going to get 30 off and you
can put the coupon code right in there
with a nice call to action and you can
measure how many people click on that
email go to that web page and purchase
the product using that coupon code so
that's an example of email marketing
okay we have affiliate marketing so
affiliate marketing is an effective way
for digital marketers to
basically create a sales force of people
so basically what you're doing is you're
getting
merchants to promote your products and
services and you're using usually a
third-party broker like
commissionjunction or cg.com as an
example to
introduce you
the the person selling the product the
merchant with the affiliate so that
affiliate could likely be a merchant him
or himself and they can basically be a
good partner of yours by publishing your
product or service on their website so
that they can sell in order to get
commissions so it's all based on a
commission so you basically are going to
use a third-party affiliate like cj get
all these affiliates to work for you
they're gonna promote your product or
service if they do sell your product or
service you're gonna pay them a
commission that's more or less how it
works with affiliate marketing and you
know with affiliate marketing to me
it's a good way to you know really
promote your product or service and you
can pick and choose the affiliates or
the publishers of whom you want to work
with so here's an example
of affiliate marketing at work okay you
basically see a banner basically you
could see earn up to 12 advertising fees
with a trusted e-commerce leader okay so
if somebody clicked on that purchase for
example or joined you could pay off that
commission okay let's turn our attention
to social media marketing so social
media marketing you know i would say
it's fairly new i mean if i think about
it we're in 2019
and i remember talking about facebook
back in 2006. so you're talking about 13
14 15 years of social media it's
definitely evolved over the years and
but the concept remains the same it
involves creating different types of
content depending on the platform okay
so you could be on pinterest or
instagram and be dealing with photos or
you could be on twitter tweeting out
certain characters up to a limit okay so
it really depends on the social media
platform uh that really drives the type
of content you're gonna promote but we
know social media can be effective
because people use social media i mean
facebook is one of the more popular
platforms and if you want to get your
product or service out there you can
certainly pay to have an ad on facebook
or you could just post your content
organically okay that's the beauty of
social most of your social platforms
like linkedin and twitter and facebook
and pinterest and instagram they'll have
a paid form of advertising that you can
use to promote your product or service
or you can go the organic route and
you know post content organically in
hopes of driving traffic back to your
website so with social you do have two
options here but social is interesting
because a lot of different social media
platforms out there really depends on
your product or service okay so an
example of social media marketing
especially on facebook with facebook you
got mobile and desktop and you obviously
have the opportunity to post something
organically and have that liked or
commented on or shared or you can post
an ad and get that liked commented or
shared or clicked and have people go
back to your website and fulfill the
goal of what you want them to do so
moving on to content marketing so
content marketing is really an effective
way of really distributing valuable
content online and when we talk about
content marketing you know we're talking
about different types of assets so it
could be simply text in the form of a
blog post or it could be a video or it
could be an an infographic or it could
be an image okay there are lots of ways
to create content these days especially
in digital marketing and the great thing
about content marketing is you're
writing content for a targeted audience
so
if you're trying to targeted audience on
say instagram then you know who your
audience is and you know what the type
of content you're going to post on there
so it could be in the form of a video or
infographic or just a graphic and so
that's the beauty of content marketing
really putting yourself out there um and
depending on the platform putting
yourself out there with various types of
content so for example we look at
youtube
you can see this video here about
digital marketing certified associate
well hey you don't need to always write
the content you can produce the content
in the form of a video and post it on
youtube this is a form of content
marketing so that's content marketing
and then let's talk about mobile
marketing so content marketing again
different types but if we go now to
mobile marketing you can kind of segue
from content to mobile because the only
difference here is with mobile it's
strictly on mobile phone it's not
desktop so mobile marketing is really a
strategy on its own that helps
you the company promoting your product
or service to reach your target audience
through a mobile device and that
includes tablets and how you can do that
is via messaging you could do it via
email or you could be do it via an app
okay so you have different ways of
getting your content out there to people
okay so as an example
you can use basically sms or instant
messaging via mobile devices to promote
your product or service here's another
example
of a mobile marketing via app install
and so you can even compound that by
running a say google ad as an example
and running your google ad on say just
mobile you could do a bid adjustment
just for mobile and the goal could be
app installs okay so and you can even do
a mobile or app extension so there's
lots of ways to
really promote your app or your product
or your service via mobile marketing
okay let's talk about the customer life
cycle
so we know why we want to do digital
marketing we want to know we want we
know
what the digital marketing channels are
because we just talked about them from
seo to social to affiliate to mobile to
content to sem okay you have a lot of
different digital marketing channels at
your disposal so now how do we go ahead
and approach our customers so that's
what we're going to talk about first so
we're going to talk about different
stages of the customer life cycle okay
and the first one is the awareness stage
so we need to get our customers aware of
what we're selling or what we're
promoting okay so the awareness stage is
really
what product does your brand offer
that's a question we want to get out
there and we want to answer okay what
does a customer need your product or
excuse me why does a customer need your
product that's a question we want to
answer with digital marketing okay what
solution does your product provide okay
that's an answer to a question we want
to make sure people understand so these
are questions that we want to be able to
answer in the form of digital marketing
whether that be mobile or content okay
so getting our information out there
that answers these essential questions
and if we could do that then somebody's
going to become aware of our product or
service okay so what product does our
brand offer why does a customer need it
and what solution does it provide okay
those are some key
questions that people tend to ask
themselves when they look at a brand
okay and when they look at a product hey
do i really need this is it gonna help
me in my life okay and who who is
selling this i mean who is this brand i
mean that's those are just things that
run through people's mind intuitively
that with the right messaging
the right channel the right type of
asset the right targeted audience you
can quickly make somebody aware of your
brand's product or service in this stage
it's help potential customers discover
your brand with the help of these
different marketing channels so
in the awareness stage you know content
is key so it's to me if we have a
website we need a blog because if
somebody does come to our blog from say
organic search seo then we can write
about that product or service via blog
and talk to our customer talk directly
to our targeted audience through that
blog and if we're not ranking
organically we can use paid search to
promote it because paid search on google
for example basically we can be right at
the top of the search results and so
somebody can actually see it when they
do a search because we know millions of
people you search on a daily basis you
could do
social media marketing okay so you can
publish that product or service on
facebook while you're building your
community and you can use affiliate
marketing to help get the word out by
using cg.com as an example build up a
sales force of people these publishers
that are going to put your product or
service out there so to me in the
awareness stage these are the
digital marketing channels you can focus
on now i will say one thing about
display ads display is part of search
engine marketing you could use display
because you can reach a large number of
people so even though it's listed here
low priority in the awareness stage
display
ads mean that if you're on google's
display number you could pick and choose
your sites your demographics keywords
topics an audience you can focus on all
those different demographics to really
attract a large number of people so low
priority but it's probably also good to
focus on in the awareness stage okay so
content marketing you must create a high
quality content that people are
searching for without content it's hard
to get found and so to me this is you
know where the blog comes in seo take
that content get it optimized okay sem
if we're not ranking organically we can
make sure we're at the top of the paid
search results or the the search results
for a particular keyword we want to be
found for and then social media
marketing using different channels
depending on the channel if we're
selling you know training like simply
learn does you know linkedin is a good
platform for us okay and then affiliate
you know basically building up a nice
network of publishers to get the word
out so these are all good channels that
we can focus in on so traffic sources
may include paid unpaid social referral
display email or direct so they they
could come in the awareness stage from
all different types of channels even
though you're focused on content i mean
you can still get traffic from mobile or
email so now that we got the word out
via all these different marketing
channels there's that consideration
stage so you know people are aware of us
now they're considering us and that's
kind of the next stage in the process
okay so a few essential questions to
address on the consideration stage hey
what features make your product valuable
to others and how will i increase
customer engagement towards my product
so those are answers to questions you
want to ask okay what features make your
product valuable you want to basically
separate yourself from the competition
basically that's what you're trying to
answer okay so if you're promoting your
product or service on paid search and
other people are bidding on the same
keyword how are you going to stand out
and then how will i increase customer
engagement towards my product so for
example if you're on facebook okay and
you're trying to get people over to your
site to purchase your product then how
are you going to improve that engagement
you got to create something really
snazzy or really it's gonna be attention
grabbing or something that's gonna get
them to become aware of it that's gonna
separate your post from all the other
posts that are in somebody's facebook
newsfeed okay so you really have to work
hard
to really convince somebody to get their
consideration towards your product or
service so in this stage your customer
considers your product so help them
understand how your product is valuable
okay to me email works really good here
because if you have a targeted audience
this gives you the opportunity to really
answer these questions in that
particular channel email you could
support that with the promotion and
display i think display is a good option
here too because even though you know
people are trying to become aware
you know you can really hone in
and really get them to take that next
step okay with display you can even do
remarketing so if somebody's been to
your site because they're aware of your
product they're curious you can cookie
them and remarket to them via display so
display to me is a good a good channel
to use here okay so you have email
mobile display
you know sem these are all you know good
channels to use on the consideration
stage especially on search because
somebody's looking for something and
they're aware of your brand then you
have the good opportunity to get them to
click on your ad especially if you're
offering a promotion and get them to
convert the goal here is to increase our
engagement so
people are aware we're moving them
further along the funnel with email
marketing we have the opportunity to
promote the product by sending an email
directly to our audience so with this
stage plan your campaigns around
welcoming emails newsletters we can talk
about product descriptions add ratings
and reviews in the email you know we
really just want to encourage people to
purchase the product that's we're trying
to sway them over so email is a good
source to allow us to do that so with
mobile marketing we can promote the
products by sending relevant messages to
our target audience display again
retargeting because we can retarget an
audience that has been to our website
already did some research about our
brand our product or service and now
we're going to reach back out to them to
sway them so remember we want to
encourage customers to buy a product by
creating detailed articles about the
product that always helps and that's
content okay we want to opt for a
customer testimonial okay that helps
sway people and add some guest blogging
okay we can have ambassadors blog on our
behalf or we can go out and blog on
somebody else's site okay so blogging
works both ways it's ways of of showing
yourself and telling people hey
we know you're looking for this product
here's why you want to choose us okay
moving on from the consideration to the
purchase stage so they're aware of you
they're considering you and now we're on
to the purchase stage so the questions
we want to really make sure we address
here are how are my prices compared to
my competitors and is my brand more
credible than others okay so they're
considering you but
that price point and it may not even be
the price it could be the shipping for
example the price could be good but the
shipping cost could be high so you
really want to do some due diligence and
research on what your competitors are
doing credibility that goes back to the
consideration stage and testimonials you
want to make sure you have reviews and
testimonials to really elevate what
you're trying to tell customers and that
that is hey i have a good brand i have a
good product i have a good service come
buy my stuff come buy my product and
service but you really need to support
that claim you just can't go out and say
it and so supporting that comes in the
form of what other people say and that
could be reviews that could be on a
social media platform it could be you
know stars on say yelp or google my
business you know make sure you do your
due diligence and make sure
you get people to you know review you or
provide testimonials because people are
going to do their due diligence before
they purchase especially if it's on
google my business or yelp or
tripadvisor or whatever it is you're
trying to sell they're going to be able
to see those reviews and so do your due
diligence to get the reviews and if it
is a negative review hey that's okay you
can't please everyone you're gonna get
them that's the world we live in just
make sure you show your upper hand and
respond even to the negative as well as
the positive reviews that you get that
actually bodes well to some people
because hey it shows that i made a
mistake and you're willing to correct it
and so people actually see that that
could be the tipping point to getting
them to purchase hey look hey this brand
really cares because they're really
responding to people they're not
ignoring negativity okay just those
small things that can get people to
change their mind now with the purchase
stage according to e-consultancy 83 of
the online audience require
encouragement to complete a purchase
encouragement what does that mean well
it could mean providing a promo giving
them that extra incentive you know if
you don't offer promo consider it
especially on the email and the example
we looked at earlier sending in an email
means that if the promo is going to end
at midnight send that email out and tell
people they have until midnight and if
they purchase today you'll even increase
it to 20 percent an email is a good
channel for that mobile can reach a lot
of people through sms okay social media
reaching people instantaneously
and then you know really with the
purchase stage it gives pro prospects an
offer to help them make that purchase so
you have plenty of channels to choose
from in fact most of these channels the
only one really that doesn't fit the
instantaneous mode is seo but you can
really focus on affiliate even though
that's a little priority here you can
really you know coordinate with your
publishers who especially those
publishers that have proven their worth
and have sold your products in the past
you get them to help promote it and
incentivize their audience so let's move
on from the purchase to the purse post
purchase stage so this is after somebody
purchases
okay so some essential questions we want
to be able to address here so what
additional product could my customer buy
now that they're my customer what else
could i sell them what you know without
being too pushy could if they buy a coat
well a hat work or a pair of gloves or
you know blouse you know you want to be
able to
not push a product on your customer but
think about how you can complement that
purchases that purchasers or customers
product and then how to improve the
customer buying experience so
again this goes back to you know what we
just said about reviews get somebody to
offer a review and if they don't give
you
a full compliment of five stars they
only give you three and a half stars
then you know what that's great feedback
because then you can learn from that and
then the other question is will the
customer refers to others and if so why
so that's
definitely something you want to be able
to address in the post purchase stage so
let's take a look here so with post
purchasing stage you know to me emails
at the top of this list because if
somebody purchases something you can
send a nice thank you email because if
they purchase they're giving you their
email in return because you're likely
going to be sending them the receipt via
email so email to me is a nice
channel you send in a nice message even
you know social media you know you can
thank your community for supporting you
on this recent campaign that you ran you
know even throwing an extra five or ten
percent on a future purchase is a thank
you and that's easily done on social
media
you know you could even post a blog you
know promoting you know the success of a
product and then offering a promotion
okay so there's a lot of things you
could be doing here on the post
purchasing stage so to me even looking
at content again you could even you know
put a survey together you could even put
a survey together for your affiliates
okay you could even post a poll on
facebook so it's just working in with
these different channels to get some
feedback about your product and service
so with email mobile you can engage
customers with follow-up emails or
customer care content you know with
mobile if you have somebody's mobile
number hey text them a simple thank you
goes a long way you know you could say
hey look if you're satisfied let us know
give us a call you can even in the ee
mobile text message you can put a link
to a survey send emails to active
subscribers give rewards for customer
feedback so if somebody does provide
feedback give him an extra 10 off you
know you want to be able to reward
loyalty loyalty comes in the form of a
partnership if you're giving somebody
discounts and you have a good product or
service then they're going to recognize
that they're going to say hey look i
really like this product and they're
giving me 10 i'm going to go ahead and
purchase from these guys again so give
those discounts to those active
customers or on the affiliate network
give referral opportunities to your
customers so if it's an affiliate
publisher hey if they're getting people
to your site you know reward them or if
it's an email and you put a four to a
friend get an extra 10 off it doesn't
hurt because you're incentivizing people
to help you sell your product so with
social display and content use those
banner ads or
use that content that you display on
social or the blog you're going to write
to give customers advice in order to
maximize the value of the purchase so
again you can use these platforms to
also enhance uh what they purchased so
hey you just purchased this product
thank you very much did you know you
could do this this and this with it and
so that's the idea of a post-purchase
stage is to maximize these channels to
be able to answer those essential
questions about what else could they
purchase you know do they like how do i
get these people to become loyal
customers okay so with the first
purchase stage if a customer has bought
a pair of sports shoes for example
running shoes you can recommend cross
product sale a cross sale it could be a
pair of shorts or a water bottle or an
accessory with an exclusive discount so
that's another example what you can do
on the post purchase stage in this
session we'll be covering some of the
most important marketing books for
entrepreneurs
digital marketing is a field that will
probably never go out of style and
thanks to this there is always going to
be people searching for new innovations
and techniques to make the process
easier which means that alongside
courses tutorials and your own work
experience you will need a little more
to bring about true innovation
that's where marketing book comes in so
let's ask the most important question
probably on your mind why should i be
reading these books
the marketing books that we are going to
talk about here and the marketing books
in general are a collection of data and
experiences from goliaths within the
industry
these books provide a window to the time
period they were written in and help you
understand how marketing is still in
some ways extremely similar to how
things work back then albeit with more
technology nowadays
you will also soon see that the books
that we revere the most when it comes to
marketing are the ones that were written
in the period of the early 60s to 90s an
era where the lives we live now would
have been impossible to imagine that's
what makes these books so special the
time period and some of the methods may
have changed but the concepts and rules
covered in these books have stood the
test of time and are timeless
let's now start with number 12
contagious by jana berger
a new york times bestseller this book is
perfect for someone looking to
understand how to spread ideas increase
brand awareness or even to grow their
customer base
it goes on to explain why certain ideas
products and stories get shared and grow
in popularity
why only certain emails and videos get
forwarded and much more
contagious also goes into detail about
the six basic principles that contribute
to content becoming viral or contagious
from products initiatives youtube videos
and more
it also provides actionable and specific
techniques to spread information
designing messages and more
now let's talk about jana berger he's a
marketing professor at the wharton
school at the university of pennsylvania
he's an expert in concepts like word of
mouth how consumer behavior can be
influenced how stories ideas and
products catch on and much more
he's also been a keynote speaker in
several prominent events and consults
companies like google apple nike and
more
now let's have a look at number 11
hooped by neral
this book called a critical work in the
field of psychological marketing is one
that delves into how habit-forming
products can be built
years of analyzing startups have led ner
to understand the customers can be
influenced
this led to the creation of the hook
model
this book talks about how the hook model
which is a four step process can enable
companies to subtly encourage particular
customer behavior
it also provides practical insights into
how the hook can be used to create user
habits that will get them further hooked
onto your product
the book also provides steps to create
such a product
finally the book also provides examples
as to how companies like iphone twitter
and pinterest hook their users
now let's talk about nirail
starting off his career in the gaming
and advertising industry nir created
different techniques through which he
could motivate and manipulate users
he also helps create behaviors that can
benefit users while educating people to
build healthy habits
he is also an active angel investor in
companies like canva everbright kahoot
and more
now for number 10 we have the conversion
code by chris smith
this book recommended by digital
marketing guru neil patel is one that
focuses on helping users to increase
sales in this internet driven era
it guides users on tips to perform
online lead generation and inside sales
it also details the many ways companies
can engage with their consumers bait
media mobile apps and blogs and how to
be effective at it
the book also focuses on leveraging the
strengths of social media apps and blogs
to capture more leads for less money
like i mentioned earlier the main focus
in this book is to convert more internet
leads into real-world prospects and
sales appointments
let's now talk about chris smith he's a
best-selling author and co-founder of a
blog called curator which is a social
media digital marketing and coaching
company
his work has been featured in a number
of major publications like adweek and
forbes he's also a in-demand keynote
speaker and is often on real estate
industrialists as one of the most
influential people within the
industry next up number nine designing
brand entity by alina wheeler call the
comprehensive pragmatic and easy to
understand resource for brand builders
by the global brand leader of deloitte
this book mainly focuses on the
fundamentals processes and case studies
behind creating a brand
it covers more than 100 branding
subjects checklists tools and diagrams
the book also acts as a compendium for
tools that can make the branding process
a success and some of the best practices
that will get you some inspiration
the book also has 50 case studies
describing goals processes strategies
solutions and results
now
let's talk about the author alina
wheeler alina wheeler is a prominent
speaker who guides teams with everything
brand related from brand fundamentals
processes best practices and much more
she's also been coaching business
leaders and design consultancies and has
worked with more than 100 companies
within the private and public sector
now let's go to number eight gets crappy
by nick westgard
called a digital marketing bible by
publishers weekly
this book helps smaller companies with
lesser resources to develop powerhouse
results
it also aims to help teams to think like
underdogs and to leverage the right
social networks and the appropriate
digital marketing tools
and to effectively reach people
it also focuses on integrating the
marketing strategy across touch points
for a unified brand experience both
online and off
now let's talk about the author nick
westgard
nick has helped brands grow from small
businesses fortune 500 companies to
president obama's jobs council
he's also a regular contributor to the
harvard business review u.s news and
world report entrepreneur
forbes
mashable and more he is also a member of
the boards of the university of iowa
school of journalism and mass
communication
the iowa city area chamber of commerce
and film scene
next we have number seven
how to win friends and influence people
in the digital age by dale carnegie
published in 1936
the book has been number 8 on the list
of the top checkouts of all time by new
york public library
despite its age the many concepts are
still relevant and have been updated to
fit modern requirements
the book lays out powerful and timeless
principles of human communications that
have impacted millions
the essentials of engagement affirming
what's good connecting with core desires
and other concepts are elaborated on
the book also explains how to make a
lasting impression to merit and maintain
trust in how to lead change
now let's talk about dale carnegie
he's a writer and lecturer and the
developer of courses dealing with
self-improvement
salesmanship corporate training public
speaking interpersonal skills and much
more by the time of carnegie's death in
1955 his book had sold
5 million copies in 31 languages and
there had been 4 lakh 50 000 graduates
of his dale carnegie institute
now for number six
positioning by al riese and jack trout
this book released in 2001 called one of
the most popular marketing books ever
released still keeps up with the current
marketing landscape
it details how brands can make their
product an industry leader it explains
strategies that can capture a large
market share and to build their
strategies around the competitors
weaknesses
the book also helps to analyze and
incorporate data from trends
now let's talk about already and jack
trout
already is an author and marketing
professional credited with resurrecting
the idea of positioning in marketing
jack trout was a marketer who was one of
the founders and pioneers of marketing
warfare theory and positioning theory
next for number five epic content
marketing by joe polizzi
this book called one of fortune
magazine's top five business book
must reads explains how to attract
customers and lead them to your
businesses by creating relevant content
the book helps determine what your
brand's content niche is
and what you need to do to keep their
attention
the book can help discover and develop
your content marketing mission statement
and to set up a process to create and
curate content
it also explains how to leverage social
media and email channels to create and
grow your audience
now let's talk about joe polizzi he's an
author and an authority when it comes to
content marketing
he founded the content marketing
institute and launched several events
one among them being content marketing
world
he also won the 2014 john caldwell
lifetime achievement award by the
content council
next up we have number four crushing it
by gary vaynerhook
a new york times bestseller this book
helps people build a personal brand and
how to achieve their goals
the book explains the many ways social
media platforms can be taken advantage
of by organizations to make a personal
brand for themselves
it provides tricks and tweaks to enhance
these strategies
it also provides tactical and
theoretical advice on how to become a
star on social media and podcast
services
it also details examples from real life
scenarios and how they were handled
let's talk about gary vaynerhook
he's an investor and advisor for several
startups across the world he's also an
expert on fortune 500 companies he also
runs vaynermedia a digital marketing
agency that helps companies like ge
pepsico hasbro the new york jets and
more
now for number three ogilvy on
advertising by davidor kelvey
this book written by david ogilvy who
was known as the most sought after
wizard in the industry by time magazine
was released in 1983.
this consists of concepts that remain
valid to this day
it covers a number of different facets
of advertising and covers the four
foundational principles of advertising
it also covers the author's experiences
working with many prominent brands of
the era
let's take a look at david ogilvy
he was a british advertising tycoon and
the founder of ogilway and mathur
he was called the father of advertising
he introduced the concept of branding to
advertising and focused on the
importance of the creative copy and
campaign themes
now for number two
the 22 immutable laws of marketing by
already and jack trout
this book covers 22 innovative rules
that help with understanding and
succeeding in an international
marketplace
the book provides insight into several
concepts that are still relevant today
it also details 22 superlative tools and
innovative techniques for the
international marketplace
and now for number one
scientific advertising by claude c
hopkins
this book released in 1923 has been
cited as the must read book by several
advertising personalities like david
ogilvy gary halbert and jay abraham
it's credited with providing the
original description for split testing
and copen based customer tracking and
loyalty programs
it also details an advertising approach
that ensures reduced losses from
unsuccessful ads and gains from
profitable ads are multiplied
now
let's talk about the author claude c
hopkins
he was known as an advertising pioneer
and was known as leader in the creation
and development of modern day consumer
brand advertising and direct response
marketing
he was inducted into the advertising
hall of fame in 1957.
before we get on to talking about mobile
marketing let's have a look at some
stats related to mobile marketing
first off mobile devices are used for
over 40 percent of online transactions
next we have marketers and advertisers
put 51 percent of their budget into
mobile ads
and finally mobile is responsible for an
average of more than 40 percent of
revenue in leading b2b organizations so
what is mobile marketing
mobile marketing is a digital marketing
strategy that started all the way in
1992. remember sms's that advertise
stuff that's what mobile marketing
started off as the main objective with
mobile marketing is to advertise
products and services to a target
audience to multiple channels on
smartphones tablets and other mobile
devices
this is done through websites emails sms
social media in-app notifications and
other applications
so here are key concepts related to
mobile marketing
first we have focusing on the customer
and personalized marketing
in mobile marketing the primary focus is
on the customer want them to increase
brand loyalty give customers special
offers or show them personalized ads
based on their location and purchase
history
basically by focusing on the customer it
gives them the feeling that the brand is
directly interacting with them and as a
result their loyalty towards the brand
greatly increases
next we have identifying trends with
data by leveraging data different trends
can be identified from there you can
create customer profiles and then with
predictive and behavior analysis you get
an understanding of what will better
grab the attention of a customer
then we have testing
testing provides insights and learnings
that would be extremely important to the
success of the campaign for example say
you do an a b test with that you'll get
the optimal variant of the two as well
as further understanding of what works
and what isn't
and finally understanding mobile
analytics
having some experience with mobile
analytics with some of the metrics that
need to be focused on like engagement
ratio cost per install and average
revenue per user are very important for
mobile marketing
experience with mobile analytics tools
can also help with insights that would
help future decisions and experiments
so if you're interested in getting
certified in mobile marketing you have
options like mobile app marketing 2020
aso advertising and monetization by
udemy and you also have digital
marketing specialist certification by
simply learn
now let's go to number nine crm or
customer relationship management
here are some interesting stats
it is stated that towards the end of
2019 86 percent of customers are willing
to pay 25 percent more for better
customer experience
also crm marketing will be worth 73
billion dollars in 2020.
finally businesses that leverage crm
software see sales increase by 29
sales productivity increased by 34
percent and sales forecast accuracy
increased by 42
now that we have looked into these stats
let's understand what crm is all about
crm is a technology with which an
organization's relationships and
interactions with existing or potential
customers are managed
it's basically a collection of
strategies tools and technologies and
crms aim to develop new customer
relationships retain them or require new
ones
along with that it also helps companies
with sales marketing and service
management
crms mainly store data like purchase
history personal information and
purchasing patterns
so here are a few areas to focus in crm
first we have data analytics crms
provide a number of different metrics
that can be analyzed and whose results
can be incorporated into forthcoming
campaigns
now although what metric you focus on
entirely depends on your requirements
here are some of the commonly used
metrics
there's customer churn which is
basically customer attrition there's nps
which is a measure of how satisfied your
customers are
best customer retention cost and first
contact resolution rate which is the
percentage of customer support tickets
that get resolved at the first shot
next understanding how different crm
tools work
there are loads of options to choose
from when it comes to crms there's
salesforce hubspot crm zoho crm
microsoft dynamics and much more
it is really important to have
experienced at least the most commonly
used ones since each of them have their
own nuances advantages and disadvantages
now let's have a look at some of the
certifications
we have options like salesforce
administrator certification training
course by simplylearn dynamics 365 by
microsoft and finally hubspot academy
sales professional credential by hubspot
so now let's go to number eight
at number eight we have designing
like usual let's have a look at some of
the stats
did you know that 32 percent of
marketers saying visual images are the
most important form of content for their
business with blogging in second
well 70 of companies invest in content
marketing which could include visual
marketing strategies
so now let's take a closer look at
designing
with designing the objective is to
communicate as well as promote the
products or services the brand is
advertising in a visually appealing
manner
designing goes hand in hand with a great
copy though
even if you had the best looking
creative in your ad it's possible it
won't catch on if the copy accompanying
it isn't good you might wonder what does
designing have to do with digital
marketing plenty actually if you have an
understanding of designing yourself in
the scenario where graphic designers are
unable to bring your idea to life you
could do it yourself desiring for
yourself what the content will convey
not only that you might be able to
provide some insight in the designing of
the creative for the ad
next let's have a look at key concepts
of designing
firstly a basic understanding of design
philosophies are necessary which means
you need to know about concepts like
using attention grabbing and relevant
images the golden point rule and much
more
then there needs to be an understanding
of tools like adobe photoshop and after
effects
these are some of the most commonly used
tools for creating creatives and even
the basic experience with these software
could be extremely useful later on
now let's have a look at some
certifications
we have certifications like graphic
design by coursera introduction to
graphic design by linkedin and
fundamentals of graphic design again by
coursera
next at number seven we have listening
now let's talk about social listening
social listening is a method through
which a brand can learn about what
customers are saying about them and the
industry online by monitoring digital
conversations
the brand's social media channels can
track analyze and respond to
conversations and feedback improving
their relationship with the users who
may become potential customers and thus
increasing loyalty of present customers
and it's a proven fact that customers
are drawn towards brands that are prompt
in response
now let's have a look at some key
concepts understanding how different
social media platforms work how is each
platform different from the other
where does most of your audience come
from which platform is better suited for
your content those are the questions
that need to be answered
then experience with popular social
listening tools like hubspot and
hootsuite these platforms can help with
a number of different situations like pr
crisis respond to customer complaints
find user generated content to obtain
competitive intelligence take
suggestions and much more
next at number six we have copywriting
first let's have a look at some stats
it is stated that 64 percent of b2b
marketers outsource their demanding copy
needs
next it also says that a compelling copy
draws 7.8 times more site traffic and
produces brand recall which brings
higher engagement rates
now let's talk about what is copywriting
copywriting is an act of creating
promotional texts that could be
advertised in brochures notifications
billboards emails and so on
the primary objective here is that the
written content called copy or sales
copy increases brand awareness and
persuades individuals to take a
particular action be it signing up to a
website buy a product and so on
now let's have a look at some key
concepts of copywriting
first understanding the customers and
the competition so from the customers
several bits of vital information can be
obtained like what kind of writing gets
the maximum amount of engagement what
kind they dislike and much more
likewise from the competition you can
find out what kind of writing they have
success with what they are doing better
from your brand and so on this one goes
without saying but to have success with
copywriting you need to be well versed
with grammar and have sufficiently good
writing skills
let's have a look at some certifications
now
here we have the creative copywriter
academy then we have the idm award in
digital copywriting by the institute of
data and marketing
and finally we have american writers and
artists copywriting course
next up number five email marketing
first let's have a look at some stats
according to statista in 2019 global
email users amounted to 3.9 million by
2023 this is set to grow to 4.3 billion
next it also states that 81
smbs rely on email as their primary
customer accusation channel and 80 for
retention
next again by statista it states that 49
of consumers would like to receive
promotional emails from their favorite
brands
so now let's have a look at email
marketing
email marketing is a method for
performing digital marketing by using
emails to promote products and services
to a highly targeted audience
in a way email marketing could nurture
the relationship with your customers or
completely drive them away
with email marketing customers can be
communicated with directly with
personalized emails helping them stay
updated with items or offers
it also serves a purpose of informing
people about your brand or keeping
existing customers engaged between
purchases
now let's have a look at key concepts
first we have focusing on
personalization and automation
emails can be set up in such a way that
customers are regularly sent emails on a
regular basis to keep in touch with them
inform them about new products and other
forms of engagement
then we have complying with data privacy
rules
privacy has been the talking point for a
while now most recently the gdpr brought
about a number of restrictions that have
to be adhered to by organizations
so it's absolutely necessary that these
privacy guidelines are followed or would
you rather spend 10 million pounds
next experimenting with different kinds
of content
emails can have images gifs or videos
attached to them and each of them can
impact your customer base in a different
manner depending on their requirements
so different kinds of content need to be
experimented with to determine the one
that works best for you
and finally understanding popular tools
and metrics to be successful at email
marketing it is absolutely necessary to
be experienced with tools like hubspot
and mailchimp
these platforms come with a number of
features like contact segmenting
autoresponders service and app
integration a b testing and much
more next up we have certifications
here we have certifications like hubspot
academy email marketing by hubspot then
email and affiliate marketing mastermind
by utemi and finally advanced email
marketing certification training by
simply learn
so now that we have reached midway i
have a question for you guys what do you
guys think is in the number one section
let me know in the live chat i'd like to
know what you guys think
if you enjoy watching informative tech
videos like this one consider
subscribing to simply learn's channel to
stay up to date on the trending
technologies and hit the bell icon to
never miss an update in the future
now back to number 4 social media
marketing
before we go in let's have a look at
some stats
according to statista nearly 50 of the
world's population uses social media
73 percent of marketers believe social
media marketing has been somewhat
effective or very effective for their
business
lastly 90.4 percent of millennials 77.5
percent of generation x and 48.2 percent
of baby boomers are active social media
users
so now let's have a look at social media
marketing
social media marketing involves the
usage of social media platforms to build
a brand drive traffic to your website
and increase sales
this helps marketers achieve their
marketing and branding goals by creating
and sharing content on social media
activities like text and image updates
video and other content that can drive
engagement social media marketing also
enables marketers to perform paid
advertising with this your brand's
content like articles videos and images
are exposed to a high quality targeted
audience
next let's have a look at some key
concepts of social media marketing
first understanding how to work with
different social media platforms is
necessary
every social media platform comes with
its own kind of audience nuances
advantages and disadvantages so it's
important to have experience with them
so that the one that best suits your
requirements can be selected
next we have monetization
on youtube which is also a social media
platform you could monetize your videos
to get some income out of them other
options include affiliate marketing
influencer marketing events and much
more
then we have analytics experience with
social media marketing tools like buffer
and buzzsumo can help organizations by
providing alerts based on keywords brand
names links domain and much more
among other things it also tracks
competitors and analyzes their content
to determine what they are doing better
then we have knowing your brand's user
base and optimizing your content it's
important to understand your brand's
user base to determine what they like
the most on your social media page and
then optimize it
now let's have a look at some
certifications
here we have advanced social media
certification training by simply learn
then we have social media marketing on
linkedin learning and finally hootsuite
social marketing certification by
hootsuite
and now for the top three number three
pay-per-click of ppc first let's have a
look at some stats
33 percent of people click on paid
search at because it directly answers
their search query
it also states that paid ads have a
11.38
ctr on google
and finally according to google
businesses make an average of two
dollars in income for every one dollar
they spend in google ads
now let's talk about ppc
it is a form of online advertising in
which advertisers spend a certain amount
of money each time their advertisement
is clicked this process if done properly
can drive people to your website without
having to get them organically
search engine marketing is one of the
most popular methods to perform ppc
for ppc most search engines are part of
an automated process performed by the
search engine to determine how relevant
and valid they are to appear in the
search engine result page
now let's have a look at some key
concepts of ppc
first it's important how different
search engines and their advertising
works each of them have their own but
somewhat similar rules prices
restrictions and so on
then we have google ads one of the most
popular and lucrative players among the
search engines google ads provides
marketers with a sizable chunk of the
internet to advertise to
it is important to properly understand
how google ads works and how its many
features and functionalities can be used
efficiently
for more on google ads why don't you
check our introductory video on it i'll
link it in the chat
next analytics different metrics like
cpc or cost per click clicks
click-through rate and quality score
need to be understood so that optimal
and well-informed decisions can be made
finally we have copywriting and visual
design ability as i mentioned earlier
either of these don't work without the
other which means the experience in both
these concepts would be greatly
beneficial for the individual and the
organization
now let's have a look at some
certifications
we have google ads certifications by
google then advanced pay per click ppc
certification training by simply learn
and finally we have microsoft and
excellence program by microsoft
now for the top two search engine
optimization
let's first look at some stats
according to zero limit web on the first
page alone the first five organic
results account for 67.60
of all the clicks
and according to google where to buy
plus near me mobile queries have grown
by over 200 percent in the past two
years
and finally according to hubspot 57 of
b2b marketers stated that seo generates
more leads than any other marketing
initiative
so what exactly is search engine
optimization
search engine optimization or seo refers
to the method adopted by an organization
to grow the quality and quantity of
website traffic by making it more
visible to the users of a particular web
search engine
this is possible with the help of
organic search results seo improves
unpaid results and doesn't count traffic
obtained from paid ads
next let's have a look at some key
concept of seo
technical seo the technical side of seo
like server side settings site maps
server response code rewrites and so on
will help you take advantage of both
page level and server level optimization
to ensure they are found by search
engines this by extension helps generate
traffic and conversions
next content marketing it is important
to be well-versed in content marketing
as both seo and content marketing cannot
exist without the other
content marketing provides high quality
content and seo provides the appropriate
keywords that would help it get noticed
by search engines
next link building
the process of search engine
optimization can only be successful if
there's a combination of both external
link building and internal link
optimization
one builds links with credible websites
and the other performs link optimization
on your own properties and social media
platforms
now we have site usability seo must
focus on good site usability this is an
indication of how objects are placed in
your website and if the information
provided is useful for the users
it also indicates if the site is easy to
use and navigate
then you need to have experience with
tools like moz and google analytics to
take appropriate inferences from the
data obtained
and finally we have google analytics and
google webmaster
google analytics will help with tracking
and reporting website traffic google
webmaster will help track your website's
search performance with the help of
google search console and additional
resources
now let's have a look at some
certifications
here we have seo training course by mers
which is provided by udemy and we have
search engine optimization training
course by simply learn and finally we
have hubspot seo training course
provided by hubspot
finally number one it's data analytics
data analysis is a process which looks
into collecting and organizing data by
doing so helpful conclusions are drawn
these conclusions can be incorporated
into the upcoming campaigns of the
organization
the information that is analyzed is
collected with the help of analytical
and logical reasoning
here are some key concepts of data
analysis first understanding popular
data analytics tools like apache spark
tableau and sas can be greatly helpful
in the process of data analysis
then we have google analytics google
analytics is a tool that helps
businesses analyze their website it
records activities of users visiting
your website along with additional
information like their age gender and
interests
this is then sent to the google
analytics server and then can be used by
you to make decisions regarding upcoming
campaigns
then we have data visualization
data visualization enables data to be
translated into a chart graph or other
visual component
understanding data visualization would
help with understanding data in a quick
and clean manner
it enables brands to identify emergent
trends and to respond to it quickly
with it the brand story can also be
shared with others thanks to being able
to create a narrative with graphics and
diagrams
and finally a clear understanding of
data structures fundamentals and basic
statistics can greatly ease the process
of data analysis
now let's have a look at some
certifications here we have introduction
to data analytics for business by
coursera then we have data analyst
masters program by simplylearn and
finally we have micromasters program and
marketing analytics by edx today i'm
going to tell you how you can become a
digital marketer so first off let's
answer the most important question who
is a digital marketer now a digital
marketer is responsible for several
things let's go through some of them
first off they're responsible to develop
as well as manage marketing campaigns to
ensure that the goals of the
organization are fulfilled they need to
create a marketing strategy which is
based on analyzing their competition as
well as the benchmarks within the
industry they need to drive website
traffic as well as acquire leads which
are then worked upon by the organization
or the business they need to utilize web
analytics tools so that they can measure
and optimize the campaign which is
basically figuring out how well the
campaign is doing and if it's not doing
well how they can make it better and
finally they need to be able to enhance
brand awareness which is just letting
people know that the brand exists and
how the brand can make their lives
better next up let's talk about how to
become a digital marketer to become a
digital marketer you need a certain set
of skills skills like search engine
optimization search engine marketing or
sem email marketing social media
marketing affiliate marketing content
marketing and finally mobile marketing
so the first step you need to take to
become a digital marketer is to learn
seo so seo or search engine optimization
is the process of increasing the quality
of your organic traffic which is nothing
but the traffic that comes to your
website without having seen any paid
advertisements just because your website
is one of the first few results when
they search a particular query on a
search engine seo involves on-page seo
as well as off-page seo so how to do
on-page seo first off you need to do
keyword research keyword research is one
of the most important steps when it
comes to seo it is the process of
identifying popular words and phrases
used on search engines by users you need
to be able to identify keywords with
high search volume high relevancy and
low competition next up we have
technical audit so search engines around
the world have internet bots performing
a particular process known as crawling
in this process these search engine
internet bots these search engine bots
also known as spiders scan a website and
copy the entire website's content and
store it within the search engine for it
to index now you need to ensure your
site is being crawled and indexed next
you have onsite optimization you need to
develop high quality content meta tags
url and sitemaps and finally user
experience you need to provide good
website architecture as well as internal
linking structure next up let's talk
about how to do off-page seo this is
made possible with the help of link
building this is the process of
navigating links from other websites to
your own and by building external links
to your website your organic search
ranking can be improved now let's talk
about some seo tools you have moz google
keyword planner semrush and ahrefs now
let's talk about the next step required
to become a digital marketer which is to
learn sem or search engine marketing
search engine marketing is a practice of
marketing a business using paid
advertisements on search engines and
other websites so basically this is a
way of attracting users towards your
website or a particular product that
you're offering so how can you do sem or
search engine marketing first off you
need to determine your goal and define a
budget you need to ensure that you have
a goal in mind for example do you want
more leads do you want to increase
traffic or improve brand awareness and
much more after you're done with that
you need to define a budget how much
money are you ready to spend to achieve
this goal then you need to choose a list
of relevant keywords which is keywords
on which you'll be bidding to advertise
you need to finalize your keywords and
then bid on them which is basically are
you ready to pay for how many clicks
you're getting or for acquiring
customers or making them leads and so on
you need to create a compelling headline
for your ad campaign you need to monitor
the performance of campaigns and measure
results which is basically finding out
whether the campaign is working out well
and if it's not to optimize it so that
it works the next time and you need to
target your audience with remarketing
campaigns for example if a customer does
not go through with the conversion
process they can be added to the
remarketing audience so that they can be
advertised to again some of the popular
sem tools are google adwords editor fb
ads manager bing ads and ad role now for
the next step to become a digital
marketer you have to learn email
marketing now email marketing is a
really efficient as well as inexpensive
way to generate high return on
investment it can be used to convert
prospects into customers by sending
personalized emails to a targeted
audience so how do you perform email
marketing first off you need to discover
your target audience and create segments
in which you can divide them depending
on their behavior you need to select and
create your type of campaign depending
on the goals you want to achieve you
need to select a suitable design for
your campaign you need to have a
compelling subject line and email
content which is very important when it
comes to email marketing you need to
send campaigns immediately or schedule
an email and finally you need to measure
results such as open rate click through
rate response rate and so on you also
need to perform a b testing to find out
what works and what doesn't some of the
popular email marketing tools are
mailchimp hubspot marketo send in blue
and so on and now for the next step you
need to learn social media marketing
social media marketing involves the
promotion of your product and services
on different social media platforms
using different types of content now
this could be just sponsored posts video
advertisements images articles and so on
now how can you do social media
marketing first off you need to choose a
suitable social media platform for your
business it could be facebook youtube
twitter linkedin and so on next up you
need to find your target audience now
each of these platforms has a particular
niche that occupies it now for example
facebook requires an active social media
marketing strategy pinterest is usually
used by females linkedin can be used for
employee networking and youtube is a
platform where people create as well as
share video content and that's the only
content that works on youtube you need
to create as well as curate engaging
content because without your content
being engaging nobody's going to be
interested in your product or service
then you need to choose a social media
management tool and finally you need to
test evaluate and optimize your results
now let's talk about some popular social
media marketing tools we have hootsuite
tweet deck buffer sprout social and so
many more now for your next step to
becoming a digital marketer you need to
learn affiliate marketing now affiliate
marketing is a form of digital marketing
that involves two players a merchant as
well as an affiliate now a merchant is
an individual who pays a commission to
the affiliate who could be a third party
site or entity to drive sales bring
leads or new customers with the help of
referrals now how can you do affiliate
marketing first off you need to choose a
tool through which you can find
affiliates who can advertise your
product now you need to choose affiliate
on the basis of how much traffic the
affiliate website gets how successful
the affiliate's previous campaigns were
and and how much commission the
affiliate asks for then you need to
specify the format that the affiliate
must use when they're advertising your
product or service you need to keep a
record of the customers who purchased
your product or service through the
affiliate and finally pay the affiliate
based on the commission rates now let's
talk about some of the popular affiliate
marketing tools there's cj affiliate
volume has offers and even now for the
next step to becoming a digital marketer
you need to learn mobile marketing now
mobile marketing enables a business to
communicate with a targeted audience
through any mobile device this is
through sms emails mms's and so on so
how do you do mobile marketing first off
you need to create a mobile buyer
persona which is you know what kind of
person is using the phone you need to
set business goals like what goals
basically determining what goals you
want to achieve with the mobile
marketing campaign then you need to
conduct your campaign and reach your
target audience with a personalized
message to these users and finally you
need to monitor these metrics and
optimize them if required now let's talk
about some popular mobile marketing
tools there's slick text localities
admob facebook mobile ads and much more
now for your next step in becoming a
digital marketer you need to learn
content marketing content marketing is a
bull marketing technique of creating as
well as sharing valuable content now
this could be blogs videos or articles
which solves the problem of the target
audience this holds their attention by
adding value to their lives and can end
up converting their interest into a
purchase so how do you do content
marketing firstly you need to define
your goals as in what you want to
achieve you need to define your target
audience then you need to determine what
kind of content you are creating it
could be blog posts ebooks case studies
infographics and so on you need to
brainstorm for new content ideas you
need to perform a content audit which is
to evaluate content elements and
information assets and choose a suitable
content management system now you can
plan create publish and measure your
results all in one place using a content
management system using a content
management system such as the hubspot
software next you need to promote your
content using email affiliate and social
media marketing finally you need to
measure your success and optimize your
content now let's talk about some of the
popular content marketing tools there's
linkedin pulse paper.li flipboard
traffic and many many more now let's
talk about some additional resources now
there are a huge number of videos online
about digital marketing and i recommend
you go through some of them so that you
have a basic idea about their
fundamentals now this is where simply
learn's youtube channel can help you you
can take advantage of simplylearn's
digital marketing tutorials you can go
to this playlist right here and here you
have tutorials on what is seo how you
can rank number one on google keywords
research facebook ads tutorial how you
can rank your youtube videos facebook
advertising tips and tricks social media
marketing google tag manager google
analytics and so much more now let's
have a look at the salaries of a digital
marketer in the united states the
average salary of a digital marketer is
approximately 65 000 dollars per year
similarly the average salary for a
digital marketer in india is
approximately 5 lakh rupees per year now
let's talk about how you can become a
certified digital marketer now there are
a number of different certifications
available for you there's the google ads
fundamental certification the facebook
certified planning professional
certification the hubspot content
marketing certification the hootsuite
social marketing certification and
simply learns digital marketing
specialist masters program now here's
another way simple learn can help you
simply learn has a number of different
digital marketing certification has a
number of different digital marketing
certifications let's talk about the
digital marketing specialist masters
program in this program there are a
number of different certifications such
as the digital marketing certified
associate advanced web analytics
advanced seo and so on the certification
also provides the omcp certification
exam voucher worth 395 dollars upon the
completion of the master's program it
has 45 plus projects and can help you
get a salary of close to 17 lakhs per
annum it is also accredited by hootsuite
facebook the omcp and so on so now let's
have a closer look at the digital
marketing course or the digital
marketing certified associate
certification training now this
certification provides 53 hours of
instructor-led training 40-plus hours of
self-paced videos instructor-led online
project mentoring sessions helping you
prep for examinations from the omca
google ads and so on it has industry
accreditations from hootsuite facebook
and the omcp and it covers more than 35
tools such as facebook insights youtube
analytics crazy egg google keyword
planner google ad manager linkedin ads
buffer semrush and so on so why don't
you go on to simplylearn.com so that you
can get started on your journey getting
certified and getting ahead hey guys
welcome to this video on digital
marketing carrier jobs resume salary
skills roles and responsibilities
so without further ado let's jump right
into it
the 21st century has given us many
things to be thankful for from
technology to healthcare our lives have
greatly improved for the better and many
of these things wouldn't have been
possible without the internet
not counting about the several ways it
has improved our lives the internet has
also made the life of marketers a whole
lot easier
earlier unless you had lots of money or
were very popular your brand's
popularity would be limited to your
locality
but thanks to the internet you can
advertise your content to anyone
anywhere in the world the whole world is
now your marketplace
and that is because of digital marketing
which is the process of advertising
goods services and your brand with the
help of digital channels like websites
social media platforms search engines
and so on
digital marketing has the following
types
search engine optimization content
marketing social media marketing search
engine marketing
affiliate marketing
native advertising
marketing automation
and email marketing
but you might be wondering who can
ensure these digital marketing concepts
are incorporated into a brand's
marketing campaigns to ensure the best
possible output
a digital marketer of course
so now let's talk about everything
related to a digital marketer
but before we can get started let's go
to a more familiar setting on where a
digital marketer belongs and strives
the office
now let's start by talking about who is
a digital marketer
a digital marketer is someone whose
objective is use digital channels like
search engines social media platforms
affiliates and other opportunities to
generate leads and build brand awareness
everything the digital marketer is aimed
at helping the brand grow
but that's not where his or her
responsibilities end a digital marketer
is also responsible for developing and
managing marketing campaigns this means
that the success of the entire marketing
efforts of a brand or an organization
entirely depends on how competently a
digital marketer develops the marketing
campaign
the work doesn't end there though the
digital marketer also needs to manage
the campaigns
next like we mentioned earlier he or she
needs to acquire leads and drive traffic
to the brand's website taking advantage
of the digital channels we mentioned
earlier alongside providing high quality
content
the digital marketer also needs to
perform competitive analysis and
industry benchmarking to understand what
kind of content works best within your
industry the kind of content that your
competition posts and what works for
them
they're also responsible for using tools
like buffer
hootsuite and sprout social to measure
and optimize marketing campaigns based
on data obtained from the tools
and finally they're responsible for
improving brand awareness by advertising
the organizations or brands content on
digital marketing channels
let's now talk about the skills required
to become a digital marketer
now let's have a look at the different
types of digital marketing
there's search engine optimization
content marketing social media marketing
search engine optimization affiliate
marketing and email marketing
let's talk about search engine
optimization first
search engine optimization is the
process of improving the overall quality
and quantity of the organic traffic
coming to your website via search
engines
with seo you're able to attract visitors
who would be actually interested in the
products or services that your brand is
offering without having to pay a single
penny
the process of seo has two parts
on page and off page seo let's have a
look at each of them in detail
first let's have a look at on page seo
on-page or on-site seo is a method of
search engine optimization that involves
the optimization of elements on a
website like its content or html code to
help increase the amount of traffic
coming to your website and improve its
search engine rankings
it also helps users easily understand
what a page is all about and whether or
not your page addresses their search
query
on-page seo is possible with the help of
keyword research technical audits
on-site optimizations and enhanced user
experiences
next we have off-page seo off-page or
off-site seo refers to actions taken
outside your website to affect your
rankings in search engine result pages
it involves promotional methods to
improve search engine and user
perception of your site's popularity
relevance trustworthiness and authority
off-page seo can also be performed with
the help of link building which is
getting other websites to link back to
your website
some of the popular seo tools are moz
google keyword planner semrush and
ahrefs
next up we have content marketing
content marketing refers to the process
of marketing that focuses on creating
and sharing valuable relevant and
consistent content like blogs videos
infographics and case studies to bring
the attention of a targeted online
audience to the brand's products and
services
the process of content marketing
involves
firstly to decide what goal you want to
achieve with your marketing campaign do
you want more subscribers
more conversions
increased leads
that's what you need to decide here
then you need to set up buyer personas
a buyer persona is a profile created
based on research that represents the
target customer that might enjoy your
products or services
with this you can identify the ideal
audience that might be interested in
your content
next you'll need to perform a content
audit it involves taking a look at all
the content on your website and
assessing its relative strengths and
weaknesses in order to prioritize your
future marketing activities
then you need to choose a content
management system of your choosing
there are a number of options available
like wordpress mailchimp and squarespace
you will need to keep brainstorming for
new forms of content that will attract
the attention of new audience
you will need to focus on a particular
form of content you want to focus on and
finally you will need to publish and
manage your content
now let's talk about popular content
marketing tools
there's buffer basumo follower wonk and
hootsuite
let's now talk about
the next type of digital marketing that
is social media marketing
social media marketing refers to a form
of marketing that involves the usage of
social media platforms to connect with
your audience to build your brand to
increase sales and to drive traffic
you'll need to listen to an engage with
followers analyze results and run social
media advertisements
the process of social media marketing
involves like before you first need to
determine what goal you want to achieve
you need to determine whether you need
increased conversions
email signups lead generation or any
other marketing goal
at this stage you need to determine what
your audience enjoys the most
you need to find out which files get the
most amount of engagement likes or
shares
then you will need to research about
your competition within your niche
see what kinds of content they post what
content of theirs receives the most
engagement from their audience and how
you can make similar content
you will then need to perform a social
media audit through which you can
analyze content on your social media
profile and understand their strengths
and weaknesses to determine what kinds
of content you can post
then you will need to create an account
on a social media platform of your
choice
like linkedin facebook instagram twitter
or youtube and start creating marketing
strategies on how to make the most out
of them
you should also take into consideration
other brands that have already
established themselves in social media
for inspiration
you can analyze what kind of content
they post and how you can replicate the
same
you will then need to create a social
media calendar these are spreadsheets or
applications that will enable you to
plan your social media posts in advance
you can plan when content will be shared
manage them and track the deadlines
and finally you will need to keep
testing evaluating and making
adjustments to your marketing campaigns
to finally reach the sweet spot where
you have a perfect social media
marketing campaign
here are some of the popular social
media marketing tools there is hootsuite
tweetdeck sprout social and buffer just
to name a few
next up let's have a look at search
engine marketing
search engine marketing or sem is a
marketing process that involves websites
increasing the amount of traffic as well
as their visibility on search engine
result pages by taking advantage of paid
advertising
let's now take a look at the process of
search engine marketing
first off as usual is to determine what
goal you want to achieve with your sem
campaign
more leads
conversions
subscriptions
you decide
then you will need to research what
kinds of keywords you want to advertise
on
this is a really important decision that
carries a lot of monetary weight as
choosing the wrong keywords may have
your brand competing against larger ones
in a bidding battle you have no chance
of winning
you will then need to decide on what
keywords you want to advertise and then
start bidding on them to ensure that the
user sees your ad when they search for
that particular keyword
you will need to set up a headline for
your ad campaigns as a well-written
headline for your ad can make the
difference between a potential customer
coming to your website and buying your
products and then being completely
turned off by your brand
you will need to monitor your campaigns
and measure how well you're doing so
that you can make the appropriate
adjustments
and finally you will need to make sure
you make regular optimizations and
adjustments based on the data you've
collected and retarget potential
customers to renew their interest in
your brand
some popular search engine marketing
tools are google ads facebook ads
manager
ad role and binge ads just to name a few
next up let's take a look at affiliate
marketing
affiliate marketing is the process of
paying an affiliate who could be a
particular website or other entity to
advertise a merchant's products
the affiliate usually promotes the
product and earns a commission for each
sale they make
this is usually done using referrals via
registrations
email sign ups conversions and
subscriptions
here's the process of affiliate
marketing first you will need to decide
the affiliate network you want to choose
the affiliate network is like a favor
for both merchants and affiliates
here a merchant gets to decide which
affiliate they want to work with and
vice versa
as a merchant you will need to set up
specific rules
guidelines image specifications
commission costs and other details that
an affiliate needs to accept before they
can apply to advertise for you
after this affiliates apply to advertise
on the merchant's behalf
the merchants decide which affiliate
they want to go with and would be the
best representation of their brand
now once an affiliate has been selected
he or she places ads on their website or
the platform of their choosing
advertising the merchant's products
interested customers then click on these
ads and are sent to the merchants
website
if customers make a purchase the
affiliate network makes a note of it the
transaction is then validated and
credited to the affiliate
and finally the affiliate is given his
or her commission and likewise the
process repeats itself
here are some of the popular affiliate
marketing tools
we have cj affiliate
volume
even and has offers just name a few
again
now we are having a look at the last
type of digital marketing and that is
email marketing email marketing is the
process of using personalized emails to
convert prospective users into potential
customers here's the process of email
marketing first you decide on what goal
you want to achieve with your email
marketing campaign
then you decide what kind of emails you
want to send is it a welcome email a
newsletter a lead nurturing email a
re-engagement email that's what you've
got to decide here
next you can choose an email marketing
tool of your choosing
these tools can help you with templates
for emails create email lists track
performance and do much more
you will then need to attract users with
a reason to subscribe to your emails
with attractive opt-in advantages like
exclusive access to sales discounts and
so on
you will need to plan emails and their
respective follow-ups with an email
calendar
you will also need to create an
attractive subject line and copy that'll
attract the attention of potential
customers
but the job isn't done after creating an
attractive subject line in copy your
email also has to have an attractive
design
and finally you will need to perform a
or b tests and use analytics to measure
how well your campaign is doing
based on this you can make the
appropriate adjustments to make sure the
upcoming campaigns are a success
some popular email marketing tools are
mailchimp hubspot sendinblue and marketo
just to name a few
now let's take a look at some digital
marketer carriers
here are some of the most popular job
roles you can have we'll be talking
about the salaries of these job roles
courtesy of glassdoor
first we have digital marketing manager
a digital marketing manager earns
approximately 75 000
per annum in the us in india he or she
can earn approximately 7 lakh rupees per
annum
next we have seo manager in the united
states an seo manager earns
approximately 62 000 dollars per annum
whereas in india an seo manager earns
approximately 5 lakhs per annum
then we have search engine marketing or
ppc expert a ppc expert in the u.s earns
approximately 74 000 dollars per annum
whereas in india a ppc expert can earn
approximately 4 lakh rupees per annum
next up we have the social media manager
in the us a social media manager earns
approximately fifty thousand dollars per
annum in india he or she can earn
approximately five lakhs per annum and
finally we have the content marketing
manager a content marketing manager can
earn approximately 65 000 dollars in the
united states
in india he or she can earn
approximately 5 lakh rupees per annum
let's have a look at a sample digital
marketer resuming
first off you start off with the usuals
like name address and the other stuff
following this you will need to add a
brief summary of your years of
experience and the different important
skills you have experience with
in this case this person has two years
of experience in just about every
important type of digital marketing
your summary can vary based on the job
role you're looking for
you give them links to your socials and
then add experience
this is the part where you can highlight
your achievements during your years of
work
here you can see how this person has
brought growth in just about every
channel he's gotten into the most
important part to remember here is that
the stuff you add here must be
quantitative with actual stats about how
your work brought growth to your
organization
again depending on the job role you're
applying for you can choose to elaborate
on some of your achievements over others
then you can cover the different tools
you've got experience with make sure you
add relevant tools related to this job
role you're looking for
for example for the role of a sem expert
having experience with google ads and
google analytics is mandatory so that
has to be a part of this list you can
add concise details about your education
and then talk about the courses you've
completed
having completed the right courses can
have a significant impact on your higher
ability today we're going to talk about
digital marketing tools so fasten your
seatbelts and let's get started so what
we're going to do is we're going to take
a look at some of the
best digital marketing tools for not
only 2019 but ones that are performed
well in the past that are popular and
ones that we foresee as being the go-to
tools for the future so past present and
future digital marketing tools is the
way to look at this
with a good focus on a lot of different
marketing channels here so we're going
to focus first on seo talk about some of
the tools related to on-page and off
page we're going to switch over to
paid search talk a little bit about paid
search tools we're going to talk about
email marketing and some of the email
marketing platforms and the tools within
those platforms the center of it all is
web analytics so google analytics is the
tool we'll be taking a closer look at in
today's webinar and all that it has to
offer okay affiliate marketing we'll
talk about some of the
tools available to you and for affiliate
marketing we'd be remiss we didn't talk
about social media and all that it has
to offer and all the metrics and tools
available
all the platforms available so we'll
hone in on a couple of examples there
and then we'll also talk about some
competition tools available for you so
there's a whole suite of tools the one
caveat being hey if you have your
favorite tool continue using it in fact
if there's a tool that we didn't mention
in today's webinar feel free to mention
it in the comment box below this video
we'd love to hear what you're using to
manage your particular digital marketing
channel okay and so the goal for today's
webinar is hey we hope you get something
out of this in terms of using new tools
there's some tools that i use some tools
that my colleagues use everybody uses
different tools so be good to kind of
see what else is out there so if you
have something to share share it by all
means what we're trying to do is share
what we think are you know best
practices and
some of the most
popular or most used tools out there in
the industry so that's what we're going
to do the goal is to get you to
better understand some of the tools
we're using a little bit more detail and
what we're going to do is start out with
search engine optimization okay so
search engine optimization
or organic search we have a mixture of
paid and free so there's a lot of
different platforms but if you're
focusing on seo you certainly need to
use an seo platform so there's sem rush
okay you also have google search console
which is free so if you don't have a seo
platform you definitely need to be using
google search console and so we'll take
a closer look at that there's google
keyword planner which is actually
situated under google ads and so if
you're running google campaigns on
google search network or even the
display network you have access to a
great tool called keyword planner and if
you know anything about seo you'll know
that using google's keyword planner is a
good tool so we'll take a look at that
moz is a freemium tool meaning they have
a free trial that you can sign up for to
test drive it but it's another seo
platform and it does cost money got a
great tool in screaming frog that's a
paid version again not too expensive
we'll talk a little bit more about that
and then we have you know a tool in
ahrefs that help us with all aspects of
seo primarily focusing on off page so
these are just some examples that we're
going to hone in on but this is just a
small
subset of what really is available out
there in the market so let's go ahead
and dive a little bit deeper and
understand why we use some of these
tools well the first reason when we talk
about seo is to find relevant keywords
not only do we want to find relevant
keywords we want to find relevant
keywords with high volume and low
competition okay we wouldn't want to
find non-relevant keywords with high
competition low volume that wouldn't
make sense so we need a tool to kind of
help us put it all together and so the
tool of choice for us is google's
keyword planner and google's keyword
planner helps us hone in on keywords we
may be interested in
optimizing for because not only one are
they relevant but two they're going to
have high volume and low competition so
let's take a look at an example in
google's keyword planner so here i am
i'm in google's keyword planner and as i
mentioned before google's keyword
planner is situated under google ads
okay so you have to have a google ads
account to use google's keyword planner
and so when you're in google ads you
simply go to tools and then under tools
you're going to select keyword planner
so what we want to do is look for
keywords we're focusing on organic
search not necessarily paid search so
organic search we want to
hone in on some keywords so let's just
use one of the examples that google has
given us here meal delivery so we're
gonna just type in mail delivery and get
some results so notice i can enter a
domain as a filter and so in other words
hey i could say look hone in on keywords
related to this website if i wanted to
but i'm asking google hey just give me
something closely related to mail
delivery because that's my business so
i'm going to click click get results
notice i can add another key to it if i
wanted to but i'm just going to stick
with one keyword but there are certainly
other keywords that i can certainly hone
in on if mail delivery is my business
and so let's just hone in on that one
keyword mail delivery we want to be
found organically for that keyword so
what google keyword planner does is not
only give us the keyword and other
keywords relevant to that but it gives
us the average monthly search volumes
and this is an average over the course
of the last 12 months and notice here i
get a column for competition so
i'm able to see whether that's a very
competitive keyword or not and then just
to give you an extra edge when you're
choosing keywords you can get a sense of
what the keyword may cost if you wanted
to bid on that for paid search so for
mail delivery i can see it's anywhere
between
7.46 and at the top of the page high
range 16.61
so that should alert me to the fact that
hey if i'm gonna try and optimize for
this keyword i know it's competitive
because not only google is telling me
it's competitive by telling me high
competition but i know that the cost per
click seems a little bit high and what
is a little bit high well you know i can
see some other keywords here that you
know a dollar to three dollars okay i
could see some other ones that are even
lower than the seven dollars they're
suggesting so that's a indication that
the keyword is highly competitive so the
idea here using google's keyword planner
is one we want to get an idea of what
other keywords are out there that are
relevant so it helps stimulate some
ideas for relevancy two we can get an
average monthly search volume so we want
to know on average over the past 12
months how many search queries i can
expect from this keyword and then three
i can get a sense of the competition how
competitive is this keyword so if i try
to optimize for this keyword and i want
to rank for it organically is it
competitive if it's competitive then
it's probably going to take me a bit
longer to be found for this keyword on
page one of google so that's the whole
idea behind google's keyword planner and
note that you could change some of the
settings here so if you want to choose a
different language okay you can hone in
on a longer or shorter period of time
you can even choose a specific location
so i chose taxes i can certainly choose
the entire united states to get a sense
of what the volume would be for the
total us so you have settings that you
can change and manipulate to get you the
data you need to choose keywords so
that's the whole idea behind google's
keyword planner to find relevant
keywords high volume low competition now
alternatively i can certainly use
another tool
to find keywords so
i have a moz account so i logged into
moz and moz has a tool called keyword
explorer so if i use that same keyword i
used in google's keyword planner mail
delivery i'm going to ask moz to give me
some data on that keyword so this is for
the entire united states and again i can
change that if i wanted to okay so i can
hone in
on a specific country or different
country so what moz is telling me hey
for this keyword in the entire united
states i'm looking at anywhere from 11
and a half thousand
to thirty thousand on monthly volume now
what moz does is they give you a
difficulty score so a difficulty score
is a score between one and one hundred
and so i could see this is pretty much
right down the middle in terms of
difficulty okay so if it's zero it's an
easy keyword if it's if it's a hundred
it's very difficult and then that means
you have a lot of competitors who are
optimizing for this keyword that are
ranking for this keyword and so
moz gives us the volume they give us the
competition and they just like google's
keyword planner gives us some other
keywords that we can potentially hone in
on so
here i could see keyword delivery plans
delivery services etc so i can see a lot
more suggestions than what's listed here
so moz delivers a bunch of other
analysis
related to the keyword you know they
also give you some good keyword
suggestions so moz is a good alternative
tool and we'll be coming back to moz
related to seo for some other of its
features but for now if you don't want
to necessarily use google's keyword
planner because maybe you're not running
google ads you can always use mazda
remember moz has
basically a freemium version meaning you
can sign up for a free account and you
can sign up for a free account as a test
trial and you can test it for a period
of days and leverage its tools during
that free trial to get a better sense of
how these tools work so we want to be
able to use mods we want to be able to
use google's keyword planner not only to
search for all those relevant keywords
available to you but we want to be able
to choose keywords with high volume and
low difficulty low competition we also
want to select primary and second
keywords wisely so remember when you
optimize you're optimizing a page for
more than one keyword so you want to be
able to have a nice portfolio of diverse
relevant keywords with high search
volume and low difficulty and then you
want to be able to identify those
keywords that your competitors are
ranking for so moz gives you that
information
and so we want to be able to leverage
the tools available to us to choose the
right keywords so if you need any more
information on this
we got a nice webinar on keyword
research for seo so take a look at that
video on youtube and to get more
specific details about using seo tools
for keyword research and all about
keyword research in general for seo so
let's talk about some other reasons
under seo what we would use some of
these tools available to us well we want
to be able to understand the search
engines and how they crawl and index our
site okay we also want to check the
correct format of the site map and we
want to monitor backlinks okay we also
want to analyze
linking to our web page okay which ones
are good which ones are not good okay we
also wanna perform some competitor
analysis so these are some of the
reasons why other than keyword research
why would we use some of these seo tools
so we have tools available to us some
majestic
ahrefs again moz let's take a look at
google search console and i want to hone
in on google search console because it
is free and it's a must if you're going
to work on seo
you need to be working in google search
console and so the whole key behind
google search console is you have a
website and you need to get that site
verified once it's verified when school
can recognize that you are
associated with this website then you're
going to be able to see some important
information so here i'm looking at a
website and what am i looking at i'm
looking at something called coverage
under index so what does coverage mean
well going back to what we just said we
want to be able to understand how
google's crawling and indexing our pages
and so what google does is through this
platform search console is they're
letting us know once they go to our
website and start crawling it and they
pull these pages back to their server
they're letting us know
if we actually have any issues so here i
could see
i have some issues with 112 pages and
some of those issues are listed down
here so there could be a crawl issue a
4-4 you know redirect okay so
you could see there's some five unique
issues across 112 pages so here i could
see submitted url marked new index
there's a hundred of those pages we have
some redirect errors there's seven pages
that you fall victim to this error and
so we can really hone in
um what the error is and address the
error okay so if google's telling us hey
this is an issue and you want that page
indexed by google
then we should probably address the
error and so that's the great thing here
about going into google search console
is you can under index go to coverage
and get a sense of what google is
indexing and what they're not indexing
okay so these are the errors i could see
they
certainly were able to crawl and index
pages they were able to crawl okay and
they excluded 54 000 plus pages and then
we also have some pages with some
warnings so this is kind of an overview
of
what google sees when they crawl our
site so when they say crawl they're
coming to our site they're following
links on the site and every link they
follow they're either going to index
that page or they're going to report to
you an error or an issue that they found
if we want these pages indexed we need
to
address the issues the errors and so
that's the beauty of this report here is
google is telling us firsthand what the
issues are so we also want to take a
look at the sitemap so you have an
opportunity to submit a sitemap in a
sitemap is just a formatted file that
includes all your website urls and so
you're going to
have this file
sitting in your root directory and
you're probably going to call it or
should call it
sitemap.xml xml being the format so once
you have this file you're just going to
let google know that that file exists so
you're going to enter in the sitemap url
so if it's in the root directory all
you're going to do is type in
sitemap.xml and click submit so once
you've done it just like this site is
done what google's going to do is say
hey look we see you've submitted this
and we last read it a couple days ago
and we could see
that we discovered
1419 urls so i can go back under
coverage and i can see some of the
issues that they found but if i go back
under site maps i can see that these are
the urls they discovered via the sitemap
and so
the whole point of a sitemap is we want
to be able to get and push the urls to
google not have google come to our site
and discover them so this is a quicker
faster more efficient way to communicate
with google all the urls that you have
on your site that you want google to
index and so that's the beauty of search
console now while we're in search
console we might as well take a look at
some of the other features it has and so
one of the most important features under
search console is this mobile usability
report okay so google is a staunch
believer in mobile first so nowadays
most people start and finish
a lot of their searches a lot of their
behavior on mobile so they begin it on
mobile and
they may end it on mobile so if they
don't end it on mobile then you know
perhaps they'll go into a store or
perhaps they'll go via desktop but
google is a staunch believer and
definitely a lot of what's going on
today
starts with mobile so they want you to
understand how your site fares via
mobile and when i say fares via mobile
is it mobile friendly is it responsive
is it loading quick enough you know is
it formatted to google standards and so
if there are any issues google is going
to let you know what those issues are so
here i can see
google's recognized 206 pages before
different issues okay so here i can see
what those issues are just like the
coverage issues we can see specifically
what they are and so here i can see for
206 pages text too small to read click
elements too close together the viewport
not set to device width and then content
wider than the screen so there's 10
pages that fit under this error and if i
actually click on it the error i can see
what those 10 pages are and so when
we're done we can actually when we
address the issues we can actually have
google validate whether the fix has been
made so you can definitely use this as a
means of communicating directly with
google telling google look i see what
the issues are i'm going to fix them and
then i want you to validate them okay so
this is important because if you can
communicate with google and let them
know hey
we do recognize the errors we are fixing
the errors please validate them you know
it's going to draw google's attention
google's going to validate them and get
these pages indexed quicker
so if you ignore the issues then the
errors especially for mobile then you
stand the chance of your pages not
getting indexed so the mobile usability
report to me is an important report
because we want to better understand
whether google's picking up issues on
mobile and if they are we want to
address them get google valid them so
google can index them quicker now
there's another report that
is of interest to you or may be of
interest to you in google search console
and that's the links report so the links
report in google search console shows us
what pages have the most links okay so
here we can see the home page has 26 000
plus links if we hone in on interior
pages we can see the links to those
pages okay so we can get a sense of what
are the top link pages from external
links meaning links on other websites
pointing to these pages i can also see
internal links so google is recognizing
links from within my website from one
page to another so external links
internal links both factors for seo when
ranking so then i can see top linking
sites what sites are linking to my site
and then i can see top linking text so
google search console has given me kind
of an overview of what my leaking
structure looks like okay so
externally i want links from other
websites pointing to various pages on my
site and i certainly want my pages
linking to one another on my site and so
i'll be able to better understand what
that structure looks like using google
search consoles links report okay
there's one more report that i think's
of interest in google search console and
that's the performance report so the
performance report is a report that
actually you can link up with google
analytics so you can see the same report
and analytics if you're able to link up
google search console with analytics and
you should be able to do that all you
need to do is make sure you use the same
email address that you use for analytics
and search console so it needs to be the
same email address you could certainly
link up the two and have this data
imported into google analytics so what
is this data that we're talking about
well it's called performance so what we
can actually see is the queries the
actual queries people are typing in to
google so when they're typing them into
google we can actually see
how many impressions the keyword queries
received and how many clicks the keyword
queries received and then i can see
click-through rate and average position
okay so here i can see for this
particular keyword on the first line i
could see
over the course of the last three months
it received 209
297 impressions so what does that mean
that means this keyword was used at le
or typed in as a query at least that
many times and that's how many times my
listing appeared in the google search
results pages based on this particular
query and so as a result of somebody
typing in this query 209 000 plus times
this site received 120 000 plus clicks
so to get a sense of the click-through
rate all you would need to do and google
can obviously do this for you is you
would simply just divide the
209 000 297
into the 120 000 397. okay so that's
really going to give you that's going to
give you a click-through rate and the
click-through rate in this case is 57
so
over half of the clicks occur
when this listing appears for this
keyword okay so we can get a sense of
the click-through rate for each one okay
and you could simply just use the
filtering here now we can also see
average position okay so we could see a
little bit more than that too we can go
from queries to pages we can go from
pages to countries so we get a sense of
how many impressions and clicks i'm
receiving by country and
importantly we can see by device so here
i can see a majority of the people who
conduct a search related to my website
primarily do it on desktop now i
mentioned the beauty of the google
search console performance report is
that you can link it up to google
analytics and when you do that all you
need to do then is go to acquisition
google search console and then from
there you can choose landing pages
countries devices or queries so i can
see the same data that i see in search
console but this time i'm looking at it
in google analytics and so here i can
see what my search queries are my clicks
my impressions my click-through rate by
search query and then the average
position so that's the great thing about
that performance report is that when i
link up google search console with
analytics i'm able to see that data in
analytics so that's an added bonus so to
speak now let's talk about some other
reasons why we're going to use these seo
tools available to us and so we already
listed a number of different reasons
ranging from
sitemaps to keyword research but we also
want to hone in on you know what domains
are
driving links to our site so i showed
you an example in search console we also
want to
hey maybe identify and disavow poor
backlinks so search console is a great
tool for that because if we don't want
to be associated with a particular
website we can certainly disavow that
link we could track a number of follow
and nofollow links okay we could track
our website's rankings we can measure
click-through rates and impressions just
as we did with search console we could
track keyword ranking for desktop mobile
cross locations just as we just did with
the search console performance report we
can identify top performing gaining and
losing keywords again the performance
report so we could certainly look at the
google search console report but if you
have a platform like moz you can
certainly also look at a lot of that
data available so for example rankings
so if you have a moz account we can
certainly go into rankings okay and we
can see
for the keywords that we've chosen that
we want to optimize for we could
certainly see where they rank the great
thing about moz is it's a great tool not
only for rankings and on-page
optimization but
for off-page optimization as well so
if i go ahead and take a look at a
domain for example i'm just going to
type in this domain i'm going to be able
to get what they call a domain authority
so a score out of 1 in 100 i'm able to
see how
authoritative my domain is and how
authoritative a domain is is based on
the quality of links pointing to it so
moz gives me some good insights as to
how many linking domains how many
inbound links i have ranking keywords
and it goes into detail as well so here
if i click on the linking domains i'm
going to be actually able to see
the actual domains
pointing to my site as an external link
and not only can i see the domains i can
actually see the domain authority of
those domains so if there's a domain for
example that
doesn't have a good domain authority and
the site appears a bit scammy per se
then we can disavow that so i can
certainly look at all the domains that
are linking to me and then i can
highlight the ones that have poor domain
authority what mazd even takes it a step
further they also give me a spam score
so moz is able to measure how spammy a
website is so if i have a combination of
say a low domain authority
and a high spam score then i probably
want to disavow myself from that site
and so i can use this report here you
can see here as i keep going down for
example i can see this particular
website has a domain authority of 26 and
it has a spam score of 16
so not a good combination this should
alert me to the fact that hey
this particular site because it has so
many links pointing to me or it has at
least one link pointing to me that i
probably want to disavow myself because
it's probably hurting my own domain
authority so that's the great thing
about this linking domains report is i'm
able to hone in on not only who's link
linking to me meaning domain but how
many linking domains does that domain
have what's the spam score of that
domain what's the domain authority of
that domain and then i can get into a
little bit more detail and actually see
you know all the links pointing to that
domain so it really goes into detail
about
backlinks domain authority spam etc
everything you need to use in order to
measure off page seo so that's the great
thing about moz is they have not only
on-page seo tools but off-page seo tools
and moz is a freemium so to speak so
here you can see if you just go to
moz.com
free dash seo tools you'll be able to
use some of these tools available to you
not just for seo but also for local seo
as well so here you like some of these
tools you can start your free 30-day
trial so i use and lean on moz a lot for
all that it has to offer from
choosing keywords to rankings report
to checking issues on my website to even
checking who's linking to me so this
fits in the mold with everything i need
to do for seo so in addition to that
keyword research video you could
certainly lean on some other webinars
that we've done in the past on seo so
we've done a webinar on seo tools and
we've also done a webinar on seo tips
and tricks so if you want any more
information about the tools we covered
or seo in general take a look at those
two videos and
check them out and that should kind of
complement what we talked about with
using some of the tools google's keyword
planner uh moz and google search console
okay let's switch over to email
marketing tools and so with email
marketing tools we have a lot available
to us
in the form of
reporting in the form of platforms in
the form of you know tools that really
help us go from a to z on our email
choosing you know what email to send out
to creating a list to measuring how the
email campaign went and so we could
start with mailchimp because mailchimp's
a freemium version whenever you say
freemium meaning they have a free trial
available then you're expected to
upgrade but you know mailchimp to me is
a tool i use i like the interface very
easy for beginners so we're going to
take a look at mailchimp but there are
certainly
many others available you know marcato
is a good tool you know marcato is a
good tool because
if you have a business and you're trying
to funnel people through
your pipeline so to speak meaning
they sign up as a lead and you want to
nurture that lead from the beginning to
the end meaning at the end they're
actually going to turn around and
purchase well marketo is a good tool for
you to use because you can then set up
trip campaigns or also known as email
campaigns you know so that you're
talking and communicating with that
particular prospect through every point
in the funnel so that's the great thing
about marketo it has drip campaigns
available along with some other features
there's a hubspot a very powerful tool
it does a lot from creating landing
pages to a b testing to social to you
know email so
this is another freemium tool that you
could use you have another freemium and
send in blue
email platform and then you also have
convertkit another email platform
there's more dimension that we can't
even fit on this screen now if you have
a favorite email marketing tool that you
use constant contact vertical response
there are plenty out there emma you know
feel free to to note that in the comment
section below this video i'm curious as
to how many people actually use you know
different tools because there are so
literally so many email marketing tools
out there why because email marketing
has been around probably the longest
amongst all the other digital marketing
channels and a lot of people use email
on a daily basis so
it's no wonder why there's just so many
tools available and so with these tools
you could certainly send bulk emails now
in the case of marketo you could send
emails to a segmented audience and so
that's
actually what you want to do as a
strategy is always send emails to a
segmented audience you know you want to
use a tool where you're going to be able
to create campaigns then send those
campaigns to again segmented contacts
and then be able to design your email
around that particular audience so you
know you have a good tool when you can
do that when you can really segment for
your audience okay you want to be able
to
use a tool that's going to be able to
segment your users you know use
transactional emails meaning hey look if
somebody go ahead went ahead and
purchased can you follow up with an
email and creating workflows just like i
mentioned with marketo you want a
workflow set up where
hey if somebody does this you're sending
email b etc so you want an email
marketing tool that's flexible enough to
handle what your business strategy and
goals are okay so you want to be able to
also use a tool that
you know has various email templates
available okay you don't want to be
stuck with just a vanilla template again
you want to be able to customize an
email for your audience you want to be
able to manage your list appropriately
meaning
if you have 10 000 users or emails in a
list you want to be able to manage them
accordingly you know break them up or or
have sub lists so to speak and then most
importantly you want to make sure you
have a platform that
not only does its tracking on its own
but will give you some detailed insights
meaning you know what percentage of
users opened your email what percentage
of of recipients clicked on your email
what links do they click on you know
which which emails bounce so you want
some detailed insights right in the
platform that you're using it just makes
it more simpler and easier and more
effective to manage you certainly want
to create those smart automated
campaigns meaning you don't even have to
send out the email and then you want to
be able to have some flexibility to set
up email delivery based on a specific
time of day so these tools also allow
you to
you segment contacts based on
geolocation you want to be able to use a
tool that allows for multi-variant
testing
again you want to analyze performance
and optimize campaigns you want to
trigger automatic responses
somebody purchases something are you
using a tool that will automatically
send that email out so these are all the
reasons why you would use an email
marketing tool so let's dive in and take
a look at an example and we're going to
use mailchimp as our example today so
let's dive in and take a look at
mailchimp so with mailchimp once you log
in you know you're going to be able to
see
some historical campaigns that you've
sent out or you're going to be able to
create your own campaign and so
this is kind of under campaigns you can
kind of see an overview of the ones
you've sent out or if they're in draft
mode you'll be able to see they're in
draft mode so you can go ahead and edit
them so here we have one that was set up
on august 26th and it's still in draft
mode so we can go ahead and edit that so
if we just click edit you know we have
the flexibility to
you know pick and choose who we're
sending this to who it's from what the
subject line is and then we can
certainly design the email so if we
click design email again this is
important because with email marketing
you want to be able to
cater your email to your intended
audience
so if you're selling men's shoes your
audience should be men okay so you don't
want men to receive an email about
women's shoes it sounds like it's common
sense but the point being you want to be
able to use an email platform that's
going to be able to allow you to put two
and two together the message and the
design with the intended audience and so
here you can see mailchimp allows us to
do that okay you can see
some of the layouts here okay you also
have themes that you could choose from
okay you could search for different
themes or you can even just code your
own so you can just paste
your code in or you can import it so
mailchimp allows that flexibility you're
not stuck with one of their templates
and so if we go back to the dashboard
the one thing i like about mailchimp
though is the reporting okay so
yes it is easy to choose a template and
map that template to your audience but i
really like the reports that they have
to offer so you know here you can see
there's some lists that we've sent to
and if we choose one of our audience
list
then we can see some really detailed
reporting here and so
here i could see this email that was
sent out in june i could see it was sent
to 95 000 plus subscribers
okay of the subscribers i saw 2000 plus
open it and 157 clicks so i can view
this report in more detail just by
clicking on view report so again we want
an email platform that's going to be
able to give us some detailed
information about how that email
campaign performed and so i can get down
really to the nitty gritty i can
actually see
you know on the content what was clicked
and what wasn't clicked so here i sent
two different subject lines so i'm able
to compare the two against one another
okay so i can really go into detail
about one of them here
so if i click view report i can
specifically see what the average for
this list is so here i'm able to compare
against the list average and it's 16
i only had an open rate of 2.5 percent
so the industry average
is 18
and so here i'm able to see the list
average for the click rate and the
industry average for the click rate as
well so then i can see some specifics
about it how many people unsubscribed
then i could see
a graph i could see the top links that
were clicked okay the top subscribers
with the most opens i can link social to
it if i want to and then i can see
geographic information so the point
being is mailchimp really goes into some
nice detail here
about
the email campaigns and how they
performed so the great thing is too with
the mailchimp you could link it with
google analytics you can link it with
e-commerce okay so if you have an email
and you're you're selling products and
somebody purchased that product
mailchimp is able to integrate in with
your
shopping commerce platform for example
woocommerce so if somebody did purchase
you can send out that thank you email
mailchimp even goes a step further and
if somebody did click on a link go to
your shopping cart add something to the
shopping cart and then abandon the car
you know mailchimp allows you the
opportunity to retarget them via email
so mailchimp is flexible and that's what
you want in a email marketing platform
you want something that's flexible that
you can cater to your audience you can
manage your audience list and you can
get detailed reporting on your different
campaigns for that audience so that's
mailchimp and summary and so most email
platforms do a lot of similar features
or have some similar features but that's
what you ideally want to look for in an
email marketing platform so here's a
tool that doesn't get talked about
enough when it comes to email marketing
and that's google's url builder and the
reason why we're going to talk about
this tool today is because most people
in the us
use google analytics as their web
analytics tool and the one thing about
google analytics is it allows you to
track different campaigns so if you're
doing pay-per-click campaigns outside of
google you can certainly track the
performance right in google analytics
and email is no different so if you're
using google analytics and you're
sending out an email let's just say on
mailchimp or any other email marketing
platform you want to be able to append
your links with what we call utm
tracking so for example
if i have a url that says visit florida
and i'm going to send out an email i
have up to five parameters that i can
use okay so here's my email or url that
i'm using in the email so i have up to
five parameters that i can use to track
this particular email so let's go
through some of those parameters
so the first one is campaign source so
what's the source of the campaign well
we could certainly identify
male champion for using mailchimp as the
source now the the thing about the url
builders you always want to use
lowercase because google analytics is
case sensitive so as a rule of thumb
just stick with a lowercase so our
source is going to be mailchimp because
that's the platform we're using if
you're using you know constant contact
or vertical response or
you know some of these other one
convertkit then go ahead and put in that
platform as the source now for the
medium which is the means in which we're
driving traffic to the site let's go
ahead and put in email because that's
what we're using to drive traffic to
this particular page now what's the
campaign name well we're in summer so
we're going to call this the summer
promo so the summer promo here is visit
florida beaches okay so we're gonna send
this email out to the masses and
particularly not only the masses but the
masses in the north because we're gonna
say hey look come to florida for the
summer come visit our beaches that's the
point of the campaign so that's what
we're going to use for the campaign name
is whatever the campaign is it's a
summer promo now
notice i got an asterisk next to these
particular parameters so google's asking
us hey these are mandatory so go ahead
and put something in there now for
campaign term and campaign content we
could certainly leave them blank because
they're not mandatory but since we're
talking about email i would certainly
recommend that you use the campaign
content parameter and why do i say that
because if we're sending an email out to
say
you have 10 000 recipients i want to be
able to split out the email into two
segments one segment that's gonna get
subject line one
and one segment that's gonna get subject
line two so
in this case i'm gonna put whatever
subject line one is
in the campaign content field so now i
have four parameters
and once i've entered in my variables in
those parameter fields i now have a
revised or pended url so my original url
was
visit florida.com slash en dash us slash
florida dash
beaches.html my original url i've now
appended that with some utm parameters
and now i see my original url appended
with the utm parameters based on those
variables so i can copy it just by
clicking the copy url
i can go to my browser i can paste that
url in there and i want to check to see
if it works so here i could see this
particular page loaded florida beaches
with
my utm parameters appended to the url so
that's for the first subject line that's
for the audience that's going to get the
first subject line i want to do another
one for the second subject line so now
i'm going to change my campaign content
parameter to subject line underscore 2.
i'm going to copy that url i'm going to
check it okay so i could see that the
page loads with those utm parameters and
so now what am i going to do i'm going
to use the first url
and the second url in my email okay so
any link
that i have in this case i'm using
subject line two so for the email with
the second subject line going to that
segmented audience this is the link i'm
going to use in the email so if you have
one or two or three links in the email
this is the url you're going to use
because when somebody clicks on that
link you're going to be able to see that
that click in google analytics so if i
jump over to google analytics after i
send out my email i'm going to go to
acquisition i'm going to go to campaigns
i'm going to go to all campaigns now
based on the variables i put into
my parameters meaning source medium
campaign name content or term that's
what i'm going to look for in google
analytics so we can start with source
and medium
so if i click on source and medium as my
primary dimension
here i can see
mailchimp and the actual date was used
as part of the variable for for source
and then i will can i see the medium
being email so now i can see for this
email that was sent out in mailchimp in
may i could see
how many users how many sessions and
more importantly how many conversions so
we could certainly hone in on that
particular email if we wanted to
if we choose some of the other
parameters available to us so here i
could see the campaign name okay so i
could see exactly what campaign what
source what email
drove in traffic and conversions and if
i'm doing subject line testing i can
choose content as my parameter so here
i'm going to change it to content and
now i can see the subject lines in this
case if i go back to
my source medium i'm going to be able to
see what subject lines from my emails
generated
the most traffic and not only the most
traffic but also conversions so that's
the whole point behind using the url
builder again you're taking a url that
you're going to use in email and then
you're going to pan that url with
different parameters campaign source
campaign medium campaign name and then
optionally campaign content or campaign
term okay once you've entered variables
into those parameters you're going to
get an appended url which you can then
use in your email so when the email gets
sent you're going to go back over to
google analytics and you're going to
look at the results of that campaign of
that source of that medium of that
content i.e subject line and so that's
why
the url builder is so important because
mailchimp gives us some good insight
as to how the email performed in terms
of open and click rates but
what we really want to see
is how that campaign performed once it
drove traffic to my website so that's
the whole idea behind the url builder if
you're using google analytics you'll be
able to
use the url builder with whatever email
platform you're using so let's move on
to web analytics tools
and this is an important section because
web analytics tools kind of the central
focal point of all digital marketing and
it starts really with google analytics
google analytics is a freemium meaning
that they have a free version that you
can use there is also a paid version of
google analytics but given the advent of
google its popularity especially in the
united states a majority of users are
using the free version of google
analytics so it's a very popular tool
especially for marketers but there are
also other tools available so it's not
just google so we have adobe analytics
which is also freemium you have kiss
metrics you have spring metrics you have
youtube analytics which is part of
google but
youtube has its own separate analytics
insights so
a lot of these as you can see are free
to use they're available
no reason why you should not be using
an analytics tool to measure your
marketing campaigns or website behavior
and why would we want to use these tools
again well again we want to really
measure behavior we want to measure
what's going on with our website so we
want to be able to identify the location
of where our website visitors are coming
from and a lot of these analytics tools
use ip address to identify the location
of a website visitor so if you're trying
to target a specific country then you
want to be able to see that the visitors
to your website are coming from that
specific country or location we also
want to measure the engagement of our
website behavior so we get traffic to
the website what are they doing how long
are they staying what pages are they
visiting so this is the overall nature
of really why we want to use web
analytics to measure how successful our
website is at treating our website
visitors with the same courtesy you
would if you had a brick and mortar
store somebody comes into your store you
want them to find what they're looking
for quickly you want them to be happy
with their experience you certainly want
them to pay for the products very
quickly and easily and efficiently and
you want them to come back and that's no
different than a website so we want our
website to perform in a manner that's
going to suit our audience and that's
why we want to track engagement so why
else well we want to really look at
who's coming are they returning visitors
or new visitors you know ideally you
want a nice mix between 50
new and 50 returning because you know
returning visitors are loyal there's
some loyalty to that they already know
your brand they're coming back to your
website new visitors are curious and you
want new visitors because that means
more traffic so you want a nice balance
between that analytics tools will help
you measure that you want to be able to
measure organic traffic whether you like
it or not whether you know it or not but
google and other search engines are
indexing your pages and your pages are
being found via the search engines and
so you want to be able to measure how
much traffic you're actually generating
from those search engines we talked
about this with email marketing utm
tracking so if you set up email
campaigns or non-google campaigns you
want to use utm tracking and google
analytics and other analytics tools but
specifically google analytics will help
you
see the results of your campaigns if
they're tracked with utm tracking so
that's another good reason why to use a
web analytics tool probably most
importantly amongst all these bullet
points is our goals our website
conversions we want to be able to see
how much traffic
is coming to our website and not only
the engagement of the traffic but how
much of that traffic is actually doing
what we want them to do i.e are they
converting and we want to optimize our
sites and channels performance so the
whole idea of collecting all this
information is that you can turn around
and improve performance so if your
bounce rate is high well how do you
lower bounce rate well we need to do
something about that and analytics tools
will help us identify what's not working
from our site perspective and from a
channel perspective and we can take
action to improve performance so that's
the whole idea behind optimizing our
site's performance so let's jump into
google analytics and let's take a look
at
everything we just talked about in those
bullet points so about improving website
performance measuring engagement looking
at our goals and conversions measuring
campaigns with utm tracking all those
good things that we can get in a good
analytics tool so adobe
mix panel spring metrics you know they
all work in a similar fashion in that
they're really measuring website
behavior and so if we're in google
analytics really what we're doing is
we're measuring the performance of our
website broken down into four components
audience acquisition behavior and
conversions so
what do we want to do well we want to
look into each one of these sections so
let's start with audience and so
audience and google analytics tells us
who is coming to our website now they're
not going to specifically tell us hey
rob sanders came to your website but
they are going to say that somebody from
san francisco california came to the
website and these are the pages they
looked at and this is the language and
they came from this device and
they're a returning user so they're
painting a picture for you okay so
they're not giving you a list of names
that would not be legal but they are
providing you with a good picture of who
is coming and when i say picture we have
to paint that picture and so if we look
at say demographics for example and i go
to demographics overview here's a
picture i'm painting well i can see that
25 to 34 year olds are the majority of
the age group that is coming to my
website okay i can see on the gender
side of it i can see that 63 of my
traffic and again this is year to date
that i'm looking at is coming to my
website so two-thirds of my traffic is
female one-third male and they're
between the ages of 25 and 34. so i'm
painting a picture about you know gender
and age coming to my website well i can
also look at geo so where specifically
might these people be coming from so if
i go to location under geo i'm going to
be able to see a breakdown of country or
i can even hone it down to city
or specific location and here i can see
united states is the primary driver but
not by much so we have 16 almost 17
percent from the u.s and then 16 from
argentina 13 from mexico 10 from india
so we have a nice mix of traffic from
different locations
in the world coming to our website so
that's geo but more importantly let's
take a look at mobile so if we go to
mobile overview how are people coming to
our website are they on a desktop or
laptop are they using their mobile
device are they using a tablet and so
google analytics breaks it down very
nice for you and so we could see
percentages and actual numbers by device
category and so in this case i can see
year to date i can see 62
are coming from desktop 35
are coming from mobile and so that's
important because most people start
their journey
from mobile and that is growing and
that's going to continue to grow so you
want to keep an eye on mobile so to me
this is one of the more important
reports under audience because people
who come from mobile have a different
not only experience because the website
should be responsive to the mobile
device but their mindset is going to be
different they're actively looking for
something they're probably going to
either then follow up on their desktop
or follow up in person at your store or
they're probably looking for directions
or they may just call you so the
experience is a lot different on mobile
so we want to hone in on the growth of
mobile okay so to me this is one of the
more important reports in google
analytics especially under audience so
let's move on to
acquisition so acquisition reporting
tells us how the traffic was driven to
the website so if audience tells us who
is coming to the website acquisition
tells us how that traffic got to the
website and so
really what you want to do is get a
sense of what channels what marketing
channels are driving traffic so remember
we talked about organic search well
those search engines are indexing your
pages well how much of that traffic from
the search engines is actually coming to
your site and i'm a believer in if
organic search is the primary driver of
traffic then you have a pretty healthy
website because that means the search
engines are indexing your pages people
are searching for something related to
your business you're being found you're
getting clicked and that represents a
majority of the traffic so that's always
a good thing so here we could see it
broken down by channel if i go to all
traffic channels report i can see in my
dimension that organic search represents
72 percent of my traffic when this is
year to date then i can see paid search
then i can see direct which means
somebody went directly to the site i
could see referral email
social then i could see more paid search
broken out so these are the different
marketing channels now analytics allows
you to look at a specific source and
medium so the source would be the actual
website or search engine and the medium
would differentiate how that traffic
actually got to the site so if we're
talking about a search engine did they
come to the site via paid search or did
they come to the site via organic search
and so all we need to do is change our
primary dimension from default channel
grouping to source and medium and we can
see specifically the breakout of the
different sources and mediums driving
traffic to the site so here i can see
google organic at 71
and then google
cpc or cost per click at 15 16
of our traffic so then i can look down i
can see email in here bing organic i
could see some referring sites i could
see some social in terms of mobile
facebook okay so
we could see a mix of the different
sources and mediums driving traffic to
the site okay so you don't always have
to look at channel per se you can look
at it via source and medium and if
you're running google ads under
acquisition analytics has a whole
section of google ads reporting so if
you're running campaigns on google ads
remember we looked at the keyword
planner in google ads so if you're
running campaigns on google ads you can
certainly see the performance of those
campaigns just by clicking on campaigns
we can also
see
campaigns other campaigns that we're
running so remember that utm tracking
that we set up for email well we want to
be able to
track the performance of email and any
other non-google campaign with utm
tracking so when we do that we'll be
able to go to campaigns all campaigns
and we'll be able to see the campaign
performance if we look at source and
medium we'll be able to see what
campaigns drove traffic to the website
so here i can see vertical response
email as a driver of traffic so that's
the campaign reporting and then also if
you have search consoles so we looked at
search console earlier we talked about
seo tools well remember i said you can
link up search console with google
analytics well here's search console and
we could see queries devices landing
pages countries so all the performance
metrics that we could see in search
console because we have it linked up
with analytics we can see it right here
so this gives us a nice snapshot
of what keywords are driving traffic to
the site organically i could see the
impressions i could see the clicks then
i could see the click-through rate and
then the average position so in theory
the higher something ranks the more
traffic you're gonna get so that's the
idea behind it we want to make sure that
we're ranking for our coveted keywords
and if we are we want to be able to
measure how many times our listing was
seen and how many times it was clicked
so that's the great thing about you know
google they have a family of products
and those products tend to talk to one
another in the form of google search
console and google ads you can connect
them directly to google analytics so
let's move from acquisition to behavior
so
here in behavior
we have a number of different reports so
behavior tells us once the traffic
actually arrived at the website how are
they behaving and so
really what i would do is from there go
to site content all pages and so this
gives us an idea of how many pages were
actually viewed so site content all
pages tells us what page and how many
times it was viewed during a period of
time and again we're looking at year to
date so i can see engagement related
metrics associated with the page so this
particular page here on line one i could
see how many pages unique pages which is
equal to sessions
so i could have a session come to the
website and look at a page multiple
times in that session i could see the
average time the person has spent on a
page and i can also see the bounce rate
so a bounce rate indicates that they
arrived on the page and didn't go any
further they left the website from that
page that they arrived on and so i can
also see percentage of exits
meaning what page did people exit the
site from so these are all engagement
related metrics so here is where i want
to react and optimize my website
performance so i if i see a page now
performing well meaning it has a high
bounce rate or maybe low time on page
then i'm probably going to optimize it
meaning test it or change it to improve
performance so these are all pages but i
could certainly look at landing pages
okay so landing pages tells us the
behavior of the page when somebody
landed on it so a landing page means
that somebody came from organic search
or paid search or another channel landed
on this page so here i can see this
particular page on line one had
4970 sessions okay and i can also see
the performance of that page so
measuring engagements against pages is
definitely important because page isn't
performing in terms of bounce rate or
time on page then we want to be able to
make changes to that page to improve
performance okay there are some other
great reports under behavior so we want
to go to site speed we want to look at
how
fast or how slow our pages load so this
is important from an seo perspective
because if a page isn't loading very
fast then chances of it getting ranked
in google are not very good so google's
organic search basically takes page load
time seriously so if a page doesn't load
very fast then we need to be able to fix
it so we can go to page timings i can
get a good sense of the average page
load time of a particular page and what
google does here is under speed
suggestions they actually will
give me some ideas and speed suggestions
on how to address a page that's loading
very slow and so
when we load up the speed suggestions
report what google does is say hey we
know that this page is loading very slow
the average page load time is 15 seconds
here's some suggestions we're going to
give you seven suggestions so if you
click on that what's actually going to
happen is you're going to go to another
tool called pagespeed insights and
pagespeed insights is analyzing the page
as you can see here and when it's done
analyzing the page it's going to give
you some feedback on how to improve page
load performance not only for desktop
but for mobile so here i can see
if i scroll down this is desktop and
these are some of the opportunities that
i can address
when trying to improve the page load
time of that particular page so here i
could see there's some server response
time issues image sizes probably need to
be resized i can remove unused css okay
so there are a lot of different things i
can do to improve the page load time on
this particular page okay this is for
desktop i can also see mobile so mobile
a lot of the same issues so if we
address these these opportunities then
we could see a lift and page load time
we see lift and page load time we're
going to probably see a lift in organic
rankings or even user engagement because
if a page takes a long time to load a
user is probably not going to stay on
that page very long so to me
site speed is an important report under
behavior now one more report here that i
want to point out under behavior is
events and to me
events are important so if you're trying
to measure engagement on your website
you need to make sure you have event
tracking set up and when we talk about
event tracking we're talking about
measuring things that analytics doesn't
measure by default so if you have a
button on your website if you have a pdf
download if you have a submit button on
a form submission if you have a
subscribe button if you have a video if
you have an external link anything that
is going to trigger engagement on your
website you need to measure with event
tracking and event tracking is simply
set up by breaking out the event into a
category an action in the label and so
here
we could see for our particular website
we have categories already set up for
event tracking so here for example i can
see on line six video i could see how
many people actually watched our video
okay so here's the action video start
okay so over this period of time i could
see
i had 49 unique events 50 total so
that's how many people actually watched
the video and you can always report to
label and that'll tell you what page
people watched in this case the video so
event tracking is important because we
want to be able to measure engagement so
if you go to events
under behavior and you don't see any
events listed you probably need to get
that set up and that is set up through
google tag manager so what you want to
do is you want to be able to set up your
events through google tag manager which
is another google platform but you
certainly want to do that so that's
where you set up your events when you
set up your events for your website with
a category an action and label you'll be
able to measure those events in
analytics under behavior under events
and the important thing here is you'll
be able to measure engagement so i'll be
able to see how many people came to the
site and how many people clicked on a
button
downloaded a pdf uh submitted a form
played a video
did whatever we wanted them to do so
events are important so let's move from
behavior to conversions and this is
important because
we want to be able to measure
conversions on a website so analytics
has four types of conversions so if i go
to admin down at the bottom
and then i go to goals i could see that
i have four different types of goals
that i can use now right now
i have event related goals set up for
the website for this particular website
so we just talked about event tracking
so if you're measuring a button click on
your website you can certainly turn that
into a goal and so all you need to do is
tell analytics hey this is the
particular category this is the
particular action so for example if i
click on this particular goal and take a
look at it i can see that we have a
category set up that anything that
resembles donate now okay or donate go
ahead and fire this event as a
conversion okay so event is one type of
goal another type of goal is destination
so somebody goes to a specific page like
a confirmation page we can turn that
into a goal so here i could see if
somebody goes to donation dash
confirmation then analytics is going to
fire that goal as a conversion and we're
gonna see a conversion against a
different metric or different dimension
like channel or audience okay so
destination is the second type of goal
the third type of goal is duration so
how long did somebody stay on my website
so in this example if they stayed at
least one minute and 30 seconds or more
then analytics is going to count that as
a goal conversion okay so duration is
the third type and then the fourth type
is pages per session okay so if i look
at this example here
if a user came to my website and looked
at more than three pages in that
particular session then analytics is
going to fire a goal conversion so four
types of goals you don't have to set up
all four different types my
recommendation is least have one goal
set up if you're not sure what goal to
set up then at least set up a duration
or pages per session okay so at least
you can measure how long somebody stays
on your website or how many pages they
went to okay so when you actually do
have these goals set up you can go back
into conversions we can go back into
goals we can go back into overview and
we can measure
our goal completions over this period of
time so here i could see 313 goal
completions total with a goal conversion
rate of 1.88
and then i could see it broken down by
gold types so remember the only goals i
have available and set up are event
related goals so 69 newsletter sign ups
156 donate click buttons i have 32
contact form submissions 37 email click
completions and then 11 phone number
click completions so i can measure
engagement as a goal and so goals
generally are important to the business
so you want to make sure that if you
have a goal for your website then you
want to be able to set that up as a goal
in google analytics so that way when
you're looking at example
channels if i go back to my channels
report i can then measure
channel by goal conversion so these are
all goals but if i want to look at for
example
how many people from organic search
clicked on the donate now button i could
see that i could see year to date 10
88 users which meant 11 000 sessions 76
clicked on that donate now button and
that's comes out to 0.65
conversion rate okay so that's important
so you want to be able to measure
any dimension whether that be channel
source medium keyword campaign mobile
device could be demographic
gender or age you want to be able to
measure any dimension against the goals
you have set up so you can measure
performance and that also includes pages
or landing pages as well so that's a
quick overview of what you can expect to
see
in google analytics again audience
acquisition behavior and conversions so
a lot of data in google analytics but
you want to be able to take advantage of
the data in order to improve website
performance now let's jump over to
youtube analytics because if you have
videos on youtube if you have a channel
set up some playlists you'll be able to
get some really good insights as to how
your video is performing and so here i
could see
i'm in youtube all i did was i went to
my account then i went to the beta the
studio version of youtube and then from
there i went to analytics so my account
youtube studio analytics and analytics
here is going to give me all sorts of
information about my videos okay so here
i can see over the last 28 days my
videos produced over 8 600 views my
watch time in minutes totaled over 17
and i've netted 48 subscribers and this
is an overall
okay so i can actually see when i
publish videos and i can see the date
they were published and here i'm looking
at you know total views over this
particular date range i can also see
specifics on a particular video so i
could see the top video in terms of
minutes here i could see this particular
video had 602 minutes over the last 28
days so here i could see views on a
particular video so this is just an
overview i could certainly look at some
other information if i click on reach
viewers i could see the total impression
so how many times my video was viewed or
how many people looked at it okay and
then the click-through rate so
here i could see the different traffic
sources so 29 came externally okay here
i could see 25 came within youtube
itself i could see how many times a
video was viewed and played via playlist
via suggested videos so i could see
different ways in which the traffic
found my video and actually watched it
here i could see externally how people
were able to find my videos and i could
see 46 percent found it via google
search see some lots of information here
about sources of traffic how the traffic
got to these videos so i could see then
once the traffic found my videos how
many times they actually saw it and
viewed it and then watched it so that's
how many times i was able to reach
viewers via different sources and then
their reaction to that how many times i
saw it and watched it here i can click
on interest viewers so again i could see
the top videos in terms of
watch time i could see the top playlist
so here i could see my partners playlist
was the top playlist so i can see some
interest here in terms of average view
duration
and then here we have build an audience
so we can look at specific audiences if
we have them built in youtube to see how
many people actually watch my videos so
here i can see 88
of the people who watched my videos over
the last 28 days were not even
subscribed so that tells me a lot of
people are finding my videos spending
some time watching them they're not
subscribed so we're trying to get them
to subscribe to our channel so they can
watch more so a lot of information here
in youtube itself about how our videos
performed again this is good insight
because ideally what you want to do is
you really want to take a look at a
specific video see how it's performing
so if i just click on one particular
video i can actually see the audience
retention over the course of the video
itself i could see the ways in which
people found the video okay again
externally or via youtube search i could
see how many people liked it or disliked
it i could see all sorts of information
on a particular video itself or
an overview of my channel so that's all
available to you in youtube analytics
under youtube studio so take advantage
of that so if you're publishing videos
on a regular basis you want to hone in
on how your videos are performing so if
you have any additional questions about
youtube analytics or youtube in general
take a look at our video that we created
earlier this year about how to create a
youtube channel we go into some in-depth
insights into youtube itself especially
youtube analytics so take a look at that
video and if you have any other insights
about youtube analytics or analytics in
general go ahead and put a comment below
this video so let's turn our attention
to competitor spine tools very important
to keep tabs on what the competition's
doing and there are a lot of tools out
there so when it comes to social we can
use a freemium tool like sprout social
to listen in on our competitors we can
use another freemium tool social blade
there's a popular tool out there called
spyfu that's freemium as well
moz we looked at moz earlier for keyword
and organic mozz is a great tool for
also leveraging our competitors in terms
of backlinks and buzzsumo so that's
another freemium tool again there are
lots of tools out there these are just
examples of some of the tools that we
use here at simply learn i use
personally and professionally to get a
sense of what our competition's doing so
why would we want to use a competitor
spine tool well it may sound like a very
straightforward question but there are
lots of reasons why and so let's look at
some of these reasons and the first
reasons we really want to identify you
know our competitors backlinks and
monitor changes in their ranking so the
reason why we have this is the top
bullet point is because seo organic
search is a long term strategy on page
off page website very technical and
creative there's a lot going on with seo
a lot going on and sometimes it takes a
long time to rank for something and a
lot of seo does depend on relevancy
relevancy being how many quality
backlinks are linked to you so it's
always good to leverage what your
competitors are doing so you can see how
you stack up and so that's why this is
up there as number one we want to be
able to really take a look at what our
competitors are doing another example
would be
hey how much
traffic a competitors gaining on certain
keywords this could go either way for
paid search organic search what are
competitors bidding on are they really
getting traffic from those keywords so
there are tools out there that help us
leverage what our competition is doing
okay we can also identify our
competitors top performing content for
relevant topics okay we can determine
what our competitors website referral
traffic is okay we can pull our
competitors data and compare it with our
own campaigns so lots of tools out there
to help you do this and we may want to
track the total amount of clicks a
competitor receives and how much they
pay for each keyword so let's go ahead
and take a look at a few examples how we
can leverage all these bullet points
that we just discussed and so we're
going to start out with sprout social
and sprout social is a tool i use it's a
social media platform there's a lot of
things you can do with sprout social
definitely generate reports for your
social media platforms you could set up
post that get published at a certain
time and day but there's also one
particular tool in here called listening
and so what we could do is we just put
in for example rv rentals in twitter so
what we're doing is we're actually
listening to see who else is tweeting
about rv rentals so we could do this for
twitter we could do it facebook some
other social media platforms the whole
idea here on sprout social
is to get a sense of what our
competitors are doing so we could have
easily put in a brand name we're just
going general here because we want to
rank for the keyword rv rentals and so
here we could take a look at you know
what some of these particular brands are
doing like go rv rentals cruise america
rv we could see just scroll down and we
can get a sense of in particular what
people are tweeting about what other
companies are tweeting when it comes to
this particular keyword rv rentals now
if i want to hone in on a particular
competitor i could just really refine my
search for that competitor's brand names
or rv share so here i can take a look at
you know what they're doing when they're
posting to or tweeting how long ago the
time of day get an idea of what they're
actually saying what campaigns they're
promoting okay i can get a sense of
everything about this tweet and so here
i can scroll down and i can see what's
been shared by other people for this
particular brand and i can see a lot of
people are as an example retweeting this
particular giveaway and so
to me it just gives me a sense in this
particular example on twitter as to what
are competitors doing okay let's turn
our attention to seo so remember that
first bullet point we want to get a
sense of what our competitors are doing
when it comes to backlinks and so moz
has a great tool called link explorer
and link explorer there allows us to
actually compare link profiles so for my
domain i can go ahead and put my
competitors domains in there and
definitely get a sense of
you know how many links my competitors
have external intel internal i can get a
sense of the domain authority i can get
a sense of page authority linking
domains so i can really do a
comparison across my domain and my
competitors domains to get a snapshot of
how i compare against my competitors so
this gives me an overview of everything
i need to know organically now moz also
has a another great tool under link
explorer called link intersect and i
like link intersect i use it a lot
because if our competitors really have a
number of external links and domains
pointing to their site and they have a
better domain authority and page
authority then you know i want to be
able to you know see what they're doing
where they're linking who's linking to
them i want to get be able to get a
snapshot of why is their domain so much
better than ours in terms of authority
and so the link intersect actually
allows me to do that so i can go ahead
and put my competitors domains in there
and then i can find opportunities and so
you just click on opportunities and you
can see
where
my site intersects with their site and
if it doesn't actually intersect then i
have an opportunity to
actually try and get a link on that
particular site so that's what the link
intersect report does it allows me to
see where my links intersect with my
competitors and if it doesn't intersect
then i have an opportunity to generate a
backlink so that's ideally what the
link intersect tool is in moz it allows
me to really get a sense of you know
where i'm linking and where my
competitors are linking now what we can
also do is also take advantage of
another report under moz's link explorer
and the discovered and lost report so we
could put in our domain or we could put
even our competitors domain in there and
we can get a sense of what domains were
found and linked to them so
really within mods we can get a good
snapshot of what websites are linking to
our competitors we get a good snapshot
of the overall links to our competitor
sites and specifically with sites so the
whole idea is if it's good for our
competitors meaning they're linking from
a site that has good domain authority
and low spam score then it's probably a
site i want to be able to tackle as well
okay so you have discovered and lost
okay you have comparing link profiles
and you have link intersect so those are
three good reports you can leverage
right in moz's link explorer tool now
there's one more report we can leverage
in moz and that's the inbound links
report and so we can go ahead and type
in our competitors domain here and again
we can get a snapshot of what their
domain authority is page authority for
the home page but really this is what
we're after linking domains so this
particular domain has over 9 000 linking
domains so what we can do is actually go
through and see
based on domain authority i could sort
by domain authority where these pages
are being linked from and so here i can
see reddit reddit reddit so a lot of
reddit here which is a good site for
backlinking new york times so
you know there's a lot of different uh
sites here washington post so i can get
a good snapshot of my competitor by
seeing every link that's pointing to
them now of course i don't want to go
through 9000 links i can really just
hone in on a specific link source or
link type or link state so i can really
filter it if i wanted to i can export
the report and do some further analysis
but really the whole idea here as i
could see what url is linking to this
particular competitor site what the
anchor text is what the page and domain
authority is so this gives me a really
really good insight on all the
backlinking that my competitor has and
again if i'm trying to catch my
competitor it's probably not a bad idea
to look at what they're doing and even
copy what they're doing in terms of
backlinking so we're not on reddit then
we probably need to be on reddit because
if that's where our competitor is and
they're getting good link juice from
reddit which has a domain authority of
90 then hey if it's good for the goose
it's good for the gander so they say so
inbound links is it just another good
report you can leverage in moz under the
link explorer reporting tool now if i
want to get a good snapshot as to what
my competitors doing on search exactly
well look no further than spyfu so spyfu
is a another tool that you can leverage
from a ppc seo perspective you know from
an seo perspective you got some back
linking data as well just like you did
in moz from a ppc perspective you can
get some good keyword insights and so
here i just went ahead and typed in the
domain and what this is going to do is
just give me an overall snapshot for my
competitors domain so here i could see
you know how many organic keywords
they're found for the estimated monthly
seo clicks they're getting based on the
volume of those keywords okay i can see
here the keywords their top competitors
also rank for the rank history 12 years
so this particular domain has been
around a long time okay so that's on the
organic side i can flip over to the paid
side and i could see that they are doing
paid search i could see 5 000 plus
keywords they're bidding on okay based
on that what they're actually paying and
then i could see you know some of the
other competitors listed here from a
paid perspective and an organic
perspective i could see the shared
keyword overlap okay now again you can
pay for this because it's freemium and
get some really good insights as to how
your domain compares to your competitors
so i'm using the free version and here
the free version spyfu is just giving me
some overall data on the specific domain
i entered in and so i entered in my
competitors you can certainly enter in
your own domain to get a sense of
organic keywords and paid keywords so
you can see top keywords top paid
keywords okay this is google ads okay so
this is what recommendations as to what
to purchase okay here you can see some
even some at google ads history i could
see exactly what ad copy my competitor
actually wrote and for what keyword and
then i can see some organic ranking
history here as i keep scrolling down
this overview report so i can see for rv
rent where they rank and then i can see
inbound links just like i did in moz
spyfu is providing me with some insight
as to hey what links are pointing to
them and what the domain strength is and
how many clicks they expect to receive
so this is all free data take it or
leave it but it's all free data
available to you under spyfu so spyfu
gives you kind of an overview for free
some really in-depth analysis if you
actually pay for it and it just really
hones in on what your competitors are
bidding for paid wise and what they're
ranking for organic wise and so spy food
is a really good tool to leverage if you
just want to get a snapshot of how your
competitor uh overlaps with you so let's
turn our attention to google analytics
because in google analytics under
audience i can go to benchmarking and
basically the benchmarking reports
allows me to see what the industry as a
whole is doing compared to my own
website now the caveat here on this
particular report is that it's all
anonymous data so i can't exactly see
what competitor is doing what in this
report but if i hone in on my industry
in this case autos and vehicles and i
hone in on a specific country or adjust
the size of the daily sessions that i
get then i can see hey analytics in this
case in this example sharing 863
web properties okay so they're sharing
the data for over 8 000 web properties
and i can compare those web properties
against my own so if we're all in the
same industry it gives me a sense here
as to how i stack up against the
industry as a whole in this case as it
pertains to channels so you can see here
red not good green is good so in the
industry we're not doing as good as
others in the same industry who are
receiving the same amount of sessions
now we could certainly adjust and we can
adjust our locale and if we do that
google is going to be able to adjust how
many web properties are actually
contributing to the report and so when
analytics makes that adjustment we're
going to be able to see in this case
just new zealand so we're going to
adjust for new zealand and
we're going to go with the 4999
and so we could see there are about you
know 300 something web properties
contributing 47 web properties now
contributing to this report so if we're
focused on the new zealand region and
this is the amount of traffic we get
we're now comparing us against 47 other
anonymous web properties so now if i go
back to the report after i've honed in
i'm looking at channels and i can see
how many sessions we're getting by
channels and how i compare against the
competition i can also measure up
against percentage of new sessions new
users pages per session average session
duration bounce rate but that's just
channels i can also do location and
devices so the whole idea behind this
report is yes you're not honing in on a
particular competitor but you're honing
in on your industry so you're getting a
good idea as to how you compare against
your industry just by making some
adjustments in the benchmarking report
you obviously want to make sure you're
looking at the same industry adjust for
your country or region adjust for the
site size meaning how many sessions you
actually get on a daily basis and then
analytics will do the rest they'll
compare you against those in your
industry and so i find this to be a good
tool because it allows me to stack up
our site against those in the industry
and obviously if we're not driving as
many sessions especially say from
organic then we have our work cut out
for us okay so that's the whole idea
behind the benchmark report now if you
want to get some good insight as to what
the competitors are doing and you don't
want to use a tool well look no further
you can always go to google.com okay so
this is how we used to do it back in the
day before all these tools became
available you just typed in a keyword
and we're going to type in rv rentals
and now we're going to be able to see
who's bidding on that keyword so we
could see we have a number of different
uh companies bidding on the keyword
we're interested in okay here i can see
some featured snippets okay and then i
can see some organic search results okay
if i scroll down i'll be able to see
some other companies bidding on that
same keyword meaning they're paying for
rv rental so if i clicked on somebody's
link here they're actually going to pay
google for the click and so this just
gives me a good sense of you know how
many people are actually
trying to rank for this keyword or
trying to be found for this keyword so
that's all i did i just did a search now
from an organic perspective if you
really want to hone in on your
competition you can always do the syntax
all in title colon and then hit enter so
now i could see i have 163 000 results
and what does that tell me that tells me
that i have 163 000 websites with rv
rentals in the title tag so if you're
trying to optimize for the keyword rv
rentals as an example then you know that
you have 163 000 different listings
ahead of you that you need to jump over
in order to rank for the keyword rv
rentals so using the all in title syntax
and the keyword right after that
actually just gives you a more accurate
picture of how many sites are actually
ahead of you for a particular keyword so
that's the whole idea so if i get rid of
the syntax and you can see for rv
rentals i have 132 million but that's
not really accurate because not all
these listings have the keyword rv
rentals in the title tag and title tag
if you're working on organic search is
one of the key important factors for
ranking so you need to have that keyword
in the title tag so that's the whole
idea behind using the all in title
syntax it gives us a good idea as to
what our competition's doing and how
many sites we have to jump over to get
to number one on google now if you're
running google ads just as we did with
rv rentals we went up there and we saw
we typed that in as a query and we saw
how many advertisers there were for rv
rentals now if we are running our own
campaigns google ads actually has a good
report that i really like it's called
auction insights and so you can get to
auction insights just by clicking on
campaigns and then from campaigns click
on auction insights and what auction
insights allows us to see is
what competitors or domains are bidding
on the same keywords we are and so what
google does here is it allows us to
actually see where we stack up against
our competition for all the keywords
we're bidding on and so here i'm looking
at year to date and here we could see us
and i can see our competitors okay so i
could see impression share so for if
we're talking about one keyword every
keyword has a 100 impression share how
much of that impression share are you
getting and when we say impression share
meaning eyeballs when we talk about
eyeballs are we getting a majority of
the eyeballs or our competitors getting
majority of the eyeballs so we can see
our average position i can see how often
i overlap with my competitors okay i
could see how often i'm above a
particular competitor i could see what
percentage i'm at the top of the page
versus my competitors the absolute top
of page rate and then i can see how
often i outrank my competitors and vice
versa how often my competitors outrank
me so i can see
all this good insight as to what
competitors are bidding on the same
keywords i am okay so this is if you're
running google ads okay so if you're
running google ads okay you can just
click on the auction insights report you
can find that the top navigation just by
clicking on campaigns and by doing so
you'll be able to gain some insights as
to where you stack up from a paid search
perspective against your competitors so
let's turn our attention to paid
marketing tools so if you're doing some
advertising on google bing linkedin you
probably want to work within those
platforms as the tool of choice so
you know if you're doing paid search
on say google search dot com or display
you could be doing display advertising
on you know a network like adroll or
google or you could be doing social
media paid ads say on facebook so
whatever it is you're doing you probably
want to work within that platform itself
to get the ideal data that you need okay
so here are some of the tools some of
the places you can go of course if you
work in google ads you also have google
ads editor that you can leverage okay
and i'll show you that in a couple
minutes you have google ads keyword
planner of course both of these are paid
if you're running campaigns okay so bing
if you're running campaigns on bing okay
you get all this good data that you can
digest through some reporting okay you
also have some third-party tools out
there that you also have to pay for in
word stream okay so
wordstream's a third-party tool that you
can leverage bing and google
are actual advertising networks so you
would advertise on the platform itself
and get all the data you need right in
the platform and leverage a lot of the
tools that they have available in the
platform as i mentioned you could also
use google ads editor
so bing also has their own editor as
well so and as well as facebook so you
can use an editor type version and i'll
show you that here in a couple minutes
but let's talk about why we want to use
the tools in the platform itself well
we want to be able to monitor how our
ads performing so which ad receives the
most traffic as an example we want to
identify keywords that are performing
for us okay so our keywords converting
not converting now they cost us a lot of
money and not netting a high enough
return for us so we want to keep an eye
on that okay so we want to monitor our
cost okay across different locations and
devices not only cost but we want to
also monitor how our ads are performing
across different locations of devices
keywords across different locations and
devices so we want to be able to
measure by device okay so we also want
to analyze competitors data and as we
showed you in the competitors section
google as an example has auction
insights reporting analytics has
benchmarking so
google itself does provide some
information in the case of auction
insights as to how
your competitors are performing against
you on google search so that's on the
paid search side then you have display
okay so
display advertisements okay you're
across a different network
so there are different types of networks
out there for example adroll okay you
have curtillo celtra is another paid
version of or paid tool you can use in
wide orbit so these are some of the paid
marketing tools you can leverage of
course i like to stay if i'm advertising
on google i like to stay on google ads
and measure my display performance that
way but if you're on adroll for example
then you want to leverage adroll's
reporting platform and some of the tools
they have to offer so if we look at
display why do we want to leverage some
of these tools well just like search for
example where we want to look at keyword
and ad performance same kind of concept
here we want to be able to monitor
whether we have the right keywords and
right customer engagement so when when
it comes to display we want to be able
to
make sure we're choosing the right
audience of course that means looking at
not only audience insights but our
target insights as well are we reaching
the right audience when it comes to
display and google has a good breakdown
that i'm going to be able to show you
here in a couple of minutes okay so we
want to improve our campaigns by
monitoring our competitors display ads
as well so there are tools available
that'll help you do that and that's on
the display side if we look at social
okay why what tools can we use on social
well you got facebook ads manager okay
you got ad espresso quiet tweepy you got
all these cool paid search tools again i
usually stick with where i'm advertising
so if i'm advertising on linkedin or
twitter i'm gonna leverage that platform
but just know that there are
other tools available for you so a
social like display it's all about
targeting our audience so for these some
of the tools like on facebook we can
review and relaunch our ad campaigns
based on target audience we can measure
conversions and gain insights
in this example about facebook users how
are our users
interacting with our ads and then we
want to target people based on their
activities such as purchase intent
device usage travel
preferences etc so social allows us to
do that and then
with facebook as an example we can
monitor any a b test we run for example
if we're running call to action test we
can measure the results that write in
facebook and i'm going to show you an
example of that here shortly so let's
jump right into google ads and look at
some tools available to us
from the search side of the house so if
we're running search campaigns right in
google ads we could see campaign data we
could see keyword data we could see ad
data so for example if i want to see
what ads are performing i'm just going
to click on my ads and extensions okay
and here are my ads and now i can see
what ads are performing in terms of
clicks click-through rates etc and so
that way i can go ahead and pause ads
activate ads so that's right here in
the google ads uh platform itself now if
i want to look at specific keywords i
can do that so i can see what keywords
are driving traffic and clicks here i
could just sort by clicks and now i can
see not only what keywords are driving
clicks i could see
what the click-through rate is i could
see the impressions how many people
actually viewed my ad after click typing
in a keyword query that i'm bidding on i
could see
how much i've paid by keyword and more
importantly i want to be able to see
conversions or conversion rate and then
with google ads you have quality scores
so we want to be able to measure quality
score so
this is a google
ads keyword reporting and so the great
thing about the keyword reporting is
that there's some other features
available to me here so here i can add
negative keywords okay just by clicking
on negative keywords i can also see a
search terms report and so
when it comes to search terms i can
actually see
what specific keywords people typed in
and based on the keyword that somebody
typed in as a query i can see what match
type triggered that particular ad and so
if i see a keyword query that
i don't particularly care to be shown
for or i want my ad shown for then i can
go ahead and just select it and i can
add it as a negative keyword okay so
that tool is available to you right in
google ads okay and then you have the
auction insight so we've reviewed the
auction insights when we're looking at
competitive analysis and so here if we
look at the auction insights we'll be
able to adjust our date range and we'll
be able to see basically you know who
else is bidding on the keywords and what
the impression share is what their
average position is what the overlap
rate is position above rate top of page
absolute top of page right now rank and
share so once we have google has data
then they'll be able to share that
information with you okay so that's just
keywords but there's a cool tool that i
really like and i leverage it for seo
and pay-per-click and that's google's
keyword planner so if you click on tools
and then you click on keyword planner
we'll be able to
leverage the keyword planner and the
whole idea behind the keyword planner is
do we want to discover new keywords or
for the keywords we have selected we can
get volume and forecast on that so here
let's type in a keyword mail delivery
and if i click get started okay so
google's going to give me
some other keyword ideas and they're
going to give me what the average
monthly searches are for that keyword
they're going to let me know the
competition they're going to give me a
range in terms of how much i can expect
to pay for that keyword so if i happen
to click on that keyword i can add it to
a plan and then once i've added to a
plan then i can go ahead and
look at that plan and
measure
what kind of volume i'm going to get and
how much i can expect to pay so now once
i've added my keyword to that plan i can
go ahead and see how many clicks and
impressions and costs and click the rate
and average cost per click i can expect
to spend so and this is based on
a maximum cpc of two dollars so i can go
ahead and adjust my plan accordingly if
i want to in order to see basically how
much i can expect to spend so that's the
whole idea behind the keyword planner in
terms of choosing new keywords and once
you choose keywords you're interested in
bidding on you can actually do a
forecast to see exactly how much you can
expect to spend how many clicks how many
impressions you can expect to get and
if you have conversions set up how many
conversions you can expect to receive so
that's all part of google's keyword plan
that's viewing forecast as well as
choosing keywords so there are so many
different tools and features within
google ads we need a whole whole segment
just on this so
really i'm just going to highlight some
of the more important tools and features
so i mentioned the keyword planner i
mentioned the campaigns keywords and ads
reports another thing i would look at in
google ads again we mentioned this as
one of our key defining why would we use
it bullet point and that's because of
devices so we mentioned devices why
would we use google ads reporting tool
because we want to look at devices and
we want to be able to see
what devices are driving traffic from
what campaign and then the cool thing
about
google ads is right in google ads
platform you can go ahead and do a bid
adjustment so if i increase my bid
adjustment for example on mobile phones
then my particular ad in this particular
campaign is going to show more than on
computer so i can always decrease it for
example do a bid adjustment on computer
and that means i'm going to show my ads
less so
i can go ahead and do bit adjustments
based on device that's the cool thing of
working right in google ads platform is
you can make adjustments right here in
the platform based on devices well you
also have locations too so we mention
that as one of the reasons why we want
to use some of these tools and
if i see a particular location i'm not
interested in advertising well i can
always select it and i can always just
pause it or remove it so
or i can change the bid adjustment on a
location as well so i can make a lot of
different changes right in the google
ads platform for those seasoned in
search advertising paid search
advertising especially on google ads you
can always use google ads editor all you
need to do is just do a search for
google ads editor you can download it so
basically
what google ads editor is it's a it's a
tool it's the software that you work
your ca with your campaigns on locally
so you're making changes to your
campaigns on your computer and basically
when you're done making changes you can
always
upload them
to google ads to the account on google
ads in the cloud so to speak so that's
the whole idea behind google ads editor
it's a great tool for you to use if you
want to make household changes really
quick for example i'm looking at an
account with a bunch of campaigns so now
if i click on one of those campaigns i
could see the ad groups here okay so for
example i just wanted to turn off all
these ad groups i can just highlight
them all and just click status enable to
pause and i can revert back if i want to
okay so you can make household changes
so here i could see the campaign the ad
group level if i choose an ad group then
i can see some key words and again i can
make changes at nauseum here i can copy
i can paste i can delete okay so i can
make a lot of changes really quick right
in google ads editor and that's the
whole point of editor is to go ahead and
work locally while somebody else is
working locally on the same account you
could both be working simultaneously and
being more efficient on getting things
done in the campaign now if you are
working with somebody else on the
campaign you want to make sure that you
get recent changes so if i say get
recent changes to all campaigns what
google editor is going to do is contact
google ads in the cloud and download all
those changes so here i can see the
changes being download in editor from
google ads and when it's done it's going
to highlight all the changes that have
been made and so
once i'm done reviewing those changes i
can go ahead and click done and now i
know i have the recent latest changes in
editor so now i can go ahead and
continue to make some changes and when
i'm done making changes i can go ahead
and post them so that's the beauty of
google ads editor bing has a version
facebook has a version it allows you to
again go at the keyword level the ad
group level okay you can look at ads
itself and make changes to the ads okay
you could do a lot of different things
write an editor in fact you could do
pretty much
most of what you could do in google ads
you can do in google ads editor and so
that's google ads editor to me i would
recommend it if you're experienced with
google ads again it's software you have
to download it you're going to use it on
your computer as software but when you
make changes all you need to do is post
those changes or get recent changes that
have been made on google ads and so
that's google editor ads editor in
summary now let's go back into google
ads and talk about display advertising
because display is a different network
but the platform's still the same and
some of the same tools are available
from the search network as well as for
the display network right in google ads
so if i want to take a look at a
campaign and ad group on the display
network i can just click on that ad
group and i can look at the ads that are
running for that particular ad group on
the display network so here the
difference being on the display network
is you can use image ads on the search
network you can only use text ads so
here i can look at image ads and i can
see how they're performing in fact you
could even go a step further and use
responsive display ads so google has
responsive display ads meaning it's
going to respond to what's performing
best okay and so now i can see clicks
impressions click-through rate etc right
on
on my ads and extensions report in
google ads platform now this happens to
be retargeting campaign so if we click
on audiences we'll be able to see what
audiences we're targeting here okay so
when this report loads when you run
retargeting campaigns you're targeting a
specific audience and so
we want to be able to see okay of the
audiences we have set up what audience
is performing best okay so here i can
see a breakout by audience again i could
see the same metrics i could see on the
search side
i could see clicks impressions click to
rate more importantly i want to be able
to measure conversions okay so that's
the whole idea when you're in these
platforms and you're paying for ads is
you want to be able to measure against
conversions and you can also measure
against cost per conversion conversion
rate okay so those are some key metrics
to measure up against whether it's
audience keyword ad whatever the
dimension is so here on the display
network we can get a sense of
demographics okay so unlike the search
network the display network allows us to
see demographic data and so now i could
see an age breakout or an age range
breakout that google provides us and i
can see again based on the age range
breakout which age range has the most
clicks impressions etc including
conversions so you also have the
opportunity on the display network to
add keywords you have the opportunity
topics and you have the opportunity to
see placements or run placements so here
if i click on where ads have shown i can
actually see
where my ads have shown up for this
display campaign and google ads allows
you the ability to go ahead and you can
exclude it from the ad group exclude a
specific placement from a campaign so
you could take action on a specific
placement and i could see the type of
placement whether it's a mobile app
whether it's a site i can go ahead and
see exactly where that placement was so
that's the
placements report you have demographics
you have audiences you have keywords you
have all these different reports
available to you on the google ads
platform so before we jump over to
social media
paid search advertising i just want to
remind you we do have you know a nice
tutorial on google ads okay so take a
look at the google ads tutorial we have
set up on youtube okay if you search for
google ads tutorial 2019 this is a good
uh tutorial on everything related to
google ads so check out this video
because in today's webinar we're just
mentioning tools across the board and if
you are advertising on google ads as
most people do
then you could see just how powerful it
is and all the different features that
are available so take a look at the
video it's a nice complementary video to
this one this digital marketing tools
and
this will give you a nice and deeper
insight into everything that's available
on google ads and if you have any tools
or features on google ads whether it's
the search network or whether that's the
display network then feel free to
comment below this video happy to hear
your comments about what tools and
reports and features you specifically
use in google ads so let's move into
facebook ads manager and show you how
the platform looks when you're running
ads on facebook so we can look at all
the different tools and reports
available here so here we can see
if we're in the facebook ads manager we
could see our campaigns we can see our
ad sets and we can see our ads so just
like on google ads you have less side
navigation so we can drill down so if we
want to see ad sets for example we could
just click on ad sets that are showing
up in this particular account and here
we can see we have two ad sets that are
live so if i click on one of these ad
sets i'll be able to see
an actual ad that's running here
and so for the actual ad that's running
i can then see
the results of that ad and how it's
performing for example you know how many
clicks it's received what the reach is
what the impressions are so impressions
similar to google ads how many people
are actually looking at the ad and i can
see the cost per click here at one
dollar as an example and so
now i can go in and i can go ahead and
look at the ad performance and go ahead
and change out that ad if it's not
performing to my expectation so if i
click on more tools and then creatives i
can just simply click on creators and
then i can actually see the create is i
actually have running for that campaign
i selected so now i can see all the
creatives that are running and i can see
the results of those creatives so
facebook ads manager also has
uh reap different reporting so if i
click on the reports pull down menu you
can see here i could see some standard
reports by add add set age and gender
and then i can see all reports here
listed out by placement by placement and
device time of day
country etc so if we just look at age
and gender we'll be able to get a
breakout age and gender here so
you can see by campaign i'm looking at
all campaigns here and i'm looking at
just age and gender i can certainly
deselect one of these and i can look at
a specific time range so now i can see
who's looking at my ad specifically so
here i could see
35 to 44 female i could see the reach
impressions and how often they're
actually seeing my ad now this is key
for facebook because if somebody's seen
your ad a lot they're probably going to
tune out to it so that's what makes the
frequency
metric so important on facebook because
then we can go ahead and
you know turn off that particular age
and gender if we needed to and we could
see how much we spent so this just gives
you some idea of the type of reporting
that's available in facebook ads manager
now the great thing about facebook
reporting in ads manager is you know i
can group or ungroup uh my dimensions if
i needed to i could change the view and
arrange columns i can get rid of columns
just as you would in google ads
reporting very similar stature here so i
have a lot of flexibility here on how i
review the reports you know you got
different metrics that you can pick and
choose as well okay and you got lots of
different flexibility when you're
looking at the reports on how your
campaigns are performing now here i can
pick and choose i can choose campaign ad
set ads objective again i can choose
different demographics so i have a lot
of options available to me in terms of
how i want to you know view the
performance of my campaign view the
performance of my ad set or my ad now
remember
if you're in facebook you can always go
in and edit the campaign you can edit
the ad set remember in the ad set that's
where a lot of your decisions are going
to be made including how you want to
drive the traffic okay what your budget
is okay you can basically choose your
audience here so you're going to be able
to choose what type of campaign is going
to be and based on the campaign you're
going to go ahead and choose the kind of
audience you want to focus in on you're
going to be able to choose the location
the age range the gender so all of this
is going to be set up in the ad set or
the campaign or the ad if you go ahead
and edit it out remember you can do a b
testing as well so you have a lot of
different options and features available
to you right in ads manager when you're
managing your paid search campaigns on
facebook so if you want some more
information about
all the different features and tools and
facebook ads manager check out the
facebook ads tutorial
2019 uh webinar that we did earlier this
year in addition you can also look at
another one that we did on facebook
called facebook advertising tips and
strategies so that should give you some
sense of everything related to facebook
ads and how to take advantage of the
facebook ads manager platform so if
there's anything on social that we may
have missed or that you use feel free to
add a comment below the video we'd love
to hear your feedback okay let's talk
about some affiliate marketing tools
let's turn our attention affiliate
marketing
a lot of affiliate marketing platforms
out there
the number one probably is commission
junction also known as cj
they're an affiliate platform they
having a freemium model meaning you can
have a free trial but
basically you're going to have to move
on and pay for the platform likewise for
house offers you have volume you really
when it comes to affiliate marketing a
lot of platforms out there click inc hey
when so a lot of these are
brokers per se and when i say brokers
like for example with cj you as a
merchant or you as a publisher can get
in touch with a merchant you as a
merchant can get in touch with a
publisher meaning cj helps bridge the
gap between
you finding somebody to build your
network with okay so
that's what really affiliate marketing
is and you really need a platform to
kind of put it all together and
it's a lot a lot of affiliate marketing
platforms we're actually going to take a
look at cj and go through some of the
features in the platform here shortly
but let's just take a look at why we
need these affiliate marketing tools
well these affiliate marketing tools
identify
you know affiliates inflowers employees
other advocates you want to partner with
so again you could be on the merchant
side you could be actually selling a
product and you're going to want
somebody to help you sell that product
somebody with a website who's an
influencer who drives a lot of traffic
to their own site who
you know does sell reputable brand etc
so
you need somebody to help you introduce
you to these sites okay so cj and some
of these other marketing platforms
affiliate marketing platforms do that
okay so these tools are there to do the
introductions the brokering the
relationship so the other benefit here
is you can contract with affiliates and
track the traffic and conversions well
what do i mean by that well if you do
use cj.com by no means am i only
endorsing that platform there are plenty
others out there but whatever platform
you use you're gonna want to be able to
set up terms and conditions with that
particular affiliate so you could set up
with terms and conditions for say 10 off
all sales as an example okay well you're
getting a platform that will help you
broker that contract okay contract terms
or program terms furthermore you're
gonna need a platform to help you track
hey is this affiliate helping me drive
traffic or is this affiliate driving
traffic to my products and is this
affiliate helping me sell so
these platforms help you do just that
okay so you can gain high website
rankings with the help of your affiliate
meaning that hey your affiliate can be
promoting your product and if they're
promoting your product you have a chance
to show up via paid search organic
search off other websites so social
so you have a lot of benefits to working
with affiliate marketing in itself and
the tools available will help you
gain website rankings as one example we
want to be able to track certain metrics
okay so an affiliate marketing you have
earnings per click epc as an example
most platforms measure epc from a seven
day period to a three month period okay
you can also figure out what the actual
cost per click is just like you do on
say google search you can actually
measure that in affiliate okay you want
to eliminate fraudulent clicks
impressions and conversions so
any affiliate platform worth its weight
is going to help you understand you know
how many impressions and clicks and
conversions you're getting and help you
manage that in terms of fraudulent
clicks or hey if you're getting a lot of
impressions and no clicks that's a
problem too so
these platforms are really built on
helping you manage your relationship
with the affiliate by offering up all
sorts of reports and tools you know the
other big benefit here to affiliate
marketing tool is hey we can influence
our customers throughout their buying
journey so
we could set up different promotions
based on hey did somebody go to the
website did somebody see our product
does somebody click on our product did
somebody go into the shopping cart with
our product did somebody purchase our
product so there's all sorts of steps in
the funnel so to speak and hey you can
work with an affiliate a publisher to
influence your customers throughout that
purchasing funnel throughout that
journey so let's go ahead and log in
here so when you log in like any other
digital marketing tool any other
platform you're gonna have your own
settings and whatnot so really the whole
idea behind any affiliate marketing tool
is really
there to manage your publishers who do
you want as a publisher who do you want
selling your product you obviously want
somebody who's relevant somebody who's
going to be able to sell a product
somebody who has a targeted audience
that's similar to yours okay so we go
into cj.com we're going to log in and
here you can see a publisher's link so
we're going to click on the publishers
link and remember when you sign up
publishers you have to have program
terms and so if we click on publishers
program terms we're going to be able to
see all the different program terms
available so here we could see
the different program turns we have set
up for certain publishers so we just
click on that we'll be able to see
that's the default program term so
remember you could set up your own
program term for any publisher so as a
best practice if you have publishers who
are actually performing well who are
selling your products maybe you want to
offer them a little bit more on the
commission side maybe you want to
sweeten the deal maybe
you know these guys these publishers get
better program terms versus say other
publishers who don't and so here we can
see the program terms basically you
could see what the terms are the action
and the different policies here so
everything you need to do to manage that
publisher in terms of payment is done
under the program terms now if the
program terms are met the publisher
actually sells your products cj is the
broker they're the ones who are going to
initiate the payment based on the
program terms so be careful on the
program terms you want to be able to set
them appropriately cj has templates cj
has some default program terms that you
can use and offer up to different
publishers so based on the program terms
that's how your publishers are going to
get paid and so here you can have as
many different program terms as you want
there's no limit here you want to be
able to align and reward program terms
again based on performance and so
here we can see what publishers are
under what program terms so again if
your publisher is performing well
sweeten the deal offer them a better
program terms and so you can align
publishers with different program terms
and so that's the whole the idea behind
program terms is you want to be able to
align publishers with that so when you
sign up a publisher they're going to get
a line with a program term meaning what
are they going to get paid for selling
your product now if we want to manage by
status instead of by program terms we
could see all the different
organizations we have in our network
these are our publishers we're the
affiliate we're the ones selling the
product we want to know
who's selling who's not selling and so
we can look at all our publishers by
program terms or by status okay so
basically you can see here the term
status whether it's active or not
earnings basically what they've sold
over the last basically seven days or
three months so you could look at
basically how your publishers are
performing just by clicking on manage by
status here in cg.com so when you're
looking at reports in
cj.com or really any other affiliate
program you might see the acronym epc
this stands for earnings per click
actually it's a little misleading it's
actually earnings per 100 clicks so
basically cj calculates you know how
much your publisher is actually making
per click you know just like paid search
we're paying google x amount per click
it's the same thing here we can't or
these publishers can't make any money if
they don't generate clicks so that's why
you have an epc model or metric so to
speak so you can measure earnings per
click cj does it over seven day period
and over a three month period so you
could sort based on seven day or three
month to see
who's earning the most per click in
terms of publishers now you can select
under publishers groups now you can
group your publishers okay so if you
have say a group of publishers in a
specific region like the united states
or india or if you're just focused on
the united states and say you have
publishers in different states like
texas california missouri arkansas well
you can group those publishers into
different groups and you can look at
your different group names here so here
we could see canada and so we have our
publishers grouped into
a group called canada why because
they're based in canada makes sense so
you want to be able to organize your
publishers because the whole idea behind
affiliate marketing cj is you want to be
able to get the best publishers
available for your network and so
as you get more publishers for your
network you'll be able to
basically start grouping them where it
makes sense now the example i gave you
is by geography you could do by
geography or
you could do by publisher status meaning
my best performing publishers go into a
group if they're in a group then they
get aligned with a certain program term
so you could group your publishers any
way you want by status meaning they're
selling more these are our best
performing publishers or by region or
you know by promotion i mean how you
group your publishers is totally up to
you however take advantage of the option
to create publisher groups because the
whole idea again i'm going to repeat it
is you want to get
publishers and you want to start
building your base of publishers because
the more publishers you have the more
chance you are to sell your product
remember if nobody clicks on your
product then nobody's going to buy your
product so if you have publishers who
are promoting your product for you
then you have a good opportunity to sell
it so the more publishers you have on
board the better the opportunity so now
once you have publishers you can start
grouping these publishers accordingly to
whatever makes sense the business
decision just know the options available
in cj to group publishers let's turn our
attention to social media marketing
tools social media always a great topic
to talk about so we're going to finish
up all our digital marketing tools with
social media we talked about seo paid
competition affiliate email you know web
analytics it's just appropriate to
finish up with social media because
social media has so many tools available
so many okay the first one i can think
about here is hootsuite hootsuite is a
great social media marketing tool to use
okay it's a freemium okay you can set up
a free trial here
you you basically a base account and
then uh you can use hootsuite to do a
lot of things anything from setting up
landing pages to actually publishing
content to listening hootsuite to me is
one of the most powerful social media
marketing tools available you got buffer
buffer is a paid version but you can
actually set up a low cost or free
account actually on buffer and then move
to a paid account okay you got tweet
decks been around a long time that is
actually free and i would recommend
tweetdeck and we're going to take a look
at that here in a couple minutes okay
and then you got sprout social sprout
social is another social marketing
platform similar to hootsuite do a lot
of reporting a lot of publishing you can
a lot of listening and so we're going to
take a look at sprout chelsea today as
well before we do that
let's go over why
these tools are important to us from a
social media perspective you're pumping
out a lot of content so you need to be
able to
smartly efficiently you know schedule
and manage your post okay so you're not
just working likely with just one
platform like facebook you're probably
on a number of different platforms
depending on your business depending on
your bandwidth depending on what you're
selling your products etc your audience
obviously has a lot to do with it you
know it could be instagram pinterest you
want to be able to consolidate all that
and manage it in one place and that's
what social media marketing tools do
they allow you to manage everything in
one place so if you could manage
everything in one place then these
social media marketing platforms need to
be able to make it easy for you to add
and manage different accounts okay so a
lot of them have the ability for you to
add you know not just one twitter
account but multiple twitter accounts
and not just one social media platform
but multiple social media platforms and
a good social media marketing so worth
its weight will help you monitor the
results so monitor social media posts
that help drive leads and sales in other
words you're going to have a lot of
different metrics associated with each
social media marketing platform
okay which one is actually doing its job
okay so you want to be able to easily
manage these platforms applications and
websites very efficiently okay so
instead of having to log into each
platform is log into one place get a
sense of what's been posted what the
engagement is did they purchase etc and
what you want to do is be able to
individually customize every social
media post across different platforms so
it just makes it a lot easier to do that
in the social media marketing tools okay
you don't want to send out a blanket
message across different platforms you
want to be able to
go ahead and customize a post depending
on what that post is depending on what
the product is what time of day what
target market what target audience so
customization is a lot easier using
these social media marketing tools you
want to be able to engage with brand
advocates so listening is a good thing
with social media marketing tools using
the listening functionality so you can
actually see who is a brand advocate
who's not a brand advocate who's an
influencer who's not an influencer and
then of course you want to analyze the
behavior of your audience and optimize
individual posts on real-time data so
if for example you post something using
one of these social media marketing
platforms and you see it go viral then
you want to be able to react to that in
real time so you're going to be able to
see that in real time on these social
media marketing tools these platforms
like sprout social and hootsuite and
then you're going to be able to react to
that behavior and then of course
monitoring website traffic and
conversion rates that's key we always
want to monitor conversions based on our
kpis our business goals so there are
also a few important digital marketing
tools that can help you in different
ways okay so without further ado let's
jump in and take a look at what's
available in terms of social media
marketing so just a quick reminder if
you are
running ads on facebook or you're
posting on facebook as an example or any
platform in general that platform's
going to have
its own metrics if you will so for
example facebook has something called
facebook insight so you'll be able to
actually see you know what's been posted
based on you know the last seven days in
this example how many page views you're
getting engagements recent posts so just
to let you know
yes you can go into any one of these
platforms on its own and look at metrics
just like you can do if you're running
facebook ads hey you can go right into
facebook ads manager and view data there
okay so the whole point here though on
using a social media tool is that you
can measure all that in one place so if
we log into sprout social i can set up
these accounts right into sprout social
so i don't have to log into twitter
individually or facebook individually i
can link them up all within sprout
social and then i can go to reports just
like i can with facebook insights and
then once i'm on facebook excuse me once
i'm in sprout social reporting then i
can go ahead just like i can in facebook
insights except it's all right here for
me i can jump into you know facebook and
dig a little bit deeper as to what's
going on with my account so
i don't have to log into facebook
directly i can see you know the
impressions the engagement the clicks
over a period of time i can see my
audience growth i can see my publishing
behavior how often my publishing i could
see the top post individually i could
see impressions by day you know a lot of
this same
material same information is already in
facebook insights so if it's available
on facebook insights you know you're
definitely going to have it available in
a tool like sprout social so you want to
be able to just efficiently log in and
jump from one platform to the other so
here you know i can go to instagram you
know and look at instagram data or i can
look at twitter information so you want
to be able to efficiently jump from one
platform to the other using in this
example sprout social now as i mentioned
as part of one of the benefits of a
social media tool is that you can
publish content you want to be able to
publish content because you want to be
able to organize and schedule
accordingly you don't want to be
submitting and publishing content right
after one another okay you want to be
able to spread it out efficiently and
effectively and so here we could see you
know we could publish and schedule
content accordingly so all we have to do
is click compose select a profile write
whatever we need to do you could
schedule it for tomorrow at a specific
time and there you go voila scheduled so
this is on twitter okay so you know we
could choose another platform here it's
just that easy to schedule so
you want to be able to schedule
accordingly because again when you
schedule something then you want to look
at the behavior of it so it's just as
simple as going from publishing to
reporting and then based on when
something got published you could see
the reaction of it and react to it so
another thing here that i like about
it's about social hootsuite a lot of
these other platforms do it really well
you got listening tools so you can
listen in on conversations that are
being had for example
mail delivery you know if we do mail
delivery and twitter search we'll be
able to see what's been tweeted about
mail deliveries you know if that's the
business we're in we can
refine our search and choose a specific
location a radius to hone in if we're
local okay so this is sprout social's
example of listening here let's take a
look at another example i'm in later.com
so later very similar sprout social and
that it does a lot of the same things
you can actually schedule content on a
particular platform and one thing i like
about later here you can actually see it
visually you can see calendar and what's
been scheduled so i could see today i
have scheduled something scheduled at 1
15 local time and again i have five
profiles set up for this account so i
can pick and choose the profile that i
want to publish to so it just makes it
that much easier and i can visually see
it and that's important so here i can
click on media library so the one thing
about later.com is that you know you
have a library of images that
potentially you can reuse so if i click
on this image here okay i can get a
sense of when it was used and i can view
it on a calendar i can add label for it
so that's another benefit to later is
that they have this media library here
they have conversations so i can
actually connect to a platform and
listen in on conversations that are
being had similar to the listening tool
in sprout social and they have analytics
so you can actually see
write in later.com how your particular
social media platform is performing so i
could see it here over seven days i can
see the number of followers have
increased i can see the growth rate i
can see the number of impressions that
i've received
okay so i want to be able to see how my
particular platform is performing over a
period of time so i can look at reach a
lot profile views website clicks okay so
i can get a lot of good insights here
right in the analytics platform later
you can look at specific post
performance so if we posted something i
could see basically how many likes it
received how many comments impressions
the reach and then if i want to do i can
click on details and get more specific
information on it engagement rate okay
discovery actions comments saves etc so
later.com goes into some nice detail
about post performance they even have
date on hashtags so if you use an
hashtag you can actually see how many
times the hashtag's been used or saved
how many impressions it's received okay
so they really go into some nice detail
here about how your post and how your
accounts are performing and here's a
tool i really like i've been using for a
long time and that's tweetdeck so what
tweetdeck does is connect with your
twitter account so you can see in a
different visual so to speak of how your
twitter account looks in terms of your
feed here i can see this is my feed here
okay i can see some notifications i can
see specific messages then on this
column i can see activity okay so i can
add different columns here if i wanted
to and basically by adding columns you
can see i can look for what's trending
as an example so i'm going to add in a
column that says trending and so now i
can go in and see okay these are all the
different things that are trending on
twitter
so you can actually add a column and pay
attention to something really specific
okay so for example search okay so right
now i have men's health but i could type
in let's just say world cup okay so i
can see the you got the cricket world
cup you got you know the soccer football
world cup going on so you know we could
pick a particular topic to follow if we
wanted to so again here i'm following
men's health so i can now see
you know everything that's been posted
on men's health now if i click on for
example one of these hashtags here
that's trending i can actually see who's
tagging or using that
friday feeling in their tweets and so
the whole idea behind you know tweetdeck
it serves up a interesting overview so
to speak of not only your account but
you know a specific topic or what's
trending or
you know other things that are being
said so if you really want to pay
attention to your brand or something
really specific like you know your
competitors or a specific product then
you can just do a search on that and so
that's the great thing about tweak deck
it allows you to kind of just look and
listen in on everything going on in
twitter now we do have a good video out
here on youtube how to start social
media marketing so if you haven't had a
chance to look at it take a look it goes
over some of these tools that we cover
today like sprout social
later.com you know facebook insights so
it does cover in more detail some of
what we covered on these social media
marketing tools so take a look at how to
start social media marketing so we
covered a lot of different marketing
tools digital marketing tools everything
from seo to email to social to paid to
affiliate to competitor but there's also
a few
other digital marketing tools that you
can use in different ways like video seo
for example so vid iq you know we want
to use vid iq to get a good sense of how
particular video is performing so here
if we go into youtube
you can see vid iq is a browser
extension or browser a plug-in if you
will
so i can go and take a look at a
specific a specific video and see how
many hours it's been watched how many
views minutes watch subscribers etc you
know the great thing here i can look at
the entire entire account so
i can get good insights into my video or
my entire account here just by adding in
the vid iq extension into my chrome
browser so vid iq actually does give you
some really really good insights into
not only your account but the video and
so recommend vid iq because it's good
for video seo okay there's also tools
related to content optimization so
you know if you're doing seo and you
have a lot of content on your site well
you know what we want to be able to use
a tool
maybe a third party tool to give some
objective reasoning as to what more we
can be doing so you got tools like seo
site checkup or site analyzer these are
pay tools but you know if you're really
heavily invested in seo then they may
pay dividends for you you want to be
able to make sure your content is fully
optimized to the fullest according to
you know google's algorithms and so you
maybe you know want to invest in that
third-party tool so these are good tools
to use for content optimization you know
there's also other key reddit but you
know there's keyboard planner uh in
google there's also a word stream
there's a lot of different keyword tools
out there so you may not have a google
ads platform and so if you don't have
google ads then you may not be able to
gain access to google's keyword planner
so having a third party keyword tool
will pay dividends and say well because
those dividends pay off in the form of
not only pay-per-click but also seo and
if you're heavily invested in content
heavily invested in social then you may
want to take a look at the keyword tool
keyword it and it's primarily used for
reddit we talk about page load time so
we looked at that in google analytics we
know that it heavily impacts seo so
there are other tools available you got
a third party tool here that's free
solarwinds pingdom you actually have
page speed insights by google so these
are free tools that you could take
advantage of in determining how you can
improve your page load time my favorite
topic conversion rate
so you got a couple in here crazy egg
and target okay so i'm going to show you
another tool called hot jar so here if
you log into hotjar.com you can set up
an account it's actually free and with
the free account you can have hotjar
measure the heat map not only the heat
map but the click mapping the scrolling
of a particular page and so here you can
see we're looking at a particular page
here so hotjar allows me to
you know see on that page where people
are clicking um i can also see where
people are moving i can also see
you know the scrolling of a particular
page okay so you can see here on the
page i can see people are moving over
here to the right that's where they're
clicking mostly if i switch over to move
mode then i can see on that particular
page where people are actually moving
their mouse and then i have my scroll
analysis so i could see you know how far
down people actually scroll on the page
and so again with a paid account you can
measure up to 10 000 page views with the
free version you can measure up to 2 000
pages and so 2 000 page views allows you
to get some insight as to what people
are clicking on or where they're moving
or how they're scrolling on a particular
page and so i definitely recommend hot
jar they also do funneling they also do
forms poles lots of other tools
available in hotjar so hotjar.com is a
tool i would recommend as well so one
final tool and i'd be remiss if i didn't
mention it and that's google optimized
so google optimize is a google platform
that allows you to a b test and so a b
testing means that you have an original
page and you're changing one element on
that page to see which one performs
better and so with google optimize it's
just very easy
to set up to run and the whole point of
google optimize and a b testing is to
improve website performance so here you
can see i have an account set up and
optimized you can see we're running one
test here and we're just testing one
element versus the original so we move
photos to the top of the page the
original didn't have the photos to the
top of the page and so we can go into
reporting here google optimize does all
the heavy lifting and so here you can
see
we can look at bounces or we can look at
you know basically a measure the test up
against the metric that's important to
our business and again the whole point
is to improve website performance and so
definitely take a look at google
optimize we'll have another webinar in
the future on the topic but you know to
me google optimize is free you can run
up to five tests okay and if you can run
up to five different tests then that
means you have the ability to really
improve website performance okay so
google optimize is a tool that i would
recommend
carl has a website on cake recipes
unfortunately his website on google is
not ranking well
moreover when searching for cake recipes
keyword his website ranks way below than
his competitors
this can be due to various reasons but
one that sticks out is seo to solve this
issue i have a few important tracking
factors that karl needs to know and
apply if he wants his website to rank
well
before we get started with the ranking
factors let me first explain what seo is
seo is the practice of getting traffic
from organic search results on a search
engine like google bing etc depending
upon the keywords search engines rank
websites based on what content they
consider most relevant to users
without further ado let me tell you the
top 5 ranking factors which can help
carl to rank his website
first is content quality then it's page
speed of a web page after that its
website structure
next is ssl certificates
and finally it's backlinks which is the
most important ranking factor let's have
a look at good content quality
a good content quality is an essential
factor that helps a website to rank on
google
google ranks content that completely
answers a user's query
in our case cake recipes
also longer content rank higher on
search engine results
apart from longer content you can also
optimize your content with few
techniques such as you can start with a
comprehensive introduction
this article on the best vanilla cake
i've ever had is a good example of
having a comprehensive introduction
ensure to write content relevant to the
chosen keyword
for example if your keyword is cake
recipes ensure to write a content on how
to bake a cake rather than focusing on
cake decorating ideas
always create a click-worthy title and
include lsi keywords in your content
in seo lsi stands for latent semantic
indexing they are used to drive content
traffic and create more visibility on
serves an easy way to look for lsi
keywords is on google serve some of the
lsi keywords for cake recipes are easy
cake recipes vanilla cake recipes
chocolate cake recipes and a lot more as
shown on the screen
ensure your heading and subheadings
consist of keywords for example all the
heading and subheading for this article
have the keyword cake
build a comprehensive internal linking
structure of web pages it helps in
spreading link equity across the site
it is important to create a simple
internal website link structure
in the below example a bot crawls on web
page 2 by following internal link of the
web page 1. next add suitable images
with descriptive alt text here using
relevant images can help search engines
understand what your content is about
and this method helps in site ranking
for example for carl's website on cake
recipes he should use suitable images
like wedding cakes birthday cakes etc
incorporate call out boxes as it will
highlight the important information and
increase the dwell time for example if
carl wants to sell his cake he should
place call out box with contact details
immediately after the cake recipes
ensure your webpage is completely
crawlable for bots as it will enhance
website ranking
here as you see this website is high up
on the google search because every web
page in it is crawlable by bots
next opt for mobile friendly designs it
will result in good user experience
for a mobile friendly design always
prefer short and crisp sentences for
easy reading
a poor example and a good example of
mobile friendly designs are shown here
and most importantly update the content
regularly by doing this search engine
rearranges your site's ranking
for example the sally's baking addiction
cake recipe blog ranks at number one on
google the reason it updates content
regularly
next we have page speed
page speed defines how fast the content
of a web page is displayed on the screen
it is important to ensure that a page
speed isn't slow otherwise it will
result in high bounce rate
paid speed can be optimized through
improving your server response time
this can be done by fixing major issues
like slow database queries slow routing
or a lack of etiquette memory
use a simple website design and reduce
the image size that is larger than 150
bytes
next use a content distribution network
as it distributes the load of delivery
content at multiple geographical
locations
you can also optimize your code minify
files if your website has numerous css
and javascript file you can minify and
combine them
google says slow page speed results in
high bounce rate as you can see here
next comes optimizing title tags and url
a title tag summarizes the website's
content and url is a web address
title tags are displayed on serps it is
a clickable headline for a given result
for example chocolate cake recipe cake
recipe
carl cake.com is a title tag of a
website where chocolate cake recipe is
the primary keyword cake recipe is a
secondary keyword and call cake.com is
the brand name
backlinko recommends writing a relevant
keyword in the title tag is important as
it gives an overview of what your
content is about
now talking about urls always refer a
well-structured short and simple url
according to backlinko analysis short
urls tend to rank better than long urls
moving on to our fourth ranking factor
let's talk about ssl certificate
websites using https server have a
higher chance of boost in rankings https
is used for secure communication over a
computer network
as you can see here google confirms
https as one of the ranking factors
there are two ways to improve site
security you can protect your domain by
enabling dns sec protocol or use hsds to
add an extra layer of security over
https whereas hsts protects from
hijacking
the next ranking factor is website
architecture
the famous digital marketer neil patel
says the better your site structure the
better your chance of ranking higher in
the search engines
also backlinko confirms that an
optimized website architecture helps
bots to find and index all of the web
page
a good site structure results in good
user experience
some of the ways to optimize your site
structure are
creating a logical hierarchy structure
which means a good site architecture not
only makes content easier to find but
also helps to gain traffic
include site maps so that the bots can
easily access and index the content
code your site navigation in css or html
because these two languages are easy to
code and understand
build a comprehensive structure of
internal linking as it improves indexing
of a website and helps in spreading link
juice
coming to our last ranking factor that
is backlinks
backlinks is an online navigation of
hyperlinks from other websites to your
own website
in this way we can drive referral
traffic and increase the website's
authority
in seo the more backlinks in a web page
receives the better it will rank in
google
backlinks enhances search engine
rankings brand awareness and referral
traffic
backlinks can be gained through
influencer marketing
engaging with audiences on multiple
social media platforms like telegram
linkedin etc
participating in high pr q a sites like
quora and post answers to the questions
related to your business
today we're going to talk about why you
would want to rank using seo and seo is
search engine optimization also known as
organic search you also may as hear us
say organic listings we're going to talk
a little bit about why you'd want to
rank your website in organic search okay
what is search engine optimization then
we're going to follow that up with how
does google rank websites so
why does it rank one website over
another and how do we get our website to
rank number one then we're going to talk
about the different types of seo or
search engine optimization techniques so
you can get your website ranked number
one and then we're going to finish that
off with the do's and don'ts of seo so
let's get right to it and talk about why
seo so we're going to use a basic
example and let's just say you have a
blog you're a food blogger you're
passionate about food and your niche is
ice cream and let's just say you have a
lot of ice cream recipes you want to get
traffic to your blog you want people to
read your blog and you're curious why am
i not ranking for my blog
why when people type in ice cream
recipes and say google my blog posts
don't appear at the top of organic
rankings and there's a number of reasons
why you wouldn't be ranked for your blog
post or your ice cream recipes and the
main reason would be your competitors so
there could be somebody else out there
who is also passionate about ice cream
and has been blogging a long longer than
you and they have more content and more
blog posts and more pages for google to
rank so that's usually the number one
reason the other reason is improper
usage of keywords and we're going to
talk a little bit or it's actually a lot
more about you know keyword usage in
your content so what kind of keywords do
you want to rank for that's really what
we're talking about when we talk about
usage of keywords what keywords do you
want to rank for and how do we work
those keywords into the content another
reason is port link building practices
and really that means our other blog
posts or other websites linking to you
also are you linking to other pages on
your website and so it's all about link
building and with link building it's
internal linking so are we linking from
one blog post to another and it's
external linking are other websites of
high quality linking to us and so that's
what we talk about when we talk about
link building and then another reason is
web page load time so you could be
running your blog post on say wordpress
for example and your blog post isn't
loading fast enough well if you look at
it this way think about it if you're
google would you really want to rank a
website or blog post in this example
number one on google rankings if that
particular page loaded very slow no you
wouldn't because when somebody clicked
on that link in organic search and went
to your website they're going to have a
bad experience because the page is going
to load slow so google doesn't want
their users to have a bad experience you
don't want your users to have a bad
experience and so that's why web page
load time is a critical factor for
ranking so we need to make sure that our
web pages load fast and then your user
experience is not good enough so
google again based on my example about
the web page load time google wants
people to have a good experience when
they go from their search engine to your
website and there's a lot at play there
specifically web page load time but also
you know google doesn't want any spam
content google doesn't want any pop-ups
or overbearing ads on the webpage they
want people who are searching for
something in particular let's just say
ice cream recipes and they want to find
a relevant website that has ice cream
recipes they want to be able to click on
that link and read some good content
about ice cream recipes it's that simple
and that's really what google's trying
to create in their environment and
that's you as an end user as a website
owner you want your users to have a good
experience and then last but not least
your website is the indexed by mistake
and really what we mean is the indexed
is google needs to be able to index all
the pages on your website so if you have
a blog with a hundred recipes you want
google to have access to all 100 recipes
so we're going to talk a little bit
later about how to get your pages ranked
or indexed on google organic search so
let's move on to what is seo so sticking
with our ice clean blog theme really seo
search engine optimization really is the
practice of increasing your pages that
google has indexed up the rankings so
the end result is we want all our pages
to be ranked number one for particular
keywords so if you want to be ranked for
ice cream recipes well there's certain
things you need to do so that's
generally how it works we need to apply
search engine optimization to increase a
page for keyword we want to be found for
so let me give you an example so let's
just say there's a hundred students that
participated in an essay competition and
so the competition in this particular
case is evaluated on the basis of is the
content relevant are they using suitable
titles for their essay do they have
structure when they're participating in
this essay or talking about the essay
and do they have a suitable synopsis
and is the content neat and readable
these seem all logical for an essay
competition well guess what they seem
logical for seo because that's exactly
how seo works it's exactly all those
points i just may mention about
structure logic readability organization
title all those things are what's
important in seo and so we need relevant
content we need titles for our pages
google needs to be able to see structure
we need to have synopsis of what the
page is about and that's called a meta
description and then again the content
needs to be readable and that's
important and so in order to be readable
again we're going to talk more about
site speed because site speed's
important okay and when we talk about
responsive design when i say responsive
design that means your site your page
needs a load both on desktop and also on
mobile and so all these things are
important just like an essay competition
google is the judge and they need to be
able to determine what page is best to
rank number one number two number three
etc on google search and then link
building remember i mentioned link
building a moment ago well link building
internally and externally also plays a
vital role and so we're going to talk
about that a little bit later in the
class when we talk about off-page seo
how does google rank website and
basically google follows three basic
steps to rank a website they need to
crawl your website they need to take
what they call back to their servers and
when they take it back to their servers
your your web pages they need to
you have them available for indexing so
when somebody actually types in a
keyword into google.com it'll be
available to be found on organic search
so that's what indexing is all about and
then google's job when somebody does
type in a search query is to basically
rank the those pages that they've
indexed from number one to infinity
depending on how many pages are relevant
to that search query so really it's
about crawling indexing and ranking so
crawling is simply a process done by
which google has bots and what these
bots do is they go to your web server
and they're going to crawl every page
that they can find and how do they find
these pages well they basically follow
links you might have heard the term
spydering but that's what they call
search engine spidering so basically
what google's doing is they're building
a web so to speak all the links that
they're following and so when they can
follow all these links on your website
they're going to be able to crawl them
and when they crawl them basically
they're going to take that content and
store it on their servers so it's
available in their index so based on
this method google finds out which
websites have relevant content and which
ones don't based on certain keywords
that are typed into google because if
they can't crawl your website you're not
going to be found and if you can't be
found they're not going to show up for
relevant keywords so we need to make
sure your site's available to be crawled
and we'll talk about that a little bit
later okay but let's show you an example
so let's just go to google search and if
i type in the keyword simply learn okay
i can see i have 1 million 10 000
results okay and that's how many results
are showing up for simply learn okay now
they may not all be simply learned pages
but nonetheless simply learned is ranked
number one here organically and there
are 1 million 10 000 pages related to
the keyword simply learn now when it
comes to organic search uh we don't want
to get it confused with paid search so
anytime you see paid search you're going
to see
something that says add next to it okay
so we could see that
there are paid ads here but when it
comes to organic search those are
generally below paid ads and so that's
where google counts the 1 million 10 000
results and so that's the whole idea
behind crawling and indexing google's
able to crawl simply learn's website and
based on all the pages that they gather
they're going to make those pages
available in organic search so if you
type in a keyword and your web page is
not available for indexing then you're
never going to show up for that keyword
so that's why it's important to make
sure your website is available for
crawling and indexing and so when a user
types a query on search google search
the most relevant websites that are in
google's index are going appear in the
search results so in the example i gave
uh was simply learn well simply learn is
the brand name of the company simply
learned so there's a lot of relevancy
there so that's why you see simply learn
show up here organically number one like
we mentioned about what is seo and why
seo we talked about that user experience
so there's a lot of factors that go into
ranking relevancy being one of them so
in the simply learn example simply learn
is relevant to a lot of the simply
learned pages because that's who they
are simply learn however simply learn
also needs to make sure that you know
for their pages the page load time is
fast meaning these pages load very fast
for the end user and google also takes
into account other factors like how long
someone is staying on a website or are
they bouncing meaning are they going to
one page that they land on and then
leaving the website okay and so the user
experience is very very important there
are other factors also like language and
location and so for example location if
you do a search say in india the results
are going to be a little bit different
than say the results in the united
states why because google is indexing as
many web pages as they can find so if
somebody's doing a search in india
their results may be a little bit
different than the results show up in
the us because google has different bots
and these bots are crawling different
pages at different times and so google's
index is updating continuously but it's
not real time syncing so if you do a
search in india you may not see exactly
the same thing because both search
engines the google and india and the
google in the us are may not be exactly
synced up so an example would be you
know if you're looking for cafe so if
you search a cafe and say san francisco
you're going to see different results
now if you do a search for cafes in
mumbai you're going to see different
results there's going to be local search
here at the top there may be some paid
search but again you may see different
results because one location but two
google search engines in india and
united states google.com aren't exactly
synced up exactly at the same exact time
you do that search so location is
important language is important and
relevancy is important along with user
experience so all those are important
factors in how google ranks websites
okay so we're going to talk about the
types of seo now so if we want to rank
for a particular keyword on google we're
going to have to apply search engine
optimization and so there's two
strategies to search engine optimization
on-page seo and off-page seo so first
we're going to talk about on-page seo so
on-page seo is nothing more than
optimizing your own website and so when
we say optimizing your own website
there's certain elements on your website
and on your web pages that we need to
take into account and so some of those
elements are headers meta descriptions
title tags linking so all of those
elements are something we can control as
an end user who wants to rank our web
page and our website on google and
before we do anything with our website
the first thing we need to do is
understand what keywords we want to rank
for in order to understand what keywords
we want to rank for we need to do
keyword research and if you do anything
in seo keyword research is the most
important activity that's the most
important thing you can do for seo and
why do i say it's the most important
because you need to understand if you
choose a keyword that you want to rank
for you need to understand how much
traffic you're going to get from that
keyword if you're ranked organically say
number one on google so how much traffic
will you get if you're ranked number one
on google so you need to understand what
the volume is and then number two we
need to understand what the competition
is for that keyword that you want to
rank for so if you choose a keyword and
there's not much competition for it then
chances are you can rank for that
keyword for a web page on your website
quicker than say a keyword that has a
lot of competition so we need to
understand those two basic factors
volume and competition before we choose
a keyword and it's it's simply the
practice of going through the motions of
getting your volume and getting your
competition data so you can choose the
keywords you want and then once you
choose the keywords you want then you
can go and apply on page seo you can
change the title tag the meta
descriptions the headers all those
elements can be changed but first you
need to choose your keywords and so
again the primary components we're
looking for are how much traffic you can
get or the search volume how much
competition there is for that keyword
and of course relevancy okay you need to
be able to choose a keyword that's
relevant to the web page you're trying
to rank for and so let me show you
example of how to go through this so the
first thing we want to do is we want to
use a tool and the tool i would
recommend is google keyword planner and
why do i choose google keyword planner
because if we're trying to rank on
google.com or google search engine we
want to be able to get the data right
from the source so google's going to be
able to give us information about how
much volume a keyword has and how much
competition it has so let me show you an
example so if i want to use google's
keyword planner and i want to rank for
the keyword how to become a digital
marketing specialist then i'm going to
type that keyword into google's keyword
planner and what google is going to do
is they're going to give me some trends
about how much volume this particular
keyword gets over the course of a year
and so for that particular keyword i can
see
that there are trends that appear for
both desktop and mobile so mobile is
important because people start their
search process a lot of times on their
mobile device so we want to be able to
get data from mobile as well as desktop
and so we could see a trend here that
for each particular month over the last
12 months we can see how much volume
this particular keyword how to become a
digital marketing specialist gets per
month and so on average on average over
the past 12 months i could see how to
become a digital marketing specialist is
averages 30 searches a month and this is
on google.com and so google gives us the
volume what they also give us is the
competition and so here i can see google
says for that particular keyword the
competition is medium and so in the
google's keyword planner what they also
do is give me other relevant keywords
that i might think about optimizing for
because you don't want to optimize for
just one keyword so how to become a
digital marketing specialist they're
going to also offer up other types of
keywords that are relevant so just
digital marketing specialist social
media marketing specialist so for those
keywords i can see the volume so for
example digital marketing specialist i
can see the average volume is 1 000 per
month on average of the last 12 months i
can also see the competition is medium
but for some other keywords i can see
the search volume being high like
digital marketing course at 2900 per
month but also the competition is high
and so what i would recommend as a best
practice is to collect all your relevant
keywords okay and put all your relevant
keywords in a spreadsheet and when you
put all these relevant keywords in a
spreadsheet you want to get the data on
those keywords and the data i'm
referring to is the volume and
competition so in this case we have
volume from google planner google's
keyword planner and i have competition
from google's keyword planner and so if
i go into a spreadsheet and i put all
that information in here i'm going to be
able to see the volume and competition
and so that's important however one
thing to note here is that google's
keyword planner if we go back just gives
us low medium and high and if i want to
compare numbers to numbers maybe i want
to be able to get exactly the
competition number for the keyword how
to become a digital marketing specialist
what i can do is go into google and i
can type in that keyword so if i type in
the keyword how to become a digital
marketing specialist i can see there's
76 million results so i could see 76
million results 76.1 actually and for
the keyword how to become a digital
marketing specialist now that's a whole
lot of results for this particular
keyword especially when the volume is
only 30
per month on average and so what i want
to do is get a more clear picture of the
competition and so what you could
actually do is type in the syntax all in
title and then colon and then your
keyword how to become a digital
marketing specialist and when i do that
i get a different result here i can see
only 136
listings for how to become a digital
marketing specialist but that's not just
136 that's 136
with that particular keyword that we
want to rank for
in the title tag okay so the title tag
is what you see when you type in a
keyword or search query in google search
and the title tag is what you see at the
top of every search result and so now i
can see i typed in how to become a
digital marketing specialist with the
all in title syntax and now i can see
every listing every one of these
136 results have that particular keyword
in it so i could see every one of them
how to become a digital marketing
specialist and why is that important
because now that tells me i only need to
climb over
136 listings to rank for that keyword
how to become a digital marketing
specialist and so the idea here is you
want to get your volume from google's
keyword planner but you want to get your
competition from google search and again
that's simply typing in the the syntax
hall in title and then your keyword in
this example how to become a digital
marketing specialist once you get those
two numbers you're going to plug them in
to your spreadsheet and then once you do
that for a number of different keyword
queries and these keyword queries again
have to be relevant once you do that
then you can go in and pick the keywords
you want to optimize for and that's
important because again if you're not
sure about a keyword then you want to do
the keyword research so you can be sure
of how much traffic you can get and how
much competition there is those are two
important three important factors in
starting the process for on-page seo so
again you want to
create content for
say a keyword like digital marketing
but digital marketing may seem a little
bit broad so you want to probably stay
away from broader keywords because
broader keywords tend to have a lot of
volume which is great but they may also
tend to have a lot of competition but
that's the whole point of doing the
keyword research maybe it doesn't maybe
there's more volume than competition
that's what you need to find out when
you do the keyword research you need to
find those keywords that are relevant to
your content that have a lot of volume
and low competition and then once we
identify those keywords then we are free
to go in and start optimizing our web
pages for those keywords and the first
place we want to start is the title tag
so if you remember my example going back
here to our search how to become a
digital marketing specialist we saw that
every one of these listings had that
keyword in the title tag and the title
tag is important because that's what
users who use google search see first
when they type in a query and get
results so they're going to see the
title tag so the title tag is the most
important element for on-page seo it's
the most important factor because that's
what people see and so ideally when we
choose our keyword we want to make sure
that keyword is in the title tag because
that's what shows up in google search
and that's what makes that particular
web page relevant for that keyword query
so the idea behind a title tag it's
between 50 and 60 characters and so we
want to make sure we stay within that
limit no more than 60 characters because
what happens if it's beyond that then
google will truncate the title tag so if
i go back to my search you can see here
on this particular title tag google
truncated it meaning they added the
ellipses after the title tag because it
exceeded the 60 character limit so you
want to stay within those character
counts and so the title tag is the first
place you should start when optimizing
your website because when we have the
right keyword
in the title tag and somebody types in
that keyword then chances are it's going
to be relevant they're going to see it
and they're going to click through to
your website and that's the whole idea
behind ranking we want to get clicks so
that's how the title tag appears so when
you optimize it you're going to update
the title tag and this is how it shows
up it's going to show up at the top of
your listing okay and it's going to be
bigger and bolder than anything else
google displays so the second thing you
want to optimize is the meta description
and the meta description is simply just
a brief description up to
155 i would say about 155 to 60 160
characters but probably no more than
that and so the meta description is
nothing more than a summary of the web
page itself so if i go back to my google
search results i see my title tag and i
see the page that this particular
listing belongs to and underneath that
is where i can see my meta description
so in this particular keyword query how
to become a digital marketing specialist
i see the meta description an ultimate
guide on how to build a career in
digital marketing and the skills
required to become a digital marketing
specialist note that it's a well-written
meta description within 155 characters
and it includes the keyword digital
marketing specialist so we're trying to
rank for how to become a digital
marketing specialist and here you can
see become a digital marketing
specialist so there's a lot of relevancy
between not only the title tag and the
keyword but the meta description in the
keyword so when you're optimizing a
keyword you want to start with the title
tag but you also want to update the meta
description because if you don't update
the meta description and you leave the
meta description blank then you're
leaving it to google to add in copy that
they deem relevant and so for on-page
seo we want to take control of the copy
and we want to optimize it for the
keywords we want to be found for so the
meta description is a powerful tool at
our disposal it gives us more characters
to work with it gives us more to talk
about so for that particular page and so
if the title tag is only 60 characters
maximum it's not a lot of information to
try and get somebody to click so the
meta description helps us in identifying
what that page is about in order to get
the click so the two working in tandem
will hopefully increase your
click-through rates so when you're found
organically we want to get the click and
then the third element that's important
is the url and url stands for uniform
resource locator and why is the url so
important because that's what people see
so if i go back to my search result how
to become a digital marketing specialist
notice that the url also includes how to
become a digital marketing specialist
article okay so it's very relevant the
url is very relevant one we can see it
in the search results but two you know
it's relevant to the keyword query and
that's important for the end user and
google google wants to know hey is this
the page that's relevant to the user's
query and if it is then this user is
likely going to have a good x user
experience after they click on the
listing so the url is an element that
helps not only with the click-through
rate but with ranking and having a poor
url structure doesn't help at all
because not only does google not
recognize the url as being relevant but
the end user
may not want to click on that page given
the the way the url looks so you want to
try and avoid a poor url structure so
the rule of thumb is this if you don't
understand what the url is then google
is likely not going to understand what
the url is and so we want to try and
keep our url structures clean and when i
say clean ideally you want to make sure
that whatever keyword you're trying to
optimize that's the keyword that's
included in the url nothing included
that is not understandable so again
going back to our example how to become
a digital marketing specialist it's very
clean the title tag is the keyword the
meta description is cleanly written has
the keyword and then the url is the
other element that the end user can see
and that url includes the keyword in it
so after we've done those three elements
the title tag the meta description and
the url then we want to start optimizing
the page itself so ideally when we say
optimize the page itself the page
remember needs to be structured and when
we say structured it needs to be
structured in terms of you know headers
and subheaders and organized in a manner
in which the end user can read the
article read the content clearly and
concisely without being confused and so
that's the job of headers they add they
add basically an organizational
structure to the content and with
headers there's a hierarchy so you have
anywhere from h1 which is the top of the
hierarchy to an h6 and so you're free to
use any one of those headers when
building out a page in order to organize
the content but ideally you probably
want to stick with an h1 or an h2
because those are at the top of the
hierarchy and what those do is they
actually stress to google that hey
this header with this particular keyword
in it is important so if you use an h6
with the keyword in it it's telling
google hey this is an h6 but it's not as
important so an h1 and an h2 tag show
importance and so let's look at an
example of what that is so here you can
see an h1 is going to be at the top of
the hierarchy so that means it's going
to be bigger and bolder then you have an
h2 which is going to be bigger and
bolder than an h3 but not as big and
bold as an h2 so with headers not only
are you organizing the content
accordingly but you're also signaling to
google how important that particular
header is and of course the header needs
to include the keyword we're trying to
rank for so let's take a look again at
that example so if we go to how to
become a digital marketing specialist if
i click on that page i can look at the
content and i can see that there are
headers in here so the headers are there
to organize the content and that's what
we want we want to be able to organize
the content and if you look at the other
example i'm showing here how to become a
digital marketing specialist a learning
path explored you can see that's an h1
but below it's a subheader the growing
digital marketing job market so that's
an h2 and so we're not stressing to
google that that's more important than
h1 but nonetheless we're stressing at
google that it's important nonetheless
so we want to be able to use headers we
want to be able to use keywords in our
headers in order to stress to google
what's important and also to organize
the content because google likes content
organized okay the next element we want
to focus on is internal linking and so
internal linking if you remember
earlier in the presentation it's
basically links from one page on your
website to another and so here we can
see on this particular article how to
become a digital marketing specialist
there's also links to
other pages on
simply learn's website and so for this
particular content it also links to seo
specialist ppc specialist social media
marketing specialist and digital
marketing specialist so the whole idea
behind internal linking is to link from
one page to another where it's relevant
and in this case it's relevant because
we're talking about how to become a
digital marketing specialist that's what
the whole content is about and so what
simply learns doing here is offering up
other pages on their website that are
relevant to becoming a digital marketing
specialist and so this is a best
practice when you're optimizing a web
page so you want to be able to have
internal linking on your site and the
whole idea behind internal linking is it
also allows users to navigate through
the site naturally so when i say
naturally they don't always have to
refer back to the top navigation they
can naturally and seamlessly go from one
relevant article or page to another and
so that's the whole idea behind link
building and internal link building it
allows google to identify
you know pages that they want to crawl
and index because they're linked to one
another but it also helps the end user
because it allows the end user to go
from one page to another and it's
signaling to google hey this particular
page is linked to this page so we're
going to also index that page and so
that's the whole important part of
internal linking it's about the end user
experience and it's about allowing
google to find the pages on your website
so they can crawl them and index them so
you can be ranked for them and so also
in addition to
internal linking we want to be able to
use natural language and so what do i
mean by natural language or natural
language processing so what google does
is in terms of natural language
processing they're looking for the
content and the keyword it needs to be
relevant so when your website is about
digital marketing you don't necessarily
want to rank or try to rank for the
keyword digital marketing one it's too
broad two there might be some
competition but three you're probably
not going to write something as broad
like digital marketing so ideally what
you want to do is you want to choose
other relevant related keywords that's
going to be more natural and so that's
what we mean on natural language
processing we want to choose keywords
that are more natural to the content
you're writing so instead of the keyword
digital marketing maybe we want to talk
about the types of digital marketing or
digital marketing examples or what is a
digital marketing strategy or how to
become a digital marketing specialist so
those are all relevant keywords to
digital marketing and more relevant to
the content because if you try to rank
for the keyword digital marketing again
it's probably going to be a little bit
broad probably more competition and not
as relevant to your content and as a
result probably not a good user
experience so think about some other
keywords that you could optimize and
rank for and that goes back to the
keyword research that's why the keyword
research is so important because it
allows us to identify
other keywords and the natural language
process what keywords are more relevant
for the content and then another element
on page seo is the sitemap and so with
the sitemap it's basically a list of all
the pages on your website and the whole
idea of listing all the pages on your
website in one document is it helps both
users and search engines
understand the structure of your website
so there are two types of sitemaps one's
an html sitemap and that's designed for
humans so if you have a website with a
lot of content at the footer or the
bottom of your web page you probably
want to have a link to sitemap so if
somebody clicks on that site map they're
going to be able to see all the pages on
your website structured in an organized
manner well an xml sitemap and xml is
just a different format it's designed
for crawlers and so the whole idea
remember is google likes to crawl
content when they crawl content they
bring it back to their servers and index
it and so we want to be able to create a
site map for google or other search
engine crawlers and so xml is the format
so let me show you example of how that
looks so if i go to simplylearn.com and
simply type in say
sitemap.xml just as an example i'm going
to get this particular page and this
particular page displays two xml
sitemaps so these sitemaps are there for
google to go ahead and crawl and nothing
more than a list of all the pages on
your website and so this is a quick and
easy way for google to get a hold of all
those pages so that they can index them
and that's the whole idea behind seo you
want to be able to have google index all
the content you want to be found for for
the keywords you want to be found for so
it all starts with the sitemap so let's
go from on-page seo which in recap is
basically optimizing certain elements on
your website so that you are relevant
for a particular keyword and that meant
updating the title tag the meta
description the url the headers choosing
the right keywords to put into the
content having internal linking and also
updating the sitemap well those are
elements that you can do on your website
so we're going to switch gears and talk
about a different strategy off-page seo
because without on-page or off page you
can't have a page ranking so the two
work together so you can do as much as
you want on on page but you still need
off page seo and you could do all the
off page seo you want but you still need
on page so both of these strategies have
to be in full effect in order for you to
rank so let's now switch gears to
off-page seo and so off-page seo is
simply the process of linking or
promoting your website using link
building and so if you remember i talked
about this earlier on there's two types
of links internal and external linking
and so for on-page seo we used internal
linking for off-page seo we're going to
talk about external linking and external
linking allows us to improve our
website's recognition or relevancy or
credibility and why do we want to
improve our relevancy and credibility
and trustworthiness and authority
because we want google to know that our
web page is trustworthy it is recognized
by other websites and it is relevant for
a particular keyword and so if we can do
that using off page seo methods then
google's going to rank our web page for
the keyword we want to be found for so
it's really off-page seo synonymous with
link building and there's plenty of
opportunities to do link building it
just comes down to creating a strategy
so again some of the benefits to off
page well we talked about you know being
credible and trustworthiness and
relevant we need to do that in order to
rank but there's some other benefits
there so if we have a link on another
credible website then it's likely going
to increase the traffic to our own
website it also creates high domain
authority and so what i mean by high
domain authority is if we have basically
links to other web pages pointing back
to us
then basically our domain authority is
going to improve and when our domain
authority improves other websites are
going to want to link to us so the
higher authoritative we are for our
website then other web pages are going
to want to link to us and so the more
external linking we have the higher the
domain authority so it all starts with
linking to
other high domain authority websites so
linking to a high domain authority
website for example having a link on
wikipedia that points back to our web
page creates high domain authority for
us and it helps drive traffic so some of
the other benefits of off-page seo are
credibility so if we're linking from
wikipedia to our webpage it does create
credibility for us it also helps us
increase our page rank so remember that
external linking helps build domain
authority helps build credibility
trustworthiness and it's going to in
turn help us rank for that particular
page and then certainly not last having
a good off-page seo link building
strategy increases our brand awareness
because if we're on other high
authority websites wikipedia or say a
social platform it's going to increase
our brand awareness and increasing our
brand awareness increases our
trustworthiness and so if somebody is
looking to say become a digital
marketing specialist then likely instead
of typing in digital marketing
specialist on google they may type in
our brand name in this case simply learn
and so these are all the benefits to off
page seo so
it's nothing more than having links on
other websites that are pointing back to
ours and again there's lots of benefits
it's drives helps drive traffic and
increases our authority so those are
things that we want to take advantage of
when we want to rank and the key behind
off-page seo or link building is always
going to be content so from an on-page
seo perspective having quality content
allows that content to be optimized for
relevant keyword and ranked but also
from an off page seo strategy
having high quality content allows us to
have other sites and it doesn't
necessarily have to be a website it
could be a social platform or can be
another blogging platform or blogging
website linked back to ours why because
the content is original it's natural
it's well structured it reads well and
so that's the whole idea behind off page
you can't have links on other websites
if you don't have quality content so one
of the ideas behind off page seo is not
only do you want to create good content
but you probably want to
spend a lot of time or a bit of time on
others websites so remember the example
i used earlier in this presentation
about having an ice cream blog and ice
cream recipes well it probably wouldn't
be a bad idea to say spend some time on
other blogs related to desserts related
to cakes related to food in general
related to vegetables or other items
that people could link from so the whole
idea is understanding who else is out
there who has relevant content that you
could share so you could share your
content with them they can share their
content with you and generally that's
how it works naturally anyway in the web
sphere if somebody likes your content
they're going to link to it they don't
necessarily have to wait for you to ask
them but it might not be a bad idea to
understand who else is out there that
has content similar to yours so that you
can you know get a link on that
particular website or blog post and so
some other ideas behind
having external links pointing back to
your website is social media so social
media is not just facebook or twitter
but it expands beyond that there's
there's core there's medium there's all
sorts of content generated websites like
reddit so the list goes on and on you
just need to find what's relevant for
your content if it's relevant for your
content then it's worth putting or
trying to get the external link on that
social media platform and then again
going back to my ice cream blog recipes
blog post yeah if you find a particular
blog that you want to have an external
link on there's nothing wrong with
reaching out to that particular blogger
you know in some cases very flattering
but in other cases if the content is
relevant then why not it's only going to
help your end user experience if you add
somebody who has a say a blog about
cakes having their link on your blog
post so there's nothing wrong with it
because it also adds to the user
experience and if you're going to ask
somebody to put an external link on
theirs you might want to be open-minded
and make sure that you're are able and
willing to put an external link on your
blog post or website pointing to their
content that's how the web works
especially if the contents are quality
relevant and of good nature okay so
let's move on and finish up with the
do's and don'ts of seo so we talked a
lot about
why seo what is seo you know how do we
rank for seo what is on page seo what is
off page seo and so
let's just wrap up with some of the
things you again want to do to rank your
page for a particular keyword and some
of the things you don't want to do so
the first thing on the list is optimize
for white hat techniques and what i mean
for
opting in for white hat techniques is
basically everything i just mentioned
today you want to do keyword research
you want to choose a natural language
processing form format so you could
choose keywords that are going to be
relevant natural to the content and you
don't want to opt for black cat
techniques and black hat techniques are
probably not even worth going into
detail but one example is choosing a
keyword arbitrarily like say digital
marketing and just stuffing that keyword
into the content so that's probably not
something you want to do because again
it's not going to be good for the end
user so stay away from black hat and
focus on some of the techniques we
talked about in today's presentation the
other do we want to do is get backlinks
from relevant sites so that's off-page
seo again it's what i mentioned earlier
it's about linking your quality content
to another person's website that also
has quality content we don't want to
have a backlink from an irrelevant site
why because it's not going to be
relevant and it's also going to hurt our
authority because if it's on a site
that's not of good quality then google
is going to look at us and say well this
site is linking to your site but it's
not relevant so therefore you know we're
not going to look at you in the same way
as if you were on a quality website we
do want to use our keywords naturally
because title tags are what people see
first on organic search but you don't
want to use the same title tag on every
page of your website so we want to stay
away from doing that so you want to have
a unique title tag for every web page on
your website and ideally what does that
mean that means using our keyword
research to choose one of two keywords
for page and optimizing your web page
for those one to two keywords so you
ideally what you want to do is have one
to two different keywords for every page
on your website we definitely definitely
definitely want to write engaging
content so the content should be
engaging remember user experience we
want users to stay on our website we
want them to enjoy the content that
they're reading and we want them to go
from one page to another naturally we
definitely don't want to leverage or
plagiarize or just copy content from
others websites because it's not one
probably going to be relevant to what
you're writing about two it's duplicate
content and it's somebody else's so
that's a black cat technique we want to
stay away from i can't emphasize this
enough we need to do keyword research
first before you do anything else you
need to find relevant keywords and not
only that you need to understand the
volume and the competition for each of
those keywords okay you don't want to
choose a keyword that has low volume
high competition you want to choose a
keyword that has high volume low
competition but above all you want to
choose keywords that are relevant to
your content we want to avoid keyword
stuffing so don't take a keyword and
just stuff it everywhere on the page
it's not going to be natural
and google's going to be able to pick up
on that so we want to maintain some
level of quality with our content
and quality with the keywords that we
choose so reminder when you have quality
content it's always going to link
internally to another page on your
website with quality content but it's
got to be natural and don't just build
site-wide backlinks meaning don't just
have an internal link to the homepage or
don't have every page on your website
linking to just one page so internal
linking should be natural naturally
linking from one page to another not
only does it help google understand and
crawl all the web pages on your website
but it's good for the end user it's good
user experience and certainly last but
something i didn't talk about does take
time to rank your content so remember
the process you're going to write your
content you're going to choose keywords
you're going to change the elements on
that page for those keywords and all the
while you're going to make sure google
can crawl that content and when they
crawl they're going to index it the
process takes time especially if you
choose a keyword that's competitive so
just be patient if you have quality
content and you've optimized for on-page
seo and off-page seo then you will rank
for that keyword and then make sure your
website's user-friendly and mobile
friendly so we talked about responsive
content earlier so remember most users
today start the process of search on
mobile so we want to make sure your
websites are mobile friendly search
engine optimization starts with the
keyword because we want to be found for
relevant keywords
and so the first step
and search engine optimization is always
going to be keyword research so it is
the most important step and so what is
keyword research all about well it's a
process of identifying keywords we want
to be found for on the search engines so
millions of people use search engines on
a daily basis we want to be found for
those keywords that people type in that
are relevant to the content we want to
be found so going back to the italian
restaurant example if we're writing a
blog post about italian restaurants if
somebody types in the best italian
restaurants or italian restaurants in a
specific city we want to be found for
that content if it's relevant to what we
wrote about so keyword research should
be done based on two factors really it's
fact based on the factor of how much
traffic or volume a particular search
engine query has and it's based on
competition and really
the underlying factor here is that all
keywords in your keyword research should
be relevant so you need to understand
what those keywords are so are they
relevant to the content that you want to
be found for if they are then really the
two factors you want to look for is the
volume how much volume or traffic each
keyword has associated with it and then
the competition how many other websites
are trying to be found for the same
keyword so those are the factors
involved with keyword research you
always want to choose relevant keywords
and then once you find or choose those
relevant keywords you want to be able to
find out exactly how much volume and how
much competitions associated with each
of those keywords and so when you look
at keywords you're always going to
choose relevant keywords but there are
two types of keywords they're short tail
keywords and they're a long tail
keywords and we're going to talk about
both of these here so let's start with
short tail keywords so short tail
keywords are generic keywords generally
they're less than three words in a
keyword phrase for example italian
restaurants so
short tail keywords generally
have very high search volume that means
that if somebody types in italian
restaurants then there's going to be a
large amount of volume with that meaning
that generally a lot of people type in
the keyword italian restaurants however
with high volume always comes high
competition so
if you want to be found for italian
restaurants know that you are ranked
number one or number two or even on page
one of google you're going to get a lot
of traffic however to get to page one of
google or even position one or two it's
going to take you a while because there
are probably a lot of websites who are
in front of you who want to be ranked
and found for the same keyword so the
whole idea with short tail keywords is
it's a lot of visibility it's a lot of
traffic a lot of volume but also a lot
of competition and generally the
underlying factor here is that if you
are ranked for a very broad or short
tail keyword like italian restaurants
then chances are it's not going to be as
relevant so if you get the traffic to
your website then chances are the
conversion's not necessarily going to
happen because we don't necessarily know
the mindset of somebody typing in a very
short tail generic keyword like italian
restaurants they could be doing research
on italian restaurants they could be a
chef who's trying to get recipes for
italian food it could be a tourist
looking for italian restaurants in a
different city or it could be a person
just looking for italian restaurants
near their location or where they're
living and so there's a lot of different
factors with short tail keywords so you
just don't know because it's so generic
and because it's so generic if you do
get the traffic for that generic keyword
then the chances of the conversion are
going to be lower than say if it's a
more specific relevant keyword so let's
take an example
of a short tail keyword let's just stick
with italian restaurants so i'm going to
go to
a tool
called moz and while moz has a tool
called the keyword explorer and within
moz so if you go to moz.com and then use
the keyword explorer you can get an idea
of how much volume and competition are
associated with a particular keyword so
in this example we're using italian
restaurants it's a very broad keyword we
could see that the monthly volume is
between 70 000 and 118 000 per month
okay so that means for a particular
keyword in the united states on a search
engine you're going to get about 70 000
to 118 000 people who type in that
keyword and so if we were to look at the
difficulty of that keyword you could see
that it's fairly difficult because out
of 1 to 100 it's got to score 43 so it's
fairly difficult however if you notice
the click-through rate's very high
so moz estimates that we'll have a 40
organic click-through rate for that
keyword if we're ranked for it so
if it's relevant to us and we want to
get some visibility to our site then
yeah we want to use that generic short
tail keyword however if we're interested
in conversions then we really want to
turn our attention to longer tail
keywords however if you want the
visibility then you want to use short
tail keywords if you want the conversion
then you want to switch over to longer
tail keywords so longer tail keywords
are more specific they usually consist
of more than three keywords so tie-in
restaurants very generic if we add a few
more keywords that keyword phrase it
then becomes longer tail so compared to
short tail keywords longer tail keywords
are generally less competitive and the
search volume is not as high case in
point so if we go back to moz and then
we look at the keyword explorer and we'd
actually type in italian restaurants and
let's just say
orlando florida
moz is going to
generate some monthly volume for us and
they're going to allow us to understand
how difficult that keyword is and so
here you could see very very little
search volume in fact so little volume
there's 11 to 50 okay so that means on
average that this keyword generates 11
to 50 queries a month so very low
compared to our short tail keyword
italian restaurants the difficulty here
didn't necessarily lessen but it is less
uh competitive so if you're interested
in conversions and you have an italian
restaurant in say orlando florida then
this is the key word you may want to use
so there's a trade-off between longer
tail and shorter tail but when visitors
land from longer tail keywords they're
usually ready to make a purchase they're
usually more specific intent there's
more intent involved with a longer tail
keyword so best restaurants in italian
in florida branded shoes in florida
something very specific is going to
generate probably a higher conversion
rate than something more generic so
that's the trade-off and so when to use
long-tail keywords well we want to use
long-tail keywords and for targeting
pages with a product or specific article
so if we're interested in that
particular conversion then longer tail
keywords are likely more the way we want
to go versus something more generic
which means if you're using a generic
shorter tail keyword you're more
interested in the visibility and the
traffic not necessarily the conversion
when you're setting up your brand and
you need to make sure it reaches the
right audience and provide the best
results there's really only one place to
turn to it's one of the largest online
advertising platforms really in the
world and that's on google and so today
we're going to talk about how to
advertise on google and let's get right
to it and talk about google ads and
its effect with advertising so we're
going to start out with what are google
ads well google ads used to be called
google adwords and it's been around a
good while almost 20 years now so really
google has grown at a really rapid pace
it's become one of google's main sources
of revenue uh you could say probably in
the 90 percentile of its revenue comes
from google ads and when we say google
ads we mean people who pay for
advertising on google.com so google ads
really what it does is it provides
services that fall under the category of
ppc which stands for pay-per-click you
may also may hear google ads or ppc
referred to as cost per click or cpc or
sponsored search really what it comes
down to it's a model so when you
advertise on google.com and somebody
clicks on your ad basically you're
paying google for they click okay so
it's just really a business model where
an advertiser pays google to have their
advertisement on google.com but they
only pay google when they get the click
so that's really in a nutshell how it
works for advertisers if i want to
advertise my business i can go to google
ads and say google place my ad on
google.com and then my ad does get shown
on google.com somebody clicks on it it's
just as simple as i pay google a fee so
google ads is just an online advertising
platform developed by google with which
advertisers can pay to display ads they
can offer up their services there's
video involved there's obviously
mobile's involved so you got all the
necessary devices and platforms
available in google's ecosystem so for
example if i go to google search even if
i type in you know what is google ads
here i could see a total of 1.8 billion
results for what are google ads as my
search query so in search you got a lot
of different things going on here you
have organic results you have videos
that are being pulled from youtube you
got a knowledge graph here you got
feature snippets you got an organic
listing but really at the top this is
what we're going to focus on today we're
going to talk about sponsored search so
you can see here for this particular
keyword query that i typed in what are
google ads really two sponsored search
or pay-per-click ads appeared now if i
happen to click on any one of these two
and go to that particular advertisements
website they're gonna pay google a
specific cost per click so that's how it
looks on google.com it really depends on
your query and what ads show up but the
great thing about your google ads is
they make it known for the user who's
doing the search query what the ad is so
here i can easily pick out what's an ad
a sponsored search or pay-per-click ad
and what's not because if it's a
pay-per-click ad or an advertiser
advertising on google.com i'm going to
be able to see this little box here that
says add next to the listing and so by
displaying that little logo their ad
it's letting the end user know the
person who's searching know that hey
this is an advertiser who is advertising
their product or service on google.com
okay so that's how you can differentiate
between paid search and organic search
organic search here or even down here
doesn't have that little ad box next to
the listing so you know if it doesn't
have a little ad box you know it's a
paid search ad now why do we want to
advertise on google ads because it
increases visibility to high quality
audience so
what i mean by that is you know search
is really a great place to advertise
because you're meeting the consumer
halfway meaning somebody's typing
something in and your ad is there to
help them find what they're looking for
so google ads advertises your product or
service to the relevant audience to
ensure the users perform the action
required of them so it's really a great
way to get quality audience to your
website because if somebody types in
something and you happen to offer what
they're looking for basically your ad is
going to show up somebody clicks on it
you pay google for the click and you get
quality traffic in return so the other
great benefit to being on google ads is
increases brand awareness so it's a
great way to get your product and brand
out there google has a vast network uh
also known as the display network but
even on google.com the search network
itself the search engine itself millions
of people use it every day in fact here
in the united states it's been said or
studied that you know people over the
age of 18 use search at least once a day
at least once a day here in the united
states so you can figure that's millions
and millions of people so it's a great
way to get your brand in front of a
large captive audience okay so top of
mind awareness refers to a brand of
product being the first one that comes
to a customer's mind when thinking about
a particular industry or category so it
really does provide top of mind
awareness another benefit to being on
google ads is retargeting so when we say
the word retargeting in marketing that
means you know showing our ad to
somebody who's already been to our
website so we can use google's display
network or we can run remarketing lists
for search ads right on google.com to
ensure that we're targeting those folks
who have already been to our website and
have not performed a function that we
want them to perform such as converting
or buying something or downloading
something or subscribing to a newsletter
or visiting a certain page okay so if
somebody doesn't do what we want them to
do it's okay maybe they're ready to
commit to our product or service and
that's why google offers up retargeting
so it allows us to reach that audience a
second time so they're going to be
familiar with their product they're
going to be familiar their website
because they've been there and so we can
offer up a very unique specific ad to
that audience so that's a really good
benefit to being on google ads so some
other benefits here increased
intelligence so you know we can
certainly get data about who is coming
to our audience so we can look at what
device what you know browser etc so we
can really gain some information about
who's coming to the website we could
certainly
measure our performance so with google
we're paying cost per click and so based
on that model you know we can certainly
measure
what keywords what ads are generating
traffic to the website and how much
we're paying for that okay and if that
traffic turns out to be a lead we can
measure that against that specific
keyword or ad or campaign so we can
certainly measure our performance all
the way down the keyboard level and can
we can measure up against how many
conversions or what we're paying for
those conversions so google ads is a
very highly quantitative approach to
advertising because there's lots of
numbers involved and you're constantly
collecting information about your
advertising on google.com and its
network and another benefit really is
high flexibility so google ads has a
number of different options so we can
customize our ads based on an audience
based on a keyword based on a specific
website based on retargeting so we
really have a lot of options not to
mention the number of options in terms
of the ad format text ads dynamic
responsive ads video ads display ads so
google ads has
very flexible options in terms of
advertising and we're going to talk
about some of those as we move along
here today so another big benefit here
and this is what i always suggest is if
you're not ranking organically then you
might want to consider google ads
because as we've shown here in our
example if i go back to our example a
couple minutes ago you know if you want
to
bid on the keyword what are google ads
why would you bid on that well it's
relevant to your business maybe you're
in the digital marketing industry and
you want to help folks who need help and
advertising on google ads but what if
you want to be found for that
organically well if you're not found for
it organically then you can bid on it so
it definitely is a good option if you're
not ranking for particular keyword
organically so it serves as almost an
option i always say that you know search
is like a fruit bowl okay you have
apples and oranges in that fruit bowl
well the orange is organic search and
the apple is paid search they're
different approaches but they share the
same fruit bowl the same real estate so
you can really really help yourself by
using google ads to complement what
you're doing organically so if you're
not ranked organically for keyword you
can certainly use google ads if you are
ranked for specific keywords and it's a
highly competitive industry then you can
use google ads to help you leverage the
amount of clicks you get from that ad so
it's okay to be organically listed and
have a paid search listing at the same
time so if we go back to our example
here we could see wordstream.com has a
paid ad and here we can see just two
spots below organically they're showing
up with an organic listing so you could
certainly be in both positions to try
and maximize your clicks so it's
definitely a good strategy to run with
google ads on top of everything we
mentioned in terms of measurement
flexibility google ads does offer up a
really good incentive to advertise and
let's not lose focus that again search
is really the only medium in which
you're meeting somebody halfway based on
what they're looking for and when i say
halfway meaning your ad is going to
appear for somebody who's looking for
something whether that be food a cafe a
plumber a doctor
or directions search is there to serve
that that person needs there's no other
advertisement platform or another
channel out there in terms of
advertising that reacts the same way
whether that be tv or radio or email
marketing or affiliate marketing search
is unique in that regard so search
engine results pages are the pages that
are displayed by search engines in
response to an ad so that's serp and so
you could certainly you know be listed
in the serps or also known as organic
search but the great thing is google ads
is there to help you get your brand or
product in front of that user looking
for a specific need or service so let's
shift focus now and talk about the
various formats in google ads on google
search we have text ads so text ads are
the only ad format on google search and
so here you can see in this example you
have a headline so not only do you have
one headline you have three headlines in
one ad so jbl headphones one headline
wide range of headphones second headline
amazon.in third headline so you have
three headlines and the great thing
about google ads with with this text
format is that you can have up to two
descriptions of 90 characters so the
headlines are up to 30 characters the
descriptions are up to 90 characters and
so you can really write some specific
information about your ad about your
product about your service okay and the
ad is also going to contain what we call
ad extensions so here you can see
shop by category in-ear headphones
on-ear headphones those are all site
link extensions meaning they're going to
link to something on your website and so
the purpose of the extension is to help
get the click so the reason why you're
running google ads is to get the click
you want to generate the click you want
to get that traffic to your website so
by writing three headlines and writing
to description lines and adding
extensions to your ad i'll help you get
that click yes you're gonna pay google
for the click but that's the whole
purpose is to generate the click from
search because remember search is there
to respond to somebody's need or query
and so if you get the click on your ad
chances are it's going to be a highly
relevant visitor to your website so
google offers up a lot of
opportunity for you to write a lot of
information in your text ad on google
for google.com so google also has other
formats and so they also have responsive
display ads so when we say responsive we
mean google can serve up a specific
image from your website based on what
somebody's looking for based on the page
that they went to so these ads are
responsive they adjust their size
appearance and format depending on the
space available so responsive can also
be text text and or image and so the
whole point of response is if you have a
large website let's just say with a lot
of different products and categories
like amazon well it's hard to write
static ads for thousands of particular
categories and products so why not let
google do the heavy lifting why not let
google serve up the images and ads based
on what somebody looked at on your
website and so that's the whole idea
behind responsive ads is it allows
google to you know show the particular
ad that's most relevant to that user so
it's a really a great option when you're
advertising on google you have image ads
as well so image ads are as we mentioned
part of responsive or they can just be
static and so here you can see an
example from slack okay you can see just
an image app but the great thing about
image ads is you have a lot of different
size options so 468 by 60 250 by 250 160
by 600 all these are pixel sizes so you
have a lot of different size variations
when you run image ads okay so you don't
have to run a small image ad let's just
say in comparison to facebook where you
have a thumbnail okay and one size for a
particular image ad on facebook first
says google you have multiple multiple
sizes that you can choose from in terms
of running image ads so image ads are
really a great option if you're going to
advertise on google okay you also have
app promotional ads these ads are used
to drive app downloads and engagement so
here you can see an example for uber so
that's another option too if you have an
app and you really want to drive
engagement for that app and then you
also have video so google owns youtube
so you can run advertisements video
advertisements on youtube so they could
be standalone or they can be inserted
into other streaming video content as
say a pre-roll meaning people are going
to look at your ad before actually
watching the actual video they went to
youtube for so you have a lot of
different options with video
advertisements on youtube so the other
ad format you have on google are
shopping ads and shopping ads are really
a great way to get your product
in front of the right user so somebody's
looking for shoes or running shoes it's
an opportunity for you to run shopping
ads so you could put that particular
shoe with a description with the price
with your brand name in front of that
user and so with a cost per click model
if a user clicks on your shopping ad
then chances are they're probably going
to convert because they could see the
product they could see the price they
could see the product name they can see
the brand and so it's an opportunity for
you to really drive high quality traffic
to your site with the opportunity to
convert somebody at a very high rate so
shopping ads are really good because it
prevents unwanted clicks if somebody
clicks on that ad they're definitely
interested so let's take a look on
search to see how that looks so if i go
to google search and i just type in
running shoes so my search results are
going to list not only some paid ads but
a lot of different options on shopping
ads so here i could certainly scroll
around and see all the different brand
names i could see the price point if i
hover over it i can actually see you
know some other information about it
like reviews
return policy so if i actually click on
this ad chances are i'm going to buy it
otherwise why would i click on the ad as
an end user and so that's the great
thing about shopping ads it gives you
the advertiser an opportunity to really
get your products in front of people who
are looking for your product or service
and given that you're listing the price
if they like the price and they click on
your ad they're probably going to go
ahead and follow through with the
conversion so it doesn't necessarily
have to be running shoes it could be
anything that you have to offer a user
so running shopping ads on google is a
good strategy if you have products okay
so you can showcase these these shopping
ads on google search by certainly
really giving google access to your
product inventory connecting in some
reviews connecting in some information
connecting in the pricing points and
voila it's really very fairly easy to
set up google shopping ads within google
search and the great thing about
shopping ads is it also appears under
images and also pairs under shopping so
if i'm on google search you know i can
go to shopping or i can go to images and
i'll see those same image ads show up
here at the top and i will certainly see
those under shopping as well so
shopping ads allow you to really
showcase your products on google search
to those looking for that particular
product so it's really a great option
with google you also have call ads so
when we say call ads really call only
ads are great for mobile so when you run
advertisements on google if you have a
phone number associated with your
business you can certainly add that
phone number to the ad so if somebody's
searching on their mobile device and
your ad is displayed along with your
number if they click on your number
they're actually going to call your
business and google can track that they
can track how many people click on your
number and even turn that into a
conversion for you so if you have a
phone number associated with your
business it's wise to go ahead and set
up you know what we call a call
extension as part of the app because if
somebody sees that ad with that phone
number on mobile it allows them to
easily just click on the number and call
your business and so google can track
calls as well so keep that in mind if
you have a phone number and you want to
associate that phone number with an ad
okay so let's move over to where is
google showing your ads i showed you an
example of google search so we looked at
text ads we looked at shopping ads on
google search network so google search
network really allows you to advertise
on google search so with google search
if i go back to google search and i go
to all i typed in running shoes okay
here i can see shopping ads here i can
see a couple of text ads so you have the
opportunity if you're running only text
ads to show at the top and if you're not
at the top then google will place you at
the bottom so really depends on the
keyword that somebody's querying in
google search so it really depends on
how many people are advertising and so
what google does if i didn't have any
shopping ads here google will list a
maximum of four text ads at the top and
at the bottom any other ads that weren't
shown at the top will get placed at the
bottom so ideally if you're running text
ads on google you want to make sure
you're always at the top and i would say
between positions one and three you
always want to make sure you're at the
top okay so you can certainly measure
that remember google had has measured
performance so you can measure
everything about your ad so if you're
going to advertise on google with a text
ad you want to make sure you're always
at the top so let's have a look at the
different types of search networks that
google ads is affiliated with so
the first is google search okay so let's
focus on google search and so basically
when we say google search or search
sites we really mean google.com or all
google search engines for that matter so
if you want to advertise to a mass
audience you want to probably start with
google.com because again millions of
people use it on a daily basis and so if
you're advertising on google.com your
ads will appear basically below or above
the search results on a google search so
if somebody searches for something
depending on the search query they're
going to see results now depending on
the device as well so they could be on
mobile or on desktop they could see
sponsored ads or paid ads they could see
local listings and they could see
organic search results so for example
this is what an ad would look like so
let me show you what that looks like on
google search so if we go for example to
google.com and type in the keyword
classes on digital marketing we could
see some search ads here these ads
appear above
some featured snippets and the organic
search results okay so
depending on a lot of different factors
again i've mentioned this throughout the
webinar there are a lot of factors in
showing up in the top position second
position third position and so forth
okay if i scroll all the way to the
bottom you may even see ads down here
depending on how many people are
actually bidding on the keyword phrase
classes on digital marketing so we could
see simply learn here in the second
position why because again i can see the
logo add here okay so i can see simply
learn using three headlines i can see
simply learn using there are two
description lines here and i could see
simply learn using some other extensions
with the ad now all of this is geared
towards getting the click so when you're
on google search the whole idea is
somebody's looking for something you're
offering that up and so it doesn't even
matter if you're in the top position
ideally you want to be in these top
three positions in order to get the
click okay so that's the whole idea
behind being on google search if you're
on google search you have the
opportunity to be at the very top of the
search result or in the top three above
local listings and above organic results
now if i change my search query and
typed in coffee in san francisco my
search results are going to be
completely different i'm going to see
local listings here okay so this is tied
to google my business not google ads
okay so this is completely different so
don't don't mix this up with running ads
on google search so google my business
is tied to local listings or google maps
and again with desktop which is what i'm
showing you the search result on you're
going to see likely google local
listings above organic results okay and
if i go back to my previous query of
classes on digital marketing i'm going
to be able to see paid search results
above local and organic listings so in
other words if you're running ads ads
are going to trump any other type of
results on google search if you can be
in positions one through three now in
addition to google.com google also has
something called google search partners
so if you set up an account and you set
up a campaign in google ads you have the
option to choose google search as your
network and then as an alternative or an
additional option you can advertise on
google search partners sites and so some
of their search partners can range so
basically these are sites that have
partnered up with google that's allowing
google to show ads on their site so the
sites can range anywhere between youtube
to amazon to new york times let's take a
look at an example it could even be
another search engine so if i go
to say ask.com and type in classes on
digital marketing it's a completely
different search engine but i can see
the same ad for simply learn so i can
see same i could see a different
headline here actually but i can see the
description and i can see some site link
extensions and so
notice the ad is still at the top in
this case it's in position one and i can
see
multiple companies running
advertisements why because they can see
ad next to it and i could see those over
over organic listings so these are
google search partner listings so you
can opt in to be on other partner sites
that google or other sites that google
has partnered up with so you have
options outside of google search and
that option is display network so
display network allows you to advertise
elsewhere which is outside of google
search and if you're going to advertise
on google's display network you have
more ad formats available to you
including image and including a video
for example your ad can be found on a
specific
website if you choose to advertise on
the new york times.com or webmd or
marriott.com you could certainly do that
okay you just need to tell google hey
this is the site i want to advertise on
so some of the advantages of being on
the display network so if you don't want
to advertise on google search okay
google.com you can certainly go to
display and on the display if you're
running display ads or or even video ads
you're going to grab the attention of
potential customers because of the
format of the ad okay so putting your
ads in front of people early on in the
buying cycle can have a very positive
effect so you're basically
reaching out to a large number of people
on google's display network and giving
them an opportunity to see who you are
as a brand and giving them an
opportunity to see what your product is
all about so for me the display network
is a good opportunity to get your
product and service in front of a lot of
people because this way the display
network works is it's a millions of
websites who want to have advertising on
their site and so you can really pick
and choose a specific site where your
audience is going to be and get your ad
in front of that audience so you can
really retarget to potential customers
so retargeting as we said earlier is
really reaching out to people who have
already been to your website and didn't
perform a particular function that you
wanted them to perform meaning somebody
came to your website from paid search on
google.com and they went to page a and
then they left so you really wanted them
to go to page b add a product to a
shopping cart and check out and purchase
that product however if they didn't do
that you could certainly run ads knowing
that they've been to page a and page b
and you can offer up that specific ad to
that person who's been to your website
and so that's what retargeting really is
all about and you can retarget on
google's display network so remarketing
your product to people who previously
visited your your website or even your
app allows you to really get your ad in
front of a qualified audience and so you
could take advantage of analytics so
google's ads has all the information you
need so let's actually take a look at
some of these options in google ads for
the display network so if i actually go
to google ads and i actually go to
display campaigns i can see i have a lot
of different options available to me so
if i click on keywords for example okay
i can choose keywords for my display
campaign so what google does if you
choose keywords basically what they're
doing is they're going to contextually
place your ad based on the keyword okay
so that's an option for you if you're
not sure what websites to be on with the
display network you can certainly just
add keywords and based on those keywords
google will place your ad on websites
that they deem relevant to the keywords
you choose so you can also choose
demographics so on the splake network
you can say hey google i only want to
advertise to say 18 to 24 year olds or
25 to 34 year olds and so based on that
google is going to place your ads on
websites related to that age demographic
you're interested in on the display
network you can also choose topics so if
there's a specific topic that you want
your ad to be associated with you can
certainly do that so google has a number
of different topics at their disposal so
here if i just choose a particular ad
group now i have specific topics that i
can choose from arts and entertainment
food and drink to news to pets and
animals and so under each one of these
topics i can get really specific so if i
go under science i can see subcategories
under the topic science i can see
chemistry and physics and scientific
institutions and equipment so i can
really pick and choose specific topics
where i want my ads to be shown as i
mentioned already you can pick and
choose specific placements okay so if
you have a specific website that you
want your ad to be shown on you can
certainly let google know okay you can
also advertise on gmail you can also
advertise on youtube so you can really
pick and choose where you want your ads
to be shown so you have all these
different options available to you to me
one of the best options for advertising
on the display network because when you
tell google you have a specific audience
you want to target and that audience
could be somebody who went to a specific
page or somebody who went to your
website and didn't convert you can
associate that audience with the
campaign and when you associate that
audience with a campaign you can
retarget them with an ad so the display
campaign is very powerful with google
because you have all these different
options available to you so with google
ads you can also determine how well
you're reaching your goals which
websites you're running your ads on
which ads are bringing in clicks and
which site gives you maximum value for
the minimum cost so you can see all that
in google ads so when i actually pick
and choose how i want to target i can
certainly measure that so for example
audiences or demographics for example if
i go back to demographics i have all
this data that google's collected on my
advertising so i can see for example
by age range based on my campaign how
many clicks how many impressions
impressions are how many times my ads
been seen click-through rate meaning the
rate at which people see my ad and are
clicking on my ad how much i'm paying
per click cpc is cost per click total
cost and conversions how many
conversions am i getting so i could see
all this data available to me in google
ads so it's a very powerful platform for
measuring performance imagine it's the
year 2004.
this is phil
phil's looking to release a book and set
up a blog he's sure that he'd be
successful but he's only worried about
one thing
he doesn't know how to ensure that his
book reaches the right target audience
who could enjoy his book
during that period of time however there
were only a few forms of advertisement
available like print ads billboards
radio direct mail direct sales and the
television
all of these options were pretty
expensive their effectiveness couldn't
be accurately determined and they didn't
let him advertise his content to the
appropriate audience
phil's book would never find the
audience it deserved now let's have a
look at the same scenario in the present
day alongside traditional forms of
advertising phil would have access to
digital marketing
a form of marketing that's a lot more
lucrative inexpensive and configurable
marketing that would enable marketers to
advertise their audience digitally using
channels like search engines websites
social media platforms emails etc among
these types social media marketing cop
fields eye social media marketing would
give phil the opportunity to take
advantage of social media platforms to
advertise his content to a highly
targeted audience it would help more
people learn about his book increase the
interaction with his audience it's
relatively inexpensive unless he goes
into advertising and will help him get
marketplace insights that might help in
understanding his audience preferences
better
phil started by taking up a
certification to learn about social
media marketing
since he was already familiar with the
concept of social media marketing his
next step was to learn about the
different types of content he could post
on social media
some of the most common forms of content
that phil could post would be images
text posts polls and videos
but over time phil begin to notice that
not a lot of people were being exposed
to his content phil needed to advertise
his content for that he would need to
use the advertising options provided by
the social media platforms like facebook
instagram youtube linkedin and twitter
most advertising platforms offer users
with a number of different options like
image ads these ads involve the use of
single or multiple images that are
attractive and have the optimal amount
of text
they also have a call to action that
encourages user interaction
phil could use images from his book
advertise websites that sell his book
and more then there are text and post
ads
these ads could advertise posts or
excerpts from phil's blog or his book
further garnering interest from an
interesting audience
he could also use video ads phil could
use video ads that feature favorable
reviews and customer testimonials to
advertise his books
phil could also use lead ads through
which he could collect information from
users who are interested in a weekly
newsletter or regular updates from his
blog
but that wasn't the only thing phil
could do with social media platforms he
could create a brand for himself and
drive audience interest to it engage
with them create an identity engage with
content finding content that works for
him
social media platforms also allowed him
the opportunity to target audiences
based on demographics like their age
location gender and much more and in
time phil began to see an increase in
the number of viewers coming to his
social media page and by extension his
blog
he also saw an increase in the number of
people who bought his book greatly
increasing his audience
here are some things he learned one to
set goals that were quantitative smart
and follow a constant deadline two to
understand his audience by engaging and
connecting with them
three to set up a social media calendar
to plan competitions polls surveys
videos and more
four
using tools like buzzsumo ifttt buffer
and more for lead generation creating
email lists setting buyer personas and
more
5. to perform visual storytelling with
the help of images and videos
but how did phil get so good at social
media marketing
phil had taken up simply learn's digital
marketing course it was thanks to this
course that phil had the skills and
training to get good at social media
marketing and now you can too
by clicking on the top right corner
and with that we've given you an
introduction to all the major concepts
of social media marketing the world we
live in now it's highly digital place
but that wasn't always the case until
four years ago so if we rewind letting
people know about your products was a
little harder then so even if you go
back say five or ten years promoting
your products wasn't as easy as it is
today i mean people had to resort to you
know good old-fashioned newspapers
putting in an ad or those big thick
books called the yellow pages that
usually sat in your closet
and wait a ton i mean those were the
ways to get your product and message out
there a lot of advertising in those
yellow pages then you have billboards
you know driving down the highway you
see that billboard on the side of the
road you wonder who are those people
that are actually advertising this stuff
of course you have television that's
been around for decades a good source of
advertising but costly and then facts
facts ads uncommonly known way to
advertise by the way who has faxes now
but people did advertise vfx just a few
decades ago so these were all the ways
in which people had to get their product
and service out there it seems like so
archaic looking at it now but back then
that was legitimate that was the way to
do it and then one thing made our lives
a lot easier so if you're a marketer
you're thinking yourself man i'm glad
i'm a marketer in today's day and age
because it's social media marketing
social media marketing has made
everyone's lives better from the company
that's selling the product or service to
the marketer promoting the product and
service to the end user who wants to see
that product or service that engages
that product or service so social media
is a good source of getting your product
and service out there and it just makes
everybody's lives a heck of a lot easier
so we're going to answer that million
dollar question and what's that million
dollar question it's how can you rise
above the rest and so today's session is
going to be how to start with social
media marketing so you can rise above
the rest leveraging this great platform
that we all take advantage of today so
let's start by asking the question what
is social media marketing social media
marketing involves increasing website
traffic it centers around engagement it
offers you the ability to increase your
brand awareness and it has other
marketing goals you know so you can
create various forms of content for
different social media platforms so
that's really in a nutshell with social
media marketing so again if we want to
increase our traffic or we want to
increase our engagement like likes or
comments then look no further than
social media marketing if we want to
engage with our users our customers our
potential and prospective customers we
can really put a personalized experience
in place using social media marketing we
want to create different forms of
content
like videos and blogs and infographics
and other types of graphics with the
potential to actually go viral and what
we mean by viral is spreading like
wildfire one user sending it to another
as rapidly as can be and before you know
it you get you know millions of views
and millions of likes i mean that's the
power of social media marketing so why
do we want to do social media marketing
and i think we just answered some of
those questions but let's dig a little
bit deeper we mentioned in our
definition of social media marketing
that we have the opportunity to
really build our brand awareness and
that is no more truthful than with
social media marketing more so than any
other digital marketing channel social
media marketing allows us to really put
our brand in a good light in a good
position in front of the right eyeballs
so it allows us to really improve our
brand by pushing out the appropriate
content in front of the appropriate
people social media is a great channel
for that we can look to conversion rates
so if we are pushing a product and
service in front of the right eyeballs
and we are building up a funnel of
prospective customers who then turn into
customers who then turn into loyal
customers who then turn into lifetime
customers we could see at every step in
the process that our conversion rates
may increase we can certainly leverage
social media marketing for seo for
search engine rankings it's about
off-page seo it's about posting content
on social media platforms to build up
some link juice okay so there is some
inherent benefits to working seo and
social media side by side it's cost
effective well if you're posting content
on twitter or facebook it doesn't cost
you anything it just takes a little bit
of time and creativity now if you want
to go ahead and do some advertising on
these platforms yes it's going to cost
you but you'd be surprised not going to
be as costly as say other search
platforms like say google or bing where
you're actually paying for keywords and
paying per click for those keywords so
social media marketing can be very cost
effective and then increase top funnel
traffic so it goes all the way back to
brand experience and brand awareness if
you're putting yourself in position to
get seen by your target audience okay
your target audience goes from seeing
your brand for the first time to
getting to know your brand a little bit
more to maybe buying a product or
service from your brand then returning
to buy another product and service and
then continuing to buy that product or
service i mean that's increasing the top
funnel traffic and not just the traffic
but the conversions so at every step in
the process social media allows you to
build that funnel depending on where
somebody is whether they're seeing your
brand for the first time or actually
returning to purchase the product or
service again so that's the inherent
benefit these are the inherent benefits
of social media marketing today we are
going to talk about all the different
ads that facebook has to offer so
introduced back in 2007
the facebook ads platform has grown
tremendously over the last few years
almost four billion dollars of revenue
in one year so what does that mean that
means there's a lot of advertisers why
is there a lot of advertisers because a
lot of people use facebook it's a
popular platform so not only is it
popular but it's popular with
advertisers because if you're
advertising on facebook you have the
opportunity to
share your product and your brand with
users who you think are going to buy
your product or associate with your
brand and on facebook you can do that a
number of different ways specifically in
somebody's news feed and specifically
that person's news feed that again is
interested potentially interested in
your brand your product so there's a lot
of ways to advertise and a lot of
reasons why you want to advertise so i
just mentioned one of the reasons hey
it's an opportunity for you to reach out
to people who are targeted who are
specific to
your product and your brand so not only
that but you combine that target
audience with the amount of time that
people spend on facebook okay people
spend a lot of time on facebook in fact
not only do people spend a lot of time
on facebook there's a lot of people on
facebook in fact 2.27
billion in the third quarter of 2018 and
so when we say spend a lot of time we
mean going to that facebook profile at
least once a day okay so a lot of
eyeballs throughout the day checking
their news feed on facebook facebook
also enables you the advertiser to find
the perfect audience and so that's the
great combination a lot of people on
facebook and targeted audience so it's a
platform that allows you to put your
product in front of people based on
specific interests specific demographics
specific location so you're really
really putting your product out in front
of the right people at the right time
and so the other positive and pro about
facebook is it's lesser spend greater
reach and what do we mean by that well
traditionally facebook is a little bit
cheaper
than other
online advertising models it is
definitely a lot cheaper than your
traditional advertising models and
facebook has been known to have good
return on investment because it's cost a
little bit less than other advertising
models and other advertising platforms
so that's the other benefit to being on
facebook so if you're into building a
brand you want to be on facebook why
because it helps you increase your brand
awareness it's going to help you allow
users to know what your brand is all
about because remember you're putting
your brand in front of like-minded
people or people you think that are
going to associate with your brand that
are going to associate with your product
so you put your brand out there you
incorporate your your advertisement in
somebody's news feed it's going to add
value it's going to establish trust and
credibility especially if that person's
friend is associated with that brand so
instant credibility if friends and
family members of a person on facebook
are associated with your brand so it has
the opportunity to really lend a lot of
credence to somebody who is on facebook
active on facebook and is your targeted
demographic and the great thing about
facebook is it also has other features
those are advertising features such as
retargeting so you could target people
who've already expressed an interest in
your services product but if they didn't
go through
the conversion process meaning they
didn't go all the way through and and
buy your product you can certainly reach
out to them again just like your
traditional retargeting options on say
google or some other advertising
platform facebook works the same way we
want to be able to reach out to people
who aren't fully committed at that point
in time but we can reach out to them at
another point in time and so facebook's
advertising platform allows us to do
that so it's a great feature that we
could take advantage of that we'll talk
about more throughout this session and
then it helps increase revenue sales and
leads and and that's primarily what most
advertisers are after you know more
revenue more sales more leads so
facebook allows us to educate our
audience again a targeted audience about
a specific product we have to offer so
the more our audience knows about our
product especially if their friends and
family members and colleagues are using
the product then the more likely they're
going to purchase so if you go back to
the other feature higher revenue less
spend this is the primary reason because
you have a chance to influence somebody
who's very targeted who's very active on
the platform and who may have
like-minded people in their life
associating with your brand and product
so it's a perfect
combination for advertising perfect
combination and so today we're going to
talk about all the different types of
facebook ads and we're going to start
out with the single image ad and the
single image ad are just single image
advertisements that have an optional
text on top and a link description that
links to the website so single image ads
are probably the most popular you can
see them on probably your own facebook
feed if you look so in fact i'll just
jump over to my facebook feed right now
and if i go there what do i see i see a
single image ad here and it's from
shopify partners so become a shopify
partner at ecommerce to your list of
qualifications so shopify must be
you know a brand that is trying to woo
my business okay so they know that
somebody that i'm associated with or
maybe i fit their demographic so they're
targeting my news feed with a single
image ad so that's what a single image
ad looks like it's simply just one
single image with some description and
the great thing about this single image
if you haven't noticed is the pixels are
pretty large it's 1200 by 628 so it kind
of stands out a little bit it's not your
traditional thumbnail it really pops
when you look at the news feed so again
if i go back to my news feed here you
can see it just really stands out within
the news feed so i can't miss it if i'm
a targeted part of their targeted
audience it's hard for me to
you know not see this ad interact in
some way especially again if i know
somebody in my network on facebook or
either that be a friend or family member
is associated with that product okay in
addition to the single image ads
facebook also has multi-product ads or
also known as carousel ads and so what
the carousel ads do is allow you in
carousel form allow you to rotate
different ads with different messaging
and different call to action and so here
you can see
simply learn has a example of a carousel
ad where they're showcasing their
different courses so this allows users
to view a range of all your different
products and services if you have
multiple products and services to offer
then the carousel ads would be a good
option for you so in addition to the
carousel ads and single image ads it
gets a little bit more sophisticated in
terms of technology where facebook
allows us to offer up video ads and so
video ads are
interactive it's a good way to really
showcase your product your brand your
service and the great thing about the
video ads is they can go from just a few
seconds all the way up to
you know two minutes or excuse me all
the way up to 120 minutes and so you can
really really put a lot of time and
effort into the video ads to really put
your brand out there and so the one
thing about video is it is interactive
most people engage with video and they
tend to get about 10 to 30 percent more
views than other forms of ads so the
video ads are really a popular way for
you as an advertiser to put your brand
or product out there so you can put your
brand and product out there in not just
a few seconds but you know really tell a
nice complete story to get the
engagement to get the person to take the
action you want them to do so that's why
video ads have become very popular
because they tend to get more engagement
more interaction than your traditional
single image ad or say your carousel ad
so facebook also allows us to
advertise something called lead ads and
what lead ads allow us to do is obtain
user details okay so we can acquire or
get an email address or phone number
from somebody who's interested in our
product or service and that person
doesn't even have to leave facebook so
if you look here in the example here we
have the ad somebody clicks on sign up
and they get this form submission and
the great thing about the lead ad is
that it can sync up with any crm or most
of your popular crms i should say for
example salesforce is a good example of
a crm where somebody fills that out the
information goes directly to salesforce
and so lead ads are really good if
you're trying to generate you know leads
for your business and the form itself
the interaction stays right in facebook
and so that's the great thing about it
they don't really have to leave the
platform another form of advertising on
facebook are slideshows okay so unlike
the carousel ads which rotate and the
carousel ads remember rotate and
showcase different products or services
these ads are are interactive but
they're rotating different imagery so it
allows you to really
put your best images out there with a
really strong call to action just like
you see here with the simply learn
example okay so they're showcasing you
know they're different classes and then
they have the get started today call to
action to really punctuate the slideshow
ad so what's interesting is you can
really gauge a person's interest by
throwing different products or images
out there you know you can really
immerse a user's experience here by
showing different different images and
then the last type of ad on facebook is
called the collection ad and so these
ads combine
basically your video your slideshow or
your product images taken from your
product catalog okay so
if you're an advertiser
who wants to advertise several products
at once then this could be a great
option for you the collection ad so here
you can see the simply learn example
here they're showing you know not only
you know some some good slide shows and
imagery with some good messaging below
that
instagram is a social media platform
that needs no introduction with nearly 1
billion monthly active users and 500
million daily active users instagram is
a platform drive with marketing
potential
more than 7 billion revenue has been
generated from instagram mobile and it's
home to more than 2 million advertisers
not only that marketing on instagram has
the following advantages too
you have increased conversions according
to research more than one third of the
people using the app have used it to
purchase products which means by
marketing your products on the app
there's a higher chance of conversion
you also have advanced targeting options
this is in part thanks to instagram's
parent company facebook instagram has
access to just about all advertising
features offered by facebook ads with
this you can advertise to people based
on their age location gender interests
and much more
you can also build better brand follower
relationships you can stimulate
conversion with your followers and build
a connection with them you'll also get a
greater understanding of what your
followers like and dislike based on
their engagement this enables you to
make content they enjoy more and
increase the chance of converting a user
to a consumer
so let's have a look at how marketing is
done on instagram
let's start with number one optimize
your bio
your bio is the first thing people
notice when they get to your page that's
where they make the first impression of
your brand and that's why it's important
for your bio to be informative
captivating and engaging
use your bio to provide a brief
description of your brand or product the
type of content you'd be posting brand
hashtags links to other social media
platforms and more
your bio should also include a url to
where you want to drive traffic to be it
your brand's website or a page for a
particular product
make sure to track this link as well to
see how much traffic it brings
here's an example of how samsung uses
its bio effectively
you can see it's a very straightforward
it's got a branded hashtag it talks
about all the services samsung offers
there are links to other pages and a
link to the website as well it's to the
point and covers everything you need to
know about it
next up at number two we have create a
content calendar
now if you ask anyone who works with
social media one of the most important
things they'll tell you is to have a
content calendar
a content calendar enables you to keep
track of your posts
it'll help you plan ahead and automate
the process of publishing your posts
when your audience is most active
a calendar helps you decide what content
caption hashtags videos goes live on
what day date or time a consistent post
schedule will enable you to make the
most out of instagram it'll also keep
your audience engaged and also give you
access to historical posts if you want
to repost your older content
next up we have number three get greater
reach with ads
paid ads can enable you to get more
followers engagement leads and
conversions
the caveat here being that you'll need
to pay for it too the ad options are
pretty similar to what you have on
facebook like audience segmentation
based on likes interactions buying
habits and more
you also have a variety of ad formats to
choose from like story ads image ads
video ads collection ads and more
moreover they can also be set up from
facebook ads manager
here's an example from an ad from
bodyshop in which they're using a single
image ad the advertising works because
of its interesting creative and
attractive ad copy that attracts the
customer to interact with the post and
click on the link
let's go to number four have a visually
consistent feed
instagram is a platform in which people
gravitate towards aesthetically pleasing
content
to authentic expressions and diverse
perspectives the objective is that your
feed needs to match with your brand's
identity and must appeal to the audience
within your industry what works nowadays
are candid shots muted earthly tones
with a low-key editing style your
content must feel down-to-earth and your
brand approachable
as you can see in the images all of them
have acidically pleasing images and a
somewhat blue or underwater theme
and that's the kind of thing you should
aim for your content following an
understandable and interesting aesthetic
depending on the product you're trying
to sell
now for number five tell a story
the images videos and stories you post
need to tell stories that can captivate
your audience and establish a connection
with them
this makes it more likely that they feel
closer to your brand and by your
products
your captions can tell stories that can
help your brand appear more human and
build deeper connections with your
audience
your content needs to align with what
your audience cares about or solves
problems they face
here's an example of how the page
patagonia talks about forests in america
each of their posts tells stories about
a different issue that affects nature
their brand on instagram revolves around
bringing awareness to such issues
that's the kind of stories you should
tell with your brand
next up number six use the right
hashtags
using the right hashtags can make the
difference between your posts showing up
on the explore tab for everyone to see
and getting lost in the sea of content
your hashtags shouldn't be too generic
like new year or hash style since
they'll have too much competition
instead mix up trending and industry
specific keywords to connect with your
followers
research on successful hashtags and
limit yourself to less than seven in
each post
the more the hashtags in your post the
more likely it seems spammy untargeted
and unprofessional
find out what and how many hashtags your
competitors use and how you can do
something similar
you could also create a hashtag for your
brand these need to be short easily
memorable and involve your brand name in
some way
let's now go to number seven
take advantage of ugc
ugc or user generated content gives your
followers to further involve themselves
with your brand
ugc also by them as well regardless of
the field your brand belongs to ugc can
be used to convert followers into
advocates of your brand
here's an example of how starbucks uses
user-generated content and takes
advantages of their audience to
advertise their products
in this post here they are attracting
customers with an image of happy
children dressed in products stored at
starbucks
the post posted by another user would be
appreciated by the audience and improve
brand loyalty
next up number eight
take advantage of video ads
most instagrammers state that users have
visited websites searched or told a
friend after being influenced by posts
even though photo ads are still the more
popular form of advertising video
advertisements aren't too far behind
there are three key video formats when
it comes to instagram ads
single video ads that can create 60
second ads corrosions are a combination
of images and videos and instagram
stories that enable you to combine
images and videos to create visually
attractive ads
here's an example of the brand pizza 73
using story ads to advertise their
pizzas
it's successful because you're showing
off the product they are advertising
with well short videos and captions
now for number nine partner up with
influencers
connecting with influencers will enable
you to connect with thought leaders
within the industry and enable you to
show off your brand to a larger audience
by connecting with them your brand will
have greater authenticity and authority
influencers need to be given new tools
resources and guidance to carry out
their role effectively and to work
together as partners
micro influencers are also considered to
be more affordable and they have a
closer connection with their audience
here we can see how ralph lauren have
collaborated with an influencer to
advertise their products the influencer
showing off the latest ralph lauren has
to offer this encourages his interested
followers to check out the page and buy
something for themselves
next for number 10 host contests and
giveaways
contests enable your audience to engage
with your brand with 3.5 times more
likes and 64 times the comments you can
give away a product or a service which
enables you to boost engagement and
brand awareness
contests and giveaways need to be
planned brands need to be partnered with
contest rules need to be identified
posts need to be created and much more
monitoring the contest and then running
it is also really important you would
need to track your contest performance
and promote the results on other social
media platforms as well
here's an example of a contest run by
domino's pizza which encourages people
to contribute their own short stories
and connect better with the brand
number 11 take advantage of stories and
igtv
stories enable you to create a
combination of photos and videos that
disappear after 24 hours
stories can greatly influence your reach
and engagement rates even giving your
story the chance to show up in the
explore section it can also help make
your brand seem more approachable and
authentic
adding links to the instagram stories
can also help with driving traffic to
your website
igtv on the other hand although now
seemingly on the decline still has a few
advantages to offer to the savvy
marketer
igtv provides you a unique mobile
friendly layout that serves as an
evergreen content very well like
featurettes and interviews
another new tool they have introduced is
instagram reels instagram's answer to
tick tock
instagram released reels through which
users would be able to upload 15 second
clips and since it released very
recently it's rife with marketing
potential
finally we have number 12 track and
learn identify effective hashtags visual
styles and the best times to post doing
this you can develop the best practices
for your brand social listening and
analytics will help you fine-tune your
marketing strategy and increase
instagram engagement so let's talk about
how to create a youtube ad so this is
going to require
some access to google ads and we'll go
over that in a few minutes here but
first we need to think about setting up
a campaign and setting up a campaign
goal okay what's the goal of our
campaign so we get eyeballs you know we
want to pay cost per 1000 impressions or
we want to run some actionable type ads
to get people over to our website so
that really is step one we need to
identify what the goal of our campaign
is then we need to create the ad so we
want to be able to create a video out
here that is going to show on youtube
and to our target audience so
or whether it be a bumper ad that's only
going to be six seconds long we need to
be able to figure out what type of ad we
want to run so here i am in google ads
if we're going to run a campaign on
youtube we need to make sure that
we're choosing a display campaign and so
remember the first step is you know
setting up that campaign setting up that
campaign goal so we're going to go ahead
and select a new campaign here we're
going to run a new campaign and so
what's the goal of our campaign so if
we're just out to generate brand
awareness and reach that's certainly
fine if it's all about sales or if it's
all about leads then you know the type
of video run is going to be a little bit
different so if we select brand
awareness and reach okay here we're
going to select the campaign type and so
if we select video
basically what we're doing is we're
going to tell google we want to go ahead
and set up some video ads on youtube and
so here you can see
the different types of video ads we
discussed today you know we got your
bumper ads you got your skippable
in-stream non-skippable so the
difference being that if it's
non-skippable somebody has to watch the
entirety up to 15 seconds okay so we
have our out stream which is basically
our viewable cpm model so we're gonna go
ahead and you know check one of these
types of campaign types or ad types so
we're gonna click continue and then once
we do that you know we're gonna get
prompted to
you know move forward with selecting our
ad so you can see here after i set up my
campaign now i'm just gonna go through
some of the settings for my ad and i'm
gonna give it a campaign name a budget
okay when it starts or ends the bidding
strategy so again we're going to focus
on cost per 1000 impressions and then
here's the network so this is an
important selection here so we're
dealing with youtube videos so
we also have the option to select video
partners on the display network so that
means that if you want your video to
show on websites that want to host ads
in video format then you can select this
option here notice you also have this
option available if you're running
certain types of ads on youtube we're
running those bumper ads so bumper ads
aren't available on search results so
i'm going to stick with the video
partners okay youtube videos and here we
can get into some other specifics like
language country the type of inventory
so here you can see the default is
standard inventory so that means that
this is what google recommends we want
to show our ads on content that's
appropriate for most ads okay so we can
go expanded or limited so we're going
with the recommended here okay and then
when we go down we're going to have an
ad group so when you create a a campaign
you can have an ad group so with an ad
group that means that we can have a more
or less a video in every ad group we
have but we have to have at least one ad
group so we're gonna go ahead and set up
you know this ad group here and here's
where it gets interesting and important
because here is where we can start
targeting our audience so here we got
demographics okay so we can choose
gender age parental status household
income okay we can focus in on audiences
if we want to so we can we can choose a
specific audience that we've set up we
can get some ideas or browse specific
audiences we could also choose a
specific placement so here you have
youtube videos or we can go with youtube
specific channels okay or we can even be
on apps okay we have to set a bid for
our target cpm and once we do that
basically it's all up to now for us to
add our video ad and so remember we're
in this example we're going to bumper at
so we're looking at about six seconds
and once we do that then that's pretty
much the campaign but i just want to
stress here that when you're setting it
up ahead of time you want to make sure
you identify what the campaign goal is
and then that's going to align with the
type of video you're going to run and
then once you choose that type of video
then it just comes down to where you
want that ad to be and who you're
targeting so it's really crucial here
that you go through these steps and
these options very closely so because
you want your video to show in front of
the right audience on the right
placement so let's talk about how you
can optimize your youtube ads so once
you get your campaign set up once you
select your channel or the type of
videos where you want your ad to be and
you select your target audience and
you're off and running with your video
ad well we're going to give you some
tips here that you can focus on for
optimizing those ads and so going back
to what i was just saying on the setup
you want to carefully define your
metrics and goals okay so that's step
one so when you're setting up the
campaign remember you have that option
to choose the type of goal for your
campaign that can be brand awareness it
could be a sale it could be a lead so to
me that's the you know a very critical
step one so you want to make sure you
align your goal with your video and then
the second is track low performing ad
placements so if we just ask
google to place our video ads anywhere
they want then it's up to us then to go
through and
choose the ad placements and remove them
okay so let me show you an example of
what that means so if i'm back in google
i'm gonna go to my campaign and i'm
gonna select placements and here i could
see placements but then i'm going to
select where my ads show and so this is
important you want to be able to scan
the list of placements where the ad was
shown so if you don't like one of the
placements on youtube you can always
select it edit it and exclude it from
the campaign or record so that's really
the key is you want to be able to
manage your placements properly and when
we say low performing ad placements we
mean really what what's your goal if
your goal is to get sales or leads if
you're that placement is not converting
sales or leads then you need to remove
or exclude that placement so it's all
done within the google ads platform and
then you know you can also use a custom
thumbnail image in your ad as well it's
always helpful in terms of optimization
so a couple of other pointers here to
help you optimize okay you want to drive
people to perform a particular action
with the appropriate cta so
again depending on the ad type you know
if it's a true view ad 20 seconds long
you want to have a call to action you
want to maybe even have your domain name
at the end of the video so at least
somebody knows where to go so you always
want to have a call to action with your
video ad you want to use negative
targeting to specify who gets to see
your ad and who doesn't okay so that
goes back to your settings so you can
pick and choose who your target audience
is you can pick and choose who you don't
want your audience to be as an other
setting you can use closed captioning in
your ads to make it more interactive so
that way people can actually see or read
what the ad is all about just to make it
a bit more interactive okay you can
always perform a b testing on your ads
so if you have one ad version you can
create another one just to see
what it which one performs better
testing is always a positive okay so if
you're paying too much maybe think about
reducing your bids so if you remember we
said a 10 cpm bid that may be too much
maybe we don't need to pay 10 so we can
always reduce our bids at the ad group
level so reduce bids in areas where you
see lower performance so in other words
you don't want to pay a lot for poor
performance you can also use remarketing
to re-engage with customers so if
somebody views your ads and doesn't take
action you could always retarget that
person uh to show your ad another even
another ad format it could be text ads
or display ads but if somebody looked at
your video and they didn't take the
action you preferred them to take then
you can always retarget them with
another ad so that's a good way to
optimize okay so we want to make sure
the ad has content that what viewers
would find relevant okay that really you
want to make sure that your ad is you
know is with the end viewer you don't
want to put out an ad that isn't going
to give somebody you know a good feeling
after they've watched it okay so you
want to make sure viewers find the
content relevant so if they don't find
it relevant then that means your
engagement rate and your engagement is
probably going to be low so you want to
take a look at those metrics that we
viewed earlier engagement rate
engagement and if they're low
then you probably need to look at the
content of the ad so try to make sure
your ad conveys your brand's message in
the first six seconds so that's why
bumper ads to me are so critical because
you've got to get the entirety of the ad
and make it impactful and so with any ad
you run any video ad you're on you
really want to make sure that that
message is conveyed at the very
beginning early as possible otherwise
you know people are going to be turned
off or not engaged and just going to go
ahead and skip it anyway so you want to
make sure you get the purpose of it
right up front and out of the way okay
you can also include visual and auditory
components in your ad that can make it
more memorable to the viewers okay
meaning music or other cool visuals okay
so again you want to be able to play
around and test different ads and you
want to be able to you know measure the
ad performance based on the metrics we
discussed i mean click through rate
engagement rate all of those are
indicators whether the ad is of good
quality or not with the end user and
when i say good quality i mean do they
find it engaging do they find it
interesting if so they're going to click
and if you don't have good click-through
rates or good engagement rates then you
definitely want to try doing something
different to the ad like adding those
audio components or other visuals that
could be appealing to the end user so go
ahead and test some of those out with a
b testing because you have nothing to
lose but higher or lower engagement
rates or lower click-through rates so
you want to be able to improve those
metrics improving those metrics means
trying some different components on
different ads so let's take a look at a
case study if you will and let's focus
on super dry
so they're a good success story on
youtube so super dry
leaned on some youtube advertising to
help lift one of their products so in
september last year 2018 super dry if
you're not familiar with the brand
they're you know centered some asian
markets european markets and they focus
in on clothing uh all different styles
and sizes and genders uh from jackets to
jeans to t-shirts and so their global
brand they really wanted to take a
different approach here and their
approach was they wanted to focus in on
sales they wanted to see if video can
help lift them with sales and so
what they've done is they set up some
campaigns on youtube and their focus
here was on jackets and jackets to
specific ages across the board all
genders and interests and so what they
did was they wanted to want to take
advantage of all the different ad types
that youtube had to offer and let's take
a look at one of those ads here so if we
go to youtube
and let's just take a look at this one
minute ad here 53 second ad buy super
dry
i'm ready now super jam paigey cakey
this is the jacket the jacket you're
raising the jacket you're waiting
the jacket you're pulling the jacket
your play pal and posing
you'll take five in this jacket you all
want to find this jacket i washed the
jacket it's ruined
it
mates
and prizes
this is the jacket
the jacket that will get you through
so that's the video that super dry ran
you could see that
you know it was it had some particular
goals there and so super dry is pretty
well known so it probably wasn't built
around brand awareness per se it was
probably growth consideration and
interest and also driving action okay
it's a pretty cool video it was
definitely not a bumper ad because
bumper ads are six seconds so it was
definitely a true view probably take
action and so whatever ads they actually
did run specifically they did see a lift
and so we kept pulse on super dry's
account and these videos actually had
you know 4.8 million views and so cool
video ran for 53 seconds not a long time
not a short time was able to you know
target their audience a younger crowd
you noticed in the ad they had different
jackets both female and male different
gender types so they were messaging a a
very broad audience of gender uh some
younger people is who they were
targeting so
younger people tend to slant on youtube
and so they were able to get some nice
views out of it 4.8 million but the more
important thing is because these videos
were to drive action and so they were
able to see a four to one ratio on
return on investment and as a result
these jackets saw
a 138
increase in brand lip i mean the jacket
ad so it was a pretty successful
campaign see as well choreographed good
audio good video just well
professionally done and they probably
were able to now get a few more loyal
customers
under their belt because of this ad
alone so that's the power of video okay
so you're able to know who your target
audience is you can go out and target
them with a cool video and given that
youtube is vast then you can really take
advantage of a lot of their ads so what
they probably did again was there's
trueview in stream ads with a cost per
view
through a skippable video ad format and
they they also use the shoppable ad
format so that is another option on
youtube so they took advantage of all
youtube had to offer in terms of who
they were trying to target the length of
the ad
and
given that their product or selling a
product or promoting a product they will
take advantage of the trueview shoppable
ad format which basically lists your
products alongside the actual video ad
and so this is just a good case study
you super dry we'll probably do this
again
based on the numbers that they're
reporting and so
basically that's the power of youtube
getting out in front of your audience
with a really good
video ad targeting an audience taking
advantage of different formats today
we're going to talk about how to
increase instagram followers today's
webinar we're going to have some tips
and best practices for you to take
advantage of to increase instagram
followers so let's get started and talk
a little bit about instagram so
instagram is not really an up-and-coming
platform it is already up and coming a
lot of users in fact 500 million daily
active instagram users 500 million daily
the user base growth of more than 300
percent year over year so it's growing
and growing and growing it's become more
and more popular ever since it's
launched back in 2010 and then there's
more than 100 million photos uploaded
daily so it's a platform where you can
upload photos tag those photos even use
and implement videos and photos have
become very popular with the advent of
mobile technology that the instagram app
makes it easy for you to post your photo
so there's no surprise there's a growth
there's no surprise there's a lot of
users there's no surprise that there's a
hundred million photos plus uploaded
daily and then there are 400 million
stories posted daily so when you post
something you can create a story out of
it and there's 400 million of those per
day and then there's more than 50
billion photos shared to date so since
2010 platform nat which is now owned by
facebook has become really really
popular a good place for you if you have
your own company if you have your own
brand if you have your own product it's
a good place for you to really showcase
that service that product that brand
because of the user base how easy it is
to use and the wide reach it has for you
in which to tell your story as i
mentioned there are lots of photos
shared today close to seven billion
dollars revenue generated through
instagram mobile so on top of everything
i just said there's a lot of e-commerce
going on here too so instagram is a
platform in which there's e-commerce
integrated within the platform so as a
business who offers up products you can
actually generate revenue for yourself
on the flip side instagram which is
owned by facebook has an opportunity to
sell advertising space on instagram so
instagram is an e-commerce platform to
say the least in fact instagram is
because it's so popular because it's
part of facebook's advertising platform
they're more than two million
advertisers on instagram so amongst all
those stories videos and photos and
hashtags you'll see some ads and then
because you'll see ads because you'll
see users you're gonna see businesses
it's just good place to really set up
shop and really tell your story through
the world of photos and videos so 25
million plus businesses have already
migrated over to instagram and that's
growing and growing and growing so it's
an opportunity for you to work with
other businesses so the arrow is
definitely pointing up on instagram
there's a lot going on here easy to use
application especially when it comes to
photos and videos so we're gonna go
through some tips and tricks today and
we're going to talk about everything
there is to know about instagram and how
to increase your followers so let's take
a look at tip one here so because
instagram is an application everything
you do on it is through the application
now you could certainly view a web page
version on it but you really can't do
much out of that so if i go to my
instagram account for example using my
desktop i could see my profile and i can
edit my profile to a degree but
everything you're doing is through the
application so when it comes to that tip
one here is take advantage of your bio
so regardless of what industry you are
you're in who you are you really want to
have a clear and concise and compelling
bio why because this is your
introduction to the world you want
people to know who you are and because
if you don't really become very clear to
people they're not going to follow you
so this is where it all starts you need
to take advantage of your bio have a
clear and concise bio and have a link to
your website or some contact information
so to me this is where it all starts you
gotta have a bio because that's what
people are gonna look at and they're
gonna decide whether to follow you or
not based on primarily that bio that's
where it all starts so make sure you
have a good bio that's tip number one so
you'll have to make sure that your
landing page is also mobile optimized
since most instagram users are on mobile
so if you're going to put a link to your
website and somebody's on the instagram
app and they see your bio and they like
it and you have a link to your website
make sure that landing page they go to
is mobile optimize so tip number two
everything you do on instagram when it
comes to posting evolves around hashtags
so that's the backbone of the platform
just like most platforms out there
social media platforms like twitter or
facebook pinterest you're gonna have
hashtags accompany those posts so
instagram is no different but in this
case you really really want to take
advantage of the hashtag so hashtags are
there to help users find your content so
you want to start out by using hashtags
that are relevant to your business so if
you're in the food industry you're going
to post something related to food do the
appropriate amount of research to find
hashtags to describe your brand and also
are being searched on instagram so what
does that mean that means do a little
bit of homework on instagram you know
see what searches or see what other
brands in your industry are using for
hashtags don't be afraid to use the same
hashtag but mix it up hashtags are
important so don't be afraid to put a
hashtag in there that really defines
what your business is about but if it's
relevant use other hashtags that are
popular or people are using to find
information so mix it up but the key
here is relevancy you want to make sure
you align your hashtags with your
content and making sure the connection
between the hashtag and the content is
relevancy so using the popular tags on
your photos or videos might get you some
immediate engagement but it may not help
with future goals like long-term
engagement new interested followers and
sales so here really what i'm trying to
say is look pick and choose your
hashtags carefully because if you use
something broad or something
non-relevant yeah you may get that click
to your instagram page but that doesn't
necessarily mean somebody's gonna follow
you or that doesn't mean really mean
somebody's gonna be interested in what
you have to offer so if you use
something really popular and broad yes
you're gonna get short-term
gratification but not long-term interest
tip number three post your content at
the right time so according to sprout
social which is a social media
scheduling platform among other things
so they deal with a lot of people using
their platform and posting content via
their platform they have data and
they're telling us based on the data
they've collected that the best time to
post is between 2 and 3 p.m and the best
day to post is thursday now that may be
all fine and true according to a sprout
social study and so you may want to go
with this 2 to 3 p.m and this is
probably local in case you're wondering
what time zone we're referring to so
this is all local to you so go ahead and
try that out try 2 to 3 p.m on thursday
the thing is what you're gonna have to
do eventually is figure out what the
best time to post is okay so if you're
pointing out a lot of content and you're
putting out content throughout the week
at certain times of the day or
throughout the day you're gonna have to
determine which time of day and what day
is generating the best engagement for
you who's looking at your post at what
point of the day what day of the week
and so you're gonna really have to lean
on a social media platform to help you
determine that because they're gonna
have the data that you need to determine
what the best time of day to post is
okay so we'll talk about social media
platforms here shortly we just know that
when you post post with some rationale
in mind ask yourself before you even
push that publish button or before you
even schedule that post this time of day
in this day of the week makes sense so
you always want to post at the right
time because you could be missing your
audience so remember when you do this
you're going to be working with some
platform and instagram also has some
analytics for business accounts so
instagram will also give you some
feedback as to how you're supposed to
perform it and we're going to talk about
that here shortly as well so let's move
over to tip four here to steal followers
from your competitors okay so if you're
dealing in a very competitive industry
and your competitors have a lot of
followers it's very very easy to see
who's following them so the easiest way
to do this is just interact with your
competitors followers you could follow a
user like or comment on their photos and
so the more you engage with people the
more you stand to gain from them so you
could see who your competitors followers
are and you can add them as a follower
just by following them so start engaging
with them if they're liking your
competitors brand then what the chance
of them liking your brand could be great
so check out who your competitors
followers are if they seem like somebody
who you would want to be following your
brand then go ahead and interact with
them and how you interact is again you
can like something that they post or you
can comment on something that they
posted engage with them okay it doesn't
take that much time
it's a good way to
gain followers so if we're on instagram
we can simply just click on the brand's
followers so here i can see this brand
has 127 followers and here i can see all
the followers and what i could do is
simply just click on one of the
followers and i can go to their profile
and from there i could see what they've
posted in terms of videos and images and
i can like or comment so just doing
something as simple as this gets you an
opportunity to engage with somebody who
can then turn around and follow you so
tip five pay for sponsored posts and
product reviews so a number of ways you
could do this here so pay for a
sponsored post so you can find an
influencer satisfies a couple of
requirements they have large following
and an email address in the profile so
you can connect with them and ask them
for sponsored post pricing so it's as
simple as that as reaching out to
somebody who has a large following okay
so if you do this then it's going to put
you in front of a large number of people
and so by doing this it'll help expose
your brand to that larger audience and
help build your credibility because
you're connecting with somebody who has
a large audience as well so do a little
bit of homework find people out there in
your industry who has a large following
and make sure they have that email
address in their profile so you can
contact them and when you contact them
you know ask them for sponsored post
pricing so if the influencer has an
email address then they're open to
sponsored post or shadow so that's the
key so they gotta have that email
address and when they do then it's all
about asking them and connecting with
them on being a sponsor to one of your
posts okay you want to get yourself out
there in front of people this is the
quickest way to do that okay so tip six
we want to use geotags for easier
discoverability okay so tag your images
videos or stories by tagging the
location city or venue where it was
posted from so very easy to do as you're
posting just go ahead and and there's an
option in there to say hey where are you
located or what city are you located in
so locations have their own feed and
stories which you can contribute to so
go ahead and add that extra element to
your tags so if somebody's in that
location the chance of them engaging are
going to be great and it's good for
local businesses because if you're local
and you're posting your location then
again somebody in that location is
likely to engage with you so tip 7 use
instagram stories to attract followers
and grow your user base a story's a
really big feature on instagram so what
stories could be used for is just show
footage of an environment so it could be
your office it could be your home it
could be you know the playground it
could be the golf course it could be
anywhere that you want to show vintage
of so you want to post new
relevant to your industry so if you're
in the food industry hey why not go in
the back into the kitchen and post a
story about how a particular bread or
cake is made okay show off your product
so if you are in that food industry and
say you're in the pizza making business
perfect opportunity to show people via
an instagram story how to make that
pizza and how you make that pizza what
ingredients you use how unique is your
particular product and that's really
what you want to get across when you do
a story you want to show something
unique and relevant that's going to
grasp people's attention you can promote
a company event so if you're celebrating
say 200 000 subscribers create a youtube
video or you can create an instagram
story it works just as well so you can
endorse your company's blog post you can
post positive user reviews so these are
all features of a story increase
interactivity with polls sliders etc and
then you can also mention other
companies that work with or follow you
so great use of instagram stories is do
a shout out to somebody else so
instagram stories is a really big
feature with instagram check it out you
know you can just do a search for
instagram stories in fact let's get some
of you users involved what best
practices do you have when creating
instagram stories why don't you go ahead
and share your instagram story with us
by putting that instagram story in the
comment section below so we want to get
everybody involved here because there's
thousands upon thousands of great
instagram stories out there to be shown
and viewed and engaged with so go ahead
and share your instagram story if you
have any other tips or tricks then go
ahead and put those in the comments
section so that everybody can benefit
from them so the only thing to keep in
mind when you're creating these stories
is what are your followers interested in
seeing so your stories could teach or
promote something to your user base so
always keep that in the back your mind
you know for me i always go back to what
industry are you in if you're in the
food industry hey you know people who
are following you are interested in food
if you're a pizza company you know show
off that pizza if you're a bakery show
off how you make your breads and goods
baked goods whatever it is you have show
it off because if somebody's following
you that's what they're interested in so
tip number eight highlight important
stories so you want to highlight
highlight serve as the easiest way to
create a first impression for a
potential follower so with highlights
can be used to tease what your contents
about create a trailer for what your
brand offers promote and promote your
product highlights are there it's a good
feature it's a first impression for
potential follower so it teases what the
contents about it creates a trailer so
to speak for your brand and promote your
product so use highlights and again any
users out there who have good examples
of highlights go ahead and put those in
the content section or comment section
uh right below this video so remember
stories have only a 24 hour life span so
highlights can be used to give them a
second wind okay so highlights serve a
purpose it teases what the contents
about it promotes the product and it
really kind of accentuates that story
tip number nine ask for followers so
sometimes people need a little push
before they can follow you on instagram
even if they enjoy your content so you
can ask users to become your followers
in the caption the comment section even
work it into your content so in other
words when you're posting something
don't be afraid to say hey follow me you
know i got some good stuff here be
confident you don't want to do it for
every post of course but you know pick
and choose if you feel you have a really
good post you know really good image
that you think is going to gain a lot of
followers and engagers then you don't
necessarily need to put a caption in
there but if if it is popular then go
ahead and say hey this is a popular post
you know think about following me or put
something in the comment section you
want to do it kind of succinctly you
don't want to be begging but just work
it in to some degree okay but don't be
afraid have some confidence and asking
for followers so when you do this it's
very similar to how we do it on youtube
so you can ask viewers to subscribe to
their channels at the end of the video
so it's if on youtube basically you're
saying hey if you like what we have go
ahead and subscribe it's no different on
instagram if you have something you've
posted just go and say hey you like this
yeah go ahead and follow us it's that
simple so tip number ten take on the
latest trends to get more followers so
align your content to cater to trendy
topics or hashtags to improve engagement
and discoverability so really what we're
trying to say here's your competitors
follow influencers what are the latest
trends and you can get an idea of the
latest trends by you looking at hashtags
so what hashtags are trending which ones
are people using the most so really what
you want to do is whatever's trending in
your industry you know ride that wave so
to speak now it doesn't have to take on
your entire profile but there's nothing
wrong with one or two posts if
something's really taking on popularity
then go ahead and post about it as well
you know for example in the wine
industry if there's a new wine that
really came out that's really gaining
some popularity go ahead and post about
it with the same hashtag and with the
unique hashtag so don't be afraid to
you know ride the wave of popularity so
to speak because it shows that you know
you know what you're talking about it
adds some credibility and it's going to
get some you know viewers over to your
instagram profile so keep in mind you
need to keep your content relevant
because if your audience is interested
in what you have to offer then they're
going to be engaged however you know if
you're joining the discussion in a
relevant manner keeping in mind whether
your audience will interact or not is
important but just always keep in mind
you always want to stay within your
industry and relevancy for your target
audience so tip number 11 run contests
and giveaways and so just like on
youtube just like on facebook i mean
instagram is no different you can
increase reach and exposure by running
contests since most followers would tag
their friends to let them know about it
it's a good idea to run contests and so
what's an idea of a contest well again
if you're running a pizza parlor you
know you could say hey what's your
favorite pizza or give me your favorite
pizza ideas and you can run a contest
and you know you can have people even
create their own pizza and post an image
of it you can have people create stories
on the best ways in which they create
pizza or their experience in another
pizza parlor there's lots of things you
can do to create a contest and you don't
always have to give something away you
could just do something for fun
especially if you have a lot of
followers if you have a lot of followers
then somebody's going to take part in it
so don't be afraid to run contests just
to make it fun and light it up a little
bit so each tag can bring you a new
audience member who could be a potential
follower so anytime you run a contest
people are gonna tag their friends to
let them know about that contest so
those friends are gonna come over and
likely engage so that's the beauty of
running a contest or giveaway is chances
are word's gonna spread and it's gonna
get you some new followers so that's the
the end benefits so to speak but the
real benefit is keeping your audience
engaged so tip number 12 we want to stay
consistent with post so having a
consistent pace and theme for your post
can have a huge impact to convert
visitors so when we say consistent you
know if you're again that pizza parlor
stay within pizza you could branch out a
little maybe and talk about salads or
talk about beverages to you know as a
complementary factor to the pizza okay
but don't talk about hamburgers if
you're focused in on pizza so we want to
stay consistent with your theme
this method involves less effort with a
faster production of instagram content
so that mean what we're really trying to
say here is focus stay focused on who
you are if you do that if you're
consistent and you're gaining some
followers and that's what people are
coming to you for the content that
you're good at for the industry you're
in okay so if you start varying it and
branching out then it's gonna muddy the
water suppose so to speak and you're
probably going to get less engagement so
set a theme on instagram by maintaining
consistency and your personality filters
colors and layout and really what i'm
referring to is post and when you have
post something you're you're really
creating a personality for yourself okay
so if you're in fashion for example and
you're in the jeans industry well jeans
jeans jeans right that's your
personality accentuate it with different
outfits related to jeans but you know
when you start talking about dresses and
shoes and that kind of blurs your your
personality a bit so if you stay
consistent with thin jeans and outfits
that go with jeans then i think people
are going to start to pick up on that
personality so tip 13 keep track of your
instagram following so you can analyze
the growth of your channel with tools
like socialblade that could tell you how
many followers you've lost over time and
how engaged they are okay so you can use
data gather from here and from instagram
business account to diagnose where
you're faltering so let's take a look at
socialblade as an example here so if i
go over here i'm going to go to
socialblade here i can enter in
basically any account after i register
and i could see how that account has
performed you know where they rank you
know how many uploads they have what
country they focused on what industry
and the beauty here is i could see and
i'm looking at youtube as an example i
could see you know how my post to
perform well you could do this for
instagram you could do it for facebook
so you can really get an idea of
how your account's performing so
socialblade's a great platform for
measuring and again you do also have
instagram business insights so with
instagram business insights basically
what you're going to do is you're going
to go to your app right and then from
the app you could basically look at your
insights from there so in the app itself
you're gonna click on the upper right
three lines and from there you're gonna
see insights and when you go to insights
you're also gonna see you know what your
reach is how many impressions and some
engagement metrics terms of your
audience where they're located the age
range okay you're gonna also see some
content related information so there's a
lot you could see from the
instagram insights analytics insights
but you can also see additional
information from socialblade so the key
here is when you're looking at your data
you want to look for patterns and post
what posts receive the most amount of
engagement so if you see something
working obviously replicate it you know
you don't want to replicate it
immediately but make note of it and use
it for future content so tip 14 use
instagram ads so instagram ads give you
complete control over advertisements so
how they appear and who sees them so
with instagram ads you can run photos
you can run videos carousels slideshows
stories so we mention this on other
webinars for facebook advertising it's
worth repeating so if i go back into say
facebook ads manager i can pick and
choose my placements and really what i
want to do is pick and choose for
example instagram and so i have
instagram feed i have instagram stories
so and i could see with the video
requirement or the media requirement is
for running on instagram so with
instagram you can run stories you can
run videos single image ads you can run
carousel to really you could put your
best forward meaning take the post
that's performing well and maybe you
want to advertise that promote it so
you're going to run this through
facebook ads manager and it's going to
tell you you know what your audience
size is your potential reach okay what
your daily results would be so you're
going to get all that information
when you run your ads on facebook ads
manager but it's a great opportunity for
you to really push forward if you're
running a promotion it's really an
opportunity for you to push for that
promotion other advantages scalable
pricing self-serve and instant robust
reporting and highly refined audience
retargeting so all of that is in the
facebook ads manager you can get all the
reporting units you need meaning you
know who saw the ad did they click on it
okay you can refine that target audience
you can go back into facebook ads
manager and refine who your audience is
so lots of flexibility here and
advertising on instagram but the key
here is if you want to run advertising
on instagram you know think about what
it is you're trying to promote if you
feel something needs to get promoted
then go ahead and you know you can
either again reach out to somebody and
have them sponsor it or you can run it
as an advertisement so let's move on to
tip 15. so we want to create visually
attractive and eye-catching ads so if
you are gonna run ads you know here's
some things to keep in mind okay you
want to use images that are natural and
seem native okay you don't want to use
any stock photography first off you want
to use something that you've done okay
you want to minimize the amount of text
so let the image do the talking you want
to ensure your caption relates to the
image and resonates with your audience
okay so you have an opportunity to add
some text below the image okay so make
sure it resonates and then of course use
hashtags to show your ads to target your
audience but a wider relevant audience
so hashtags do play a role here as well
so these are some tips if you're going
to create ads you want to take these
into account the whole point of the ad
is to get people over to either webpage
or to your profile page okay so that
they can engage and take action so
instagram ads will help showcase your
product service or brand in a way that's
memorable and unique so if you really
want to get your vision your brand your
product out there in front of a lot of
people then advertising on instagram is
a good way to do that so since we've
been talking about pizza throughout this
webinar there's a good instagram a
profile here about pizza you know i'm
getting hungry just looking at this
hopefully this is an example for all veg
and non-veg pizza consumers i mean you
can see this profile here they got the
website you know they got the handle
okay so they have a lot of followers so
you know if i'm in the pizza industry i
can go ahead and you know click on their
followers and see who who's following
them who they're following so
some really good shots of pizza here it
looks like you know a lot of people were
involved in this you could see lots of
different examples here some cute ones
you know some funny ones some humorous
ones so you know just taking a look at
something like pizza which you know most
people enjoy you know most and you can
kind of appreciate you know how much of
an advantage instagram can be because it
really you can accentuate photos you can
have fun with it you can really run some
contests here you know give us your best
pizza photo so
here you know you could say use daily
pizza as a hashtag for feature okay so
they're even encouraging you to use a
specific hashtag so you can really do a
lot here on instagram this is just a
good example of what you can do and have
fun with you know with an example like
pizza just to give you some ideas so
let's move on to tip 16. take advantage
of instagram tools so you can use
scheduling tools like later hootsuite
and buffer so i can't stress this enough
you know when it comes to
measuring the engagement of your
instagram post you're definitely going
to need a social media tool so you're
also going to need it if you do a lot of
you know posting on instagram so let's
take a look at an example we'll use
later.com
so if i go to later here i can see you
know i can use this to upload my images
to my profile so here you can see it's
scheduled throughout the day of the week
so that way we're not overlapping you
know we're scheduling based on the times
of the day that people are gonna look at
this so you know here i could see you
know particular stories if any stories
are posted okay i can look at it from a
weekly or monthly preview i could see
what's been posted okay and more
importantly as a schedule tool i can
also see the analytics i could see you
know how many were posted how many
followers so this is really important
because you know if my profile is
growing i want to be able to see what
posts perform best what the audience was
like you know by gender by age by
location so again i can look at it by
post performance story or hashtag
analytics as well so later really goes
into details about you know what's
driving engagement so here you can see
some hashtags that this become a
particular company is using on instagram
so here you can see how many posts with
this hashtag you know and what and kind
of engagement did they receive do they
receive likes comments impressions how
much reach do they get how many saves
and it really just does go into detail
so later does a good job i like this
platform especially for instagram it's
great for scheduling but more important
you know in addition to the instagram
analytics you can really lean on you
know this particular platform to get a
really good idea as to you know how
particular posts are performing remember
if a post is performing you want to
reuse it at a certain point in time okay
learn from best practices learn from
what's working learn from what's not
working if something's not working then
don't do it again so you can really get
a good breakdown here and later.com so
remember these tools place an emphasis
on automation okay enabling you to
automatically post at a scheduled time
so you want to lock it in at a certain
period of time and i have to worry about
it so it allows you to really hone in on
that particular time of the day and day
of the week so that you're really
maximizing your chances of getting good
engagement okay so develop your own
signature style to set up a style and
content theme so that you're able to
stand out amongst the various
competitors so you know again just going
back to our pizza example lots of good
photos of pizza and but this is their
style this is who they are you know
they're not a particular brand they're
just you know people who like pizza okay
and they're having fun with it okay so
that's their style you know they're
posting really good shots of all this
different types of pizza different
styles different toppings and just to
give you an idea of how popular pizza is
and what you can do with it okay so
again this is a good basic example um of
what you can do
with something as simple as pizza so
don't be afraid to experiment you know
try something different with your
profile you know do something different
you don't always have to follow what
everybody else is doing that's the great
thing about instagram it allows you to
be free and creative in fact if anybody
has any styles that have worked for them
you know feel free to put something in
the comment section we'd love to hear
your thoughts so tip 18 use user
engagement to your advantage so i just
mentioned that using the later example
so we want to be able to
learn from what's working and not
working so user-generated content shows
off your brand to be authentic and
improves your relationship with your
followers so you know you want to be
unique with the content that you're
posting so
if you do that you're likely to build
that relationship and you know increase
your followers and you want to be able
to see of that user generated content
that ugc which is performing which is
not performing okay so basically your
followers and your audience are telling
you what's working and not working so
take advantage of that remember going
back to hashtags you could set up your
own unique hashtag and ask your users to
post images or videos relating to that
which you can post in your brand's
account so just like the whole pizza
thing they're saying hey look you know
use daily pizza for a feature okay
that's a good example of something you
can do as well so you could set up a
unique hashtag and say hey use this
hashtag and that'll help you gain some
followers that'll help you gain some
notoriety and some visibility on your
platform tip 19 use high quality images
and videos just like on youtube just
like on facebook instagram is no
different images must be of high quality
authentic and original i mean again one
more time go back to the pizza these
images look to be pretty high quality i
mean if you have a decent mobile phone
that's all it takes a mobile phone with
a camera that is that's all it usually
takes you know you want to be able to
get that that right shot you don't want
to use anything that's of low quality
because it really is going to take away
from you know the story you're trying to
tell so you don't have to be
professional per se just make sure what
you're posting whether it be video or
whether it be an image is of high
quality and remember videos needs to be
fun and informational without causing
the user to lose interest so you know if
you're going to create a video you know
go ahead and you know make you can make
it short make it fun okay you can see
here these guys are just showing you how
pizza is made doesn't take a long time
they're just going through the motions
they're not boring you with details
they're not talking really quick and
easy just to give you an idea it doesn't
have to be as serious it can be fun so
video content needs to be fun and
informational without causing users to
lose interest that's the key short sweet
unique authentic and fun have fun with
it so worth repeating don't use stock
images on instagram because you know
they don't really bode well for your
particular brand you know it's instagram
it allows you to post original content
that's the whole purpose of it okay and
on the video side be concise high
quality and informational enough okay so
you have to hold the user's attention
here so when we say concise you know
don't make it a five minute video
obviously make it high quality relevant
to what you're trying to offer and if
you can do that you're likely going to
hold the user's attention so tip 20
promote your instagram page and other
social media channels so facebook and
instagram are part of the same family so
this seems like a natural but you know
don't be afraid to
promote it on other channels like
pinterest or or youtube the whole idea
is to get users to your instagram page
and encourage them to follow it so you
know you can always put that url in you
know other platforms like youtube
nothing wrong with that at all okay you
can also promote your page offline with
print ads and during other relevant
events and then i would even take this
to further is you probably see you know
an instagram logo on a web page along
with other social media icons so you
always want to help promote instagram on
your web page as well but you can do it
for offline with print ads so you can
simply just put you know whatever your
your slug is for instagram whatever your
id is whatever you're using on instagram
that's what you can use don't be afraid
to promote it offline or online today
we're going to talk about how to
increase twitter followers so welcome
and let's get started so with twitter
it's all about tweets it's actually a
verb now uh when you do something on
twitter you actually tweet and there are
a lot of people out there tweeting in
fact twitter has over 1.3 billion
accounts so
a lot of tweets going on in the world of
twitter so as of the third quarter in
2018 last year twitter had 326 million
global monthly active users okay so
active meaning every day using the
platform on a daily basis so a lot of
people using twitter it's very easy to
use as you'll find out and what you're
going to find out today is how to
increase followers on your twitter
account so they can see more of your
tweets okay a little bit more about
twitter there are 500 million tweets
posted every single day that's a lot of
tweets so you can imagine with every
tweet is a hashtag that accompanies that
tweet so a lot of information being
disseminated across the platform so
tweets with videos so twitter does allow
videos as well as images attracts 10
times more engagement than other forms
of content so
if you watched our youtube videos and
some of the other videos we had out
there regarding facebook or instagram
you'll know that videos do perform
better twitter is no exception so if you
have a video even if it's done on
youtube or if it's not unpublished on
youtube use it with twitter you're gonna
get more engagement so twitter has 75 of
its users use the platform for news okay
so people go to twitter to get their
news that's where they go they don't go
to a regular website content-based
website they get their news via twitter
it's just very easy to digest because
it's so few characters 75 percent of b2b
businesses market on twitter so not only
is it a b2c or business to consumer
platform it's a b2b business to business
platform so a lot of businesses are on
twitter
basically promoting either a product
service or trying to establish
themselves in the industry using the
platform so let's take a look at twitter
and let's take a look at some of the
ways in which you can increase your
followers it all starts with your
profile you always want to make sure you
have a complete profile your name
obviously the twitter platform that you
have is going to have a handle okay in
this example here it's a totally real
person at totally real person is the
twitter handle and that's what you're
going to want to use to disseminate your
twitter profile to others so you want to
make sure that you have a good image you
have a real name and a good handle that
people can associate with and remember
so you want to be able to set up this
profile with a keyword friendly bio okay
a link to your website and a picture
that represents your brand always helps
so make sure it's complete you can even
take a step further by customizing the
color scheme of your profile you can add
a header image that sticks to your theme
that will help your profile stand out
and so let's take a look at an example
here so if i go to twitter here we go to
simply learn twitter account okay their
handle is simply at simply learn okay
and they've customized the header they
use their logo now if you're an
individual you probably want to use a
nice profile pic here where they're
based a little bit about them so
just a you know customized complete
profile goes a long way you don't have
to go overboard with an elaborate design
so to speak but just make it stand out
make it associate with who you are as a
person and a brand those are best
practices in getting that profile up and
running you don't want to use something
bland and generic you know take the
extra step create something unique make
sure your profile is unique you have a
good image okay make sure it's complete
with you know telling people who you are
and what you're all about that's really
the first step on really any social
media platform so
you want to promote your twitter profile
to drive users from other social media
platforms so when you actually get that
twitter account set up and you actually
do have your handle go ahead and share
it that's the first step in getting
followers if you're already on facebook
if you're already on instagram then use
those platforms to announce that you're
on twitter you can also take that a step
further and you know send out an email
to friends or family or like i said if
you're on facebook go ahead and set up a
post say hey guys i'm on twitter you
know come follow me so you could also
use business cards advertisements
marketing materials events to put that
twitter profile on okay so it doesn't
have to be
within the social media sphere it could
be even on your website it can be even
in email so you can basically promote
that profile again you want to make that
profile that handle easy to remember so
totally real person is the profile in
this example we're going to use that
profile every way we can whether that be
offline or online you don't don't be
afraid to use it on a business card
especially if it's easy i can just
simply go to twitter and type in that
handle so you want to stay active on
twitter with regular retweets replies
and favorites and that's just it's just
so easy to retweet and reply and add
favorites so let's take a look at that
on twitter so you could just simply i'm
logged in as me and if i want to retweet
something that simply learn did i can
just simply click on the retweet button
and i can add a comment if i want to and
then i'm going to retweet that simple so
now that tweet is going to show up on my
profile my handle and i could simply
like it if i scroll down here okay top
10 it trends shaping 2019 notice a
simple tweet supported with an image so
i'm just going to like that so i can
even comment on it i can click on the
comment and click a reply here okay and
that's gonna show up in this tweet here
just like if i click on this i'll be
able to see what other people have
written and so it's that simple if i
want i can just click on the email
button and even send a message to
somebody right from that tweet the point
is i can do everything i need to do
right in the platform but to get started
if you don't have any tweets you know go
and find other companies similar to you
look at their tweeting and you can
always retweet that that's a good way to
get going with tweets that's what i
started doing when i started on twitter
in 2008 i didn't know what to write
particularly and i didn't know how to
write it particularly well so i looked
at what other people wrote and and
tweeted and just retweeted those that's
a good way to get your twitter account
started okay so engaging with users is a
great way to get more followers so on
simplylearn i retweeted one of their
tweets i liked another one of their
tweets and it's probably gonna get their
attention somebody at simply learn is
gonna say okay rob sanders
went ahead and liked us and you know
what we're gonna go follow this guy he
seems to be
somebody who's an audience member who
likes what we have to do likes what we
have to say like what we're tweeting
let's go ahead and follow him and so
that's a good way to get going with your
twitter account is to really start
retweeting and liking other tweets from
other users so you can find an
appropriate time to post your tweets to
increase exposure retweets and followers
and you want to do this you could do it
within twitter or as i'll mention later
you can do it in a social media platform
like sprout social or hootsuite or later
or buffer and there's plenty of social
media platforms out there for you to
schedule tweets point is you want to be
able to schedule those tweets when it's
the appropriate time so you don't want
to do it in the middle of the evening
because what's going to happen is likely
by the morning other tweets are going to
bury your tweet so you want to be able
to find the appropriate time to post
your tweets so according to a survey
conducted by hubspot the best time to
post is between 12 and 3 p.m and why is
that well most people are usually on
lunch checking their phones yes twitter
has an app and in fact most people use
the app just like on instagram just like
on youtube the app is very popular on
twitter so it's very easy for somebody
to check tweets especially during the
lunch hour and then from five to six pm
that that in between time when when
people are wrapping up work or heading
home okay so weekdays have shown to have
the maximum amount of engagement so
during the week when people are working
highly engaged with whatever they're
doing depending on what industry you're
in they're likely going to
check the twitter and react during those
times okay so that was a a survey
conducted by hubspot but really what you
want to do is you want to be able to use
one of these social media platforms like
a hootsuite or later and find out
exactly when are people engaging with
your tweets when what time of the day
what day of the week are you getting the
most retweets or the most likes okay
that's what you want to do so you can
use this as a starting point as a best
practice but eventually you're going to
have to cater to your audience based on
when you're getting your tweets engaged
so you want to increase followers by
following more people it's that simple
and so it really is that simple let me
rephrase that so it really is that
simple so if i go back to twitter you
know twitter is always going to
recommend somebody for me to follow and
normally those are people that are
similar as myself okay so they're not
just going to choose random people
they're going to choose people who are
following people you're following so
there's going to be a connection to some
degree or they could be people who use
similar hashtags tweeting the same
content so you want to go ahead and
follow people the rule of thumb on
twitter is if you follow somebody on
twitter chances are they're going to
follow you back you know i was once told
when i was using twitter that hey you
want to give somebody about three days
to follow you back so that's always what
the rule i stuck to you know wait about
three days start following people
you can see here 833 people that or
accounts twitter accounts that simply
learns following and over 10
900 followers to simply learn's twitter
account so for me i don't mind having a
nice balance myself i have just as many
followers as i do following and that's a
good thing so because you want to be
able to keep up with what people are
tweeting and so you can retweet at the
same time you want to be following
people as well because they're going to
follow you back okay and that's how you
can build up your twitter followers by
following people and it's as simple as
clicking on a follow link so the key
here is to follow people who follow your
content people who are followers of your
followers and you can use twitter's who
to follow list and upload your email
contacts to twitter okay since they know
you they're more likely to follow you
back okay so you can use twitter's who
to follow list and so if we go back to
twitter here's the who to follow list
and so this is what twitter is going to
recommend but you can click on this link
here find people you know okay so if i
click on find people i know then i can
upload my contacts from outlook or gmail
and they're gonna find people who are
already on twitter based on who i'm
connected with so generally that's how
it works that's a quick way to get more
followers is to connect with people you
know by the way i'm going to follow
simply learn because i wasn't following
them prior so now i just clicked on the
follow button now i am following so now
i'm gonna see simply learns tweets in my
feed so let's take a second to look at a
brand okay so it's time for brand watch
let's have a look at some of the best
tweets of 2018. now remember there are a
lot of active users millions of active
users that's a lot of tweets so what we
did was we scoured twitter from 2018 and
we went ahead and picked out some tweets
that we thought were pretty good and so
the first one is wendy's now i don't
know if any of you have actually eaten
at wendy's i used to eat at wendy's a
while ago i know their frosties are
pretty good so
what they've done is they incorporated
that frosty as part of a giveaway okay
so basically they're saying hey grab
yourself a free frosty with any purchase
in our app so they're encouraging people
to use our app and then they're
following that up by saying hey and then
join us on twitch from two to five
eastern as we unlock all that frosty
goodness so they're promoting something
that's going to happen on a specific
point in time this is last january
they're encouraging people to use their
app and they're using that frosty as
kind of a carrot if you will okay it's a
catch it's a giveaway so they were able
to you know basically wrap a bunch of
things into one so get encourage people
to take part and i'm sure a lot of
people went ahead and took part of this
but we could definitely see that 206
retweeted this tweet 302 basically
commented on it and over 3 000 liked the
tweet so the tweet was good and it
basically engaged with users who doesn't
like a free giveaway especially free
frosty so that's why this particular
tweet really does some justice for the
target audience their audience they're
they're giving something away to their
audience just by allowing them to you
know use their app okay so this tweet
combines a lot into one and i like it
apparently a lot more people than i did
3 000 plus also like this tweet and so
moving on to how to increase your
followers on twitter you want to mention
other people in your tweets to increase
engagement so what do we mean by that so
let's look at twitter so go back if we
look at simplylearn just take a look at
some of their tweets what they're doing
if we scroll down here they have
hashtags so they are mentioning specific
hashtags but you can also mention
handles as well so the hashtag is always
going to start with either the pound
sign but if we scroll down here if you
use the at symbol you're actually
mentioning somebody so in this case
we're mentioning matt bailey so matt
bailey says is matt bailey's handle and
so if you get a shout out to somebody
they're gonna pick up on that and then
they're going to probably follow you
okay who doesn't appreciate getting
recognized for something especially
something as small as a tweet okay
notice i can go ahead and click follow
if i want to follow him out bailly but
it's not a bad idea to add people into
your tweet and you simply do that by
just using the ad symbol and using their
twitter handle it's a good way to get
recognized by that twitter follower it
also increases engagement because it's
adding validity to the tweet and it
definitely catches the attention of the
person mentioned remember if you use
that person's handle they're going to
see that that you mention them okay and
what it's likely going to do is start
some type of twitter relationship okay
they're going to then follow you you're
going to follow them and chances of them
retweeting you in the future or
mentioning you in the future is probably
going to increase and overall that
increases engagement so another
important thing you want to do is find
and use hashtags that are relevant to
your brand and audience so this is a
must this is mandatory on twitter you
need to use hashtags twitter's all about
hashtags every tweet that goes out
should have a hashtag okay so what you
can do is figure out what hashtags are
trending so here what twitter does is
they trends for you so these are all
specific hashtags that are trending it's
mother's day happy mother hey sunday
morning whatever works for you these are
trends that happen to be moving meaning
a lot of people are using them clicking
on them okay so you can use a popular
hashtag what i would also recommend is
using a unique hashtag the rule of thumb
is usually about two hashtags in a tweet
but that's a rule of thumb but rules are
made to be broken do what's best for you
if you want to include more than two
hashtags go for it the only thing i'm
recommending is include a hashtag so
find out which trending you could just
look right in twitter or you could just
create your own unique hashtag it works
both ways but when you have a hashtag in
your tweet and somebody clicks on it
then they're going to go to that
particular handle that hashtag and so
when they look at the hashtag you're
gonna see all the tweets with that
hashtag in it so that's the idea behind
hashtags you want to have hashtags okay
so if somebody clicks on a hashtag that
you used then they're likely going to
see your tweet in that hashtags feed
okay so that's how hashtags work you
want to use hashtags okay but you want
to use hashtags that are relevant to
your brand and audience that's really
the key so hashtags help your tweets to
be found through twitter search thus
improving your reach and increase the
visibility of your post so that's
another benefit twitter has search
functionality so somebody can simply go
in and start searching on twitter so if
i go back to twitter i can just do a
hashtag and start typing in something
like spanish and i'm gonna get some of
the most popular spanish hashtags or
hashtags with the word spanish in it and
so this is an idea for me that if i want
to use a hashtag with spanish in it
these are some ideas but they're
certainly searchable on twitter okay so
if i just click on spanish okay i'm
gonna be able to see all the hashtags
with the word spanish in the hashtag so
definitely use hashtags it's the most
beneficial feature of twitter bar none
so some reasons why using hashtags also
a good idea well you're gonna get more
engagement and you're likely to get
retweeted as well so when you get
retweeted then that means more eyeballs
because if somebody sees your tweet and
retweets it they're retweeting it for
their audience and so it could go viral
so to speak on twitter and that's where
the engagement comes in so if you're
using a hashtag that's trendy well
somebody might like that okay if you're
behind a specific movement or you're
following a specific baseball or
football team or cricket team or
whatever team you're following then if
you use that team in the hashtag that
could also get you some some likes so
don't be afraid to use hashtags mix it
up play around a little use something
unique use something that's trending
just use something but make sure it's
relevant to the tweet find out what
works for your competition what works
for them might work for you too so you
know i work with simply learn but you
know simply learn has a good twitter
account you know they have lots of
followers they're doing a lot of
tweeting so if i wanted to be just like
simply learn well i could simply just go
to their twitter account and see what
they're doing okay see what they're
using as hashtags see what kind of
tweets they're implementing and see
who's following them so i can simply
just click on the 10
900 followers that they have and what i
could do is i can go through and start
following the people that are following
them so just mimic your competition to
some degree or mimic others in the
industry you know look at what they're
tweeting again start out by retweeting
some of the stuff they're retweeting if
it's good stuff if it's a good tweet
don't be afraid to retweet even your
competitors tweets okay use unique
hashtags use the hashtags they're using
look at who's following their brand so
you can really learn a lot from
others in your industry including your
competition because what works for them
again might work for you especially when
it comes to hashtags or people who's
following them again people who are
following them would likely follow you
if you're in the same industry so it's
as simple as looking at who's following
them and following those same people
remember the rule of thumb is if you're
following somebody they're likely to
follow you back so again you can analyze
things like the number of followers they
have the frequency of their tweets what
their profile looks like how they
respond to the competition of customers
okay what are they tweeting about what
types of content brings them more
engagement meaning of all the tweets
which one is getting the most likes or
retweets get some sense of what they're
doing and again when i say mimic i mean
what i'm saying is pull best practices
from that twitter account this will give
you an idea what you need to do to get
more followers so it's always a good
form of flattery when you can mimic what
somebody else is doing just like every
other social media platform following
twitter influencers who belong in your
industry is always a good idea so if
you're in the food industry and there's
these star chefs out there probably not
a bad idea to follow those star chefs
you know if you're in the technology
industry well probably not a bad idea to
you know follow bill gates or elon musk
or richard branson or somebody else and
that's a big influencer has an influence
on a lot of people okay but make sure
they're in your industry that's the key
if you can make sure they're in your
industry and you follow them chances are
if they look at your twitter account and
see you're posting or maybe retweeting
some of their tweets they're likely to
follow you and if they're following you
your tweets are going to show up on
their handle on their feed and so don't
be afraid to go out and connect and
follow those influencers it's a good way
to boost up your followers so again this
will help you gain followers since you
can replicate what they've done with
their profile so again just like the
competition mimic what your influencers
are doing okay so people tend to follow
people who follow influencers so you're
all of one like mind so to speak okay
influencers might retweet or share your
post if they find you retweeting
favorites and replying to their post so
remember if you're following a retweeter
or excuse me an influencer and you
retweet their post chances are they
might retweet one of your posts and
again put you in front of a large number
of people since they're influencers so
all of these are good valid reasons to
follow influencers because if you're out
to increase your reach and exposure it's
hard to ignore influencers in your
industry okay you want to use images and
videos while tweeting remember videos
get multiple multiple times more
engagement than not using them at the
very least use images but you use images
don't use stock photography use images
that are relevant so one of these tweets
caught my eye here from simply learn so
if i click on you know here it was
further down here it looked like you
know these are people who are engaging
in a conference and it might have been
one that matt bailey was at so it was a
retweet from matt bailey as a matter of
fact but you could see what simply
learn's doing is they're including
either a video or they're including an
image in every tweet and so that's
likely to boost up engagement so
according to buffer which is a another
social media platform adding a relevant
high quality image in your tweets can
help you gain more than 150
engagement okay videos are six times
more likely to be retweeted so if you
have an arsenal video or even one video
don't be afraid to use it my
recommendation is trying to use images
as much as you can in almost every tweet
images go a long way and again it's
going to help improve engagement meaning
more retweets more followers okay more
followers more eyeballs so it's a
snowball effect just by using images
okay so let's take a look at another
brand from 2018 okay pizza always my
good example to use on these webinars i
like pizza here this just says it all
you know they're talking about art and
they're using pizza in the form of art
so they didn't really have to say much
else here this pretty much says it all
and they did get some retweets to get
some to some likes so sometimes you
don't have to say a lot to make your
point sometimes just the image itself
will do the job this was actually not
from 2018 this goes all the way back to
2016. so still holds true if you use an
image that image is going to get
engagement okay so on twitter just like
most other social media platforms you
can promote your tweet so you can use
twitter ads to do that so you can
promote your tweet and what you do by
promoting it is putting it up above so
that most people will be able to see it
okay so see if we can find an example if
i go here i can see this person is
promoting their handle but if i go down
here i can see a promoted tweet by
constant contact so they're promoting
their tweet here so it's not a bad idea
if you have some media budget to go
ahead and either promote your tweet or
advertise on twitter so what that's
going to do is put you in a more
prominent position and get your tweets
out there and the whole idea for that is
to get people to engage here you can see
a call to action from constant contact
so if i click on that i'm going to go to
probably a landing page on their website
and so the whole idea when you advertise
on twitter is really just like any other
social media platform you want to put
yourself in front of the right audience
and so twitter's no exception so with
twitter you could put yourself in front
of the right audience so what you could
do is you could promote a tweet you know
do promoted trends or you could do
promoted accounts so you have a number
of different advertising options on
twitter what we just looked at was you
know looking at promoted accounts and a
promoted tweet so when you do advertise
there are advantages you have to pay
only after achieving your marketing
objective so that's a benefit of twitter
the cost per click it's a cost per click
model so it tends to be fairly low you
could tell your audience so again you're
picking and choosing who you want your
promoted tweet or trend or account to be
in front of and it's targeting is based
on either engagement or it's based on
keywords i.e
so really you could tailor who you want
your tweet or your handle to be in front
of and so that's the really the benefit
of twitter if you have a lot of active
users on twitter you can really put
yourself in front of those active users
if they're your relevant audience at a
low cost per click so it's definitely
worth the test so you want to offer
twitter support
to your users okay so i can't stress
this enough okay so what you want to do
is when users have questions about your
product they're more likely to tweet you
for support hence they're likely to
follow your account so don't be afraid
to use the messaging option as well so
if we go back to twitter okay chances
are somebody might have a question for
you here you can look at big ads it's
great connecting with ppc experts can't
believe tax season is here we've got
some great insights so what they're
doing is they're using the messaging app
but they're offering that messaging app
in the form of customer service so don't
be afraid to use you know direct
messages to reach out to people in the
form of support what you don't want to
do is buy twitter followers chances are
you're going to get the wrong followers
so even though it may boost your twitter
follow account these bots cannot use or
buy your products or services so stay
away from all sorts of buying of twitter
followers you want to build your twitter
following naturally twitter is also
cracking down on bot followers so a lot
of bot accounts that were paid to follow
users were shut down shut down by
twitter so just my point is everything
we've mentioned today is what you want
to take advantage of okay if you want to
pay for something pay for a promoted
tweet reach out to influencers look at
what your competition is doing use
hashtags okay these are all best
practices and organic ways to build
followers so don't get involved with
anything that's going to involve bots
and adding thousands of followers to
your twitter account because chances are
it's just going to lead to no engagement
so create useful and relevant content so
what we started out by saying is hey if
you're not sure what to do retweet
retweet what somebody else is doing you
know look at your competition's twitter
account see what they're tweeting get
some ideas as to what you want to tweet
so you want it to be useful and relevant
to your industry okay you want somebody
to engage that's the whole idea behind
twitter the whole idea is if you're
going to tweet something you want to get
somebody to engage with it so use
twitter polls your old recent blog post
brand news industry news and events and
highlight customer stories i mean all of
those are ideas that you can do to put
content out there okay so for me one of
the things i do is i'm definitely one
for industry news so if i'm in the
industry of digital marketing if google
did a recent algorithm update i'm going
to likely tweet about it or retweet it i
also am a blogger so on my particular
website if i blog i'm going to make sure
that blog gets over to twitter so those
are some ideas in which you can create
useful and relevant content on your
twitter account you definitely want to
get that content out there but you want
to make it useful and relevant quality
over quantity because you want people to
engage so bring variety to the type of
content you share so i'm in digital
marketing i deal with pay-per-click seo
but am i going to just do pay-per-click
and seo no i know that analytics i know
that you know google tag manager i know
that av testing all of those are
elements of digital marketing so i'm
going to branch out and talk about some
of those things that support digital
marketing so that's an example of
bringing a variety to the type of
content you share so don't just stick to
one thing you know feel free to reach
out a little bit shake things up by
sharing other forms of updates like
engaging quotes and questions these work
best when complemented by an image and
an act as a great discussion starter so
good point here even if you want to
branch out of your industry and just
throw in a nice useful quote it's always
a good way to gain some attention and
get some engagement okay let's look at
another brand and see what they've
tweeted about so we're looking at
forester here so think about emotional
qualities and their implications so
here you can see customers that feel
surprised or grateful or appreciated
they're sharing that insight with you
and so this was interesting when i saw
this so what i did was i simply you see
the hashtag here for digital basically
if you wanna look at this particular
study i just went to twitter and i typed
in that hashtag and now i'm gonna be
able to see you know some of the other
studies that they've done here you can
see top 10 i teach friends shaping 2019
so i'm just following the twitter handle
that they used so forrester does a lot
of good research a lot of good insights
and so what they've done here that makes
this tweet look so good because they've
actually
put an image of the results in the tweet
so they used an image to help gain
engagement or increase engagement notice
they also gave a shout out to somebody
as well as use some good hashtagging so
good tweet this was back in 2016 but
again a good use of the image with the
tweet so you want to organize tweet
chats to interact with your users and
bring in new followers so you know you
basically want to be organized when
you're dealing with chats so tweet chats
enable you send out tweets on a
particular topic using a designated
hashtag so during a certain time to
interact with your your followers and
other users so you could do it at a
specific time to really get out a
specific topic but you want to be able
to stay organized so that you know you
what you're chatting about is reaching
the right audience and you're getting
the right following and the right
engagement okay you can also pin your
best updates and tweets to your profile
so you can just use that pin and what
that's going to do is pin it to the top
and keep it there so that you know
people who go to your twitter handle are
going to be able to see that best tweet
that you've done so what you want to do
here is use the one that's most engaging
so pinning your best update or tweet
meaning the one that's really had a lot
of engagement meaning retweets and
followers and likes you want to do that
you want to pin that to your profile and
that will enable first-time visitors to
see it and if they could see something
that other people engage with and that's
going to encourage them to share and
probably follow you so and and that's
always what you want to do you always
want to put your best foot forward so
pin your best tweet to your profile so i
mentioned this earlier use tools to
schedule when to publish your tweets so
here are some of the most popular
platforms you know i use sprout social
so if we take a look at sprout social
here i'm in sprout social i'm connected
to my twitter account i can simply just
start tweeting about something here so
you can see it's gonna let me know how
many characters i have remaining so to
180 to start out with when i'm done
tweeting notice i can add an emoji i can
upload media i can tag a specific
location okay i can even you know call
out a specific twitter profile now i can
schedule this myself or i can use the
schedule below i can pick and choose a
time to schedule the tweet now again you
want to be able to use the sprout social
whatever social media tool you're using
two
figure out when the best time of day and
the day of the week to actually tweet
when are you getting the best engagement
so ideally that's what you want to do
you want to tweet when you're likely to
get the best engagement when those
eyeballs are actually going to look at
that tweet okay but you also want to
separate out your tweets so they're not
on one on top of another because if you
actually tweet back to back then those
tweets are just going to get buried so
if you spread them out a little bit then
you're likely to maximize your number of
impressions or eyeballs on that tweet so
if you schedule a tweet multiple tweets
in the same day then post them a few
hours apart or an hour apart so that way
you're always going to get that maximum
visibility so these social media
platforms really help you in not only
scheduling but figuring out what tweets
got the best engagement and when and
then that way you can replicate that
success so again it's not just sprout
social hootsuite buffer they'll help you
determine the exact time your audience
is most active and schedule posts to
increase traction so you know most of
these social media platforms do the same
thing so really what you want to do is
you really want to nail down that exact
time your audience is going to be most
active okay that's the whole idea behind
using it and when you actually do tweet
you are going to get results and these
social media platforms are going to
share those results with you and then
when you understand based on your
audience behavior when they're engaged
when they're not engaging that's when
you're going to fine-tune your
scheduling so what you also want to do
as you're doing these tweets as we
looked at earlier with wendy's is run
contest or giveaways remember randy's
gave away that free frosty you don't be
afraid to give away something if it
means more engagement more eyeballs
which could lead to basically future
customers so contest can help increase
your reach and exposure and each new
participant can be considered as a
potential follower so it also gives your
followers an opportunity to tag their
friends who would be interested in
participating so really come up this is
a great way to be creative come up with
a good idea to get your your audience
involved because what's likely going to
happen is your audience is going to
share this contest with others that
aren't following you and so what's going
to happen is when they share it you're
going to get more followers you're going
to get more eyeballs and again
potentially more customers so embed your
twitter updates on your website you
could simply do that uh it's very simple
but when you do then people to your
website will be able to see your tweets
so if i just go to my website here if i
scroll down we actually have your
twitter embedded on our website as well
because we want you know people to see
what we're tweeting about and you can
see i just retweeted the simply learn
tweet at the beginning of this
particular webinar and it's showing up
in my feed here so that's when people
actually go to my website they'll be
able to see what i retweeted and that's
gonna help simply learn out because
simply learn is likely to get some
clicks on this particular tweet from my
website so it's also a good way to keep
your website fresh and updated because
if you're an active twitter user and
you're tweeting a lot then hey that's
gonna show up on your website and it's
going to show that hey you're fresh
you're engaging you keep up to date it's
just going to make it look good and make
your website feel fresh and not stale so
embedding your twitter updates will help
you add new followers as well because
it's people who come into your website
that may not even know you have a
twitter account so you can also do this
in a blog post and a newsletter and
other forms of communication media so it
doesn't necessarily have to be just your
website but i would definitely recommend
it because it will give a boost to your
twitter account so now let's take a look
at the final brand watch let's take a
look at another tweet that caught our
attention and this is from playstation
so playstation is mentioning hey we got
a multi-view on apple tv today with
support for up to four live channels on
one screen okay so you know they're
promoting a new feature that they have
with playstation and you can see they
supported that with an image and they
got some really good engagement here so
they're basically saying hey look what
happened to us today you know check out
this new feature that got supported on
apple tv so you never know what's gonna
happen with a tweet when you tweet good
things are likely going to happen
whether that be somebody liking it
retweeting it or somebody adding you as
a follower something good is going to
come out of tweeting twitter is an easy
platform to use and if you take into
account all these best practices you are
going to increase your twitter followers
after watching this video you should be
prepared to explain why the human
tendency to daydream can be interrupted
using a storytelling marketing approach
to list three key benefits of
storytelling when it comes to consumer
engagement to realize that different
consumers are looking for different
relationships with your company and to
explain the difference between
storytelling and story sharing let's
begin lesson one why storytelling is
essential in social marketing
when we think about the way that our
company or our brand or our organization
is represented to the world it's easy
for us to be focused in on things like
quality and credibility and whether or
not someone wants to buy from us but
it's also important to understand that
for a lot of consumers the very idea of
who you are is also important it's not
always just enough for people to know
the name of your company or product
they're interested in understanding what
the story is behind your brand and that
might be something like how you came to
be or why you exist or what your mission
is or it might be something about the
personality and sort of the lifestyle
that's represented by your individual
company now the storytelling movement
has been an area that we've really seen
a lot of growth and a lot of improvement
in the last several years in social
media with more and more brands moving
towards this idea of sort of humanizing
their companies by telling the stories
that come out of the company itself out
of the use of the product or even out of
the consumer stories that you know share
how products benefit their lives or
again just what goes on in that
interaction and that dynamic between the
organization and between the customer
side of things now when it comes to
storytelling there's several different
ways in which this approach offers value
to a business and one of the key ones is
on the emotional side we've talked a lot
in the social sharing dynamic in some of
the other areas of you know the the
spread and the viral concept about how
emotion is one of the most powerful
things that impacts people's
decision-making and engagement with the
brand so when it comes to creating that
emotional connection or leaving people
with some type of emotional response
storytelling is one of the most powerful
ways to impact that it gives you an
opportunity to sway the emotion of
consumers in terms of how they look at
or view or are receptive to your brand
now another thing that storytelling can
really do that adds a lot of value is
the idea of making you credible because
a lot of times the way we tell stories
especially when we're incorporating in
true to life examples or you know
consumer stories there's an implied
credibility that comes through that
storytelling and comes through those
third-party experiences that can help
people feel more secure about doing
business with you not just more
emotionally positive but actually feel
that security of trusting that what they
think they're going to get or what
they're hoping to get that there's going
to be enough follow-through and enough
other people have had a positive
experience for them to really trust that
that's what's going to happen now
another area that storytelling brings a
lot of value into a company is the in
the idea of making you memorable
because human beings are wired for
stories we are much more capable of
recalling broad ideas and concepts and
emotions when they're communicated via a
story so if we give someone a list of
facts a list of selling points you know
a list of reasons why to do business
with you the ones that touch them
emotionally or that you know problem
solved those tend to stick with them but
a lot of the data gets lost but when we
put it in the format of a story and
someone is sharing what their experience
was our brains literally archive it and
categorize it differently and our recall
level goes up so again along with
building trust and along with creating
that that emotional impact the fact that
people are better able to recall the
information that's communicated to them
via that story helps make it a very
powerful marketing tool
now in addition to that it's important
to keep in mind that on average people
tend to be daydreamers in fact study
after study shows that if our minds
aren't occupied with an important task
if we're not truly focused on something
we tend to drift off and when we look at
that concept of daydreaming the average
human spends literally half of their
waking hours daydreaming we average 2
000 waking drifts per day with an
average length of about 14 seconds so
you do the math on that 2 000 times
times 14 seconds that's a pretty good
portion of our day where our brain is
drifting off
but when they look at the brain's
ability to stay focused versus having
those drips we stay focused during a
story if we're reading a book if we're
watching a movie if someone is telling
us an engaging story we are better
equipped and better able to put those
drifts off and really stay focused on
what's happening so that's one of the
other sort of scientific and concrete
reasons why that memorable factor comes
into play when we present things via
stories now stories also allow us to
connect in one of the easiest ways
possible again because our brain is
going to be a little more focused on
being able to receive that message so by
using stories to spread your brand
message or to explain your offerings or
to demonstrate how they work you
increase the chance of keeping your
audience focused on you and giving them
enough recall that they can come back at
a later point to actually do some
business with you
now think of storytelling from sort of
the mindset of how we meet and engage
with other people so in general when
we're meeting up with a prospective
friend or a job prospect maybe we're
coming for an interview a service
workers even just a stranger on the
street any conversation that goes past
just hello how are you doing and the
cursory you know kind of polite
responses it tends to be a story this is
what we do when we meet we're naturally
wired to seek out insight and common
ground and information
about who another person is
and in those interpersonal relationships
the types of questions we ask you know
the words we use they're indicative of
the type of relationship we want to
build so clearly if you know if you're
single and you see someone else that you
know you hope might be single that might
be one of the early questions you ask
and then based on whether you know
there's a romantic interest there you're
probably going to ask different
questions than if it's a interview
prospect for a job or if you're meeting
up with a you know co-worker for the
first time the relationship that we're
looking for denotes the type of
information we want and that's one of
the important things for us to keep in
mind when it comes to storytelling is we
also have the ability to tailor our
story to the audience so we can put
those different features up front we can
weave them in in a different way if
we're appealing to
a group of 60 something females that
love to sew versus a group of 20
something millennials that love whiskey
tasting it's a different message that
gets put together with different focuses
and features there's also different
things that we're going to put forward
if we're proposing you know million
dollar contract versus a 25 impulse buy
that someone can you know click and
order online and have delivered the next
day
now on the business side of this we need
to think about what the story that we
need is because a lot of times we get so
focused in business on getting the
conversion
that we forget that sometimes part of
getting that conversion is creating
those emotions building that credibility
and trust you know helping them have
exposure to what's possible and for a
long time this has been done through
education we might put up videos or
articles that aim to educate and to
demonstrate the story side of it brings
that more social interaction and
environment into the mix and that's
something important for us to keep in
mind
so a quote that i really love about this
concept that sort of lays the foundation
of why it's so important comes from the
chief content officer over at digitas
and he says the challenge is clear by
now intrusive interruptive self-centered
marketing no longer works the way it
once did and its effectiveness will only
continue to diminish in the social age
because again the way that we share
information back and forth with each
other and the ways that messages spread
it happens differently in the social
media age than it did before when it was
more advertising focused and where
marketing really was more about you know
pushing the advertise pushing the
message and sort of the don draper style
of you know if you don't like the
conversation change the conversation and
tell people what you want them to hear
because so much marketing is now driven
by consumers through that conversation
we need to be able to approach it in a
different way now another side of that
is the idea there's a difference between
storytelling and story sharing and some
of it boils down to semantics but some
of it also does need to be kind of taken
into account when we look at how we
might put our message together because
semantically consider the difference
between telling and sharing so to tell
is to communicate information facts or
news to someone in spoken or written
word it's to order instruct or advise
someone to do something that second part
that i want you to keep in mind but to
share is to give a portion of something
to another to tell someone about
something especially something personal
it's a again it's a slight semantic
difference but it's a huge difference in
terms of our approach
and i love this seth godin quote that
really pairs up with that idea the best
part of show and tell has never been the
telling part it's been the showing
letting someone see an experience and
inviting them into that shared
experience and that's one of those
things that makes the social version of
storytelling really more like story
sharing especially if you want to do it
in a way that creates that back and
forth consumer engagement story telling
in its traditional sense is more the
stories that we've put into commercials
and advertising and there's a place for
that there's a place to put that
together in the social realm and it's
very important but the other area that
that we're just starting to kind of
merge into and that really needs some
exploration by brands is that idea of
the social sharing where it really is
about engaging back and forth with your
audience and inviting them to be part of
an experience with you and with your
brand so ask yourself do you want to
tell your story to people or do you want
to share it with them and let them share
their story with you and how do you meld
those two together and what does that
look like within your particular company
or among your target audio
so now that we've laid the foundation of
why storytelling is so important and
sort of what type of impact it can have
the next thing we need to do is look at
the business side of telling your story
what does it look like to create a
narrative or something that's
representative of either your business's
story or sort of the lifestyle or
concept or ideas that you want to
promote to people
now there's tons of questions you could
ask yourself to start building your
story
but we can focus in on a couple key
areas as a starting point
to build from
one of the first ones is the idea of
whether or not you have a founder's
story now for a lot of brands the story
of their founder is so interesting or
inspiring that it catches the eye and it
makes people take a second look at the
product so think of the companies that
are sort of iconic in terms of who their
their founder or their leader is so
whether that was steve jobs and the role
he played at apple or walt disney and
the inspiration and the role he brought
to you know the entire disney complex or
loads and loads of other businesses
there are lots of examples out there of
how the brand itself was so tied to the
person who was sort of leading the helm
that that became part of their story and
people were really interested in it now
we can find loads of examples of
different brands where the founder
really plays a critical role in
representing who they are
now great example of this is spanx the
founder sarah blakely has really
embraced the story both of how she came
up with the idea which was basically she
was trying to fit into a pair of cream
pants for a party and they didn't fit
quite right and she knew that when she
put her pantyhose on everything seemed
to lay nicer so she literally cut the
feet out of a pair of pantyhose and put
them on and that's what launched the
brand you know she loves to sort of tell
that story but she also loves to tell
the story you know from her tagline of
putting her own butt on the line pays
off because the way that she made her
first sale to neiman marcus is that she
literally dragged the buyer into a
dressing room
and she went in and she put on a pair of
white pants and came out and said you
know here's what i look like without
them and went back in and put her pair
of spanx on under the white pants and
came back out and said now here's what
happens when i'm wearing these and the
buyer from neiman marcus ended up
placing a huge order and it was the
first major sale that she got that put
her in place somewhere
so those stories and sort of the yeah
this is how it happened you know this is
literally what a difference it makes
that becomes part of the brand and sort
of sarah blakely's journey as an
entrepreneur and you know moving her way
up into the you know the forbes list
of uh you know highest earning females
in the united states
all of that plays a huge role in how
they promote the brand itself and in
sort of the
the storyline and the lifestyle line
that they want to promote to the people
that might buy the product
now on a completely differently themed
vein we have fast food chain wendy's in
the u.s and canada where dave thomas was
the founder and even though he's you
know he passed away several years ago
he's still a critical part of the brand
and of the story because basically it
was the idea that a working class guy
makes good and continues to act like a
working-class guy while building a
massive charity because it wasn't
uncommon even when he was ceo to see him
show up in a store somewhere and start
working behind the counter or sweeping
the floor somewhere he always played
that role that made it clear to his
employees that he wasn't above them that
he was one of them and part of them
and has a huge huge ongoing charity
effort for adoption because he was
adopted as a child and so all of that
plays into the narrative of wendy's and
who they are and what their brand
message is and and the lifestyle that
they want to promote to customers in
fact if you if you go there now and you
buy a meal and you get your cup all of
the cups have stories of kids when they
were finally adopted and what it meant
to them when they were adopted or you
know what their first experience was
having a new family so again that plays
into the story just because people are
interested in the start of where how it
came to be
so looking at you know what the stories
are from within your team and it doesn't
always have to be that founder story
sometimes it's just someone who works
there
post cereal paired up with burns group
and use real factory workers to create a
round of honey bunches of oats
commercials and let's let's take a quick
look at what one of those actually look
like so you can kind of see the
storytelling in action here
i get out of work and and i go to the
store
and somebody
smell around
i smell cookies i said oh no you just
smelled me i just got out of work that's
honey bunches old that's all i said
don't eat me now
[Music]
now they're short simple easy stories
there's nothing complex to them they
more just make you smile and laugh but
they're the types of stories that come
from listening to the people who work at
your company from thinking about
how your company and their experience
impacts the world around them
now another question that we can look at
is does your company or group solve a
problem now this isn't about the reasons
you think you're great or the reason you
think people should buy from you
it's about that unique way that you
solve an issue that consumers or
on the b2b side of things you know that
the buying agent is looking at that
they're trying to fix
now great example of this is airbnb or
you could look at uber or lyft on a
similar vein
allowing people to experience travel
in a new and affordable way but also
letting you know owners or drivers earn
extra money
you know from something that might have
been sitting there empty anyways you
know that idea that when you're
traveling you don't have to stay in a
bland expensive hotel in fact when i
travel for business pretty much any
place i go i always book via airbnb
because you know if i can have a bedroom
and a living room and a kitchen
especially for traveling as a family and
there can be you know separate bedrooms
as opposed to having my kids all stay in
the same room with my husband and i
it just makes sense but there's also the
story side of that of its different
experiences and that's one of the big
things that people talk about is how the
experience changes and even on the side
of trying to recruit people to put their
properties it becomes about the freedom
and the lifestyle that's enabled and
there's tons of examples on youtube of
people sharing how you know leasing out
that you know their vacation property
the rest of the year when they're not
there you know pays for the vacation
property and more or you know the people
who now travel full-time because they're
able to lease out you know their
apartment or their home or something
else on airbnb the story side comes from
the problems that are solved for people
now another great example of a company
that focuses on their story from that
side is dollar shave club they basically
took a problem everyone complains about
and they made it go away you know the
idea that razors cost a ridiculous
amount of money that you always forget
to buy new ones until it's too late so
you're shaving with a dull blazer and
it's just inconvenient so all of their
messaging focuses in on that idea of we
make it cheap we make it easy and
you know it shows up right at your house
and you don't ever have to think about
it anymore
and their commercials all tell the same
story with kind of a you know funny
modern millennial focused way so let's
take a look at one of those as an
example
as a founder of my own club i'd love to
know how does yours work dollar shave
club presents what the fact it's simple
you choose from one of our three great
razors we'll give you a free reusable
handle and each month we'll send you
replacement cartridges for just a few
bucks that means you get to shave with
the fresh blood anytime you want which
feels amazing
will i be locked into a contract
no we wouldn't lock you into anything
that's a relief how long for delivery
i've got a conjugal visit next week
well what if i don't have to shave that
often
no problem after you sign up you can
choose to get replacement cartridges
every other month you sound like my mom
i like that
ew
what's this i hear about dollar shave
club selling more than just razors you
heard right we make all our own high
quality grooming products like dr cover
shave butter boogie's hair gel and
big cloud daily face moisturizer with
sunscreen
now you know what the fact is up from
dollar shave club so join the club today
[Music]
now before we get into the tips and
tricks let's take a refresher on what
exactly is social media marketing
social media marketing which is one of
the most commonly used and lucrative
forms of digital marketing
is a methodology that has brands
creating and sharing content on social
media
now if you've ever been on any form of
social media be it linkedin facebook or
instagram you've probably been exposed
to some form of social media marketing
remember that burger king video
advertising that new whopper
or about a marketing tool that can help
you visualize your team's workload
better than any other in the market
right now
now these are just some of the many ways
that you've been marketed to
the objective when it comes to social
media marketing is to achieve the
brand's marketing and branding goals
now this could be increased engagement
more clicks conversions and so on
so how do they do it
with text and image updates videos or
any other form of content that can
attract the user's attention and can
drive engagement from them
now alongside publishing quality content
it also involves analyzing your data
and running social media advertisements
now some of the more popular social
media platforms right now are facebook
instagram twitter linkedin and so on
next let's talk about some of the
advantages of social media marketing
first off social media marketing
provides great brand awareness
now with the help of interactions with
people on social media brands are able
to build up their reputation as a
business
and with each interaction each post each
share the brand is exposed to a larger
network of potential customers who might
be interested in the products or
services offered
next it gets you more traffic to your
website
marketing your products or services on
social media will also attract customers
to your website
outside your usual custom base
next it improves your brand's search
engine rankings
now although this isn't a direct
correlation
social media marketing does have a part
to play when it comes to helping your
page rank higher up in search engine
rankings now if you start posting high
quality content
people will start liking and sharing it
this will in turn bring it to the
attention of influencers within the
industry who will be willing to write
about your business
and then this gives you backlinks which
as you know will help you improve your
search engine rankings
next it will give you improved
conversion rates
now with your brand being much more
visible and interactive on social media
every text image video or comment could
potentially drive users to your website
social media also humanizes your brand
now this leads to more customers
trusting your brand and being more
interested in your products and services
then we have improved customer
satisfaction
when your customers interact with your
brand on social media it provides you
with an opportunity to show compassion
for your customers
personal messages to customers
addressing their concerns will be viewed
in a positive light and can go a long
way when it comes to humanizing your
brand
social media marketing is also cost
effective
now compared to other forms of digital
marketing
social media marketing offers some of
the most flexible and relatively low
cost options available
now this opens your budget for more
marketing and business expenditures
now if you do get into paid advertising
a good strategy will net you a great
return on investment
and finally it will help you become
thought leaders
now with your high quality posts
communicating with your audience sharing
content and promoting your authority
you can have your followers look up to
you now this will allow you to become a
figure of expertise in your industry
now let's go into the social media
marketing tips and tricks
number one
set up your goals
now what good will your actions do if
you don't have a goal in mind
the goal of your marketing strategy will
be the driving force behind every
decision that you make
now this is exactly why setting up goals
is very important moreover your
marketing efforts have to align with the
goals of the organization
now here are some things that you need
to keep in mind while setting up your
goals
first of all your goals need to be
quantitative
for example you need to have thousand
conversions by the end of the quarter or
5000 followers on instagram by the end
of the month and so on
number two you need to stick to a
consistent deadline this gives wait for
each of your actions
number three make sure your goals are
smart
now smart refers to specific
measurable attainable relevant and time
based
now let's go to number four
like i mentioned earlier your goals need
to be aligned with the marketing
strategy
now alongside these goals there also
needs to be the north star metric
now what is the not star metric
this represents a main goal or a fixed
reference point that will ensure that
your team is on the right course
this not star metric will also give your
team clarity and focus
now let's have a look at some popular
not stars there's increased engagement
greater conversion rates more leads
generated app downloads and so on
now let's go to number two
understanding your audience
social media enables you to interact
engage and build relationships with your
audience
now by understanding what they need want
and desire you can deliver content in a
way makes your product or service the
answer that they're looking for
now there are also other ways you can
understand them better this could be
surveys to determine the issues that
bother them
the age demographics of your audience by
conversing with them in forums
responding to their comments on blogs
and social media taking up their
feedbacks of suggestions into
consideration and acting on them
and so on
now here's an example of different
channels and the audiences that use them
now here we taken our personal example
here is simply learn now simply learn's
audience is predominantly working
professionals and graduates
an academy has high school graduates and
the baiju's app
has high school students as users
now let's go to number three
determining the right social media
platform
now while performing social media
marketing choosing the right platform is
really important
now while selecting them you need to ask
questions like why you're using that
particular platform
who you'll reach with this platform what
content would work best on the platform
and is there any content that was unique
to that platform for example youtube and
then there's videos on it
now answering these questions will help
you zero in on a platform for you
now while there are several platforms
available for you to choose from let me
tell you about some major ones this is
linkedin facebook instagram and
pinterest
let's talk about the purpose of each of
these platforms
now linkedin is a professional network
that's best suited for b2b audiences
now for facebook just about everyone has
an account on it
content that's related to news or
entertainment usually finds success on
facebook
then we have instagram
visual content works best on instagram
now although it works well for static
images and short form videos it doesn't
drive a lot of traffic to your website
then finally we have pinterest pinterest
is also limited to static images
however it's highly effective at driving
traffic to your blog
now let's go to number four
setting up a social media calendar
a social media calendar determines the
message you want to convey to your
audience it also consists of information
regarding the different kinds of content
that will go up on the social media
platform
now let's have a look at some of the
most popular types of posts on social
media
first off we have competitions
now i'm sure all of you have seen posts
like tag a friend who does this or
comment or like to win something and
stuff like that
competitions like these provide great
opportunities for engagement with the
audience
now they can be used to encourage your
followers to share your content it could
be also for them to create their own
content along with the predefined
hashtag
competitions help grow your presence on
social media
then we have polls or surveys
polls can help you with data collection
that also encourages followers to take
action and interact
polls and surveys also provide
opportunities through which you can
learn from customers to understand what
they like about the product or service
or what they don't
and to receive their feedback
then we have videos and live streams
now although we'll be covering this in a
little more detail further on
visual storytelling along with videos
and live streams goes a long way to
drive engagement among your audience
now these help get your followers
attention increase trust and credibility
and have a high response rate and so
much more to offer
livestream with its live nature and
having a human face alongside your
business humanizes your brand and by
extension helps increase customer
loyalty and trust
then there's infographics articles and
images
social media calendars are successful
because of their ability to increase
collaboration within the team help
understand what works and what doesn't
and in distributing resources in an
effective manner
next up we have number five using social
media marketing tools
social media marketing tools align to
the goals of your organization
with it you can create high quality
content attract new potential customers
and drive engagement
it also helps you with the planning
process
you can plan create and schedule posts
on your social calendar
now some of the more popular social
media tools include buffer hootsuite
buzzsumo if triple t and much more
now these tools also help with
generating leads creating email lists
finding a relevant audience to show your
content to
creating buyer personas
providing you insights on what works and
what doesn't and giving you templates
for different kinds of posts
now for number six
visual storytelling
now visual storytelling involves passing
out a lot of information in the simplest
of forms visually
using pictures and videos your followers
are able to grasp the message quickly
and remember it for a long time
afterwards
visual storytelling is also not limited
by language barriers this helps it
become interesting and entertaining to
anyone watching it
this can help your audience stay
interested and engaged grab the
attention of potential clients and so
much more
but it also has some other advantages
it helps you build a bond with your
audience
visual storytelling connects with your
methods like live streaming help
humanize your brand and help grow
customer loyalty and trust
it helps the audience quickly grasped
the intended message thanks to its
simple nature
and finally most importantly
content like images and videos are what
go viral with visual storytelling you
increase the chance for your content to
be seen by more potential customers
have a look at some of our videos
now here's what is machine learning data
science in five minutes and ai in five
minutes
now these are some of our most viewed
videos on our channel
and now you know why
visual storytelling
if you guys are interested in watching
these videos you can check them out on
our channel home page
we also have similar videos about
blockchain devops and six sigma
now
back to our list
let's go to number seven
paying for advertising
this is a method that helps you find
target and reach your audience with ease
it can greatly help with achieving your
organization's marketing goals
this can help you improve your reach
and improve your brand's visibility
its pay-per-click model ensures cost
effectiveness while providing great
results and return on investment it also
helps improve targeting by letting you
control who sees your ad
you get to choose from a number of
different factors like interests hobbies
personality types and so on alongside
the basic user demographics like age
location gender and so on now since most
social media platforms have native
analytics you also get to assess and
refine the performance of your ad
campaigns
now as great as it sounds there are
certain pitfalls that come along with
paid advertising
first of all your audience could get
exposed to your posts too many times and
tune out your content disregarding it in
the process
second it could get really expensive for
smaller businesses or startups to manage
a campaign to its maximum effectiveness
third people could pass off your content
as irrelevant and unimportant
you'll also have to deal with a whole
lot of competition
smaller companies with lesser budgets
have an uphill battle to deal with
better funded organizations
next we have number eight newsjacking
new stacking is a method that involves
using current events to promote your own
brands products and services
now it's a popular method that's used to
improve brand awareness
news jacking uses the popularity of the
current events and drives it to your
brand it also helps shine a spotlight on
your products it also helps you show off
that you are up to date with current
events in the industry and that your
product is relevant
by extension it also improves engagement
and website traffic
now for number nine
a b testing
ap testing is a popular method for
comparing copies creatives and ctas or
call to actions of the posts that you
put on social media
now since audiences would react
differently depending on the content a b
testing helps determine which of the
variants your audience engaged with the
most
a b testing can also be performed on
variations of location age gender
education your audience interests and so
on
next up number 10
community and influencers
joining communities helps your brand
link up with like-minded people and
other companies belonging to your niche
it'll also help you establish your brand
as an authority within the industry
now actively participating in these
communities can help create your own
audience of potential brand advocates to
group up with
on the other hand partnering up with
influencers
helps promote your products or services
to a brand new audience
it helps provide an additional layer of
authenticity in youtube which is also a
social media platform if you didn't know
here are some very very popular
influences
we have marcus brownlee unbox therapy mr
who's the boss and lioness tech tips
each of them with more than 4 million
subscribers
and finally we're at number 11
measuring and analyzing results
accurately tracking and measuring your
marketing efforts are an important part
of the process
it ensures that you're making the most
out of your campaigns
now it's really important that you find
key metrics that are crucial for your
brand
now these metrics can be tracked weekly
monthly or in a quarterly basis
and based on these results appropriate
actions can be taken
on facebook you could look out for reach
and engagement on twitter you could look
out for impressions
clicks and impressions and interactions
on linkedin
likes comments and mentions on instagram
and engagement and impressions on
pinterest
some of the most popular tools used for
this purpose
are sprout social buffer hootsuite
google analytics and so on
now before we get into the tips and
tricks let's take a refresher on what
exactly is content marketing
content marketing is a form of marketing
that involves the creation and sharing
of online content to help generate
audience interest in a brand's product
or services this means providing
information that the audience considers
valuable and relevant in a consistent
manner so that it drives some sort of
profitable customer action
so let's talk about the content that
falls under content marketing there's
options like blogs
videos
infographics case studies white papers
and ebooks
so why is content marketing so important
firstly it helps build awareness
trust and loyalty in your brand
the more your brand provides accurate
and well-researched content the more
people learn about and trust your brand
the more the audience trusts in you the
more they're likely to buy from you
creating the content is relatively
inexpensive and can be done in-house
content marketing will also enable your
brand to increase traffic to your site
and get more conversions
it also helps improve other marketing
tactics like search engine optimization
social media and public relations
now let's have a look at the content
marketing process
the first step is to determine what
goals you want to achieve with your
marketing campaign it could be increased
conversions website signups and so on
then you set up buyer personas from
among your audience that can buy your
content
but what exactly are buyer personas
now these are research-based profiles
that represent your target customer
buyer personas help you describe your
brand's ideal audience
the decisions they make the challenges
they face their interests and so on
next you'll have to set up content
audits to determine the best type of
content that works for you
you also need to set up a content
management system like hubspot
squarespace wix and wordpress they'll
help you with increased collaboration
greater support run a b tests and much
more
you need to brainstorm for new forms of
content that your audience can enjoy
after that you can zero in on a
particular form of content that would
work the best for you
and finally you can publish and manage
your content now let's talk about
content marketing tips
number one
remarket your content
content marketing is one of the many
ways you can spread your content to a
buyer audience you can define the
audience you want to market to and then
tag visitors who come to your site and
using google's display network you can
strategically position your ads in front
of people on google or its partner
websites who previously interacted with
your website and advertised to them
through this you can build awareness and
engagement with your audience
here's an example of a banner
advertisement i would be shown if i was
shopping for a macbook pro on amazon and
changed my mind at the last moment
this ad would maybe stay at the back of
my head until eventually i go and finish
that purchase
now let's go to number two answering
complex questions with your content
targeting specific keywords is extremely
helpful with your content this is why
you need to focus on google's featured
snippet this position also known as
position 0 enhances and draws user
attention on the search engine's result
page
through the featured snippet you can
drive a large amount of traffic to your
website while cementing your position as
an expert in your industry
you can have different forms of snippets
like definition boxes where a snippet of
text gives researchers direct and
concise definitions and descriptions
you could have tables where data is
taken from the page and displayed in a
table you could have ordered lists where
items are presented in specific order
and you can also have unordered lists
next up number three we have create a
personality for your brand
if you're looking to grow a following
for your content try not to copy how
already established and successful
corporate blogs do things
nowadays audiences tend to prefer
content that has a certain humanness
about it
tend to follow solo influencers
they advertise their brand by being
themselves
in a way they're selling themselves by
being themselves
you need to analyze what these popular
and influential blogs are doing and
incorporate into your brand's website
thanks to this your audience will
connect with you and come back for more
now here's an example of one of the
largest players in digital marketing
neil patel
see how he himself is the brand and if
you've gone through his content you know
it's pretty great as well
that's what you should be striving for
moving on to tip number four ensure that
your content matches your brand's voice
to make sure of this you need to
constantly review your editorial
standards and make sure your tone and
quality remain consistent
you need to ask your audience questions
about how you can develop and refine
your brand's voice
by answering these questions you can
provide your audience with a more
cohesive and helpful experience
your tone of your brand can vary on the
basis of what type of content you are
planning to post and what the goal you
want to achieve from the campaign
next up we have number five back up your
arguments for data
using statistics and facts to make a
point by including a link to the
original source makes it extremely
credible this data can help the audience
grow trust in your brand to persuade
them that your content is valid and
valuable
this will also help your brand grow as
an industry expert
at number six
we have use specific keywords
now make sure you use specific keywords
in your content this takes care of the
seo aspect behind your content
this will also help your content have a
greater chance of being found indexed
and ranked
it could also help your content rank for
niche topics within your industry moving
on to tip number seven
evaluate the success of your content
with data
earlier we talked about why it's so
important that you back up your content
with data
now let's talk about how data can help
you improve
analytics tools will help you learn more
about how well your content is doing the
age demographics of the people enjoying
it who doesn't their locations the best
time to post and much more
with this data you can make sure that
your time and money are being used in
the best possible way
some of the most popular tools in the
market are buzzsumo evernote hubspot
trello and wordpress
these will help you find topics and
influencers within your industry you can
capture organize and share notes
collaborate with team members create
sales funnels and much more
now we've reached midway right now so
i've got a question for you
do you guys have any tips for content
marketing that we haven't covered yet
let me know in the live chat
alright so let's get back to our list
tip number eight is to be consistent
with your content
post your best performing content and
make sure they follow a consistent
schedule
finding a balance of the different types
of content to be posted with the help of
a content calendar will show your
audience that you're committed to
providing them helpful and informative
content
this will also establish your brand as
an authority and thought leader within
your niche it will help your audience
depend on you for quality content and
give them a reason to return tip number
nine is to make your content actionable
providing actionable steps or
information in your content will coerce
your audience to take a particular
action quickly
it can help you create valuable content
and fix pain points faced by your
audience build a strong relationship
with them and earn their trust
it also leads to increased engagement
and a positive brand experience
it provides users with real value and
solutions leading them to take action
here we have an example from trello
where we see a pop-up with a call to
action asking interested users to input
their email ids to sign media today
involving more than 200 marketers more
than 49 of them felt content marketing
was really important to their digital
marketing campaigns and more than 25
percent of their budgets are used for
visual advertising content like images
infographics
videos and other forms of rich media
will help you enhance the message of
your brand and reach a wider audience
here's an example of advertising by
coca-cola
although there's not a lot of text in
the ads you can immediately recognize
the unmistakable branding and the
message they're trying to send moving on
to tip number 11
create trending and evergreen content
creating content that's evergreen and
trending with your own unique angle
statistics and research will be a huge
advantage since you'll have to update it
every now and then
you'll get a great deal out of the work
without having to do a lot of work
here's an example of one such evergreen
article
people are never going to stop wanting
to learn how to do seo so with a little
tweaking every few months to reflect new
changes that google may have done you'll
have an article that you can get
considerable mileage out of
next up tip number 12 is to understand
content that works for you
you need to analyze what content works
on different social media platforms
for example you all know youtube is the
best place for video content instagram
and pinterest for visual content twitter
for smaller snappy content and so on
understanding what works and what
doesn't will help you better spread your
content across the internet
tip number 13 is to understand your
target audience
now like i mentioned earlier your
marketing campaign isn't going to bear
fruit without targeting a specific
audience
understanding who your audience is is
one of the most important steps for this
you can find this out by asking
questions like who you're engaging with
online their age location language etc
by using social listening to find out
what audiences are talking about your
brand using tools to research what
social channels your audience is using
and so on
after understanding them you can set up
buyer personas for your audience
tip number 14 is to perform a b testing
now abs testing will help you understand
what your audience likes or doesn't what
content works for you and much more
you can do a b testing on headlines and
title tags call to actions content
formats image types content length and
much more it can also help you make
better decisions in the future
and finally our tip number 15 is to
reach out to people sharing similar
content
one of the best ways to build your
audience is to get people or influencers
who already share content within your
niche to share your content
now since these people already have a
trusting audience they would be a lot
more likely to enjoy your content
content marketing strategy
so buckle up and let's get right to it
and we're gonna get right into some of
the best practices some tips some
methodologies some things you should be
doing with content marketing so right
out of the gate let's start talking
about knowing your audience okay so
content is all about
writing for a particular audience so
it's just like speaking except when
we're speaking to somebody we're
speaking directly to them content is
very similar and so we have to be able
to know our audience ahead of time so
what you can do is collect demographics
of your target audience based on
who's coming to your website so you can
get that data in google analytics under
audience email subscribers i mean
who is subscribing to your emails who do
you already have in your email database
and you can look at social media i mean
you look at facebook you can look at the
people who already connected to you okay
these are just some three three of many
examples you could be doing to
gather data on your audience okay you
have to know who your audience is before
you start writing you know for a
successful content marketing strategy
you really just need to know your
audience and
basically you're going to segment them
based on their interest so that content
is going to be catered to that audience
okay so if it signs that likes a
specific you know product uh that you
offer or feature that's part of that
product that you offer then that's the
segment you're gonna be writing about so
you need to collect your data on your
audience ahead of time then you're gonna
segment that audience okay so you're not
gonna write content for everyone because
the shoe doesn't necessarily fit for
everyone okay the shoe has to fit for
specific foot and in this case we're
talking about an audience we need to be
able to segment our audience out and you
could certainly segment them out by age
by gender by education level by income
by interest i mean these are just some
of the examples again it could be new
returning or new reusers versus
returning users it could be users who
have purchased from you in the past
versus users who haven't purchased from
you in the past it could certainly be
an age range or it could be even going
further on interest level or combination
thereof okay so for example you can get
that demographic information using
google analytics
just got to go into analytics under
audience under demographics you're going
to see age and br it's age is broken out
by age range and they're going to see
gender so you're going to see a
breakdown of gender and use that to your
advantage so if you're going to
you know write some content and you know
99 of your traffic is female the age of
18 to 24 then you know that contents may
catered accordingly so
we could certainly go to facebook page
insights and get some really good
demographic data there because facebook
is all about demographics okay so
you could see exactly
you know how many fans you have broken
out by men versus women and then you can
see again same thing as google analytics
you could see an age range breakout you
could use twitter analytics i mean
twitter has share some really good
insights into education level so
you know if you're dealing with
you know highly sophisticated people who
have master's degrees or even higher or
let's just say even on linkedin you know
that majority of the people you're
trying to target are c-level meaning
ceos or cfos or cmos you know chief
marketing officers or chief executive
officers then you're going to cater your
message a little bit different than say
mid-range managers or or you know even
high-range managers or even vps so use
your audience information that you
collect on these various platforms to
your advantage okay so let's jump into
number two we want to create high
quality content now i know this sounds
like a given but and i say but heavily
there's not a lot of high quality
content out there on the internet so
separate yourself first and foremost
always always always create high quality
content it's gonna result in a lot of
things that are gonna benefit you you
know one you're gonna come across as you
know somebody who knows what they're
talking about and that's gonna help
increase your brand awareness okay when
you increase your brand awareness people
know about you so it's likely going to
increase traffic to your website or if
you're on social media you know if you
produce good high quality content people
are going to share that content okay so
from an seo perspective it can improve
website ranking meaning if you have good
quality content you know and it's really
focused in on a specific topic or a
certain set of core words keywords then
you're gonna rank improves website dwell
time meaning hey you get good content
people are gonna hang around to see what
else you have to offer okay so it's no
secret that you know good content you
usually leads to you know quality
engagement and then
certainly last but not least you can
gain a lot of leads here meaning hey
somebody likes what you have to say
whether that's a video or blog post or
or infographic you know people are going
to become more interested more engaged
spend more time and that's all going to
funnel through to somebody taking that
next step in the funnel and
becoming more interested in your service
or even purchasing one of your products
so creating high quality content
involves brainstorming topics and terms
you know you got to do the upfront work
due diligence is at work here so
brainstorm some topics use a keyword
research tool to gather results so if
you have a topic you know one of the
benefits of quality content is rankings
go to google's keyword planner
understand how much quality
and and understand how much competition
each keyword has or understand how much
volume each keyword has that's what's
available in google's keyword planner or
any really any keyword planning tool
you always want to create original
content okay so you don't want to
plagiarize or take somebody else's
content and then you want to support
that content with compelling headlines
so if you have a piece of content you
got to get somebody's attention
write a nice headline that's going to
grab their attention okay so give
valuable content to readers and add
resources from well-known sites so if
you you do borrow say
a data point from another source then
you know cite that source you also want
to create engaging and thought-provoking
content get somebody to think i mean
people are going to rage your content
because they not they don't know the
subject matter their interests in the
subject matter and they want to be able
to spend the time taking something away
from that content follow a logical
structure and use relevant images i
can't stress this one enough you know
just throw things on a web page you know
put some structure to it maybe you have
to break it out if you feel like you
have too much content there's no harm in
breaking it into part one versus part
two get people uh tease them a bit get
them to come back and read part two okay
use different content forms in case
somebody's interested maybe you want to
capture some data you know prefer short
paragraphs to make the content readable
remember if you're talking to c-level
folks you know maybe you don't have to
dummy down the content so to speak but
if you're dealing with you know folks or
people that are right out of high school
or still in high school then adjust your
content in format and paragraphs
accordingly and then update the content
as well just because you publish it
doesn't mean that it's done i mean when
we're talking about a web page we're
talking about something that is actively
changing or can change the medium that
is dynamic okay so if a data points
change go back in and update that data
point and then let people know about it
because they may want to come back and
and you know check in to see how much
that data points changed so these are
all
you know good takeaways for creating
high quality content you know some other
things that you should be aware of you
know grammatical mistakes you know you
need to avoid those there's no reason
for grammatical mistakes today's
technology doesn't allow for it and
hey listen we all have friends we have
colleagues my desk is sitting next to a
colleague who's more than happy to read
something before it gets published so
take advantage of the resources you have
available no reason for it because if
you have a grammatical mistake you just
lost a lot of credibility you know don't
be afraid to add a clear call to action
at the end of your content if somebody's
interested in reading it they're
probably gonna be interested in taking
the next step whatever that next step is
okay so creating content that fulfills
viewers requirements meaning somebody's
searching for something and your content
shows up in the search results then
they're actively looking for you what
are you offering them is it fulfilling
their requirements you know don't be
afraid to use examples throughout your
content in fact work in or integrate
some case studies in there show clear
examples to stress your points
and then just don't put words on a web
page you know so break up that content
with an image that's going to be
visually appealing okay and you can add
images from public domain sites meaning
stock imagery if that's what's going to
help create visually appealing content
and then give more information to your
audience and we say prefer to give more
information meaning hey going back to
the content i was saying about breaking
it up organizing it if you have more
information you don't withhold it have
them come back and read a secondary blog
post or secondary piece that supports
the original now we want to move from
high quality content to running a b test
baby test's so important why because
with a b split testing you can increase
your conversion rates okay so
four elements to test in your content
marketing strategy so if you have
content say a blog and you're testing
that blog you know test out the images
test out the forms do you have a long
form or short form you know test out the
content length you can have a variation
that is a lot shorter than the original
does that increase or decrease bounce
rates play around with call to actions
your call to actions do matter you know
do you want to use a softer call to
action a softer tone or do you want to
use something very direct and strong you
know test call to actions to see what's
going to get people to move closer
through the
closer to purchasing and through that
funnel so a b testing to me is something
that should be naturally done with
google optimize it's free so with images
you know you could test a lot of
different variations of images anything
from people
to
you know outlandish imagery just
something very stock and neutral but
just make sure that those images are
relevant to the post you know test the
length of that content you know again if
you know that your average time on page
is very low
you know don't write something very long
write something that you think is going
to stick with that time on page but on
your a b test create something maybe a
little longer if it's engaging enough
maybe somebody's going to stay a little
bit longer on the page so
you know create a variation it's going
to play with that length okay so use
analytics to your advantage to figure
out
as a baseline what amount of content is
getting people to stay on the page then
see if you can push the envelope one way
or the other okay improving the page
with sign up forms really what you want
to do is create a user friendly
experience so when you have sign up
forms and don't make them non-intuitive
don't make them difficult you know link
maybe up to facebook or google so
if they're creating an account they can
create an account via google or facebook
or you know don't put too many forms on
the page and then on those ctas as i
mentioned play around with the tone you
can also play around the color i mean i
test color all the time believe it or
not color does matter don't use red use
green people react to different colors
but again you have cultural variances as
well so you got to take that into
account if you're in the middle east or
the far east asia you know color schemes
and what you say matters and it changes
versus say you know europe or the west
okay so keep that in mind when you're
making changes on color or tone or
placement and things of that nature so
you want to conduct a competitor
analysis so we're talking about creating
high quality content testing that
content you know brainstorming some
topics you know looking at your audience
you're doing all this work you might as
well take the next step and figure out
what it is your competitors are doing so
you can opt for competitive analysis by
identifying your competitors top
performing content for specific topics
okay and so
really what we're trying to do here is
improve our conversion rates so what are
your competitors doing what are their
baselines we can maybe up that annie i
mean that data is also available in
google analytics so you can look at
benchmarking reports in google analytics
to get some form or fashion you can also
go to facebook and look at your
competitors facebook pages and see
what's performing in terms of engagement
but what you want to do is find out your
strongest competitors by using search
engines or check which websites are
competing with you and again that could
include facebook as well or maybe even
linkedin so you go with the search
engine route you can always type in that
coveted keyword that you want to be
found for see who's ranking ahead of you
and you can see the metadata meaning the
title tag and the meta description you
can actually see hey what are these guys
writing that's getting them recognized
in the search engine rankings so you can
certainly if you go to search engine
route you could certainly leverage an
seo platform like search
sem rush or moz or something like that
that's going to allow you to get some
good insight on competitor information
so keep in mind there are seo platforms
that will give you information on your
competitors and that's what these seo
platforms are good for so number five
moving on choose a suitable content
format so
now we've done all this homework we know
what we want to say we know who we want
to say it to we're ready to do some
testing but we need to find a format
because it's not always about a web page
per se meaning content on a web page
there's not always about a blog post
with content in that blog post okay we
need to decide the type of content
that's going to fit what we're trying to
say so again you can go the traditional
route with just posting a blog post and
there's nothing wrong with that because
with a blog post you can incorporate
video and imagery you could also go a
more harder route when i say harder more
i say official route with an e-book or
case study something that
a user is going to be able to take away
with maybe download
something more
official um something more in-depth
something with a harder stamp on it so
that that shows individuals that you've
taken the time you've done this homework
you've done this research you've done
some really in-depth analysis and now
the proper format for that is not a blog
post it's an e-book now if you're into
talking like i am then you can certainly
do a podcast and podcasts are always
popular depending on the topic so you
got to be aware of the topic now videos
are always always a good option you got
the likes of video and video and youtube
and some other you know video platforms
out there that allow you the ability to
get found very quickly especially with
the likes of youtube you know people use
youtube before they go on to purchasing
a product so think about that so if
you're trying to get somebody if you're
trying to sway an audience to move from
being a brand awareness and a loyal you
know customer to taking the next step
okay to purchasing more or purchasing
for the first time and so videos kind of
help convey that now if you're trying to
convey a lot of different points then an
infographic might be your best option
instead of having to write out all those
points you know try using an infographic
to convey those points visually now
again with blog posts it should have
valuable content that can be shared by
your website
visitors on social so that's the key
make sure you have those shareable
social icons now with ebooks it should
have longer in-depth content so and it
shouldn't be published frequently so
maybe if this is something you're doing
annually then ebook could be the format
with a case study what you should have a
customer story that succeeded in and you
solving that customer's problem so the
case study is always there for
you know somebody to get an idea of what
you're all about infographic is just
visualizing data in a more organized way
in a more visual way so somebody
understands what you're trying to convey
now with that podcast again suppose your
audience doesn't have an interest in
reading again it could be a certain age
certain gender a certain culture
hey everybody absorbs information
differently so think about it ask
yourself is a podcast the best way to
communicate to my target audience and
then videos are highly engaging they're
also shareable on blog posts and pretty
much most if not all social media
platforms so once you've done that once
you choose the proper format you want to
choose a content management system
that's going to work for you so you want
to be able to choose something where you
can plan appropriately produce
manage publish and measure results all
in one place there are plenty of content
management systems out there that will
help you do all of those things okay so
some examples are wordpress hubspot
binder i mean we can list hundreds if
you're into blogging you know wordpress
is the way to go if you're into building
out landing pages that you want to you
know share
you know hotspot could be the way to go
okay there are lots of available options
out there so moving on number seven
target your audience using emails okay
so what are we talking about well we all
know what emails are emails help us to
communicate directly with our target
audience and convert them to leads so
email is a good way to follow up with
your audience so if you've done a
podcast follow up with an email you
maybe get them to you know fill out a
survey via email based on that podcast
or if you create a podcast about some
data that you talked about in that
podcast follow up that with with them
via email with an infographic perhaps
okay built into the email okay there's
lots of ways that all these formats can
complement themselves via email okay you
could certainly take a blog post and
package it into an email and have a link
pointing back to the blog post maybe as
a teaser or if you're doing a series a
series of blog posts you know you could
tease that in an email so an email is a
good way to
you know follow up with your target
audience indirectly or directly when we
say indirectly
you know you can collect emails and send
out those emails with you know certain
information or what you should be doing
is targeting and segmenting your emails
just like you are your content so if
you're producing content for a certain
audience then make sure that particular
audience gets that same email now some
of the email content that you could
share with your target audience or
newsletters okay seasonal emails
promotional emails automated messaging
and what we mean by automated messaging
hey if somebody just purchased from you
send them a thank you email maybe follow
up a couple days later with another
email with a survey or
what you could do is if you know who
your loyal customers are you target them
with a promotional email so there's lots
of ways to slice and dice content via
email okay just make sure you know your
target audience is there's lots of
things you can do in email again you can
complement lots of different formats
within email as i mentioned before with
a podcast or a blog post so keep all
that in mind email's a good way to
communicate with your audience okay the
last point we want to make here is use
native ads okay so we talk about native
ads it's one of the smartest ways to
connect your audience with your brand so
for example this is a native ad on
buzzfeed okay it's about 15 bands that
probably won't exist without led
zeppelin okay so for you folks out there
that don't know who led zeppelin is a
rock group from the 70s late 60s 70s
okay disbanded in 80 81 82 early 80s
okay but you know people grew up like
myself listening to led zeppelin okay so
you can see the headline here 15 bands
that probably won't exist with the
outlet zeppelin you know i'm interested
in who those bands might be even if you
don't know who led zeppelin is okay you
might be inquisitive to say okay
who is this led zeppelin group and what
are these 15 bands the key here is not
necessarily the headline or led zeppelin
per se but it's a native ad and it's
sitting next to
content talking about music okay so
according to forbes online audiences are
25 percent more likely to look at a
native ad than at a banner and so that
native ad
in this case we're talking about music
needs to be sitting or accompanied
alongside content talking about in this
case music you know would help if it was
rock music just music in general might
get enough to get peak people's interest
okay so if you're going to create
content you know align that content with
something that's you know naturally
going to fit and that's why we call them
native ads because they're native to the
content that they're associated with so
finally after all that's said and done
when all you've done is create good
content follow up via emails targeting
your audience and associating that
content with you know content natively
then you can always measure your content
performance so
my favorite part of it all you going to
analytics going to facebook insights you
know you want to go in and check out how
that content's performing and you want
to do that because you want to be able
to see what's performing what's not
performing the key here is associating
the content with kpis that's really the
key so measuring the right metrics can
help you understand whether your content
is engaging or not so again measuring
the right metrics okay so when we're
talking about a video you're not
necessarily going to look at page views
you're going to look at video views so
you know some of these basic metrics of
users and sessions and pages bounce rate
you know dwell time that's all great but
you just need to make sure that
you're aligning the right metric with
the right asset so for example if you
have a case study or ebook you want to
make sure that
you're measuring how many downloads
the ebook or the
case study received again with the video
you want to measure video views now if
you're packaging up emails and sending
them out to your target audience you
want to make sure you look at open rates
and click rates okay so a lot of things
you can be looking at so make sure you
choose the right metrics because there's
hundreds and hundreds of metrics to
choose from so just be aware all the
different metrics that are available
you know if you're in it for search okay
how much traffic getting from search
where are you ranking so there are a lot
of things you need to think about so
think about the content that you're
producing and think about how you want
to be able to measure that content so
let's go back over our checklist here
so
what you could do is create an editorial
calendar in fact i would highly suggest
you create an editorial calendar in
order to keep track of all the content
you've done over a period of time are
you making your content worth reading
that means are you
checking the results of that content
what we just went over measuring the
content is it worth reading have a
column set up in that editorial calendar
you know performing or not performing if
it's not performing don't do it again
okay curate your content okay you always
wanna you know make sure you're reusing
or using or adding to the content that
you've created guest post on influential
blogger websites you want to add
statistics numbers and quotes to your
content make it engaging make it look
like you've done your homework you could
share all your content not just on
social media but you know platforms like
slideshare now you can share it on all
social media platforms i'd highly
recommend it and again you can even
repurpose it as a blog post so if it's a
podcast then you know you can recite
that podcast in the form of a blog okay
so get some testimonials that support
some of your content again create a
podcast you can send out an email with a
survey or trying to solicit some
testimonials or if you post something on
facebook you know leverage the feedback
you get from facebook in the form of a
testimonial okay and then you want to
promote your blog post for maximum
success and a lot of that means seo so
make sure you do your due diligence and
get the right keywords in that blog post
okay so you can create personas for
different user audiences okay so
remember it's all about tone okay so if
you're going to create a blog post make
sure your tone is aligned with that
right audience whether that be young
middle aged or older are you choosing
the right type of content okay you'll
know based on the results okay you want
to add h1 and h2 tags on your web pages
why because when we're talking about
content we're talking about organizing
the content and h1 and h2s help you
organize the content appropriately
customize the metadata metadatas title
tag and meta tag descriptions and even
alt tags okay all of that is for search
so you want your content to show up in
search whether that's video infographic
or blog post all of it can be shown in
search results so make sure you write a
good title and make sure you write a
good meta description because that's
what people are going to see when they
search okay so you want to create a
detailed summary and title and again
that goes along with the title tag and
meta description and then you want to
make it easy for the audience to ask
questions and comment on your blog so
don't be afraid like i'm going to do
right now in this video is if i'm
missing anything from this checklist
feel free to comment hey i've written my
fair share content but i could be
talking to an audience that is just as
qualified as i am and they may have some
tips so feel free to comment underneath
this video now don't be afraid to ask
just like i just did people are always
willing to provide constructive feedback
so don't be afraid to ask for it and
make it easy so to me every blog post
needs to have some form of a comment box
because blog posts are out there to
solicit engagement now let's recap
everything we talked about because we've
certainly covered a lot and there's a
lot to cover when it comes to content
marketing so one know your audience
again you can lean on google analytics
you know demographic data whether it be
age or gender you could do the same with
facebook and twitter and linkedin you
know every platform has some data you
could take away create high quality
content when i mean high quality content
just brainstorm some topics has it
already been written to death about or
is this unique you know don't write
something your competitors are writing
okay don't copy what your competitors
have written organize your content
support it with good imagery all of
these are tips to creating high quality
content okay when you create that
content think about running to maybe
test you know run some variations
and switch out the image switch out the
call to action see what's going to get
people to react and engage with the
content conduct competitor analysis so
lean on the facebooks of the world to
see what your competitors are posting
see what's engaging for them okay you
can also lean on these seo platforms
like sem rush and moz all you gotta do
is plug in a domain and they're gonna
give you some information about where a
particular competitor ranks for keyword
or how many backlinks and what websites
are linking to them so all that's
available in these seo platforms okay so
you want to choose a suitable content
format we listed a few from ebooks to
case studies to podcasts to infographics
to blog posts to videos it's up to you
what you think is best for your audience
just keep in mind you need to be able to
measure it and so that's the important
thing if it doesn't work the first time
out then you might want to consider
changing out the content format choose a
content management system you know
plenty out there wordpress is a good one
if you're going to be a blogger okay
blogging allows you to
you know post optimize that blog post
you know you could have the ability to
share that blog post across social
platforms and you can also have that
blog post show up in search engine
results so you can't do any of that
without a good content management system
so you want to target your audience
using emails okay so email is a good way
to again further communicate with that
particular segmented audience and again
you could use it to send out promotional
emails to loyal followers or
you can use systematic emails to send an
email a thank you email somebody
purchases and then another follow-up
email and again you can repurpose some
of the content you've done in another
format in the form of an email so
you know if you created a video you know
put that video in the form of an email
and send it out to your audience to make
sure they're not missing out on that
video you just created so lots of ways
to use email take advantage of email
it's your ally here okay use native ads
okay don't be afraid to put that content
and pair it with some other content on
another website it's been proven people
are going to engage in an ad that they
see based on the content they're
currently reading because the ad if it's
native it's going to be similar in
nature to the content they're currently
engaged in and then measure your content
performance i can't say this enough make
sure you're leveraging google analytics
okay with google analytics or facebook
insights or twitter or linkedin or any
other platform you're running on they're
gonna have data on what you've posted so
take advantage of it
line your kpis so if it's an ebook or
case study don't measure just traffic
measure how many people are actually
downloading them okay if it's a video
you know how many people like the video
how many people are commenting how many
people are sharing the video how many
people subscribing to your playlist
based on that video content okay so
these are all things you can measure
okay so every platform from wordpress to
youtube to reddit has some form of
analytics associated with it today we're
going to talk about how to get traffic
to your website so thank you for joining
and let's get started so
let's imagine you're setting up your own
website okay you're clicking away you're
developing using some good tools you're
developing you're designing
you're doing some qa
you're testing you're sharing with
friends in an alpha version and then
finally
your website is all set up
congratulations well when you hit enter
and your website is finally published
what's going to happen well a few days
later you're checking your website and
you're looking at analytics and you
notice your traffic's very low okay well
you're scratching your head because
you've done all this work with your
website but you're not getting any
traffic so the reason is
you
spent all your time developing designing
the website to make it look good but you
didn't do anything
or any planning or any strategy around
bringing users to your website so the
two go hand in hand you just can't build
a website without
thinking about how to drive users to the
website and so before i tell you how to
bring traffic to your website let me
tell you why this is so important okay
why do we want to bring users to our
website i mean it has to be on equal
ground as web development and design is
somebody who goes to your site and then
does something when they get to your
site so you have users and when those
users get to your site they're
generating page views and traffic and
you want to turn that traffic into
engagement okay so each page's traffic
is configured independently of all their
pages so when you go when somebody goes
to your website they look at a page
that's a page view in certain pages on
your website you want to turn that page
view into a conversion okay whether that
be
you know looking at a video or
purchasing something so think of these
pages on your website as salespeople
they're trying to convert visitors who
come to your website but first we need
to get the visitors to your website so
when you get visitors to your website
again you can generate sales which means
revenue or
you can increase brand awareness or you
can earn revenue through sponsored posts
and advertisements so if you have for
example a lot of content on your website
you can turn that in to
revenue by hosting ads on your website
so when somebody clicks on that ad
you're gonna earn a percentage of that
click okay what that click is worth so
having a website means
a lot of good things for you but first
you got to get the traffic there and so
what we're going to do is we're going to
tell you how to drive traffic to your
website so there's lots of different
ways in which you can bring traffic to
your website well the first is paid
advertising so paying to advertise your
products services with ads is one of the
easiest ways to drive traffic to your
website so some of the options available
are
search ads social media ads or display
ads so search ads are ads that are
displayed in the search engine results
so when a user types in a keyword query
you want your ad to show up based on
that keyword query okay so an example is
digital marketing course somebody types
in digital marketing course and simply
learn is the first app that shows up how
do we know it's an ad because you can
see the word ad
next to the domain so when somebody
clicks on that link simply learn is
going to pay google so that's how search
advertising works okay the next is
social so social media marketing
involves increasing traffic or
engagement or brand awareness a lot of
different strategies but you're instead
of doing this on search you're doing it
on a social media platform okay so
for example
you can advertise on any particular
platform and the way you advertise could
be with an image it could be with a
video
so in this case you could see cobreo
is doing a sponsored ad here how to
succeed with google ads and then another
form of advertising is display so
display means creating ads that are
placed on specific websites so with
display
unlike search you have a choice in the
ad format with search you only have text
ads but with display you have text edge
image ads rich media ads video ads so
you have lots of different options in
which you can advertise on other
websites so the idea here is to get your
ad in front of the right audience when
they could see your display banner your
banner ad then it's going to be more
visual
more appealing generate some brand
interest and hopefully you can get
somebody to click on that ad and over to
your website so that's paid advertising
again through search through social
through display but you can also promote
your site on social media so once your
content has gone live you could take
advantage of different social media
platforms i mean it really depends on
what you're trying to promote because
what you're trying to promote needs to
align with the appropriate social media
platform so
facebook is best suited for industries
like food and beverages and news and
media and if you're selling a product so
you fall into one of those categories
and facebook could be the right platform
for you if you're involved in again
beauty or food and beverage or
e-commerce then you can also leverage
instagram which is part of facebook's
ecosystem so if you advertise on
facebook
you can also advertise on instagram and
or instagram so it doesn't have to be
and facebook and instagram it could be
facebook or instagram you also have
linkedin as a platform linkedin is great
for b2b so
if you're trying to promote industry
news or or tips and best practices or
job postings then linkedin is the place
for you it's a b2b platform it's great
for
targeting specific industries targeting
specific job levels or job descriptions
okay so linkedin is great if you're into
b2b focusing on the business side of it
so you also have youtube now youtube is
part of google's ecosystem youtube is a
video platform okay so it's great if
you're trying to promote gaming or
entertainment if you're a vlogger okay
so youtube's a great way to promote your
site uh by getting your product out
there in the form of a video and then
you have twitter twitter to me
encompasses a lot of different
industries beauty and fitness news and
media entertainment okay you have
limited number of characters but a lot
of people are active on twitter and it's
a great way to generate some awareness
and get some clicks over to your website
so these are just some of the most
popular social media platforms of course
there are plenty more out there the
third way in which you can drive traffic
to your site is guest
blogging so
most of you already know what blogging's
all about well if you're blogging for
your own site you can jump on somebody
else's site and blog on their behalf so
having the opportunity to guest post on
another website can be very helpful
because one that other blog could have
lots of traffic and have a a well-known
brand so if you're blogging on another
blog it's going to build your brand
awareness and potentially increase
traffic to your blog or website so it
exposes to you to targeted traffic so if
you're going to guest blog guest blog on
a site that's very relevant to your
business or industry that way you're
targeting the right audience okay you
can expand your personal network so
getting yourself out there getting your
brand out there in front of a different
audience and then obviously for serves
because it generates a backlink so serps
search engine ranking pages means that
hey if you want to rank organically
you're going to have to generate some
backlinks so guest blogging is a way to
generate some backlinks to your site and
an effect that's going to help you get
your pages ranked higher because google
is going to recognize the relationship
from one blog to your blog and build up
your relevancy so some other benefits
here to guest blogging is you can grow
your social media
following because you can then promote
that on social media that you're guest
blogging okay again you can improve your
online authority okay because when
you're guest blogging and you have
recognition on that guest blog if it's a
popular blog then it's not going to help
your domain and page authority for seo
and then the end result is going to
improve your backlink score so a lot of
benefits to guest blogging to me at the
end of the day it's just about reaching
out to your audience using another
platform to do that in the form of a
blog and the results of that is going to
mean more brand awareness for you and
turning that traffic from that other
blog into qualified leads so you can
also interview industry thought leaders
so that's another way an interesting way
to generate traffic to your site so
reaching out to
thought leaders for interviews okay
could generate some credibility for you
and the other person so it's reciprocal
so it means that you're active in the
industry that you're in and it allows
you to engage with other leaders in the
industry and the indirect net result of
that could be increased traffic because
if you do the interview and you record
it or if it's via video then you can
obviously post it on other platforms and
that could in turn drive traffic to your
website obviously just like guest
blogging it's going to increase your
reach so getting yourself out there if
nobody knows who your brand is and they
know who the thought leaders are and
they see you're interviewing the thought
leaders then that's going to put you in
front of these people and so it's going
to increase your reach another way to
drive traffic to your website is just to
make sure your website's responsive and
what do we mean by responsive well we
mean does it work on multiple devices
specifically mobile so depending on the
device your website hides shows shrinks
enlarges or moves content so that it
conforms to the browser that that
person's looking at on your web for your
website so if somebody's looking on
mobile at your website you want to make
sure that your website adjusts
accordingly so you want to be able to
you know test to make sure it's
responsive and so is content arranged
based on importance okay does it work
across different browsers on different
devices and do the images text and
everything else align just like it does
on desktop so there are plenty of tools
out there on the web all you need to do
is just do a search for you know check
my website for responsiveness you know
so you you can use plenty of tools to
check to see if your website is
responsive towards multiple devices why
is that important because if somebody
goes to your website via mobile and your
site doesn't align properly or the
contents all stretched out and somebody
has to maneuver their browser just to
see your website then chances are
they're not going to come back chances
are they're not going to convert okay so
you want to be able to revise your
device browser combinations you want to
make sure that everything works
accordingly you want to be able to test
those fonts make sure they look good and
then you also want to make sure that
people can navigate so if they're on
mobile are they going to navigate just
as easy as they can on desktop and if
you have any pop-ups you want to
probably make sure they're removed so
that way when somebody's looking at your
website they're not getting interfered
with on mobile and then of course you
want to make sure that these pages load
okay so they load just as quick on
desktop as they should on mobile and
vice versa so this should not take a
long time to load so moving on from
responsiveness a mobile to building a
brand community so brand community
refers to a group of people who identify
your brand and use your brand as a
platform to exchange ideas and
contribute content some advantages of
having a brand community are promoting
brand evangelism and loyalty it can be a
source of feedback loyalty and ideas so
build a community build a brand
community who you know identify with you
okay so continue to you know treat these
people as loyal customers okay maybe
give them a promotion uh to use
specifically just for them that they can
use on your website or talk directly to
them because you know that they're
followers they're repeat customers they
purchase for you multiple times so talk
to them differently as well you know who
these people are and that's what
building a brand is all about it's about
identifying your brand with other people
okay and identify people who identify
with your brand and messaging and
talking to them as if they're part of
your own community your own family so
you can use user generated content that
provides future marketing strategies so
the feedback you get from your own
community could be in turn used to
promote or used in future marketing
strategies i.e advertising i.e post on
social okay it can also provide pr
opportunities so it's a chance for you
to you know put out press releases based
on the community that you built so any
brand regardless of who it is should be
able to identify with their audience
their target audience and that target
audience eventually going to become part
of a community these are group of people
who identify with you what you're trying
to sell what your cause is what your
mission statement is what your services
they identify with you so leverage them
and reciprocate identify them talk to
them separately
give them the
what they deserve the respect and
loyalty that they deserve as well
because they're communicating and
they're following you as a brand so the
next thing you could do to drive traffic
is be active in the comments section so
engage in relevant and thought-provoking
conversations on other blogs and sites
it doesn't necessarily have to be
another blog per se could be other sites
like reddit or quora or media sites that
have a lot of content that are broken
out by industry that allow you to engage
in conversation allow you to either
upvote or share or respond okay so be
active because when you're active people
are going to see that hey
you're a leader in the industry you know
what you're talking about you have some
some brand equity you have some thought
and some knowledge on the specific topic
and subject so it just puts you in a
better light when you can respond and be
active on these different platforms okay
let's turn our attention to
search engine optimization also known as
seo or organic search so in order to
drive traffic to your site you're going
to have to implement an seo strategy why
do you want to implement an seo strategy
because it can help you improve your
overall search ability and visibility on
search engines and obviously that comes
with advantages one of those advantages
is obviously more traffic to the site
search is still king in terms of volumes
of people using search on a daily basis
so you have a great opportunity to be
found it also builds trust and
credibility because still a majority of
the people who do a search click on an
organic search listing and so if you're
found organically
and you're ranked number one then
chances are somebody's going to click on
your listing and it provides increased
engagement and traffic
and so what that means is more traffic
more engagement an engagement is
something you define it could be again a
download of a document or the clicking
on the play button of a video or or
submitting a form or signing up for a
newsletter or calling these are all
forms of engagement so
the amount of traffic you drive from
organic search to your website is only
going to improve engagement okay so you
can also provide an improved user
experience and what do we mean by that
well if you're getting lots of traffic
from organic search you have a really
good opportunity to do a b testing and
when you do a b testing you can improve
user experience meaning you're showing
one variation against the other from
people coming from organic search and so
this is helpful
and that you know if you're running an a
b test the variation has a chance to
improve or outperform the original and
if it outperforms the original you're
improving user experience and then it
helps target quality traffic so seo to
me or all search is the only medium in
which you're meeting somebody halfway
you're you're addressing what they're
looking for so somebody's looking for a
pair of red women's nike shoes
the 2019 model and you have that
particular product to offer well you
have a chance of showing up via organic
search somebody types in new women's red
nike shoes size whatever at the year
2019 model then of course they're going
to probably likely click on your listing
because you have what they're looking
for and and that goes with any keyword
any industry any business any segment
any type of
product you're selling so
again you have a chance to really be
visible for what people are looking for
and so that's the beauty of search
engine optimization you have a really
good opportunity here to meet people
halfway to drive quality traffic to get
them to enjoy a good user experience all
the while generating engagement and
along with seo we want to be able to
build backlinks so
seo is a two pronged approach meaning
you have two strategies in one on page
and off page and so
off page involves backlinking so
backlinks are just links that direct
users from
other websites to your own website so
with that inherently it's going to drive
traffic qualified traffic to your
website because if somebody's on a
relevant website that's linking to yours
and they click on that link and go to
your website it's likely going to be
qualified meaning they're going to be
relevant and so
back linking because it's an off page
strategy why is it an off-page seo
strategy because if google crawls that
other site that has a link to you
then that's going to give you credit
because google say hey this site's
getting some links from some relevant
sites we must think they're relevant and
therefore
we're going to trust the site so
by google
trusting your site it's going to improve
your organic ranking and with the
organic rankings being improved meaning
it's going to mean faster indexing so
what does that mean so you want to be
indexed by the search engines and so the
quicker google can find your pages even
if it's on somebody else's site then
that means they're going to follow that
link go to that page on your site and
take that page back to their servers to
be indexed okay so the quicker you can
get indexed the quicker you get found
and then it helps with referral traffic
so
again we noticed that our efforts are on
seo organic search but if you're getting
traffic from another website hey that
still counts that's referral traffic
okay so that's a side advantage to
having backlinks is good traffic from
other sites okay so those those are
inherently the some of the reasons to do
backlinking okay never hurts i mean
there's brand awareness reasons to being
on other sites as well there's industry
leadership meaning if you you post
content on reddit okay you're coming
across as an industry leader but yet
generating a backlink which helps with
seo and referral traffic so there's a
lot of benefits to building backlinks
and the opposite of backlinks are
internal links so
you want to do internal linking and that
just means connecting one page on your
site to another and why is that
beneficial because it can help direct
visitors to other pages they wouldn't
normally otherwise find via your
navigation so if you're active on a blog
don't be afraid to include multiple
internal links you want to move people
through your site you want the flow of
traffic to go from one page to another
to another and so when you do internal
linking just like with backlinks it's
going to improve the indexing of your
website google is going to follow those
links and index those pages and google
does give credits from an seo
perspective from an internal linking
perspective so if one page is linked to
another and that page has really good
relevance in the eyes of google then the
other page is probably going to benefit
from that the other reason you want to
do internal linking again you want to
move people from your one page of your
site to the other and when you do that
it's going to reduce bounce rates so
bounce rate is simply the rate at which
people land on a page and then leave so
if i have 100 people land on my homepage
and only one person went to another page
and the other 99 left the site then
that's a 99 bounce rate so by putting
internal links in place you're helping
people move from one page to the other
and thus
reducing the bounce rate and that's what
you want you want to keep people on your
site you want to be greedy it also
drives traffic to older posts so again
when we say older posts we're really
referring to blog posts so if you have a
relevant blog post and you're writing a
new blog post then link the two together
if it's relevant link it i don't you
know regardless of how old it is you
know you want to show google that these
older blog posts just because they were
written a year ago doesn't mean they're
outdated and old-fashioned okay or
useless you want to keep them alive by
linking to them so to me that's a good
strategy for internal linking link to
older blog posts you know show people
you're an industry expert you've been
doing this for a while and then you have
lots of content to share okay so the
longer you can keep somebody on your
website the more likely it is they're
going to engage and convert and some
other inherent benefits improves
pagerank so what we mean by pagerank is
simply just a rank that google gives
pages so the more internal linking you
have the better off you are and then it
helps spread link juice across websites
and we'll meet me by link juice again
just like backlinking it builds
relevancy so just keep all these
inherent benefits in mind to internal
linking the end result is keeping the
flow of traffic on your site and all
these other benefits will fall into
place okay so another way in which you
can really hone in on traffic to your
website is long tail keywords and long
term keywords to me are more than just
one or two keyword phrases okay so
they're usually three or longer keywords
in a phrase okay so long tail keywords
really nowadays account for most web
searches people
really take the time to even post
questions as a search query say likely
somebody it's unlikely somebody's going
to go into search and just type in the
word shoes they might type in red shoes
but that's unlikely what they're
probably going to type in is you know
red
nike running shoes 2019
or some variation of that okay that's a
long tail keyword and some of the
advantages of using long tail keywords
to be found for are less competition so
if you're using broad keywords like red
shoes then who doesn't want to be found
for red shoes well you don't necessarily
you don't want to be found for red shoes
because it's too broad you don't know
what type of shoes somebody's looking
for you just know they're looking for
red shoes it could be running shoes it
could be work shoes it could be you know
boots it could be
slippers okay it's too bright so long
tail keywords help narrow it in and the
more narrow and focused the keyword is
the less competition it's going to have
and when something's not competitive in
the form of a keyword then that means
your chances of ranking for that keyword
are going to be greater and the chance
of you ranking faster are going to be
greater and then of course if somebody's
looking for exactly what you have to
offer then you have a higher chance to
convert that person so if you have
exactly those 2019
red nike women's running shoes and
somebody does a search for that and
that's a long tail keyword and they
click on your organic listing if you
have the right price then they're
probably going to convert so you have a
really good chance of converting
somebody using long tail keywords so my
point here is if you're looking for
keywords to use focus on longer tail
don't focus on one or two keyword
phrases what it also does is it brings
targeted traffic so even if somebody
doesn't convert hey they could be back
because it's exactly what they're
looking for and if you're focusing on
longer tail keywords like i just
mentioned stay away from the shorter
ones it's just easier to optimize your
page for seo so remember seo is a two
pronged approach on page and off page we
talked about off page with internal
linking and backlinks on page is all
about making sure those keywords you
choose are integrated in with the page
you want to be found for and so if
you're using a long tail keyword it's
just easy to work that keyword in so it
enables easier on-page optimization okay
let's switch away from seo to email
marketing so let's focus on email
marketing as a form or method of driving
traffic to your website so email
marketing has been around a long time in
terms of digital marketing why because
it provides an effective way to convert
leads into sales why because you can
send personalized emails to a target
audience so when you send an email to
somebody on a regular basis
you know who that person is so what are
you doing in the email you're writing a
specific message to that person well
email marketing is the same thing except
you're just sending an email to a larger
group of people and when you send an
email to a larger group of people you're
still going to personalize the message
right you're not going to send a generic
email to 1 000 people okay nobody's
going to do that so make sure your email
is targeted if it's targeted it can be
cost effective why because sending large
amounts of emails or let's just say an
email to a large amount of people or a
large group of people is going to be
cost effective it's not cost per click
you know it's not cost per open
okay so email usually depending on the
the email provider you're using really
is a flat fee so it just really depends
on how many emails you're sending or how
how many people you're sending the email
to as well so but email generally tends
to be more cost effective than other
forms of marketing so look at the email
content provider you're using and just
get a sense of what they charge but if
you look at it and do a comparison email
generally is cheaper than say doing
pay-per-click because with pay-per-click
you're paying for each click okay so
that could be expensive depending on the
keywords so email marketing is also time
saving okay meaning it's a one-time
thing and done so once you send the
email it's just a matter of you know
watching and looking at the metrics and
learning what's going on so you don't
make the same mistakes again but it is
time conducive meaning you send out one
email and that's it with pay-per-click
you're constantly measuring and managing
the campaigns and it provides real-time
marketing so when you do send the email
more than likely a majority of the
people
on day one or the day you send the email
are gonna be able to view it open it
click on some of the links and convert
so
that's normally what happens an email
majority of the people open it on day
one and it kind of tails off from there
so think about it as real time so when
you send that email and if you have a
thousand people on your email recipient
list break it up send the first 500
first with a different subject line and
then you can see the data come in and if
you don't see the good results from the
subject line or the body of the email or
you know the page you're going to then
make adjustments before you send the
other email to the next 500. so that's a
great thing about emails you can break
up the email into two groups the first
group and then the second group with
different subject lines and you can
probably send them a little bit of time
apart that way you can learn from the
first email because with email
you are generally going to get results
right away okay within the first 24
hours so that's a great thing about
email okay so the other thing about
email it's less intrusive so normally
people who are going to get the email
are the ones who sign up for the email
so they're almost expecting your email
so when they get your email again as
long as you're not sending an email on a
daily basis normally most companies send
it monthly or bi-weekly it's not going
to be as intrusive okay and then it also
helps build credibility increased
visibility and brand awareness meaning
you're going to build your brand in that
email you're going to put content in
that email that's going to show off your
credibility meaning you could put some
testimonials in the email you could put
some good affiliations you can put a
good article to an industry article you
just wrote so email is going to
inherently continue to build brand
awareness for you okay and it's an easy
way to track roi so if your e-commerce
it's pretty clear you send the email
somebody opens it clicks on it checks
out and purchases something it's easily
trackable because you could track it
right from that email so one thing i
want to say there is just if you do send
an email make sure you're tracking that
campaign and you want to be able to use
an analytics program like google
analytics if you use google analytics
you're going to be able to track when
you send the email who clicks on it and
who converts so you want to be able to
measure an roi for these emails and you
can and that's the beauty of email
marketing okay let's move away from
email marketing to webinars so webinars
great method for effective social media
promotion it's a great way to bring
traffic to your website so why do we
recommend webinars well because it
provides direct content contact within
your target group what do we mean by
contact with your target group well
you're going to host a webinar and
you're going to invite this targeted
group of people who are interested in
your product or service so if you have a
facebook community you could do a
facebook live event or you could do a
youtube or
you know you can even set up a webinar
on another platform but promote it on
social media and if you're pronouncing
something on social media you're
probably promoting it to people who are
already following you or like you and so
that's what we mean by direct contact
with your target group so you're going
to be able to create a webinar and talk
directly to that group and that's going
to help build brand awareness and
credibility and the great thing about
webinars is you don't need some fancy
software i mean i'm talking to you on a
webinar right now and so webinars are
free all you need is a video camera and
a recorder that's all and that's all
built in with software so there's plenty
of software out there that allows you
just to do a webinar really quick and
easy there's lots of opportunities in
software so and a lot of them are very
cost effective so if you want to build
uh create a webinar you can do that by
spending very little money in webinars
again allow you to talk to your targeted
group your community maybe prospective
clients it helps build credibility and
in effect drive traffic to your website
and when somebody does attend a webinar
they're likely going to be highly
engaged because you're inviting them
they're going to opt into the webinar
and the great thing about webinars is
even if they don't attend the webinar
the day you have it it's going to be
recorded so they can always go back and
watch it so whoever watches the webinar
is going to be engaged because it's
going to be a topic they're interested
in and then users are likely to become
prospective customers so having a
webinar talking about something
inherently interesting to maybe a larger
group of people you can promote that on
social media and potentially get
prospective customers to
sign up and watch the webinar and if you
do they're going to be engaged and then
take the next step oh i like what this
guy this person has to say they seem to
be credible i like their personality i
like their brand i like their product
i'm gonna go check their web out their
website okay so webinars allow you to
kind of pull in more people as well as
just your community because you can
promote the webinar and you can promote
it in advance and you can leverage
social media for that okay so something
related to webinars incorporating video
content so videos have been proven to be
a really good way to attract new
visitors and it just it makes your
website very engaging when you have
videos on your website as well so if you
create video you have an opportunity to
post it on various video platforms like
youtube or vimeo okay there's plenty of
video platforms out there or just
embedded in a blog post or embedded in a
facebook post or a tweet okay so you can
do a lot with video and having video on
your site is going to increase
engagement okay when you increase
engagement good things happen that's
going to lead to increased conversions
in sales or
roi or just like we mentioned the
webinar can help build trust with your
audience even that webinar you could
post on your website so you want people
to engage by watching this video they
watch the video they're going to gain
trust in you because you're talking
directly to that person that user that
audience that visitor to your website
and when you get built trust it's going
to increase engagement and that's the
beauty of video unlike text or imagery
videos really do engage with the
audience and so the more video you could
do the better off you are because again
you can leverage social to draw
attention to your brand and product and
service and then you can have that video
on your website to increase engagement
which in turn increases conversions and
sales and improves roi so always think
video there's plenty of video software
out there that you can leverage and the
great thing about video 2 is hey most
people are using mobile phones these
days smart smartphones and so video
works just as well on mobile as it does
on desktop so keep that in mind you know
video is going to be engaging regardless
of what device somebody uses and then of
course if they're watching the video on
facebook or youtube then chances are
they're going to
share
that particular video which is going to
bode well for your brand and traffic
okay so video if somebody likes a video
it's very easy to share video especially
from a mobile phone so youtube just
makes it so easy to share or like or
subscribe to a channel it just it
becomes that much easier things can go
viral and chances of them going viral
video are going to be greater okay so
other ways to drive traffic to your
website is submit your content to
content aggregators so what's a content
aggregator well a content aggregator is
like reddit that provides a great
platform for you to post your content so
that's what a content aggregator is
really a site like reddit or medium or
quora where you could post content to a
large number of people okay so with
reddit people are either going to upvote
it or downvote it so the more upvotes
you get or thumbs up or likes or people
who encourage that content the more of a
chance it has to be found and so first
thing out of the gate if you do provide
content to a content aggregator like
reddit make sure it's good quality
content that's interesting and that
should be a case the case around across
the board whether it's a social post or
blog post make sure the content's unique
professional and interesting and then if
you do say put something on medium or
you do put something on cora and it is
professional and interesting and
thought-provoking then people are going
to react to it and then that again could
lead to traffic but even if it doesn't
lead to traffic it helps build brand
awareness so if you have content just
like videos leverage it put the content
out there and when you put content out
there it's only gonna especially if it's
good content but it's gonna put you in a
good light so don't be afraid to share
your content on the likes of reddit or
medium or core or some of these other
content aggregator websites because good
things are only going to happen and
again referral traffic seo brand
awareness conversions so all these are
inherent benefits of just sharing your
content okay and then finally we want to
learn from analytics okay so what do we
mean learning from analytics so there
are plenty of analytics platforms out
there one of the most popular is google
analytics so you want to make sure
you're tracking traffic on your site
with google analytics so i have to do is
just go to google analytics via search
sign up add the analytics code to your
website and voila they're doing all the
heavy lifting they're going to track
traffic coming your website and not only
they're going to track traffic but
they're going to tell you how that
traffic engaged and so the benefits of
it google analytics is hey you could
figure out where users are coming from
are they coming from that email campaign
that i sent out to a thousand people are
they coming from youtube based on that
video i posted or they coming from
reddit based on the content i just
posted there or are they coming from
organic search it is so google analytics
can help us understand how much traffic
we're getting from organic search so to
help us measure our seo efforts and then
with google analytics you could segment
so we could segment by mobile we can
segment by desktop returning user new
user by campaign by page by language by
city by region i mean there's so many
ways in which to segment your audience
and segmenting simply is breaking up the
entire group of people who come to your
website into different segments based on
what you want to see so
if you want to look at you know females
between the ages of 18 to 24 who come
from mobile via organic search that's a
segment and you can look at that
information and analytics if that's your
target audience then you could see how
they're performing okay so anna there
are a lot of benefits to google
analytics definitely want to take
advantage of
segmenting in google analytics you could
look at your competition so there's a
benchmarking report the great thing
about google analytics you can also look
at content and how your content is
performing when somebody lands on your
website are they what page are they
spending time on what page are they
engaging on the most okay what pages
have the highest bounce rate or the
lowest time on page so you can really
determine what pages work best and then
of course the end result in analyzing
all this data
is you want to be able to fine-tune your
website so take advantage of the data
that google analytics or any other
analytics platform is giving you
by learning once you learn what's going
on with your website you can make
adjustments to your website to improve
user experience okay so we went over a
lot of different ways to drive traffic
okay you can incorporate all this to
your website immediately welcome today
we're going to talk about email
marketing tutorial so buckle up and
let's get started with email marketing
tutorial and so let's start out asking
the question why email marketing so
linda is the owner of an e-commerce
company and basically she isn't able to
take her leads leads she's collecting
per day per month and convert them into
customers okay so customers sign up but
they don't buy her product so she's left
scratching her head wondering what to do
so how she gonna solve the problem of
converting the lead she gets into
paying customers well look no further
than email market so you can boost your
sales funnel with the help of email
marketing so email marketing leads to
email campaigns that lead to website
visits that can lead to product
purchasing email markings also and a
it's a very good way to generate a high
return on investment so
linda thinks this is too good to be true
your tail i made is a very efficient way
to generate a return on my investment
how expensive is email marketing well
email marketing is neither expensive or
time consuming that's the beauty of
email marketing and so linda is now
very interested we've piqued her
interest she wants
us to explain
email marketing to her in detail and
that's exactly what we're going to do
we're going to talk about email
marketing in detail so for everyone out
there listening
what's in it for you
why are you going to invest your time
and listening to
simply learn and me talk about email
marketing because we're going to talk
about everything there is about email
marketing in today's webinar so what is
it for those that aren't really familiar
with the intricacies of email marketing
we're gonna talk about how to set up
email marketing we're gonna discuss all
the benefits of email marketing we're
gonna get into a b testing we're gonna
get into the automation of emails the
types of emails how to engage new users
and we're going to give you a demo so
there's a lot going on in this webinar
like i said buckle up and let's get
started and talk about
what is email marketing so as i
mentioned to linda it's an efficient way
to convert leads into sales why because
we can send personalized emails to a
specific audience a targeted audience if
somebody's interested in our product we
can reach out to them via email it can
also be used to remarket pre-qualified
leads so anybody who's pre-qualified we
can go ahead and communicate with them
as well so email marketing is very
effective at different stages in the
funnel okay so when i say funnel
customer life cycle so we have awareness
consideration purchase retention and
advocacy okay so let's talk about each
one of these parts of the funnel or
customer life cycle if you will so let's
start with awareness at the very top so
email marketing allows customers to
recognize their problems after which you
can educate them on how your brand can
solve them okay just like any other
marketing channel somebody's looking for
something in need of something and we
can come to the rescue in this case
we're going to come to the rescue with
email and we can go ahead and educate
them on what their need is and how we
can collaborate with them help them
educate them solve their problems with
our product okay so that's what email's
going to do we're going to communicate
with them via email and we're going to
bring awareness to the problem by
solving the problem that's what email is
good for okay good for generating
awareness for our brand for example we
can share a newsletter with our
customers so we're running a cosmetics
company we can basically educate them on
the five important skin care products
that everyone should have okay so we can
get them to click on the call to action
to learn more so if somebody's having
some skin care issues or not sure what
products to buy you know an email can
cover that okay the next step in the
customer life cycle is consideration so
customers focused on searching for
relevant products and compares the
products with similar ones okay so
they're definitely looking they're a
little further in the process they're
educated they know what they're looking
for so we can really hit them with the
right email we can send a relevant email
to promote our product okay discover
that perfect moisturizer for your skin
that perfect skin moisturizer smooths
hydrates and contains spf 20. so we got
the perfect product for that person
who's further along the funnel and
really is ready to purchase that product
so we can hit that person up with the
perfect messaging talk about purchase
the next step in the life cycle well
purchase well with purchase we can send
an email that encourages that customer
purchase our product by offering them
something okay by giving an offer for
example we can give a discount discounts
always tend to work so that moisturizer
that that particular customer was
considering buying well they can move
from consideration to purchasing because
we're going to offer them a discount
they can't refuse okay so you know it
could beat for a specific date okay it
could be you know something that's going
to get them excited to buy the product
20 off of moisturizers pretty good deal
and especially if that percentage off is
better than the other products that
we're considering buying so getting
somebody that extra incentive to
purchase the product goes a long way via
email okay we want to take that next
step in the life cycle and nurture our
relationship with customers to ensure
they're loyal okay they've already
purchased how do we get them purchased
again that's retention we want to retain
our customers we want to get them back
to buy the same product or similar
products or completely different
products in our inventory so what do we
do we're going to send an email we're
going to send an email to active
customers okay we're going to give them
an offer just for them exclusively just
for them in this example we're gonna
give them a combo pack a facial kit at
just 39 and get a sunscreen worth 10
dollars for free so you can come up with
all sorts of different combinations on
offers key is the offer is exclusively
just for those who you want to target
and retain as customers because if you
just get somebody to purchase once it's
not going to work those people have
already taken the that step in the
relationship where they trust your
product they purchase your product now
you want to go ahead and treat that
customer special by giving them an
exclusive offer and then what we want to
do is advocacy last step in that
customer lifestyle we want to convert
that active customer into brand
advocates okay we want that customer to
talk about our brand for us we want them
to promote it and talk about it with
your friends so for example we want to
send an email to those customers to
promote our products okay so for example
we could say hey the sales of our
products for this particular day or for
this month is going to go to our
favorite non-profit could be educating
poor children or cleaning up plastic in
the ocean or saving animals we want to
be able to get them to speak on our
behalf and say look guys this is a
really good company you know they're
offering me products exclusively they've
offered me discounts in the past they
have good products they have a lot of
different products and on top of all
that they help they help the environment
they help the needy okay they care and
so we can go ahead and provide a call to
action for these customers that are
loyal to our brand and have them share
the email with their friends to spread
the word on you know what we're trying
to accomplish for our nonprofit or if
anything just get them to promote it
maybe give them a discount for every
friend that they get to buy a product
okay it doesn't have to necessarily be
you know just sharing with friends it
can be that extra incentive of giving
them a discount if they do share with
friends and their friends buy okay so
this is the customer life cycle and
examples of different emails that you
can use at every step along the way in
the life cycle so let's talk about the
benefits of email marketing so what are
some of the benefits well we've already
mentioned to linda that it's cost
effective it's time saving real time
marketing less intrusive builds
credibility increases visibility and
brand awareness and it's an easy way to
track roi these are all the benefits for
email marketing we're gonna go talk
about some of these now so basically
when we talk about cost effective you
know some email marketing platforms
charge based on the number of users who
you send the email to time saving well
you saw how quick it took me to set up
that email campaign the key is figuring
out who you want to send it to when we
talk about real-time marketing you know
we're sending this email out basically
in real time trying to meet our
customers needs at the right time it's
less intrusive because we can customize
the emails okay we can as you saw i can
put first name in there to make it more
personal so when something's more
personal it's less intrusive especially
if it's a segment that already knows
your brand okay builds credibility hey
we gain credibility when we offer
exclusive offers to repeat customers or
you know try and build advocacy by
working with non-profits okay it
increases visibility and brand awareness
why because you know we could send our
email out to a large group of people and
that's a good way to generate brand
awareness and as you saw we can easily
measure you know not only open rates
click rates but roi so how many people
from that email went on and purchased so
we can measure that it's very easy to
measure email today we're going to talk
about affiliate marketing
so
let's jump right into it and take a look
inside an office environment right now
we have chuck here chuck's doing a
little bit of pacing john walks in the
office hey man what's with all the
pacing everything all right chuck
responded hey i'm just worried that i
might have exhausted every way we can
advertise our product i mean i've done
seo i've done paid search i've done
email i've done social man nothing's
working i gotta come up with something
new asap well john responds hey don't
worry i think i've got your solution for
you man hang tight relax take a load off
here's my solution affiliate marketing
first off before you ask the question
what's affiliate marketing let's talk
about why we need affiliate marketing so
let's dig into affiliate marketing so
john's just taking over now and he's
gonna let chuck know everything there is
to know about affiliate marketing so the
first question john answers for chuck
what is affiliate marketing so affiliate
marketing is a form of digital marketing
that involves a merchant it involves a
merchant paying commissions to a website
or other entities so if i'm selling a
product basically somebody else sells
that product for me i'm gonna pay that
person a commission for selling my
product it's that simple that's what
affiliate marketing is okay so basically
what these merchants are doing or other
entities they're advertising your
product so they're advertising your
product with a referral so they're
passing on their own customers to you so
that they can buy your product and again
the exchange is you give that website or
other entity a commission that's more or
less what affiliate marketing is so
john's gonna have us take a look at each
of these components of affiliate
marketing in detail take it away john so
john
says first we have the merchant aka the
brand the seller the creator the founder
the owner the inspiration the innovator
hey this is the person who came up with
this brilliant idea this brilliant idea
has to get out there we're the merchant
we're trying to get this brilliant idea
out to the masses so this is the
component of affiliate marketing that
creates the product the merchant could
be anyone okay so it could be startups
to large multinational companies
international companies nonprofits
for-profits individuals independent
contractors freelancers a group of
people who have a passion for something
okay it could be anybody there's no
limit the affiliate aka the publisher so
the affiliate is basically that
third-party website or entity which
promotes the merchant's products and
tries to convince potential customers of
the merchant's products value so this
affiliate is going to represent the
merchant on their behalf and try and get
their clients to basically purchase that
particular merchant's product so the
affiliate could be incentivized based on
you know registrations email sign up
sales and subscriptions so it doesn't
always come down to you know sales you
know if i'm just trying to get you know
build my email list then hey i can
incentivize that affiliate to push email
signups if i'm got this big you know
offline you know promotion that i'm
doing at this particular mall and i want
to get people there well i can get an
affiliate and incentivize that affiliate
to drive and help me drive registrations
for this event so it doesn't always have
to be sales per se so in effect you the
merchant and the affiliate work out some
type of commission deal based on what
you're incentivizing so the relationship
between the affiliate and the merchant
is made possible with the help of an
affiliate network so that's the third
component here we need somebody to bring
the two together that merchant who has
this brilliant idea and the affiliate
who has potential customers that could
potentially drive registrations sales
signups etc to the merchant so the
affiliate network is the one who brings
the two together so the affiliate
network in effect acts as the middleman
the person in between the merchants and
affiliates it allows merchants to find
and collaborate with not just any
affiliate but the affiliate best suited
for their particular brand and product
because you want to find somebody who is
going to be passionate who's relevant
who has your prospective customers in
mind because they're the ones that are
going to help those protective customers
purchase your product so that's what the
affiliate network does it helps bring
the merchants and affiliates together so
that the affiliate can help advertise
and sell on behalf of the merchant so
with the affiliate network merchants can
use tools for tracking and reporting and
processing payments for affiliates so
really that affiliate network is the
glue that holds it all together they're
not just one to introduce a merchant an
affiliate they offer it all so as a
merchant you want to be able to manage
your affiliates so you're not gonna have
one affiliate you're gonna have multiple
affiliates so you wanna be able to use
the appropriate tools available to you
in the affiliate network to see and
track how sales are going and when sales
happen okay or commissions happen you
want to be able to use that affiliate
network to compensate that affiliate
appropriately and then finally the
customer customer aka the consumer is
the most important component of all of
this take it away john so the consumer
is the final and most important
component without customers to buy
products the merchant would not have any
revenue and the affiliate would not get
any commission so we need customers so
john what is the process of affiliate
marketing well john says let's have a
look at the process so it's affiliate
marketing time so we're going to use a
tool or platform like commission
junction commission junction is a
popular
you know platform that
affiliate network platform that brings
merchants and affiliates together so the
merchants can use those affiliates to
advertise their product so let's take a
look at
commission junction as a good digital
marketing tool for affiliate marketing
so we're going to use commission
junction as an example here remember at
affiliate marketing it's an ecosystem
between publishers
and merchants so remember merchants are
selling products publishers are selling
those merchant products on their site
and so commission junction
is the middleman so to speak okay so
commission junction just known as cj now
is the middle person they're introducing
the publisher and the merchant and so
let's go ahead and log in here so when
you log in like any other digital
marketing tool any other platform you're
gonna have your own settings and whatnot
so really the whole idea behind any
affiliate marketing tool is really
there to manage your publishers who do
you want as a publisher who do you want
selling your product you obviously want
somebody who's relevant somebody who's
going to be able to sell a product
somebody who has a targeted audience
that's similar to yours okay so we go
into cj.com we're going to log in and
here you can see a publisher's link so
we're going to click on the publishers
link and remember when you sign up
publishers you have to have program
terms and so if we click on publishers
program terms we're going to be able to
see
all the different program terms
available so here we could see
the different program turns we have set
up for certain publishers so we just
click on that we'll be able to see
that's the default program term so
remember you could set up your own
program term for any publisher so as a
best practice if you have publishers who
are actually performing well who are
selling your products maybe you want to
offer them a little bit more on the
commission side maybe you want to
sweeten the deal maybe
you know these guys these publishers get
better program terms versus say other
publishers who don't and so here we can
see the program terms basically you
could see what the terms are the action
and the different policies here so
everything you need to do to manage that
publisher in terms of payment is done
under the program terms now if the
program terms are met the publisher
actually sells your products cj
is the broker they're the ones who are
going to initiate the payment based on
the program terms so be careful on the
program terms you want to be able to set
them appropriately cj has templates cj
has some default program terms that you
can use and offer up to different
publishers so based on the program terms
that's how your publishers are going to
get paid and so here you can have as
many different program charms as you
want there's no limit here you want to
be able to align and reward program
terms again based on performance and so
here we can see what publishers are
under what program terms so again if
your publisher is performing well
sweeten the deal offer them a better
program terms and so you can align
publishers with different program terms
and so that's the whole the idea behind
program terms is you want to be able to
align publishers with that so when you
sign up a publisher they're going to get
a line with a program term meaning what
are they going to get paid for selling
your product now if we want to manage by
status instead of by program terms we
could see all the different
organizations we have in our network
these are our publishers we're the
affiliate we're the ones selling the
product we want to know
who's selling who's not selling and so
we can look at all our publishers by
program terms or by status okay so
basically you can see here the term
status whether it's active or not
earnings basically what they've sold
over the last basically seven days or
three months so you could look at
basically how your publishers are
performing just by clicking on manage by
status here in cg.com so when you're
looking at reports in
cj.com or really any other affiliate
program you might see the acronym epc
this stands for earnings per click
actually it's a little misleading it's
actually earnings per 100 clicks so
basically cj calculates you know how
much your publisher is actually making
per click you know just like paid search
we're paying google x amount per click
it's the same thing here we can't or
these publishers can't make any money if
they don't generate clicks so that's why
you have an epc model or metric so to
speak so you can measure earnings per
click cj does it over seven day period
and over a three month period so you
could sort
based on seven day or three months to
see
who's earning the most per click in
terms of publishers now you can select
under publishers groups now you can
group your publishers okay so if you
have say a group of publishers in a
specific region like the united states
or india or if you're just focused on
the united states and say you have
publishers in different states like
texas california missouri arkansas well
you can group those publishers into
different groups and you can look at
your different group names here so here
we could see canada and so we have our
publishers grouped into
a group called canada why because
they're based in canada makes sense so
you want to be able to organize your
publishers because the whole idea behind
affiliate marketing cj is you want to be
able to get the best publishers
available for your network and so as you
get more publishers for your network
you'll be able to
basically start grouping them where it
makes sense now the example i gave you
is by geography you could do by
geography or
you could do by publisher status meaning
my best performing publishers go into a
group if they're in a group then they
get aligned with a certain program term
so you could group your publishers any
way you want by status meaning they're
selling more these are our best
performing publishers or by region or
you know by promotion i mean how you
group your publishers is totally up to
you however take advantage of the option
to create publisher groups because the
whole idea again i'm going to repeat it
is you want to get
publishers you want to start building
your base of publishers because the more
publishers you have the more chance you
are to sell your product remember if
nobody clicks on your product then
nobody's going to buy your product so if
you have publishers who are promoting
your product for you
then you have a good opportunity to sell
it so the more publishers you have on
board the better the opportunity so now
once you have publishers you can start
grouping these publishers accordingly to
whatever makes sense it's a business
decision just know the options available
in cj to group publishers now when
you're in cj and you're starting out
okay you want to start recruiting your
publishers so you click on recruit and
based on your settings based on what
you're selling cj's going to try and put
you in front of
some good publishers and so here we
could see if we click on recruit we're
going to get a list of publishers and
this search results list of publishers
that we can recruit into our network are
all listed here and you could actually
see what's interesting you can see the
name of the publisher and you can see
the url
and then you can actually see
if they're a good performer or not so
you could actually see
their history as a publisher just by
looking at their network earnings and
then also looking at their seven day
earnings per click or three month
earnings per click and so if a publisher
has a very high earnings per click epc
then they're probably a good publisher
somebody you're probably going to be
interested in so if i see a publisher
with you know three month earnings per
click of 105
then that means hey if that's my
publisher i'm paying 105 or 106 over
seven days you know they're generating
some clicks for me and they're
generating sales you can't deliver
commission if they don't sell and so to
me i want to be able to look at the
seven three month earnings per click for
these publishers and so i can just click
on any one of these publishers here and
get some more insight about that
publisher right here in cj so
here i can see the particular url the
company some other urls that they have
associated with them in cj i can see the
category that they're in again i can see
the seven three month epc here you can
see description okay you can see some
other promotional methods that they'd
use when promoting products and you get
some program performance from this
particular publisher just by pulling
down the pull down menu here i'm going
to look at this year and see what the
performance is and why i'm waiting for
that to load i could see hey they're
also in other countries as well so i can
get a good snapshot of a particular
publisher by recruiting publishers
seeing what their performance is over a
period of time and potentially you know
recruiting that publisher would be part
of my network because if they're part of
my network then hey if they're selling
products if i'm selling products and i
want my product on their site and
they're doing a good job of selling
other products then i want them to be
you know part of my ecosystem part of my
network now remember
cj's doing the introducing here they are
introducing you to recruits so
you want to be able to again take a look
at the site does do any of the sites
that a particular publisher has interest
you you know again we could just click
on it go to the specific site
take a good look hey virgin atlantic
okay do we want them selling our product
maybe maybe not um so you want to take a
look at the website make sure it's not
spammy make sure it aligns with your
business goals it makes your aligns with
your product your target audience
remember a lot of things you want to
make sure
the website aligns with because they're
representing your brand okay very
important here very important and so
that's what you want to be able to do
and you could do all that just by
looking at the publisher detail in cg
and then again take a look at earnings
per click if they're selling products
for other merchants and they're doing a
good job maybe you want them selling
your product as well okay so you can
also you know sort by country
you can also do network earnings and you
can really filter here so if we want you
know choose high network earners in a
particular country a particular state
you know we could definitely filter in
on a particular
type of publisher okay so you want to be
able to hone in on somebody to align
with your geography or you know
definitely you want to align with
somebody who's a high network owner now
when you get all your publishers set up
you're going to need to provide them
with some good promotional materials
some good banners um you know it could
be text links some messaging okay so
you're the one who's going to provide
the publishers
with you know the information they need
now
as a best practice remember you can get
on the phone with these publishers have
monthly calls or quarterly calls see
what they need you know reach out to
them via email or reach out to them via
the cj platform figure out hey you know
how's your banners working for you do
you need new banners so you want to be
able to constantly you know push new
content out and so
if i click on links here
and manage i'll be able to see
everything that i have available for my
publishers to use okay and then you can
actually look at
banners that have actually produced for
you in terms of epc
or you know if it's a specific promotion
okay you could set that up here so
you're gonna be able to see it here you
can see all
the banners you can see some text links
in here so all the you know advertising
that you want these publishers to have
is going to be situated under links and
so you can see what the active ones are
you can look at archived you can look at
again text links content links or
banners and as a best practice if i
click on a banner as a best practice
ideally what you want to do is use utm
tracking okay so you want to have some
type of tracking in place however
cj does a lot of the tracking for you so
they're going to be able to tell you how
many times
a banner has been clicked and how many
times a banner has been seen okay
they'll also tell you more importantly
not only was that banner click but did
it generate a sale and so here i can see
that i have three publishers using this
particular banner i can see over this
period of time 412 impressions meaning
412 people viewed the banner and i
received one click on it so you can get
some in-depth detail about your
different marketing materials and how
they're performing okay you can also see
what publishers are using them okay so
the key here is
you want to be able to communicate
with your publishers give them the
promotional material and that they need
to promote your product now you could
set up specifically you could set up a
unique banner for a publisher or you
could set up a banner for a group of
publishers that's where the group comes
in so you have some options here and
then as a best practice what i would try
and do as you can see here is come up
with different banner sizes so you can
see here we got a 728 by 90. okay you
got a 160 by 600 you got a 300 by 250.
okay so you want to have different
banner sizes and you also want to mix in
some text um ads as well okay you want
to be able to give your publishers some
options in terms of what to use on their
websites so that's the whole idea
because a publisher may not have space
on the home page they may only have
enough space for you know a text ad or a
300 by 250. so you want to be able to
mix it up and then also mix up the
messaging as well so you can have the
same 300 250 banner but you can have
different messaging just like you see
here 300 by 250 got this messaging here
and we got a different set of messaging
with the same banner size so the more
options you present for yourself the
more of an opportunity you have for the
publisher to use that messaging that
banner that text that on their website
and then that gives you a better
opportunity to get the click get the
conversion that you seek out so
that is
links so you want to be able to continue
to push out different banners and text
ads now cj also has a great feature in
here if you're selling a lot of products
you have a large inventory of products
you could actually upload a product feed
to cj so you can see in this example we
don't but if you did let's just say you
have a hundred products that you want to
sell you can go ahead and upload that
feed to cj and then the publisher will
be able to use that entirety in its of
the feed or pick and choose different
products to use and sell so let's jump
over to reports in cj you have reports
so this is really the bulk of where you
want to be spending your time because
you want to be able to
you know not only recruit those
publishers but after you recruit them
you want to be able to see the
performance how are things moving are
are publishers moving product are they
generating clicks are they selling your
product so go no further than reports
right here at the top navigation we're
going to click on performance reports
and so we want to be able to see over a
period of time you know are we selling
our product and here you can see over
the last 30 days you could see how much
commission was paid out remember cj gets
a fee they're the broker okay so that's
part of the program terms okay so it's
based on program terms who's selling
okay what program term are they
associated with cj gets their commission
okay so you can see the total commission
and then the sale amount okay so we
could see how many sales were generated
how many items were sold how many clicks
were generated how many impressions so i
can get a good sense here day by day
over who's selling who's not selling and
it's all broken down at the very end to
earnings per click so that's my
performance report so we want to be able
to see over a period of time you know
are we selling now i can go into detail
if i click on transaction here from the
pull down menu i can look at a specific
order i can choose a specific publisher
or website and i can get details about
that specific order publisher website
etc just be look by choosing transaction
so i can get really granular about the
data i see for a specific transaction
that's just by clicking reports
transaction now you can also click on
promo codes and if you're running any
promo codes for your publishers you'll
be able to see
how many conversions those promo codes
delivered and the set total sale amount
over the last 30 days so building a
network is all about recruiting the
right publishers giving them the
materials they need measuring the
performance of the publishers and then
communicating it's just so key so cj has
a nice message center built in so you
can actually you know look at the
messages you're getting from your
publishers and turn around and
communicate with them so
communicate
seamlessly and efficiently right in cj
here so i just clicked on mail and we
can see the messages we have so you can
also click on email campaigns and if you
have any email campaigns that you want
to run you can look at them right here
in cj so cj offers up some email
campaigns then we can see how many
people we targeted you know how many
people opened it and how many people
joined in this case joined our network
so
here we have you know a breakdown of
each of the email campaigns that we've
run over a period of time and their
status and how many people were
targeting and opens deliveries etc so if
you want to run an email campaign right
in cj it's available to you as part of
the platform so if we move over from
mail to placements we have an
opportunity to place some promotional
material on a publisher's website and so
here we could see a breakdown of
different publishers who basically will
offer up some promotional material that
we can leverage okay so here you got
this particular promotional placement
it's a one month placement and review
page with your ad so we can actually you
know take advantage of what publishers
are offering up on their own website so
the whole idea here is if it's in a
prime position on their website then we
can take advantage of that so then what
we want to be able to do is if we like
what they're offering up you can see hey
this particular publisher saying hey i
have a creative the placement is a
homepage banner or full page review
provide an email with a copy of the ad
that you'd like to be displayed and
we're going to email this person here so
if we want to take advantage of a
specific promotional placement on a
publisher's website then we can do that
just by clicking on placements and we'll
be able to see who's offering up what
notice there's a fee involved so it just
gives you an opportunity to
reward a publisher that's performing
well for you and if they turn around and
offer you a better placement a little
bit more money it might be worth it so
the whole idea is to take advantage of
placements because if your product is in
place properly then nobody's gonna see
it if nobody sees it then you know
they're not gonna click on it and then
you're not gonna get sales so that's the
whole idea here
is take advantage of what publishers are
offering up in terms of promotional
opportunities so cj also has a
pay-per-call
click uh model as well pay model so
basically
your pay per performance is based on
calls so
basically the whole point here is a cj
points out you want to promote more high
ticket and consultative products and
services you want to expand your reach
and you want to get more qualified sales
then you can offer up a pay per call and
the beauty here is cj tracks the calls
so
you will be able to see
the actual phone number and calls so
instead of offering up say you know
banner with a click you can offer up you
know promotional number and have cj
track the calls from the publisher and
that just opens up another opportunity
for you to give your publishers an
option to have people call if they call
then great you know it's another way for
somebody to get in touch and purchase
the product so the pay-per-call method
is available under cj as well so if we
want to get more insights about how our
program is performing we just click on
the insights cj's gonna take us to this
overview this dashboard if you will with
some really good data based on a time
frame okay so we're comparing july
through
of july of 19 through july of 2018 we're
able to see revenue and commissions paid
out and how many clicks average order
value so there's kind of an overview
dashboard if you will about
how our overall program is performing
there are other similar tools and
resources to include you know max bounty
trade doubler amazon associates there's
plenty of networks out there you want to
find a network where you're going to
have affiliates that are going to be
passionate and going to be relevant and
have the prospective audience that you
need to sell your product so do your due
diligence on the number of different
platforms out there
and with that we have come to the end of
this digital marketing full course for
2021 i hope it was informative and
interesting
if you have any questions about the
topics covered in this video please ask
away in the comment section below our
team will help you solve your queries
thanks for watching stay safe and keep
learning
you